all right y'all i just found out that
we can't do 24-hour streams i probably
should have googled that before
but this is part two of our 24 hour
stream i'm dead
i've done truth or dare
i've read pilled women
i've i've learned about planned
parenthood i've done a lot
so
we were just talking about how planned
parenthood basically
was started as a eugenics movement
oh gosh
oh gosh okay i'm sorry it was started as
a eugenics movement and
essentially
was put in black neighborhoods to like
eliminate the black race and that the
birth rate
among
black women is 46
so this is like red pill
facts and it's crazy because we were
just connecting the dot just is gone
right now but we were just connecting
the dots that at the same time that row
versus wade was
happened
you also get
you also get the
the welfare state that was implemented
and you also get
the implementation of birth control
so it seems like all of this
it's just crazy it just seems like all
of these systems were put in place to
break down the family
and i i while i do think it affected the
black community the most it's happening
in other communities too
oh you got to switch the thumbnail the
on the live
yeah yeah
it's the same thumbnail no it's not
just to get it um
yeah no it clicks
[Music]
let me see that
but what else should i read tell me guys
what i should read on the chat
oh thank you for the 10 super chat ring
me up girl
um
guys we don't know how to do reactions
on the street screen we're a little bit
um
new to some of the tech stuff
but
guys
let me know if there's something we can
read on the stream that's like a red
pill fact that that'll red pill us even
more so
because i think
that red pill and conservativism is like
the same thing
um
okay let me see
so one thing that
oh my gosh the last one has 21 000 views
yeah yeah it's live still
the last one has 21 000 views and put
part two in the title will you
oh yeah amazing you got the new
thumbnail yeah oh the same thing yeah
yeah
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna message sarah
where are you at
sorry get your old black
boy if you don't
what if he bails i'm gonna be so sad oh
boy bro
let me
pick up these headphones okay oh my gosh
we got a new membership yeah and another
ten bucks
wow
thanks for joining you're gonna you're
gonna get some cool memberships okay
um
are you sure we got the new thumbnail i
don't see it on this but let me refresh
it again it's still saying save
well i've clicked save but
it's not click it again i'll redo it
again if you need
okay
the weave you've been acting interesting
click it again
oh you're gonna have to go back into
stream
did you do it in stream labs
i didn't change the thumbnails for your
stream now yeah i think you tried to i
think they didn't let me
you should be able to if you edited it
now
this shoe
hair hair hair because i did that
um
when i set it up in stream labs the
first time it changed the
uh change the wedding she says i preview
file and then it doesn't let me to
change it here oh wait i gotta text my
personal trainer i can't do it today
oh my god i would die if i went to the
gym right now
i got an email on homegirl
[Music]
did anybody else have to learn like
other countries like national anthem
and like all the military songs
when they were in elementary school
i did
i had to learn uh the canadian national
anthem
i grew up in michigan so we were right
next to canada so we had to learn that
and then we had to learn all the
military branches song
it was a
it was interesting because i never
thought i would need to sing those if i
did a summer camp and we were at this
church and they did all the branches of
military time i was the only one in the
group that knew every single one was
your was your mom religious oh yeah both
my parents still are group i grew up in
the church i was in the church before i
was even born
so
someone commented that's why you're
based
that's why i'm what
what does
help me understand oh you know what i'll
do i know what does base mean
like
solid basically
okay
that's not a bad thing that that term is
not a bad term
now it changed
okay good wow
i want to go to this hold on
bass
i want to go to the studio
[Music]
most single fathers are divorced
wow
by comparison most single moms have
never been married
cool
huh
single fathers are more likely to be
white
older somewhat better educated compared
to single mothers
according to a recent report on single
parent families
by the national center for marriage and
family research 56 of children living
with single fathers identify as white
compared to 33 living with single
mothers
really wow furthermore
they report single fathers are more
likely than single mothers to have a
bachelor's degree
and when it comes to age single dads
tend to be slightly older
single fathers are more likely to be
cohabitating a 2013 study of single
fathers found that 40 1 of single
fathers were living cohabitating with
their partner compared to 16 percent of
single mothers wow
that's so interesting single fathers are
better off financially than single
mothers
i believe it
um so you would think that with that
there's that right there like single
fathers are more financially
like suitable than single mothers you
would think that it would be in favor
for the kids
if the mother is not fit to be a mother
you would think you'd be in favor
of them going to the father but
yeah while the research on single
fathers is limited studies show that
children and single father families
spare about as well as children and
single mother families on many outcomes
though there are differences
with a few possible exceptions the
children of single fathers do about as
well in terms of internalizing behavior
and academic performance sometimes
better however the children of single
fathers appear more likely to
participate in externalizing behavior
and substance abuse abuse as of yeah a
few there the few studies of young
adults do not seem to indicate
significant long-term differences as it
returns
as related to marriage teen birth
divorce between those raised in single
father versus single mother homes
a study by child tr child trends
research in 2010 used a sample of 4 000
adolescents okay
this study was unique in that instead of
co-grouping cohabitating fathers with
lone fathers it distinguished between
them among the studies finding
cohabitating single fathers had fewer
family routines less less eating dinner
together and single fathers living with
a partner had lower lower levels of
closeness and awareness than they did
in other family times the author
concluded that offspring who resides
with a custodial father and their
cohabitating partner may face additional
challenges
finally a more recent study in november
um
the
um okay
examine sexual behavior among 15 to 19
year olds being raised in single-parent
families the authors compare various
sexual behaviors among boys and girls
living with single fathers and single
mothers surprisingly they found view
difference between say okay sex related
outcomes
wow
that's so hard
what
nothing
i'm not laughing at that i'm laughing at
because something i said in my head
i was listening but i'm like pearl wants
to read all of this
and we ain't slept at all i'm like i'm
hearing it but it's like i need you to
read it a couple times for me to
comprehend it so that's why i'm laughing
but
i'll i'll go i'll go in less words i
won't read all of the words it's okay
but man
it's
i would love for that like
that right there to change
if there was anything that changed about
laws when it comes to single parents
i'd love for it to be more
fair and like
i won't say equal
but more
investigated if that makes sense into
like
both parents and like it is really
decided if the mother is not fit
if she ain't got the means to
um
to do it
then the father
is and if the father is more suitable to
have the kids and the mother visits then
that's how it should be
fc dallas under 15 boys squad beat the
women's national team
what which national team soccer
oh really
wow a little asmr for y'all again
men's under six months
what
the american woman's
i think so yes in dallas um
when was this
like the usa national team yeah wow
interesting what makes sense because
i was saying basketball but dude
actually played
i can usually take them up to like a
year or two high school in terms of
skill
same
you know alison felix's
yes what about her she got beat by 300
high school boys
win
is this like they raced her or they beat
her time i don't know i'll find out
yeah i don't know the time yeah yeah
i can
okay 2018. i
when did she start
she was like
she started young in the was it like
was
it her time when she was 18 or was it
her time when she was in the olympics
okay and olympic time
i can
i can see that because
for
a
male to run if a 18 year old man is
running her time
they're not good as a 18 year old
like
because they have to
i can see if they're running they're
that's allison felix ashley is one of
the best women runners like cool you're
beating her time
what
a second is a lot is a lot in track
that's true
i won't say they're not good
but it's like okay cool you'll be alison
felix you're not going to race against
her in a regular race
i could see if you were beating uh
tyson gay or um usain bolt or
anybody else's
pace
i don't know the disparity though
between the 18 year olds
fastest time
yeah
yeah i won't say they're not good i'll
say like okay cool like
great you're beating
or olympian woman okay get up there with
the men
i wouldn't
i wouldn't be like oh my gosh
because i just know that in track and
field it
um
a millisecond
is a lot
of who do you think's the most desired
on dating apps for women
guess what race
black
most desired
swiped right on
i would say black men
no no i'm talking about women oh for
women yeah
white or latinas asian
asian woman that was my uh i said
i don't know
it was just tinder
yeah black or second after white and for
men
wait are the white men are the most
swept right on black men are second
black men are second really
okay no no i can i can see that because
um
yep i could i can definitely see that
just
giving the dynamics of who's on on
tinder
yeah who's on that dating app
asian men and indian are last
man
i would say asia might be getting up
there because all these these k-pop
stars
everybody's having a little asian
persuasion fantasies
i'm not saying it's not me i'm not
having no age of persuasion fantasies
but these lots out here are
who
no not you not you i'm just saying just
oh yeah
these
btx
bts i said btx bts um there's a lot of
them and i don't know my friends would
be disappointed at me i don't know the
ones that they showed me
you get over there ish
it's just like
empowering better than the rest of it
yeah even up dancing and whatnot
i mean that's tough in itself in it
i know i'm like running out of things i
feel like i've talked about i can't
think of any more red pale points
i feel like i've talked about every red
pill
i i feel like you have it says you can't
hear you speaking in the back
like ish is there any red pill points i
haven't gone over
i'm not too sure you know i don't think
so i think i feel like you've been
through neddy every single yeah
every single point can you you can hear
me now guys right yeah they should be
able to i can hear you in the headphones
uh yeah
i think so
i made a whole google doc and like once
i got through it i was like wow
i mean i'm sure there's always more but
when we get more people here they can go
through it
grape culture is a lie hypergamy oh
solid oh this is one thing actually i
didn't go through
i don't know how to say it like i've
only read this word i've already said it
out loud but solid soliplism solicism
yeah appreciate it guys
so
it's how other women relate to women
so if you say
i go to the gym then other girls respond
oh i go to the gym
where like men see that as like self
like they they it seems like
narcissistic to men
oh
but it's like how we relate to each
other so if a guy says oh i do that then
we go oh i do that like to men that's
like narcissistic
you're just trying to
can you
no but we're not trying to one up it's
just we're trying to relate like it's
like kind of like oh we have something
in common yeah i realized with girls
they do that so i'm just like yeah you
like guys not friends anymore then i'm
like oh no this is just
how we are
um can you look up the definition for
narcissism
we need the people in the chat to work
for us a narcissist narcissist is a
self-centered personality style
characterized as having an excessive
internet interest in one's physical
appearance and interest in preoccupation
with one's own need oftentimes at the
expense of others
wow
interesting
let me see in the chat if there's any
do you all want to see us sleep on
camera
how long should we take a nap for
i want to see if they answer the
question
talk about lgbtq
right now um
not the time not the place
no maybe i might have that again okay
how long for a nap
do you want to see us now
hey some of the
guys on the stream are really tripping
through with us i know we appreciate
y'all
y'all been here for the long haul
yeah
hey
there might be some special merch for
for the people who
sign up for a membership and have stayed
on the live for us oh yeah yeah so if
you sign up for him
if you sign up for a membership and
you've been on this live with us since
9 00
pm 9 30 yesterday
you
you will i won't even say maybe because
that's a big deal that you you stayed on
the live with us this long you will see
special merch for members only who've
been on this live with us so if you're
not a member i'm sorry you're not going
to get the merch it's going to be
exclusive
so
if you want it
what'd they say someone said i feel like
you saying y'all want to see us sleep
together on chant camera is going to be
deliberately and gleefully
misinterpreted
no i never said sleep together i said
you guys want to
see us sleep
on camera i never said together y'all
added that word um lgbtq
anyone ever realized they can't define a
woman but lesbian is the first letter in
their name
[Music]
yeah that's the thing like like
i i've met so many lesbians that are
like we cannot get with like the
movement anymore because they
they keep adding people to it
oh like a straight woman
it's not straight but like like now
they're putting trans on the same
categories lgbtq
tx
plus
it's just
lgbtq
sorry xyz
no i'm kidding would you date how would
you date a guy 25 years older than you
no
actually question would you rather date
a 35 year old with potential or a 45
year old who's there
a 45 year old who's there yeah
anthony thank you anthony graham thank
you thank you so much look it
this is the energy i'm trying yes i love
it i love the members
it will be the
the membership don't be bummed if this
next week the membership is not popping
like it needs to be i'm going on holiday
for my birthday so i won't be here but
once i come back it's gonna be pop and
popping so yeah yeah just wait for the
first vlog
i mean you can just give me the footage
from saturday i'll go to the editor okay
i'll hopefully have one bye yeah
next week it's just so excited he's like
please get that he's like bless the lord
oh my god
hey
love you in what you do
pearly and your co-host thoughtful and
intelligent except the feminist please
don't talk about lgbtq it's boring guys
i just like think that we've literally
covered everything like we've talked
about am i the feminist no no that's um
someone else okay i was like did i
become the feminist
no maybe maybe in your first streams
um
my dad says that women should date
younger because we live longer
jess jess would you date dwayne the
johnson
no but my mama would and a heartbeat in
a harvey she says that's your daddy
i'm like every time i see him on the
screen i'm like hey step daddy oh
another member yay
you guys are giving us energy
yes
yes not if
if i could
if i had that kind of pool i would get
dwayne the rock johnson for my mom's
like next big birthday
or just her next birthday if i had that
pool oh
i would do it and she would probably cry
she she
loves that man so i can't
i can't marry my stepdaddy
this is your ultimate celebrity crush
just looks just looks my personality
ultimate celebrity crush just looks
young
joe
joe biden no no no no no no joe budden
no no the singer joe
oh no he does i don't know who that is
who's that um
yes he does i'm trying to think
all all of the thing is one of his
popular ones
or um
my phone for me
um
baby
i wanna do
i love
the things you meant this guy
no no no no no what
it's just joe like j-o-e
he's not coming up
actually
no not young joe i'm just saying joe
uh the
joe biden
jeffrey
who said that
oh no not news he was out here he had a
performance out here
um
[Music]
you're asked to join a panel to solve
world peace what's the first thing you
solve
starvation
all right pageant
i would kill you
i would eradicate child rapists
i know that's not about hunger but i
just feel like it contributes to the
problem anyways
this is him someone said eliminate the
one percent
what's that
really that's your ultimate celebrity i
mean don't remember he's fine yeah and
if you hear him sing you have to listen
to all like ultimate
oh is someone here
please god
i'm so tired
is it sarah hey eddie how did you get
back the door's open ellie how did you
get back in
i'm sorry
ellie said yes
ellie said that was my opportunity yes
sir take calls to hit but i when i was
younger i used to have celebrity crushes
but now that i'm older i'm not like
i don't really have celebrity crushes
like that or at all someone said you
should do a live stream every day at 24
hours
who said that you can you can do a live
stream every day for 24 hours
i have an idea i just have to do it so
fast
you can do a live stream yo
someone says
what are they saying
i can't say that i actually can't say
that
guess who it is
zara's here
sarah
you're saving us yay
[Applause]
guys sarah's here sarah
sarah
i almost fell asleep on stream we both
did yeah
i don't even know what we've been gone
i don't know what i don't know what
we've been talking about for the last
two hours right let me just go to the
bathroom
no
sorry sorry i'm sorry before you go say
i have to stream we over here what's
going on folks um sarah's in the
building i've got a couple of hours um
we're going to try and help the ladies
out right now
and um yeah but i'm going to go to the
bathroom first
i'm sorry i'm not dramatic at all
oh wait she said
save us
oh
what did it say in the
chat hey hey ellie
this one she said they're delusional
she said she couldn't feed but she
wasn't that
you can take that piece and give it to
her okay fine fine cuties
hey we got another member yay another
member thank you patrick o'brien us yes
patrick energy
oh doing the right things we appreciate
it black pearl
they said black pearl said um
they said sarah's head but they had
another
statement before that
oh
yeah
my my they say
she's going to be in there for a minute
i see the chat that says pro you need to
do a 24 uh 24 hour stream every day yeah
i'm glad you enjoy it though
oh i am in insanity is a member too we
didn't say him
and his energy
yeah mike williams second yeah no i
don't live stream at the moment
um just live streaming for pearl
oh joe his last name is thomas no not is
it i think so i don't know we're not
going back to that
jason momoa is single now that i forgot
about him
i guess
yes he is single
[Laughter]
hey we got super chat i feel like i've
been through
things uh the
five the five one yeah
i said pizza if you want some i said
sarah wish you were here when the bp guy
was on the phone
what people
oh what bp guy my friend i'm i'm in your
seat pal you is bp what does bp mean
hold on
what does bp mean
is that bait or something
bp can you guys help us out what is it
it's probably talking about your friend
that's what i thought
of dates this stream oh really yeah did
you say yes oh this has been interesting
i was laughing you guys must be tired
man i hate it when i'm left out of the
loop i just like to be included in
things so what happened there jess
a man called that said he was her male
friend
and i'm like i don't think men and women
can be friends really right so like you
you're red pill aware right you know how
it'd be right why am i sitting in
between both of you
oh blue pale blue pill let's say jess
said i want to smash you down
guys like hell yeah well then that's not
your friend beautiful i'm like
yeah
and then
so then he's like talking the man's been
in the friend zone for like years and
i'm like have you ever asked her on a
date and he's like no and i'm like well
why not
jess you're just keeping guys in the
friend zone like that right
i know
[Music]
you never know
and then come to fast so then she says
yes to the date come to find out
she's not really attracted to him like
that and she accepts dates
from men she wouldn't sleep with that's
well that's the women of nowadays isn't
it that's what's going on right i didn't
think she was a modern woman now come on
come on i thought i thought i'd read
pill trained her
no i mean it takes a while for the pill
to take effect
pizza box is just on the table
you listen guys do you know what i found
right
i was on my way down here and i was
listening to my
r b
90s 2000 playlist oh yes right
do you know what
that the men in the 90s and 2000s you
know people are wondering why are modern
women like this blah blah have you
listened to the way these guys what
these guys were saying what'd they say
these guys were like
gassing up these women they were i was
into um boys to men end of the road do
you remember when it like stops
and the guy starts speaking
yeah do you know what he's saying during
that time he's like baby
i know i missed it i knew i meant no no
it's like i knew you were cheating on me
i just didn't care because i just wanted
you back baby i'm just like oh did he
really say that what can it be argued
what the hell are you doing did he
really say that hold on that's what he
says hold up it's kind of funny because
with the red pill lens you realize the
woman's the victim in every
every song every song the girl's got to
be the victim i was listening to like
drew hill like i was just into like
i'm just like these guys are begging
these women like it's crazy i was like
no wonder why these women that
the guys were singing this stuff to them
they produced some bops though like
morgan wallin that's the country version
oh my god do you know that it's good
songs though do you know forever my lady
was written by um
uh oh my goodness
what is his name
babyface no no uh quincy no quincy jones
no no no quincy the uh p diddy's like
son
really it was written by not written by
him but written by his actual dad oh wow
uh i can't remember his name off the top
of my head and it was about
the
p diddy's uh ex-wife that passed away
when they had quincy
oh
i didn't know that yeah
i didn't know that but yeah these r b
cats man they were just like
they were simple simplesauruses maybe
that's what let me that's what's wrong
with me i love 90s but the thing is i
was i was like yeah and i was like hang
on what did he just say
some crazy stuff okay let's see so what
did i miss while you guys were doing
24-hour stream uh she poured she poured
ice water over my head
for truth or dare right she got asked is
it girl i'm here for you you got awesome
on the day i guess i gotta ask somebody
to hurt me did you accept well not a
date no this guy shot us
there wasn't really a next step
yeah he just yeah first of all she
called him twice
no audacity he was like let me shoot my
shot and so i was like all right let's
do it on the stream
call a man twice i'm like am i
and we getting
like
like being ghosts he called me back but
then later oh my god the audacity he was
like he was like
i i saw him looking at it when it ended
on scene
right
i'm not i'm that [__] so i call it out
i'm like you left me on scene and he's
like no no i didn't see it i called you
back i'm like i can see it on the app
on instagram
respect me mother
i don't know the audacity
and he's trying to play off i'm like i
i can see it like
anyways
that's crazy it says girl i'm here for
you all those times of night when you
just hurt me
and just ran out
with that other fella i have a guy baby
i knew about it i just didn't care
you just don't understand how much love
how much i love you do you i'm here for
you i'm not out to go out and cheat on
you all night just like you did baby but
that's all right hey i love you anyways
and i'm still gonna be here for you till
my dying day baby right now
i'm just in so much pain cause you know
because you just won't come back will
you
just come back to me lonely lonely
lonely come on
man this time instead just come to my
bed and baby just
what this guy likes this song no more
this guy basically said
i know you're cheating you're going out
there cheating i'm not going to do it
but i didn't care i knew you were doing
it but take me back what a
simp i i don't like this song anymore oh
my gosh i'm telling you
wow
maybe i should start stop listening to
90. no no the thing is i still listen to
it right but i listen to it with a
different ear if that makes sense now
yeah ish could you hand me my phone
please
what pieces did you guys have
hawaiian and pepperoni and meat lovers
okay
i think phil just got a delivery i don't
think it's actually somebody who's uh
coming on the stream do you want to come
on the stream
do you guys have anyone coming
uh
so so this so this started at what time
last night 9 30. so you're doing it
until 9 30 tonight again
we got new lights yay new lights
someone's here no it's the same guy
oh okay unfortunately why can't i
exit out of it he was on uh
yesterday
everybody's name you remember the guy
that was sitting next to the guy in the
yellow shirt sylvie i think his name is
okay it was him and then um
sasha
what's her name that was sitting right
here
you need to get cheska back on that's
what you need to do
i wish
you guys bullied her
i never bullied chess girl
you know every time they always they
still ask they're like they have jessica
and sarah coho i'm telling you
oh my god i i've thought about paying
her to come back
pay cheska to come back man i've i've
thought about it give her like 10 pounds
that's how much she's worth
i want problems good luck love you
jessica
love you love you chesca come back you
can come back on i won't buy it you
think that that one clip just went a
little too bad i think listen someone
posted it just two days ago again really
like someone else like
like someone posted it like two days ago
again wow all right guys if you're ever
wondering what i order on my amazon
packages
oh i need to email her back really
exciting okay
this is adhesive spray oh yay wow
so now in this fall we have more glue
lovely product placement
[Laughter]
oh thank you
don't put it in your hair like that let
that go i'm gonna get a slick back do
you remember you remember last year with
that girl that done her hair with the
the gorilla glue that was the stupidest
thing do you remember the gorilla
glitter
she won that last two i'm like did she
she sticks her hair back with gorilla
glue and the hair just wouldn't it [__]
my
because it didn't say
on the package don't use on hair
ah
people see
oh
it's like speaking to children
this is gorilla glue
to stick things don't use on your hair
so right now should i do it
say what go for it should i cancel it
cancel
[Music]
i forgot i was supposed to meet with my
advisor for my dissertation i'll just
tell them next week
i'm a really bad education comes first
no it doesn't
stay in school kids stay in school don't
do it
i'm the most over educated like i'm like
i wish i was less educated i was so like
i have a four-year college degree i have
a market research certification
and now i'm gonna have a master's in
psychology but i didn't want any of this
education i just wanted to keep playing
sports
kevin samuels had that
things like i'm a phd oh my gosh i'd be
so mad
i'm a phd no no i could never
i was trying to okay so i was telling
people the pillars of red pill
okay and i feel like i've literally
covered everything today like i i can't
think of anything i haven't talked about
but i want to see maybe you could think
of anything so i'm gonna tell you stuff
we've talked about
what's a high value man went over that
yeah i've been red pilling jess
um
high value men can cheat and often do
um but cheating is different for men and
for women talked about that how do you
feel about that though as a woman
do you want a high value man that would
be able to cheat
no not really
i think i mean it depends like
i want a guy taller than me is that high
value
um if you're looking for a high value
man and it says the pillars of it
he can cheat
no i don't
like
i don't know how he's like
crazy
it's just like uh
no no no no high value man says nothing
but height
it doesn't it doesn't say anything about
height okay so he's i haven't written
down right yeah go i'm going it's 10k
wait hold on 10k a month 10k a month
other men must accept you as high value
network of high value ben
visibility linkedin level utility useful
to others in the group he doesn't
automatically count entertain your
entertainers
um
and yeah that's the
and you must have had the 10k per month
for three to five years uh okay so
i mean i don't the guy doesn't have to
make 10k a month
like that's you know
your guy doesn't have to make 10k a
month no i mean if he's i'm 25 so he's
my age
i said he just has to make like a normal
like salary i don't know 40 in the u.s
so it's not 30 here 30k yeah like and
you'll be good
yeah i mean i think
i it would be more back to like the i
would hope he would make more over time
because again i think there's a
difference between a guy being 25 and
45. 100 yeah so like like i don't if he
if he's younger and he's a hard-working
guy and he's just starting off in his
career i worked in sales i made 42 a
year plus commission in sales and so
much so right yeah i'm not gonna be
super judgmental yeah okay when i were
like that was like what two years ago so
you're gonna find a guy in london or the
u.s
do you think
oh it depends i think it'll depend where
i stay if i stay here another year i
feel like i'll probably find someone in
london yeah if i go back next year in
the fall
then
yeah and
i don't know i think your chances will
be less if you go back to the states no
that's what i'm saying if i go back to
the states like why i wouldn't meet a
guy in london no no i think your chances
of
um
[Music]
i was
i would say your chances of meeting
the person that you
want
would be less going back to the states
it would be more if you stayed here why
because
because of what we've talked about how
like men are different
out here and the way they approach you
and
what's the difference
they're
if you're saying they're more proper and
they're more forward with it out here
like they'll actually approach you
instead of in the states like some will
and
some won't but really yeah they
definitely are guys are more direct in
london
but and you also get a point in london
because the girls aren't as pretty here
so you can't say that no no i mean
you can't say that i'm like i'm dead
serious at any big city like
like miami chicago i'd say the girls are
all prettier like miami chicago dc
like i don't know
but then but then london girls are
probably more intelligent
probably yeah you know yeah probably
but i'm very smart so that doesn't
no but i'm just saying on average like
if you say like miami girls i get it
like girls in miami this is going to be
about their looks but
what's the intelligence like over there
dallas girls in dallas are like pretty
more well-rounded and like down there
see i haven't been in enough places in
america actually from time to time i've
talked to multiple girls about this like
americans and we're all from different
cities and we all say that in the uk you
get a point
so like fives become six the sixes
become sevens hmm
until i leave i want i want to stay for
a while right okay so i don't know see
everybody comes to london and falls in
love with london
i know i think i'm probably gonna stay
one more year yeah yeah
wherever the wind blows yeah i'm trying
to get dual citizenship anybody wanna
give me that i'll let you girl listen
you can find a guy to marry you and give
you like
you know give you a citizenship
hey
i know a couple of people
that have married for a passport yeah me
and jess we're gonna live together next
year oh right we're gonna have a reality
tv show yeah we're just gonna live
stream our whole life oh my god on
camera
like we won't
every two girls one cup no no no
no no no no
no no no
we're gonna literally like live
you're gonna live stream like the hope i
don't know i'm gonna start another
channel i'm gonna do one that's like
we're gonna have so many cameras
whatever whatever i freaking want to do
we will do it yes
like our whole life you're gonna call it
ebony and ivory ah
like the gray area you've got the gray
area now you've got ebony and ivory okay
okay
i couldn't laugh [__] i couldn't we
could livestream i couldn't let people
in my like just me and you eating yes
just asmr
you stop
someone
someone earlier was like oh uh
chew louder please
listen people got their kinks man
people got their kicks
yeah they said you louder and then
slower i was like
i was like okay sir true louder baby
because people watch like mukbangs and
stuff don't you yeah yeah they they
watch people eating for asmr and i'm
like
i was listening to myself and i said i
cannot stand the sound of smack
listen man people got their kinks out
there um
kinky kinky so high volume we also went
over there's no wage gap i think that's
part of the red pill yeah it's like not
as you know but
men and women are different we have
different mating strategies men don't
care about your career your body count
matters um they're the wall for women we
went over um i'm excited i'm gonna hit
mine soon
celebration when i hit the wall
i'm over here about to cry pearl's like
whoa whoa whoa make content off of this
pay gap doesn't exist feminism isn't
always has been a hate movement women
initiate divorce 70 to 80 of time grape
culture is a lie single mothers are
selfish
um and hypergamy what'd i miss
what did you miss
i don't think anything
what about
okay okay so that's the red pill
do you think that a lot of men within
the red pill
think of themselves as high value but
aren't
yeah
like i think a lot of guys think of
themselves as like alpha but they aren't
right especially when more than one says
it from the same friend group you can't
all be the leader only one of you is the
leader in the friend group interesting
because like that's what it means like
in every
pairing even if it's male male female
female there's like one person that's
following and one leading
one makes more of the decisions so i
mean what i mean it doesn't mean it in
at home you're like like you're not the
leader at home right yeah but
like you can't all be the leader in a
friend
i think
even with like women to women one of
them like i think that men that scream
i'm the alpha are probably normally not
yeah you know do you know what i mean
and i hear it so much and i'm just like
i don't know guys because
you kind of walk in it
and you live it do you know what i mean
and it becomes like self-evident you
haven't really got a shoutout from the
rooftops do you know what i mean so i've
been seeing that quite you know i've
been seeing that quite a bit with a lot
of men like just saying yeah i'm an
alvarez i'm alpha's just b man they're
just in if they are in that alpha energy
they're just there you can see it you
can feel it when they walk in a room you
know i mean you can you can see it by
the way in which they
live their lives and stuff and i just
think don't say it just be it when you
think of alpha who do you think of
like who's the
perfect example of one vladimir putin
how interesting
i think of trump
there you go yeah
because
you're just laughing
no i'm just just both of y'all answers
i'm like
vladimir putin and trump i'm like
yeah they're both leaders
it doesn't look like they're being told
what to do
whereas most leaders
nowadays you can kind of sense that here
they're not in control of what's going
on yeah
and i don't i don't think beta like a
lot of girls marry beta guys and are
happy with them like it doesn't
necessarily mean like oh she's i mean i
like to use it i'll be like keep your
beta ass husband
but like but you can this is a thing you
can can you still be a beta and still be
a leader
well you can lead in your relationship
in your relationship yeah so like
you can
like your beta at work if you work for
someone
you follow them um
and i think
they were
they weren't talking about my friend
they were talking about the one that
spent
like 500k on
his ex
and um
like they bought the house and he like
uh sent all
he spent all his money oh my god i kept
talking and
talking so there's this guy he was in a
relationship with his ex
and he
spent all his tesla shares
on a house and then cove it happened and
like extra money it was like i think
like 500k 200 some 200 500k
in the in his uh like relationship
and um
then kova hit and he had to move into
uh
the girl's parents house and all the
family stayed
in like the same like row and so they
took out like the back wall of
all their houses so they could just walk
through like each family's house and did
she end up cheating on him yeah she
ended up cheating on him
i was falling asleep during that story
too
i heard you said so
so what happened i was like because he
just wasn't like oh my gosh and
that was the low point in the street
that was like
that was the oh that was like the
decline we were going there must have
been a dip or a couple of dips oh there
we've been like this on a road i think
we're on the upswing now now
i knew it if we made it to nine or ten
that we
yeah we would get back up
yeah because like our body is going to
think and then
lays the question then you know um
do you think that
women break their rules for the right
guy oh yeah yes yes
right okay
and
does that guy necessarily have to be the
guy you're gonna marry
it could be enough that they're gonna
marry but they wanna marry
right doesn't mean they'll get it right
okay
because in my life i've experienced
a few women saying these are my rules
and i've heard them and then all of a
sudden they've broken those rules
for me and i'm like he's so following me
i'm like what happened to that
truth got it like this all the girls
were like
cap yeah
like oh i have these rules but i break
them for like
it's it's crazy because like
i don't know if
she might have to help me out here do
guys have
girls that they break their rules for
and when a guy breaks his rules does he
then become a simple guy tell me he's
breaking a rule for me weirdly enough
what was the rule it wasn't real he just
says he doesn't usually like
he was like helping me with a lot of
[__] and like just like doing a lot of
[__] for me and he was just saying like
he doesn't usually do this like
this early on but
because you're such a nice person
i don't know i did then he just said he
because he knew it was like going
somewhere
but then i broke it off
i guess it didn't go anywhere far
seriously why do women always break [__]
off like why is it women that are
breaking [__] often like eighty percent
of the time
i don't know they've got options
not even that it was like
because i'll get to know a guy for a
couple weeks and like when it's getting
to the point we're gonna like
like potentially like sleep together
well it's just like i either have to
sleep with you or break it off like are
you worth like yeah like are you worth
me like up in my body count for
yeah yeah because that's kind of how i
think and like i'm like no i don't like
them that much so then i'll like wow
yeah
[Music]
that's what i told him i was honest i
was like i just don't like like you that
much
hey wish you were honest yeah he asked
me why i didn't
i didn't tell him at first but he asked
why and i just like i've just felt
better like connections with other guys
before like where i felt stronger how
how quickly do you know
that you're gonna sleep with somebody
no it's like like i'm talking about not
not sleep with them like the first day
or something i'm like how off that how
quickly do you know once gone on a date
like yeah i'm a [__] this guy
we're gonna have sex
because i think women know quite early
okay
i'm kind of different though i'm weird
because if the guy is too hot like i'm
super super attracted to him like i've
historically
in the past rejected him
if i'm like really
yeah this is like every guy that i've
like ended up liking a lot i didn't like
him that much at first
but
i've also never really gone for the guy
that like
i was crazy and i didn't realize it
until later
because it's like a girl's protection
against alpha widowing because it's like
i don't think i could keep up
so you would
sabotage it yeah yeah like okay this is
this is i've explained this to people so
there was a guy a couple years ago that
had i would rank him one to ten he was
i'm gonna tell you i fumbled this bag
okay one two three
yeah he he was probably a nine okay wow
and to me i was just like oh my gosh
he's so out of my league like i i like
and so
yeah i ended up like breaking it off
with him because
i um i just didn't think i i don't know
i didn't think i could keep him so
and and i didn't want you didn't believe
in your own source pearl that's the
thing
no because i don't know i just thought
he was
he was like six seven light skinned i'm
like that was trouble trouble oh yeah
well you thought that he like broke yeah
you have like he's picking women yeah
yeah and i was just like
but did he like you
i mean yeah well this is what i find i
didn't know it then but
it's funny because the next girl he
dated he actually ended up getting
engaged to
oh wow she looked like me
yeah i know and he told me later i like
caught up with him and he's like no i
probably probably would have been you
like there if you i know
i don't know and i was like oh damn i
said wait wait wait no i am wait wait
let's just go back let's go back i mean
who knows maybe he was just telling me
that like i don't know nobody
but you could see that the girl looked
like you though
yeah and i was just like oh [__] do you
guys do that like if they don't get the
one they want they get a girl that looks
like the second best um it doesn't it's
not exactly like that it could be like a
tight
you'll find that you dated one girl and
then the next girl looks
very similar
do you know what's funny if you were to
go through my like relationship history
you wouldn't find a similar
not even two you wouldn't you would you
wouldn't find like
two like i don't have a look that i go
for
it's like because people are like oh
what's your type i'm like if you were to
look at like my past girlfriends you
wouldn't think you'd think okay that's
the first one
and then you'd look at a second and you
were like she doesn't look like that one
you look at the third one like she
doesn't even like the second or the
first one it's like so i don't know i
don't have that thing where i'm like
trying to find the type
yeah i'm similar but like i realized
that
with
the last few like they've all looked
quite similar oh really
you got a tight ish
not i wouldn't even have the top
if you're with a girl and she looks at
you like you know girls have to look at
your ex-girlfriends and [__] and compare
themselves so
if she looked at your ex and looked at
herself do you think she'd feel a little
bit paranoid like oh my god like no
no no
i've only had one girlfriend you've had
one girlfriend yeah okay i've dated
how long was that
uh eight months
wow okay
i don't know if people don't know how to
bloody keep a relationship nowadays
i was in my first year of uni
all right fair enough
fair enough i'm like when i say people
when i tell people i was in like a
10-year relationship like what 10 years
well you're also older than all of us
yeah but i but i also think
i don't know if the generation coming up
after me are able to hold down
relationships well yeah hypergamy's on
steroids yeah it really is
yeah this generation like
it's like microwave
yeah relationships looks michael b
jordan just done with laurie harvey and
everyone thought oh my god that's great
that was like a year and a bit
yeah
she saved him and she said
she saved him back to the trees
[Music]
she we all knew she was for the streets
and
it's almost as if he didn't get the memo
the streets are coming she tried to save
her
and
she was like no i don't want to be saved
when what she could have done was don't
save her thank you
hand in marriage
taking the ring
then messed up his life did they get
engaged no she left that's why she she
left because i think he
posed i don't know if he proposed but i
think it was like the thought of
marriage that's what
how did she though
25 i think someone said don't save her
she don't want her
don't save him
[Music]
how old is he
he's like must be 30 now at least right
32.
okay i think she knows but i i
personally don't think that people
really should i know it like
kevin samuel spoke about like getting
married quite young in your 20s
but the way the world is going right now
you don't really know who
he's 35
you don't really know who you are taking
and around your 30s
so i'm like do you really want to get
married before
[Music]
you know who you are
i would like to you would like to like
do
but you don't think you know here or to
your 30s like that's just my experience
like i don't think you kind of know who
you like like who you really are until
you like get into like 30 29 30. really
i feel like i've always been the same
person
like i feel like who was at 15 it's like
you're 25 now yeah do you think you'll
be thinking the same at 35 yeah
that's what i thought like
seriously that's what i do i feel like i
was the same like even i was talking
earlier i was like i always knew
that
like you would be doing something like
this yeah like i always knew i'd be
doing something like that this that i'm
talking about like as a person like who
in your being like the things that you
accept the things that you don't accept
the things
i think things change
would you say sarah told me to i'll wait
till post wall to settle down
i mean i know it's like not
where's my beta
but i'm just like this is what i have
experienced i think people are
i think i think i don't think you know
who you are to like your 30s [__] about
you sarah all right you can talk about
me go for it
are there any lovely ladies in the
picture
yeah
you got a female yes sir
the silence says yes oh so there's a
there's a special lady there's a miss
sarah garvey
no there's a mystery recovery sure no
are you sure
i'm very sure there's a missing mister
i'm kidding nothing
there is
there are potentials
[Music]
there's just potentials and it's whether
or not i choose but the thing is like i
said i've been
single for what like three years now
any front runners
at the moment no
no no front runners i kind of keep
myself to myself if i'm totally honest
like
people like people don't like to believe
it they're like oh my god your dms must
be like blowing up blah blah blah and
i'm just like yeah but sometimes i just
can't be bothered
right you're just like busy
yes i've got a lot going on like
literally i came from dropping my son to
school to here
do you know what i mean i've got stuff
to do like you know like i've got a
whole
life to live someone said sorry got a
rotation
[Laughter]
people laugh when it's true
listen you can't prove anything do you
know what i'm saying the most girls
you've juggled in a rotation at one
point
three three okay i've heard that and
that was in my 20s i've heard that three
is the perfect number because if one's
annoying you you can go to the other and
then another's annoying you you can go
to the other i won't lie right in my
like in my like late 20s when i was like
between relationships let's say um
yeah there were like three girls
there were like three girls and i would
like spend oh my god i would go like one
friday
and then stay over to the saturday
i'd have like a little night bag i'd go
to
the second one on saturday
and spend the night there and then
go to another one on sunday oh wow and
then like spend the night there and then
go to work
[Music]
do you okay
did you hurt their feelings did they
find out about each other
um no they never never because it was it
was a casual situation i didn't have
like girl they weren't my girlfriends
they knew what it was yeah like we were
just sleeping together like yeah this
great this caribbean man
whatever no it's just like i mean this
was like
20 i was like 27 maybe like 27
and like
yeah i was just like why not do you
think men hit a wall too
if so what age
i can't imagine a man at 60 has the same
options as a man at 35 no i would i
would say probably into the 50s maybe in
the 50s you think men hit a wall maybe
but the thing is even 50 year olds can
still bag like 30 year olds yeah do you
know what i mean so it's like i don't
know
i think 35 is like the most attractive
age for men around there really in my
opinion
there's some attractive older man oh no
i think like yeah i'm not you're talking
like
majority you get the more you you know
that yeah
i just noticed in general like men their
looks kind of start to like
like they'll usually stay in a little
bit better shape than the women at least
in the u.s like a little bit thinner but
like they still start getting the dad
gut in their 40s usually
we're like
like i mean some guys don't and usually
more of like the top guys that don't but
yeah i'm just talking about like in
general
yeah
so
i think um people tell me that i look
like sometime i look 32 the other day i
was like i'll take it yeah yeah yeah
i mean i'll take it you look young i'm
right no i'm 41. okay folks i'm 41 years
old
i don't think i don't think i look for
you i don't
you don't
at all black don't crack period
someone said i look 24 and i said i'll
take it yeah thank you jess has gone
they love her hair
yeah i like your hair today thank you
thank you everyone's been complimenting
the hair in the chat i appreciate it it
wasn't working so
this is what i got but i appreciate
thank y'all
yeah what we got you know i said i said
i think what really killed kevin samuels
was screwing a girl over 30.
someone said he came into the world
naked and he left this world naked i was
like oh my goodness i mean
what's wrong with a girl level 30 no
nothing like but i'm saying that was
this whole thing like 30 years they're
at 30 you're half off
yeah but i mean he was i know it was he
was having sex with him
but it was just a joke yeah yeah but no
it's like
as someone who's a little bit older like
you do want someone you can
definitely have a conversation with
and someone who's quite young
in their 20s
okay if you were to get remarried what
would the ideal age be
if i were to marry like probably 30
okay 30 30
in 31 32 yeah that's what i've heard
from guys yeah they still are like they
still look good yeah but they're not
you know but they've learnt enough
what are they what could you could you
marry someone like me or pearl
and since we're not 30. yeah
because you display you've got some
intelligence
and that's the thing for me like a woman
like
a lot of guys like bimbos and that don't
know anything but i want to have a
conversation yeah do you know what i'm
saying i want to be able to have a
conversation with a partner it's just
like
like there'll be no dummy out just yeah
you're like just oh my god i love
shopping and i love shiny things okay
all right fine
i find it really hard to relate to
people my age because like
i'm just not into the same things as
them usually i feel you on that
like what are they normally into
clubbing
out being super drunk
yeah
and and you're just not
i just like doing youtube
my homebody i'm like i like sitting here
debating about stupid [__]
it's not stupid [__] man it's a real
[__] it is very educational you are
saving lives
no it is it is really educational but i
mean sometimes it's stupid [__] let's
just get your ice bucket challenge
you know do you know what is really
stupid [__] that i
yesterday for the first time in two
years i turned my tv on my tv's i don't
watch tv
right
for the first time for the first time in
two years i turned my my tv just on the
wall with i i don't use it
no no i clean it
like
[Laughter]
sorry what's that it said i was shouting
all over the place no no they're
shooting shooting like shooting yourself
oh
i can't read
i'm tired i thought you said i was
shouting because i was just no no
so
pulling off from half court no i'm
kidding i got it i got to know if the
older men would date me do you know
what's on tv
what okay do you know what what
advertisements were yeah what
poor children
animals poor animals help the children
help the animals buy something
or do you have some kind of illness
wow like i was watching it i was like
why are all the advertisements so
[__] negative mm-hmm how was it i got
turned to [__] oh i turned it off after
like an hour yeah i couldn't watch it
because all of the stuff i was i felt
like i was being brainwashed or
something i was like is this what tv's
like now this is what they're
advertising
which is why youtube is so great because
you just get to watch
the stuff that you want to watch yeah no
sometimes i'll i'll take pride in them
like i never watch tv shows then i think
about how much youtube do i watch no but
youtube is you being in control of what
you watch
no i know do you know what i mean like
we're actually in control like that's
what that's why netflix is so popular
sometimes i miss my feed from before i
did red pill stuff because it's so hard
for the algorithm to give me anything
else now
really yeah because i reacted to it for
so long true so do you watch your old
stuff
do i watch do you watch your old stuff
like your old youtube stuff or your old
like tick tock stuff i don't i don't
know about you as a content creator but
some of my old stuff makes me cringe
yeah because as the content gets better
you're like oh i can't watch it you were
like is that what i used to do yeah
is that what i used to say oh god yeah
no i get that but you have to grow you
every you know everything's a process
mom
no i know
and we're gonna oh my gosh i'm so
excited to react to when just first came
on the show oh goodness
i think this week probably when did you
first come on how long ago was that came
on brainwashed and i un-brainwashed her
you're talking about podcasts
that's what this yeah is about i love
killing women that's like what i love
doing
because i i feel like i've done this
sort of behind the scenes for like more
conservative value stuff just like like
that's why
like i've just always done this to girls
like where i'm like no the pickup
doesn't exist and like stuff like that
that's crazy the pay gap does exist
there is such a thing men get paid more
in every which way in every industry
all right so what what double standards
have you spoke about double standards
oh yeah we talked about the prison like
men go to jail three times
women march the women complain about
inequality but they don't complain about
it when it doesn't benefit us like we
get into bars for free we get free
drinks
um but we don't talk about men go to war
they're the first off the boat or the
first um
the stay on the boat when it's sinking
yeah like last off the plane yeah
um we just reacted to what matt walsh's
um oh what is a woman what is a woman
um and i really want to see the whole
documentary have you seen it jess no
what is a woman no matt walsh is asking
that question what is a woman so he's
gone to like
trans um he's gone to like
doctors who do like reassignment
he's gone to like people within that
congress
other doctors and he's asking that what
is a woman
me and paul like done a reaction and
this one
that's gonna be a funny one
this is the lady that he was interviewed
man like i don't know what's going on
with the left but
they're nuts i want to get your thoughts
on this we had a
really cool guy come on earlier his name
was doug
and he um
he asked me a question about uh michael
b jordan and
he asked about
what exactly ish did he ask him
you're too tired
you too time for this jess let me it's
right so
diet asked if she was falling
she was falling asleep i was just in la
la land um so we had a guy asking about
michael b jordan yes and black women and
black women oh and he was basically
saying exactly what he said
please
don't come for me chad i'm tired but
more so than anything i think he was
asked he was saying that
um
laurie michael b jordan is going to get
a tough rap if he goes or diverts away
from black women as in the dating realm
because
um
they were they were talking about our
black love and how empowering yeah will
he
will
black women like
his
hurt his like market value yeah would
you mean if he goes to another black
woman no if he go to a white woman
michael b jordan doesn't need anyone but
hollywood
he makes movies
in my personality he doesn't need black
women white women doesn't need it he
just needs people to employ him in
hollywood and
he's doing in my personal point of view
he's doing a great job of it it would be
so it's like
people are attaching themselves to this
star saying oh
i want you to
show me something other than just being
in a movie like i said you know like the
guy's an actor he's a paid actor that's
all he's got to do um he can love who he
wants do you know what i mean like
why do you think
black men
don't
don't date
or
marry black women as much
now as we saw like back in the day um
because i think a lot of black women
have taken that from that
and feminazi pill
and i think a lot of black people
ah yeah
they were taking that feminazi pill and
a lot of black men just ain't here for
it
what's a feminazi pill so is that you
know it's that extreme form of feminism
is that extreme form of i don't need no
man
i don't need a man for anything i'm
independent blah blah blah it was pushed
it was pushed throughout society but
black people are very like musical
people aren't they so it was pushed
through a lot in the music ah
do you know what i mean like if you
listen to black music women push that
[__] i indeed
amazing
it's just that oh you know what they're
doing so it's like we ain't down for it
like me personally i prefer black women
all of my partners have been black
my son's mom's black
um
like i i like black women and i always
have been with them but
i can see why men are just
black men are opting out
i can see why
but
um
mike will be
michael b jordan he doesn't have to
he just needs to live his life yeah i
think
we can't attach and i've always said to
people like people always have something
to say about people's relationships
always and that's just relationships in
general like people always got time to
say i'm like just be the change that you
want to see
if you want to see black love create it
yeah i did it with my when i was in a
relationship like with my son you know
what i mean if people see it and if they
don't see it that's on them but i know i
became the change that i wanted to see
do you know what i mean and it's just
like i think people should stop worrying
about other people's relationships and
be the change that they want to see
yeah you know what i'm saying
i don't think so
i'm saying
listen i am the least tiredest one here
we are
[Music]
drink a red bull i'm alive in fact
that's a good look there you go
there you go
don't
and
half of a monster so
i've had a lot really so there
there was times i was i was twitching i
don't know if the camera caught about it
i'd just be like is that red bullet this
is like oh my gosh i'm going crazy and
i'll just start laughing and i'm like
i'm not drunk i'm just exhausted
um there'd be some moments i'd be like
we're really doing this guys and i just
look at ish and pearl i'm like we're
really doing 24 hours are you breaking
some kind of record i don't i don't know
is anyone done like a 24 hour
live stream on youtube before
youtube
not halfway through an hour before the
12 hour walk
so then we had to just start again
well it's still it's still 24 hours
okay
well you got you might be breaking some
kind of record here
hey you guys could be witnessing history
right now
y'all may be a part of history you guys
could be witnessing history right now
well at least i can say i was a part of
history yes you can say your part is
longest stream on
youtube yeah google that
longest live stream i'll say longest
longest live stream on youtube because
people actually want other platforms
don't they mm-hmm
but on youtube yes pro switched it up
i was switching up
yeah i was saying pearl like is this is
this history
has anyone ever 24 hour live streamed on
youtube before oh i'm sure there has to
have been someone plus we had to break
it up into two because youtube stops it
at 12. yeah h was saying
youtuber holds a new guinness world
record for having
268 hours of live stream i don't know if
that's executive
okay hold on okay we're on 2400
that's 200 what longest live stream
video
oh ish can i get some pizza
yeah we got a lot during the
livestream how did you do that if you're
only
maybe they changed it
do you want to say right in the middle
oh we have
your friends coming back
in the microwave microwave
you gotta do old school uh we have like
wood and fire you gotta rub your hands
together
we are cave
people in here
um
how many people are in their life
like 300 oh still yo they've been
tripping with us
thank you everyone for tuning in yeah
thank you guys
i'm starting to feel awake again i know
i knew if we got through the morning
like if i knew if we made it that
morning that was horrible
that morning it was
whoa
guys we met we made it
we're here
or it's eleven twelve one two three
okay we still got ten hours oh
he's kidding i know i recognize it huh
it was on my uh my phone oh okay look
how baby he is he's got big cheeks i
know
then look at him now baby cakes you just
don't know i'm gonna
those
yay buddy
something like that
i like it
everything tastes better with chili
flakes man
[Music]
what else we talking about in the red
pill sector
so you guys are about to see me eat on
camera so uh
yeah no luck bang you've been watching
us mukbangs
[Music]
this is
my nephew
i don't know seeing
these kids and prime mark the other day
wailing and screaming i'm like my eggs
have disintegrated they're dried up no
because i will backhand a kid real quick
you acting up like that in the store i
don't condone abuse but
not but um
if you were to have kids how many would
you want
in a perfect world like if i could like
push a button i would want
twins for my first pregnancy boy and
girl and then everything's getting shut
down after that not having any more kids
i want seven boys
i'm like dead ass i know you are
i know i know you gotta get started go
for it what if you had a seven would you
what if you have seven girls would you
try for seven boys
nice i just take the l
i just take that one move on what if
your husband was like i really want
seven boys
my husband wants to keep trying but i'm
just thinking i'll be probably too old
not if you pop them out trust
well i thought you can't get pregnant
after the first year because you
breastfeed
so if you like that's what my mom told
me um that if you breastfeed it's really
hard to get pregnant in the first year
and most of the people that and i would
want to breastfeed my kids because it's
like better for them
i'm not sure i feel like my friend
uh that i went to college but she popped
hers out like back to back to back
if i like if i could i want them to be
back to back to bed yeah
like a year and a half two years apart
oh two years i should have laughed at
you
or do we like do like nine months you
have the kid next nine months you have a
kid
yeah i'm trying to get it get him moving
she said i'm trying to get it cracking
i'm trying to the closer i have okay
that i think about this about that shoot
up the club it's okay
they have to be
ah that makes sense
if i'm driving them to practice if i
make them closer together they can all
go to the same practice that is true
like you gotta you gotta make all your
kids do the same sport
are you smart because like then you're
only going to one place
my parents spent so much time because we
went to all different sports so she had
to do it over again she would have made
us be like rollerbladers
skater that's cheesy because i didn't
keep skating for a summer she's like i
would have made you stick to that
that's funny
so you see with
serena is dad
have you made them both play tennis
something like that you see him
yeah
yeah would you be that mum that would be
like all right you're gonna be like a
professional athlete this is what you're
gonna do for your career well for a girl
i'm like good luck there's not much
money
for the most part um
no i mean i always my dad always told me
to like
do what you love and the money will come
that's that's like always what my dad
told me so
because you're gonna be able to work
harder at it than everyone else because
and he also told me not to wait to do
what i love because a lot of people like
wanna wait but they waste the time when
they're the most energetic and have the
least responsibilities
so
he said like if you want to like build
something to it while you're young
because a lot of people wait till
they're older and then they have kids
and they have like these other
responsibilities so just do it as young
as you can
if you want to like take a big risk do
it now that's what he always told me
so like a 24-hour livestream
that's a big
yeah i don't know
we're doing one every month guys
i'm playing i'm playing i'm playing i'm
playing no no if we did it again we'd
have to we had no it would be different
you're gonna do eight hours sarah i'm
gonna do eight hours and practice like
each of us yeah
damns
we could do competition so you can get
the most super chats yeah i like that
what do we do can we do anything to get
super chats hey
within reason
you guys will
definitely cat
i'll show a little cap
i'm kidding not not if you can get you a
feminist on here
bring chess bring back tesco yeah i know
cheska bring back chess i i think about
i seriously think about pain or like 50
to 100 bucks to come back because i
think i'd make my money back you for
sure would yeah i know but because she
kind of i told her i'm like jessica
like
you can clip him the same way i mean
like so she was angry at me oh yeah
she wasn't mad at me because you're the
one like clipping the
i mean no look at she she you gotta own
your own words i i didn't make her say
what she said i'm sorry i agree i'm not
we're all the same but i'm saying like
if you if you were confident in what you
said you could post it on your channel
too
like you could clip it and just you know
make a title where you look bad and like
put the same thing
if you really feel like you were right
but she's very entertaining so i was
like
i told her i'm like you just gotta play
it the other way
but yeah she didn't she didn't want to
come back you guys bullied her off the
show i'm not gonna lie guys
no
[Music]
did we get any more members
jessica 2022
what i said hashtag cheska2022
true love is
yeah at 200k we'll do another 24-hour
live yo i thought about that when i went
to the bathroom earlier yeah each 100k
would do
yeah i can't
he's fading it's just like guys what are
we doing our quarterback the whole time
yes he's been he's been the one holding
it together better than anyone else
not
not so much me and jess we were dying
yes
it's not my turn
to die
but i'm gonna stick with it no one's
dying you're just gonna sleep that's all
no one's dying
have you ever heard of stephen crowder
if so would there be a video of you and
stephen crowder having a discussion yeah
if you wanted to it's so be down
guys sign up for memberships we're gonna
do some exclusive yes behind the scenes
content yes
and if you
again if you were here
on the live it gets wild here this whole
time you get
special special merch
it shall be there
only if you sign up as a member
be exclusive
so sign up if you
[Music]
if you don't sign up and you see people
supporting it posting it on the gram
posting it in the community and
um we'll actually do that if people
dm us
the picture of the merch that they buy
the secret merch on the membership we'll
post it and be like huh should have been
the membership should have been in the
live to get this exclusive merch
it'll be
i've got a question
that doesn't include pearl because we
already know pearl's answer okay growing
up
was there a relationship
between a man and a woman that you
idolized and said
that's the type of relationship that i
want
yes
who was it it was my youth pastor and
his wife wow yeah
what was it about it
it was just like
whenever they they just seem like till
this day they still seem like very very
happy with each other like they just
love
being around each other and he just i
could tell he didn't do like outrageous
stuff
that i saw but just the way that he
interacted around her and just like
talk to her
i it was just
yeah the best way to tell that he loved
it yes the way that he interacted with
her i could just tell that he loved her
and that he then that she loved him and
it was just like wow
like that's something that
i want
do you think it's better for you
as a woman to love the man more than he
loves you or vice versa
i
or do you think it should be equal
i don't think it'll always be equal i
hope i love him more than he loves me
right
yeah i don't know girls don't really
like guys that put you on a pedestal
um
yeah i i've made the mistake of loving
someone more than they love me didn't
work out well yeah
i
i think guys
should understand that they have a duty
of care
and your duty should never trump your
feelings
and so therefore finding yourself in a
position where you love someone so much
where your feelings compromise your duty
will lead you into a place where you
will start simping for a girl yeah
correct she won't see you as the alpha
that you need to be or the leader of the
household or even just respect you
i agree
and then you find yourself being yeah
yeah i think the woman should love
the
guy more it's not like
she's all the way up here and he like
doesn't love her but i think they're the
woman should have love for the guy more
yeah i just found when i was in like
it was like my first relationship i was
just like
i feel like i love this woman more than
she loves me because the guy can tell
yeah
you'll be like no and then you'll think
about it you'll be like yeah you
actually do like me more than i like you
and it's
yeah like i just felt like [__] i'm
putting in a lot and she's not putting
in that much
so yeah i would
definitely want a girl to love me more
than i love her which doesn't mean i'm
gonna take advantage or anything but
it's just like something that you like
you know
because i think you know women need to
kind of be told no sometimes and i think
sometimes when you're
too loving you don't know when to say no
no because i was saying it makes us
question you guys judgment because we
look to you for logic like we know we're
crazy
we know damn well that we are crazy
and so we
if a guy is like
like the best thing you can do when a
girl's acting crazy is just to be
unbothered and ignore it like i i yeah i
hate this but like you gotta treat girls
like children because
like sometimes we act like it and when a
guy is like
like fighting with the girl like playing
like playing with her games and doing
all that [__] like it makes us lose
respect i'm not saying it's right but
it's just like yeah sometimes we get
hormonal you know you know i've noticed
with women right it's like like
women and men argue differently right
yeah so it's like
what i learned and i was in like a long
relationship what i learned is that
women
tend to argue
and if they're not getting the reaction
that they want from you
they'll just say some flagrant [__]
like they'll try because they want to
get an emotional response do you know
what i mean so you're they're not
getting the response that you want so
okay maybe i'll just go up a little
level you know what i mean and say
something else and it's like go below
the belt yeah that go below the belt and
it's like what where the [__] did that
come from do you know what i mean yeah
we were talking about that earlier um
yeah daniel was like his dad told him
never to tell a woman your deepest
darkest secrets not even your wife
because she will use that against you in
like a serious moment
like okay so yo do you think you'd do
that
i wouldn't because i wouldn't want
someone to do that to me like if we're
in if we're in a heated argument and i
thought yeah that's why your daddy left
you when you was five and he don't talk
to you no more i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna throw that out cause it
has nothing that's so mean yeah and i it
has nothing to do with what's happened
but you want them to feel
hurt
just even worse than you and it's just
like i wouldn't want someone to do that
to me i want to be able to confide in my
partner if i tell them one of a deep
dark secret i don't want to come back
and slap me across the face because
they're
angry it happened to me
once in a
situationship or
relationship that i was in where i told
the partner
an insecurity of mine
and like months into the relationship we
got like
we didn't really argue too much but like
we got into an argument and
it was brought up
and i was just like wait a minute did
that just happen and it was only after
the argument like when we were trying to
like reconcile i was like
you brought that one thing up
and she was like no never ask you
wow hold a minute
yes you did
um and it was like okay
that's when i learned that
i had to start understanding female
nature
and like the rules are just different
and i was just like okay
i need to understand that i can't
certain things that i would feel
very compromised or problematic about i
cannot be sharing
like my
my my fear i shared my fear my fear was
like
i grew up without a father
right my father wasn't there so my whole
thing was oh my fear is when i do become
a father
is to be like my dad and like leave my
children and stuff so i was like i'm not
gonna do that never i don't care i don't
care if i had a child with a crack [__]
i'm not gonna leave the child
and like
when i did break up with like my son's
mom it's one of the first things tried
to say oh so you're not gonna see him
enough aren't you going to be just like
your dad
i was like
[__]
she she
like cheated right yeah yeah wow
so
she
like the audacity of this woman
the audacity i was like
don't do that
do you know what i mean but yeah people
use your weaknesses against you
sometimes
no i've never really
i've never even seen anyone do that ever
actually
i've heard a lot about that like i've
heard that from guys but i've really
never
seen someone do that
yeah because if you like confide to me
i'm like okay cool you've confided him
i'm gonna use that [__] against you
yeah
i mean that's not the type of person i
am anyway but i think women who do that
are
the scum of the earth
they're
just
trash
i
hate it
i hate to see
women
just
i don't stoop that low and try to
diminish
someone when they confided in them and
knowing that
men don't usually do that and when you
take that and you use it against them oh
i
hate it so pearl do you see the other
day when i posted that um
you reposted my uh
the thing that i wrote about women being
in toxic relationships
um
so i wrote listen a lot of women say
that they were abused
but they were just in a toxic
relationship
they were doing some [__] he was doing
some [__] they used to abuse each other
verbally probably they both got violent
with one another and then they come out
and say oh you know what my ex was
abusive and
it's like stop lying
you were in you were in a toxic
relationship yeah it's not like
one-sided and i think
women know how to tell those stories
yes to make it seem like it was just a
guy like even the other day when um
the lady was here and we were doing i
was on the gray area pearl and she was
talking about her abuse and stuff i was
just like
i don't know if i necessarily believe
everything
i don't know someone in yeah
we got a new we got new meat we got
fresh meat yeah
ellie stay out
fresh meat
ellie's like
oh so you could park at the tesco and
take the train one stop down that's
where we park
because we i don't know
oh yeah sorry
i just paid for parking
oh you can pay for it yeah yeah just
down the road you can pay the view if
you can find the space
buy the um let me come out
yeah
it's hitting me again jess is it oh no
all right
i think i've got over that threshold
look at this picture
i found this beautiful chocolate man
on the internet
i said who this sexy beast right here
let me show you
oh did you say that
yeah you can park in the asda and you
take the train one stop down and your
wreck aliens reach
it's like closer than you think
he popped up on my instagram i was like
oh
i know that ma'am
it's a beautiful chocolate man
you know what that's from
uh yeah right now white chicks
it's okay
oh there's a super chat
so again
mr d
hey
ah
are you going to eat your crust no let
me have it
yeah i was lucky enough to find a space
and just pay for parking so
we good
are you sure she's trying to stay up
trying to break kind of break dance
behind the camera boy
listen you guys are troopers for this
man you're soldiers for this
you must have fallen asleep at least
once no no
you look like it now though
[Laughter]
pour water on me again
where's the ice
ice bucket ice bucket challenge now
okay
truth or dare
um
truth
because i ain't about to be like taking
off my clothes and [__] no i wouldn't
have done it
what is the most savage thing you've
ever said to a girl
um
it was a remember when i talked to spoke
about jesus cop blocking me yeah he said
that i just said i said go be with your
boyfriend jesus
i told it to go and be my boyfriend
jesus
yes
so
huh
sorry
um i was with a girl who was like very
heavily like religious
and um
it just became a problem
even though i wasn't and she would
always be talking about god and jesus
and stuff and i was like you know what
just go be with him
you don't need me like you just go be
with him because you die you ain't got
time for you to be talking about another
guy all the time around me so uh yeah go
do it
that's probably the most savage thing i
think
they said you're rethinking your life
what's the most savage thing that's been
said to you bro bye guys
[Music]
nothing that crazy i don't think wait
what did
what did she say to you i wasn't here
what was the most average thing said to
you that was said to me
um probably the thing i'd said about um
you're going to be like your dad oh
that's probably like the more savage oh
okay
oh oh actually no actually i have a lot
to pick from now that i think about it
um
[Music]
what's the most savage being said to you
jess
um
and then the most happy thing you said
to somebody oh i said to somebody um
yeah we got fresh meat up in here yay
hello hello
morning morning um the most average
thing said to me
was um
i uh
i got a text from this dude and it said
like it's over but then he was like oh i
accidentally typed that
but um
it was like you know how when you text
something like the letters if they're
like next to each other you'll
accidentally type something different it
wasn't easy
yeah it wasn't even close to being like
that
and so i was like you know what i think
we should just and he was like i'mma
treat every girl after you like a dog
like you treated me i was like sir how
did i treat you like a dog and you were
broke and i was doing everything huh how
did i treat you like a dog
actually
not it makes sense so what was the most
savage thing that you said
to someone
be honest
i i don't know
oh i guess this is the most happening i
said
if i i told someone if i were to
like continue to talk to you it would be
a it would be mental prison
that's pretty savage yeah
yeah what's the most savage thing you've
ever said to a man
microphone please
yeah
no
i think that one might be off yeah well
okay hello yeah i can hear myself now um
i'm quite nice i try to be diplomatic
um
i think i just
i know
i don't know you know really i'm not a
person all right as some someone said
like a really savage thing to you then
in the relationship break up or
something like that
not really because i'm quite diplomatic
so
if i'm gonna break up and it's like
unreasonable the most unreasonable thing
i did was
kind of like just post the keys through
the little box and disappear off the
face of the earth
and i don't you know like it takes a lot
for me to
be angry
and be annoyed
so my silence says everything
that kind of thing so i'm not a person
that would
be savage and start casting you out and
that's not really my style
so
fair enough yeah
ish
the most savage thing you've said to a
woman man
um
i don't think i've ever been savage to i
had
a savage thing like you're smiling go
ahead no i had a savage thing said to me
right okay so like back in the day when
didn't really understand women um
[Music]
met
i don't won't get into too much story
but
the ending of that situation was a bit
messy
um and
she was just like yeah
i didn't want anything from the start
blah blah blah
like yeah leave me leave me alone
whatever i was like what
but
we were talking i was so confused but
yeah it was kind of
yeah it was a bit wild
yeah but i learned a lot from that but
so you've never been a savage
you have an indie to be savage
i'm what we i feel like if he gets
pushed no i'm what we call an unassuming
[__] boy
wait oh what wait say that again he said
he's an unassuming [__] boy you better
say that with your chest so he does have
hoses oh no no no no no i don't have
hoes i don't have you better say that
with your chest ish
he has concubines
i'm just oh you didn't deny it
he has concubines i don't have
concubines i don't know what concubine
is
don't know what that is i i'm just it's
a glorified hoe
i've not glorified her no no no no
what would your ex say about you oh
i think she'd have nice things to say
about me
okay i think so no i don't really know
who
who broke up with him with the ex
she broke up with me okay classic women
but
it was well the reasoning was she'd
moved to antigua oh okay um to study
medicine and it was long distance so
like she was antiguan no she
she studied
um and then she moved towards hugo to
study medicine and then we tried the
long distance swing and then like six
weeks fair enough he was like yeah like
this isn't working out i said fair
enough is what it is
so then yeah
what would your ex say about you
what good or bad
uh bad he would say yeah if she's hungry
leave her there alone
and
be direct i like directs when when guys
talk to me directly don't talk around
the bush i hate that
um you would probably say i've got good
sense of humor i take things quite
lightly
so
when i'm serious i'm ultra serious and
when i'm joking i'm overly jokey
um
and
i don't know maybe you'll say i'm too
i don't want to use the word because of
this show but use it very independent
right i don't ask for much i get things
done and i i find it hard to take
compliments i think that was kind of a
deal breaker for us because if he would
do stuff for me it was like you'll not
appreciate i don't appreciate it because
i'm trying to do it myself kind of thing
right so i think he would say yeah
that's the hardest part about dating me
back then i think and i've learned a lot
from it
speaking to the mic oh
sorry
it's too far away put it close right
close to your mouth there you go yeah
like that yeah yeah okay so yeah for me
i think
that was my learning curve allowing guys
to do things for me and
show gestures of love because i found it
quite hard
so he would just say yeah make sure
she's fed if she's tired don't bother
her because i get miserable
when i'm hungry and tired
um
yeah
okay
what would your egg say about you pal
um
like good or bad good and bad all right
that's really good what are the good
things he said about you
um
you know i say i'm very supportive
okay and encouraging
um
[Music]
and like i don't
pick fights a lot he'd always say like i
don't
like i'm not i he didn't use different
words but like i'm not super
disagreeable so like i kind of just go
with the flow okay
he's so i'm a bad cook yeah bad cook yes
i'm a bad cook
are you cooking it up now
and i'm better now i miss out
i've improved a lot this year you see my
chicken yeah chicken chicken cooked
chicken y'all
um
and then
trying to think he'd always say that
he didn't forget how he said this but he
didn't like the way i admitted when i
was wrong
like it was something about the way i
said it because
i would be like
i can't i literally can't remember why
but like
he he didn't like the way i said it
like
is it as if you didn't take any
accountability or something is that what
it was
no because i would say like that was my
own like but it was
i like i wish i could tell you because i
literally like cannot remember could you
show us
no i can't remember
that's what i'm saying like like i just
remember it like
like
when
we like one of the reasons we we broke
up like we were fighting over something
that happened a while ago and i was just
like i i don't
oh i
i remember what it was it was like i
didn't feel like i was wrong about
something and he did feel like i was
wrong about something and i said why
don't we just like agree to disagree
you don't say like i was like okay like
you know you see it one way i see
another one let's just leave it
and he like wanted me always to
like say that i was wrong
and i was like i'll tell you if like i
think i'm wrong but i'm like just being
honest like i don't think i'm wrong
like so i'm sorry if like i hurt your
feelings i really didn't meet like but i
just genuinely don't think i'm wrong so
maybe i'm stubborn fair enough
and so yeah i was like yeah and then i
was thinking about the most savage thing
i ever said he had this song it was
actually pretty good but i'm gonna be
honest his brother like carried this
song and so like when we broke up i was
like your brother carried that
that one hurt him i know that one hurt
how are you gonna say that i worked hard
on this song you only went platinum
because of your brother
jess his brother was a good rapper i'm
not even gonna count
yes
what would your ex say about you good
and bad
um
good
i would say
that they would say i'm very accepting
of um
them are just like just upset up
oh accepting
of
a person's like past or just like where
they are
um
down to earth easygoing
i'm a hard worker
uh
adventurous
what bad would they say about you
um
communication i don't communicate when
i'm like upset i'll get quiet
and it takes me
it takes me a second to
talk about it right okay you just
reminded me another negative that i have
that i don't
like when he would bring something to me
i would think it was stupid a lot
um yeah what do you mean
like he'd bring me a problem and i just
thought it like i thought it was stupid
so that's not even a problem yeah
type of stuff and i think i have this
problem where like
if i don't think something i'm not going
to lie to you
do i mean so like if you like if you
bring me and say hey this is genuine
like i might say i'm like i'm sorry
you feel that way which i know isn't
like good and i'll be like yeah like i
don't think
like i'm sorry i just i still think this
right okay so i think it's like stubborn
like i'm very stubborn mm-hmm
okay i don't give fake apologies
but i think sometimes you probably
should for the good of the relationship
at times
yeah like where's that line i don't know
i didn't i clearly didn't find like
where's that line in relationships where
lies are okay
um
i think when
it's not that important when it's
something small
you you can kind of brush it off and be
like okay that yeah the opposite
but if it's something important to the
person and you know that it will have an
impact on your relationship in the long
run you shouldn't lie about it you
should be transparent all the time
i think lies
have their place
in terms of losing battles to win the
war
so
if
the
lie is a kind of thing to be like all
right there's a bigger picture here so
for example
let's just say
she's having a bad day
and
she's tried to dress up and she's
probably not looking the greatest but
she's really tried you might
i don't know like because then
i don't know i'm just saying
they have their place in some way do you
do you tell your girl or tell a girl
that she's put weight on
i i do i would appreciate it
i would appreciate it yeah you've told a
girl yeah
really yeah and then you were dating
[Music]
yes
how did that come up it didn't how did
it come up you just said you you looking
fat no how to how did it go
it just be like
are you getting a few pounds
oh that's a good question i understand
something when you're telling a girl
that she's gained weight never use the
word fat yeah oh yeah did you see why
yeah you never use the word for never
like if i've had to address that i've
never used the word fat because because
they will tell you that you called them
fat and then you can say that's not the
word i used but in their head is like
the term fat
is like a no-go it's a no-go word yeah
yeah and also like it would be like
depending on how she responds to what
i've said
it will be like let's say if i go oh you
gain a few pounds
and she goes so you're calling me fat
i'll be like no
i like i like the size i i like what
you've done
i'm just saying
this has happened like whether you like
it or not
i'm just pointing out and every girl
knows that they've put on weight
and that's why they ask
do you think i've put on weight do you
think this looks did
it's and if you're honest yeah then they
get upset it's like but you already knew
yeah but i think you knew exactly
i really hope i'm with a guy that'll
tell me when i'm like
i hope i'm with a guy that would tell me
because
like i feel like if your your man tells
you that you get you gained a few pounds
guys don't really notice things so yeah
you notice it like
you must be quite a lot it's time to
get on the treadmill yeah yeah
and i feel like he would tell you out of
appreciation for you no he'd probably
tell you because it in his head he's
going this could be a deal breaker at
some point if you don't stop oh do you
think so hot yeah like in my in like my
first relationship
like
we were together for like seven years
right yeah and she gained some weight in
that time
and then she would say oh do you think i
look fat and i'd be like you've you've
put on weight you've definitely put on
weight do you get what i'm saying
listen when we broke up
that woman slimmed right back down
i was like what the hell is this
a girl that like really values you like
she'll stay in shape
yeah because she's afraid to lose you
mm-hmm like for whatever reason she just
forgot but there is that sense of
comfortability that happens within
relationships isn't there sure sure yeah
if she thinks that or if like one of you
thinks that they're not gonna lose you
then yeah like
it's it's one of those things that it
does happen in most relationships like
it's like oh i've got my partner now
i've got my partner now i'm probably not
going to lose them
maybe yeah i hate people thinking that
they're not going to lose me yeah but
is it
are they correct
because like it no her about cheating
right yeah it's like but then that was
that that was like my last major
relationship she cheated but i was like
well all right well i guess it's time to
go
and it was like did she gain a few
pounds before that
yeah and
you didn't leave her at that point or
didn't i like make it clear that this is
unacceptable or oh no i mean it was
definitely a conversation yeah it was
definitely a conversation how did that
come
this is it yeah and
but i think the thing is that was also
my
um
my mistake because you know when you
have children with somebody yeah you get
into this place where it's like well
this is it isn't it
with each other it's like well we're
both not going anywhere we've got a
child together now do you know what i
mean and it's like that is the
complacency that happens i don't think
you should ever be complete because a
lot of people say oh you've got to stay
for the children you've got to save for
the children it's interesting because um
when you like when you have like
extended family and you go to them you
say okay cool we're having this problem
what do you not think should be done
like you'll go to your mother or your
father and try and get like advice from
people who have actually done this type
of thing
yeah and it's like well you know you
guys have got children together
you know i mean like i heard that so
much like you got the you got the
children like you got
and i was like
okay so is it about the children or is
it about
the relationship or the happiness and it
was it was a hard thing i had to learn
how to navigate that yeah like i had a
lot of people don't know how to navigate
it because i'm not saying it's easy yeah
it's definitely not easy but i'm just
saying like
yeah when you've got like children with
somebody
it's a it's a difficult role to navigate
sometimes you don't know that you're
making the right decision you may think
you're making the right decision because
you've got children involved but it's in
the long run that still may not be the
right decision it may just be about you
just saying you know what peace i'm out
yeah so
i don't know and these ladies going to
sleep now i've had enough yeah
um
five minutes in five minutes don't you
find that when um
people have children men start to gain
weight as well like yeah yeah start to
relax like they start to be see it more
i learned a tactic that some women do
like when
they've got a man that
was at some point highly sought after
right they feed their man
so that he can kind of get a beer belly
or like some sort of gut so that
they don't have the whole competition of
women approaching him
so they're okay with their man gaining
that weight i
this is what i've heard
and i've actually seen it in action as
well so i have seen that where when guys
have kids they start to let himself grow
a bit
i don't know what happened to me at one
point yeah they look proper rough they
go for a rough patch yeah it happened to
me i'm not gonna lie like one of my son
was born all i was in was going to work
coming home sleeping going to her eating
coming home like i was literally like
just working crazy hours right
and i just realized that i'm not taking
care of myself
like i'm literally just like neglect
yeah i was neglecting myself i was
literally just working
to keep the family like unit together
and all this kind of stuff and it was it
just got to point where i looked and i
walked past a mirror one day and i was
like
is that
well that's not you
that's not you bro i was like nah shit's
gotta change yeah so yeah but the thing
is i've definitely done that for at
least like a year yeah like a year and a
half i didn't even care about myself and
i think as well when it's a first child
because you've never had a child yeah
that was like my first my first child
yeah like i was so dedicated to just
anything that just kept that together i
didn't even care about myself yeah yeah
you do see that with guys when they have
their first child they just let go no of
themselves yeah maybe that's a good
thing it shows that they're invested
sorry we got any super chats oh
i can check
i appreciate that
man
these ladies are having a little break
isn't there having awesome they were up
all night honestly i was watching and i
said ah
they've been doing the um the work
cause how many hours is it now at least
we are at 14 hours now oh you still got
another so
hang on
um
right i don't even know where to start
what can you see
i can see
dragon stallion matt butcher sam
onochie
and ryan reynolds yeah just read those
all of them yeah and just human yeah
just
okay just human five dollar super chat
do we have to hold people accountable as
a whole why can't we make the decision
independently whether we want to
entertain someone
or their content
okay
ryan reynolds at 20 20 super chat um
just 20 super chat sam
appreciate that 4.99
the guy in the red hoodie is on point
regulation is key
thank you very much sam um dragon
stallion
1001 10 super chat you're free to say
whatever you want as long as it's not a
crime or in sight crime if people get
offended just don't listen grow a
thicker skin i like that and then matt
butcher has a 10 super chat there's
nothing there thank you appreciation for
that uh matt butcher
uh did you get one from here mac oh let
me double check
not that i can see okay i see one from
ian mack um
so much on this channel which i enjoy by
the way is single people talking
how to be in a long-term relationship i
really think you need to add at the
start age status and longest
relationship
okay we can
we can do it now yeah we can do that now
so age state is the longest relationship
my age is 29 yep my status is single my
longest relationship five years okay
nice okay and i'm i'm 41 um i'm single
and my longest relationship was 10 years
wow um i am 26
i'm single and my longest relationship
was eight months
you're a baby yeah i'm still a baby yeah
but like i learned a lot that that eight
months was when i was about when i was
20. so
ah um i haven't been in a relationship
what did you learn from being in a
five-year relationship
um i learned a lot about myself
um
i think
as i said earlier just being able to
allow men to do outside of my family to
do things for me like kind gestures and
not being so stubborn so when i had
beliefs or i was very on it like that's
my belief and i'm sticking to it and it
can create conflict in a relationship
because you're not being open
and also having the condition that i
have just coming into the relationship
thinking oh this guy don't rape me like
he likes me but does he rape me and just
projecting that onto onto that person so
yeah i learned a lot about myself um
thinking about
how i see myself
and that's not how necessarily how
somebody sees me do you know what i mean
the beauty that the man sees in me i
might not see in myself right and
allowing it to be what it is not
manifesting things that are not
happening
so i did learn that about myself
um do you know i kind of think that
people don't
know about relationship is the logistics
and when i say logistics like for
instance if you're in like a long-term
relationship and you have children yeah
like people don't understand like
logistics meaning how much time we're
going to spend together yeah when are we
going to spend that time together when
the children being picked up when are
they being dropped off who's taking them
like like the whole thing of logistics
within a relationship is a thing when
you actually get into a long-term
relationship and especially if you have
children and i think that one of the
major reasons why
this generation don't do relationships
that was because they don't understand
logistics like they want all the time
with their partner to themselves yeah do
you know what i'm saying and if you
don't spend that time
then it's a problem i had so for me i
had the opposite problem in my
relationship so i'm a person i like to
do things i like to go places i will
fill my day up with things even now i
fill my week up with things
and it was getting that time with my
partner it was kind of like
are you going to spend time with me are
you going to like and then when we did
spend time i messed it up a few times i
could admit that
i'm not even going into that i was
embarrassing but
um
i didn't appreciate that because i'm
doing what i'm doing i'm actually
detracting from the relationship in
itself so i'm guilty of that because i'm
like oh well i'm gonna do this and i'm
gonna do that and i'll see you here
for maybe like four hours i'm not
thinking of the time
but i'm thinking i'll see you on
saturday but if i'm working sunday and
we we so i live in north london they
live in south london there's the
traveling to get there yeah then it's
like
actually
dude sitting there waiting
i think this door was at the door yeah
you can come in is it open
okay
and then just considering that you know
as a like we said the other day men
don't necessarily express their feelings
like emotional feelings so me being like
oh yeah i'll come in three three hours
or something i'm kind of
neglecting the relationship and he's
considering his feelings right so i had
to learn from that because i used to be
like why are you so frustrated about
this i'm coming but just not right now
and i think they were i hate that no no
i hate
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying so just
appreciating that actually this guy does
like me a lot and he's get
okay what i learned is that guys will
show you they love you through gestures
rather than just saying it if a guy
loves you they will show you in many
ways and i wasn't acknowledging those
many ways
and i think
sorry one of the highest values that a
guy can give you is his time 100 yeah
it's not just guys
people yeah people in general time is a
thing man like don't waste it for me of
course but
in the relationship i didn't expect to
waste his time i was just putting time
limits on it so he was like yeah come
today like come today yeah i'll come
maybe four o'clock in the afternoon be
chill but then i'm going to work
so what's that you go i mean so i'm
putting restrictions on the relationship
and because of the distance i think that
added a bit of dimension where it put
strain on the relationship
at the time
and i think because it was maybe my
longest and one of my first fully i
could say solid relationships i didn't
know how to navigate the dynamic do you
get what i mean yeah yeah it's a
learning curve though yeah like you do
you learn like relationships are like a
learning thing yeah i mean people a lot
of people think that they're going to
get into the first relationship and it's
going to be like perfect never
i never had that idea i always had the
idea that
i have to try i think effort is always
necessary in relationships and it must
be not constantly like 100
but you must have effort you must apply
effort one i mean 100 i just don't think
people have
the time to put in the effort nowadays
oh oh
rise and shine yeah dribble
dribble running down the face
yeah i just don't think they um
but it's the same amount of time i think
social social media has made it easy to
make excuses like imagine you're fed up
you're kind of fed up with your girls
you can go online there's a lot of girls
ready to talk to you especially if you
have a platform
oh yeah i mean it's the same looks i
won't lie like it's the same with me
right i can go into my dms and be like
okay cool who's in my dms today type
thing right yeah yeah and that's not
just me being arrogant it's just it just
it just comes with the territory but it
doesn't mean i have to entertain it of
course do you get what i'm saying it
really doesn't mean i have to entertain
it so it's like
you can you can choose whether or not
you want something to take you away from
the thing that you say that you like or
love yeah yeah i'm saying that you can
choose that and
i choose to do this do you know what i
mean like i could be you know i mean i
could be out there with
whatever girls and time consuming
yeah yeah it's just that i choose to do
this it's like
i could do that but then that'll take me
away from this yeah like when i i tell
them because i'm like dad where are your
wives
yeah like more women more problems than
right yeah
and i think i got one headache i don't
need three and i think like for me as a
woman even like online dating i find it
overwhelming talking to multiple people
saying the same things over and over
again but you're not actually getting to
know the person you're just saying
you're hoping that someone's a match for
you and that kind of thing have you have
you been on a dating app but like have
you been yeah yeah i've tried but i
always and because i'm impatient so i'll
pay to be there so i don't have to go
through certain processes like swiping
and all this stuff and then on top of
that
i'll last maybe three days
because i don't it's it's not for me
i've never been on a date and that yeah
it's nice
i don't do dating apps it's not for me
honestly it's just hello hey
what's going on i like your crocs
hey
we got more people
well yay
we got
[Applause]
you got energy listen i feel a little
bit
overwhelmed there's too much estrogen
here oh yeah
there's too much estrogen yeah some
testosterone man
eat
yeah we're talking about dating apps and
if you guys have been on dating apps
before yeah oh i hate dating apps they
give me anxiety yeah that's been on
dating
there's too much do you know what it is
as well there's too much going on like
how do you discern who a person is for a
dating app you know oh hi how are you i
like your picture they're talking to you
on the premise of your image
and as you know as women like we might
use a lot of filters i'm not saying i do
but in general a lot of filters and you
know one thing that i notice on dating
apps on the women's side we like to tell
kind of men what we don't want why are
we on a dating app telling them we don't
want this we don't want that we don't
want this in the profile
um
and then when guys talk to us
it's basically sorry
i'm not asking them it's it's basically
their their whole thing is based on the
way we look so if we don't look like
that in the first place
it's a fail it's yeah but then why would
you like
fake who you are no but you know this is
what how this is what happens in real
life people say i got catfished
because when they meet the person in
real life they're not they don't look
like the image
yeah so why do women catfish
men and women catfish yeah you have fish
do you absolutely it's a confidence it's
a woman thing though generally it's a
woman it's a confidence thing because
obviously you feel like you're in a
dating pool online with a lot of
attractive women and there's an
aesthetic to keep up with
that's all right if you're if you feel
that you don't fit that aesthetic then
you will use filters you will wear like
a lot of makeup you will do certain
things so that you have a chance of
competing do you get what i mean
especially when it's the guy's kind of
selecting you
and then you say yes or no
do you think women just walking around
insecure then
uh a lot of people walking around
insecure of course
everyone has insecurities yeah because
especially how
society is now
you've always been judged on a daily
basis
all the time no matter yeah if you've
got makeup on no makeup on
automatically you're going to judge
someone and then you'll be like oh wait
hold on i shouldn't be judging this
person i don't know them do you forget
what i mean so especially your dating
now like
let me give an example when i go out
and i'm drinking i meet a guy i'm like
oh yeah he looks nice next day
i'm like oh wait
that was not what i saw that was bear
goggles yeah yeah
so you do have that as well and you also
have the aesthetics of the makeup the
shades the jewelry all of that yeah
strip she was like oh wow
so
so yeah
we got a new group of ladies in here
yeah oh new group all right
come on paul you can do it girl
get it ready we're getting ready we're
gonna fly around some red pill truth
okay we're gonna
headphones are back on headphones are
um
okay
so i believe who wanted to talk about
high value men
it was it was me that you mentioned it
okay do you guys know what a high value
man is
um
i'm just gonna say no
not based on the public definition
of what it is so i'd like to know okay
so it's like a coin that kevin samuels
he didn't make up but he made popular
okay um so basically a high value man is
a guy that makes 10k per month and he
must have done this for three to five
years
other men have to accept him as high
value he has a network of high value men
he has a linkedin level of visibility
and he's useful to others in the group
okay
so
um
a common thing in the manosphere was
that high-value men have the right to
cheat
um
i would say that high-value men are far
and few in between so it's a small
percentile of men
um they have the capability to cheat
more
because of their financial position and
position of power
but if they should do that that's a
that's an ethical thing morality thing i
would say they shouldn't i know they
shouldn't but they probably do
and they get away with it because they
have money yeah and i think women who
are with them are willing to accept it
because of the financial benefits in the
lifestyle so without the lifestyle and
the benefits on her side she wouldn't
accept that
so yeah
okay that's the rationale for me so if
you guys got 20 000 a month would you
look the other way when it came to
cheating
20 000 he's not he's not in love with
her it's just it's just some strange
here and there
would you look the other way
20 000 tax-free yeah 20 20k you know
yeah
yeah 20k a month
what's it you can do
first of all no
you can't i can't no you can't he kind
of you can yes
i i couldn't look that otherwise even
thinking about it
i couldn't look the other way just
because i know i can live off of less
than twenty thousand a month
um and i think because of the family
that i come from
i was taught that it's not about
materialism um it's about honoring
yourself
respecting yourself and if a man is with
you and he doesn't feel that he has that
respect for you even though he's saying
oh you know it's just a thing
in myself there's something inside of me
that just wouldn't allow that to go down
okay so you wouldn't you would i would
but i have boundaries what's the
boundaries um i need to understand
everybody needs to be tested first of
all okay this sounds crazy and yeah i'm
a bit crazy but
no it's not i don't think that's crazy
everybody needs to be tested
oh like for st okay that's reasonable
yeah
um
as long as it's not a constant thing
yeah if i have what i also need sexually
and also
if there's no
limits on what i can do with the money
if that makes sense yeah like it's it's
yours yeah yeah so
i mean i would so you can save it
yeah i can save it
i can do whatever the hell i want with
it then yeah
but at the same time saving for an exit
[Laughter]
but um
yeah no i think if it was a situation
but then i say that
if this was me maybe like three years
ago
these would have been
my limits on what i would have said to
do but maybe now
i wouldn't accept it just because of my
personal values and x y and z but yeah
okay
what what about you to be honest i was
thinking about it's like
you know there's a lot of people in
those situations but um
if you're gonna pay me to just be there
then why am i here i might as well just
no no you're the
you're the wife you see you're not just
there you're the mother of his kids your
name's on the house you get you get the
ring it's just a casual thing here and
there you know what culturally that
happens a lot so much so it's kind of
it's the ones i can say oh i'm kind of
used to that like you see a lot of women
that men are just out here got the sugar
babes got the you know the sugar babe of
the sugar babe so
i don't know
because
my thing is you're probably getting
cheated on for free yeah
because it happens like people get
cheated on 24 7 and then they don't even
get the benefits of the 20k
so i mean
but then doesn't that highlight that
you're kind of in the relationship for
the 20k then
are you in the relationship to be with
the man or the money that's that's the
question
a relationship com
encompasses a load of things whether
it's money
love wealth status
um
what else
character like there's many things that
come into what a relationship is yeah um
like you're still the wife he still
loves you it's just it's just like men
crave variety and he says look i make a
lot of money i love you you're always
gonna be the main chick it's just here
and there i might step out from time to
time you'll never know there'll never be
any stds like yeah i can't stop here
yeah so if i can't stop you muzzle
people but at least it's elise is saying
it lisa's like telling you show me the
money
you know
something yeah because it's a team
effort you can see as the relationship
as a business
you could be like okay yeah this is this
is what i am to you this is what you are
to me i can't stop you from doing what
you're doing
so
if you're going to give me an allowance
for the headache yeah cool but you have
to one vital thing is you have to be
clean about it don't be messy don't be i
would get caught here and there and all
my friends can see you doing this yeah
but that's the thing that's one thing
you can't control what the other women
do
so you know if your mind is of high
value and then a woman decides to come
out and say boom i'm in america that's
why they pay it escorts yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you can control she took
pictures
even in that scenario you still have
women that kind of break that boundary
because they start to have feelings if
it's a consistency no not not for the
those girls are professionals
for the right amount of money though
those girls are used to sleeping with
those like that's all just
escorts only then but they're they're
high-end escorts yeah okay that's what a
lot of like rich guys do
they're they're beautiful they're
they're just they're clean yeah and and
you have to like make a certain amount
of money to like actually yeah yeah
because if you think about it it's in
the pop culture the hip-hop culture
already yeah about it like we'll talk
about this area about offset and cardi
why would you cheat on cardi she is she
was a former stripper she's got the
stereotypical body right i can't think
of a lot of reasons
she's she's very loud and can be
obnoxious but you liked her for a reason
but yeah but guys like women for
aesthetic at times you can look at
someone and say you're attracted to them
and as you get to know their
personalities and the facets about them
you realize actually i don't really i'm
not feeling it why why should he be
faithful when she was a stripper
but the thing is
on the flip side he already took an l
because he wiped the stripper yeah
that's a whole element in itself oh for
sure but if well i mean because men want
to be with her like let's not get it
wrong like if you're a stripper no but
that's like a thing a man a lot i'm not
going to say woman a lot of men they
fantasize about a life or a type of
thing but when it comes down to it the
real life scenario they're not built for
it a lot of men are not built for that
they don't have they don't have the
resilience to be in a relationship with
a woman like cardi b where she makes
money yes she has a stripper background
she's loud she's not like a quiet person
who was a stripper she's out there you
know and
and the facets that make her her
stripper past part of her her current
present moment are still at the
forefront do you get what i mean so
not a lot of me
not a lot of men are built for it
and i think in their minds it's like
having a threesome a lot of guys are
like yeah i want it when it comes down
to it can they do it though
the pressure is i was going to say that
um
wow that went left
i've seen it like on not on in my life
but on tv and stuff on those programs
they're like yeah that's my dream and
then when it comes down to it they
couldn't they could check it out too
much pressure
too much pressure i don't know i'm still
a virgin
same he's born again yeah
every week
i was gonna say that i'm
sorry
i feel like if offset did not cheat on
cardi
she wouldn't make certain music which
wouldn't make her certain money
because even when summer walker came out
with her outward before she came out of
her album she encouraged her to do the
album
so that she would make money off it so
again it's like really if cardi b
met a guy who was that good guy that
would treat her right she wouldn't want
to be a stay-at-home wife she wouldn't
want to be
a
stay-at-home mom she wouldn't want to be
she'd she'd get bored and she'd probably
show that she shouldn't
have been she could eat him
if beyonce never got cheated she
wouldn't have a lot of the music yeah
got cheated on sorry if beyonce would
have never gotten cheated on she
wouldn't have a chunk of with the music
that she has
yeah because lemonade was huge
lemonade i think i think someone like
cardi's forever for the streets to be
honest like that's but that's her
persona and that's who she is right
offset signed up for that when he
married her yeah just like if you look
at drake having his child with that
young lady
it it's in a man's mind it's a fantasy
really a lot of men i don't think he was
trying to have a kid with her i know but
he he took it there and the fact that
he's an accident
she probably she probably i i think she
probably did something we already know
for instance this man is a
serial cheater oh i don't know sorry who
christopher thompson who's that
basketball player
i don't know him you don't know about
him actually
yeah everywhere every week something
something something something something
well because cheating makes you more
attracted to a guy
does it really yes yes yes i mean how
many how many girls do you know that
they get cheated on they keep going back
and you're like
and how many of you have ever taken back
a cheater no no it's pre-selection so we
can't undo our biology
so when a guy can get multiple women
we find it attractive it's like what's
worse you got your guy cheated on you or
he tried to cheat and he got rejected
i don't know i have that mentality of
like okay if you go cheat
just be careful one day i'll just
oh if i do it you're gonna feel it
basically so you
it's a weird like well why would you
cheat on
why would you cheat it lowers your value
like a little your body count lowers
your value as a girl so if you cheat
it's just like showing you're less
valuable
so like how i don't understand what
girls like to cheat on what do you think
about it because
in the sexual marketplace guys
they want a woman with a lowest a lower
body count they say that but then also
too you want to go with experience so
for fun for fun they don't want to wife
them they don't put rings on their
finger and if yeah unless you're cardi b
so but things are changing women are
evolving so
but are they but are they evolving
but women are also women are also less
married
so women are getting less rings than
ever
what do you mean by women um it's
evolving what do you mean
we are
noticing things from the past more than
ever and we're trying to let's say push
the boundaries of it so being more
selfish
yeah we'll be more self aware um more
conscious of our relationships our
values
or our
morals and stuff like that so
for instance in the western culture we
are more modern than
anyone else in the third world
so there are a lot of freedom on our
side we can work
as much as we want we can even do jobs
like construction plumbing all those
kind of things now
than probably like 20 years ago 20 30
years ago so what does that have to do
with us
like what does that have to do with the
conversation what do you mean so what
i'm trying to say is like you're
you're not seeing certain things oh
that's gonna take away from my value
it's oh okay that's my experience that's
well it can be it can be your experience
but when you survey men and men say we
prefer women that have slept with less
people
like you don't get to tell men what they
value like men value what they value
there's a man right here is she referred
a woman to make a wife that's got a high
body count a low body count
[Music]
i prefer one with a low body cat if i'm
going to waffle but women
you want a man with sexual experience
question so we're talking about women
and women's body count making them less
valuable yeah
so why is it accepted when men have
such a high body count
because women are attracted to it
it's not it's not about it's not about
being accepted it's about
women deal with it so women want the
guys that have slept with more people
drake they don't they're asking drake
what his body count is they don't care
but that's what i'm saying and why i
don't know ask the women we pick him if
we're in a situation whereby
um women are devalued for having high
body counts
my issue it's not a really issue but the
question i'm querying is like why is it
acceptable like why is it
why is it normal why is it normalized
because it is because men and women are
different
so so biologically women liked a guy
that could get multiple women because
that that takes that's a sign that he
could take care of them i mean
historically
um there was
8 000 years ago there was 17
women reproduced for every one man
so that's like part of history where men
they had to ensure paternity so if you
were ho you're thought around they don't
know if they're giving you a kid that's
yours so they're biologically
pre-predispositioned to be like
disgusted by that and so it's more like
supply and demand
that's what the sexual marketplace is
it's not people telling them what to
like it's just what people like the same
way men are attracted to like thinner
women have you noticed that on that on
the mori show there's no women on there
being brought on to see who the child is
yeah because it came out yeah because it
exactly because and that's what i was
saying because
like the we know children come from
women where if a woman's got multiple
penises inside of her as a guy you don't
know who but we always know who the
mummy is right we all we always know who
mom is right and but we never sometimes
know who dad is which is why we gotta do
paternity testing etc etc so
um yeah women
prefer men
to be
that guy who can sling it around and
then whereas guys don't prefer women to
be that woman that's things around no i
think maybe because of my experiences i
don't want a guy that springs it around
and and the numbers the numbers back it
up because if a man has more partners it
doesn't really affect his marital
happiness not by a lot but if a woman if
she's slept with if she's a virgin when
she gets married she has an 80 chance of
having a happy marriage if you've slept
with more than five people you have a
less than 25 chance of ever getting
married or having a happy marriage just
over five people
so so it's like
because
is that because of the comparison is
that because women are comparing it well
and it's also linked to higher it's
linked to higher rates of depression on
top of that um but and women married in
their mid-20s when they've never lived
with a guy have the lowest rates of
divorce
because could you imagine like if two
virgins got together
that's the ideal thing yeah i do that's
the best actually that's the highest
rates is when two birds get together and
yeah the marriage probably lasts forever
because you don't have anything to
compare correct two this is your
relationship well women are hypergamous
so it's like it's like it goes back to
the alpha widow effect because if a girl
experience a guy that's say she's 22
okay then she she gets with a guy that's
an eight
like one to ten he's an eight in terms
of like status money whatever whatever
she looks for in values then now she's
30 right she's less attractive maybe
she's gained a little weight maybe she
has a kid then she can't get the guy
that's in eight anymore so she ends up
marrying the guy that's a five and she's
always thinking about the guy that's
yeah and so it's not the case for every
woman there's girls that are exceptions
there's girl that's so marry up but
we're talking in general like most girls
don't like the best they can do is in
their like early to mid 20s
there was a there's actually a netflix
um
series that was on i don't know what's
called sex life or something where this
is woman who had this perfect life
and she was married to a perfect man
but prior to being with this perfect man
and having this perfect life with his
perfect children the white picket fence
and the whole thing she was with this
bad boy right and this bad boy was
[__] her down like no one ever [__]
her down right so she's got this perfect
life and she kept on thinking about this
guy she she couldn't get out of her
system and then eventually she went back
and
and and i see it i see like i mean i ask
this question to girls all the time you
ever have a friend that has that one x
they can't get over they might be dating
the new guy or another new guy but they
keep thinking about that one x and i see
it all the time in girls
and
like it's just it's just it's
unfortunate because i think society lies
to us and says there's no consequences
for that but
like there definitely are
i think when women become happy they
become
sometimes yeah i think a lot of the time
they become bored i think
a lot of women just want something a
little bit more
turmoil it's more interesting
curiosity curiosity kills the cat but i
think there's different things that you
can do in your relationship that
stops the boredom no
yeah there are just women often choose
not to do them
because we leave we leave 70 to 80 of
the time if we're college educated it's
a 90. when men aren't the ones leaving
it's women and i think when a woman
sleeps around it's the biggest damage
she does to herself because a man's not
like a lot you can get away like you
move a guy's not really going to know
who you slept with but like mentally i
feel like you can't turn a hoe into a
housewife because she's always going to
want to go back to the streets
and you see it with sierra what happened
with her
like sierra like what would happen she
she marries she's you know going around
with the he's wildin out he has his kid
marries russell westbrook perfect guy
who who here would like
super good he's got everything you'd
want in a husband and now and now he's
he's boring yeah so a lot of women yeah
but i'm saying as a husband great but
like what's she doing now she's wilding
out on instagram shaking her at like how
disrespectful is that this man wifed you
yeah i haven't i haven't seen that is
that what she's doing now yeah but why
would can i just ask why would russell
be boring i don't understand oh i mean
not to us yeah but it's like um some
girls when they just prefer the rappers
and like the exciting
yeah they prefer that exciting guy
that's gonna you know so you're saying
if you were to marry man like russell
and he's he looks conservative and calm
and quiet that you should also replicate
that
if you were someone that was like
not a hoe but
just out there well your partner is a
reflection of you
so it's like if i'm going to get with a
woman and i'm kind of
cool and conservative oh my god is that
sierra now does that sierra in the white
in the blue hair
yeah yeah that's what i was talking
about at the gas station
she looks good though like i think being
a woman she's got a whole husband and
she's got here and then she goes and
she's got kids
and the whole world is seeing that
that's my woman and
everyone can see us sorry i just heard
someone say
she's letting us know that she's got her
what
hush her what [__]
like she's got basically what i'm trying
to say is that
she's letting the world know that she's
a guy i'm a mom she has a wife that
she's at home but you know
so what like yeah you know but you know
it is for me like as a mother you have
to put yourself to the side like you're
a mother now i just i saw the video
and i do believe that you know as a mom
you may say again huh
you know that
you make you make like sacrifices in a
lot of ways and that's part of
motherhood but then it gets to the point
where your child is now grown and
they're their own individual adult so
they didn't want her children up no no
but i'm saying her kids
her kids are her kids are young like her
children are young so what example are
you kind of sitting as a as a mom you
see it now a lot as well with like young
girls and stuff
they got
they've got weaves and nails and
stuff like that sorry i really sit in
here but it's it's i mean it's it's
selfish and that's the thing like modern
modern women are selfish because
because they're putting themselves above
their children and that's what she's
doing you you know you know how
embarrassing that is to have your mom
twerking as a kid even you could be 10
15 like even if i to this day if my mom
put that on the internet i would be so
embarrassed
like you're you're putting yourself
above your kids are you seeing it in a
more traditional aspect
or
i'm seeing it like right and wrong i
don't think it's tradition
she was a regular if she was a regular
woman
people were saying how could she do that
that's that's her wish behavior she
shouldn't be doing that she has kids but
but because she see era i think she
people are giving her more of a pass
what if what is that what if the dad was
going to strip clubs and posting that
post it exactly i mean what would we be
able to do about it i mean nothing but
like that would be that would be
disrespectful it would be disrespectful
like what she's doing there she's
disrespecting her husband attention from
other man what else are you putting that
on the internet the way i see it is
sierra was a dancer
she wasn't just a singer she was
actually a dancer
so
i mean maybe the twerking is a bit
because me as a mother i don't agree
with that i don't even me i don't like
to look wild
like i like to have fun don't get me
wrong but i think there's a level of
why why did you ask me to be out yeah
she could still do like a dance routine
but no i think like
maybe because she was a dancer and she's
a performer it's like people are taking
the twerking as like
she's twerking for attention but
sometimes people don't necessarily twerk
for attention we are grown adults we
know exactly what the internet is like
we know exactly how many people are
gonna watch it we know exactly where
it's gonna go stuff will go viral like
let's not play dumb wait wait do we know
where actual booty shaking came from
beauty shaking i mean yeah do i care yes
yes you should in
because beauty shaking actually if
you're going to see the cultural aspect
it's in our blood it's in our blood like
if i was going to shake my arse now to a
song that is from my tribe
you wouldn't have
but it's about appropriateness
people from here i would say it's more
of a cultural sense people in the states
it's not a culture since that's
something that i've noticed that
in africa it's just
in you and like here you all know where
your roots are from and everything and
it's in you to do that because it's a
part of you in the states it's just
something that oh it's twerking we call
it twerking it's ratchet behavior yeah
and there's a shot away sorry to call
you no no you're good and
it's like we
we look at it as something different and
elsewhere it is a part of the culture it
is like cultural to do that and it's not
it's not un normal to see a little kid
doing it because
it's just
it's not a
sexual dance move for
other cultures but in the states it is
deemed that way but do you know why it's
deemed that way in the states because
when you sorry to say but when you guys
were taken to the states you were
already stripped of everything that you
came with
so
if you came with your culture your
language your your you couldn't even
wear your clothes that you
came with so in reality it's like you
just don't have that culture because it
was taken away from you that's why it
would be seen as wrong
questions sorry um are you ladies saying
that twerking isn't sexual no no no
what exactly are we arguing yeah because
like i think it's not sexual
yeah
because i've seen sierra yeah you may
say she's a dancer and that's fair
enough
um but she's a performer
or
was a performer and she's shaking her
ass and she has kids
and
for me it's like it just reiterates that
you can't wife a hoe because they will
always go back once they've secured what
they need to secure
and like you're you're kind of saying
it's okay no i'm not saying it's okay
you guys because you're making excuses
with that you're saying then why bring
up the culture if it's not an excuse
because my point is i feel like twerking
has become a thing that has become it's
an exaggerated form of
people's culture it's like it's been
exaggerated and made to look bad and
that's why it looks bad on her that's i
mean you won't catch me twerking because
that's just not about me but i'll shake
my ass yeah i'll enjoy my dance but
different i just feel like
it's when when it comes to twerking it's
so quick to be like oh she's she's so
she's disgusting she's wrong don't you
i'm not saying it's excusable
but i just think that like
for me it's just this whole thing of
women are wrong women are ruined are
wrong she's wrong for twerking but like
we said if her husband went to the strip
club and it was shown on the internet it
would be like oh
but there we go
there are many
african cultures that do it
um when you're single
and women do it in a setting
to show their vital their their
what's their assets are they know their
virility yeah and to show that they are
of childbearing age they they look
they're they're they're gonna be their
wife
right
once that's done
lockdown time yeah once once you show
he locks you down this generation or
this culture
married single they're just doing it so
there's a difference in the culture so
it's like there can be um into places
like even places in south africa or west
africa where there are rituals and there
are dance rituals where men will say
okay the women will come around and show
who the single one is and men will kind
of pick and they will dance cool and
then they get taken that's it i don't
think it's necessarily all single
because you get older ladies who um
there are older ladies who will
shake but like why does it matter when
in the u.s that's not the culture so
she's not doing it because of the
culture
i mean she's doing it because it's a
dance and she's enjoying herself so
she's doing it because she's a thought
and she's for the streets
i think if you like if you think about
it right that's a bit cold is it true
though
i don't think i don't know i don't
really know anything about her so i
can't say she's full of stress wait you
don't know anything about sierra
i grew up on sierra you gotta remember
she portrays what she wants us to know
and see
same like beyonce said it word for word
like i will give you what i want to give
you well that's what hoes do they
portray their body that they want you to
see
um like so are you saying that if you
were married to a man
and you were doing that he wouldn't find
that disrespectful if you found me shake
your mouth
like like that sierra video
he wouldn't like
booty shorts in beauty shorts if i got
an ss
no for you know
me personally if that's how you found me
and that's how you like you that was
what you're attracted to he didn't find
her like that do you not remember after
the future after future she came with
the whole church vibe i'm i've changed
my ways i've done all of that i'm now a
new person
he found her in like the church kind of
format
then they had kids
then she was being the wife that america
always wanted and now she's gone back so
he didn't find her like that she's doing
her megan good but he knew who she was
before oh one good is a difference no
she's doing a megan good good is that
one
well i know but this is what what he's
saying is that reinforces that men can't
wife hoes they can't wife girls with
past because they will always go back to
the streets
once they've had the streets they always
go back to the streets and they'll put
they're so selfish that they'll put
their feelings and their need for
attention above their children
who you're supposed to love more than
anything in the world i would i would
never want to put my kids in a position
where they would be embarrassed like
that
just look at kim look at him like
she she became a mother and then she
started crying about how
her sex tape got leaked
only to find out that she and her family
are the ones that leaked her sex tape
again and and she didn't have kids then
but you know you're gonna have kids
and and so that's that's what i like
when i'm posting today i always think
what i want my future kids to see this
that whole family can get thrown in the
chest
i think look certain things you put out
the internet is knowing
what direction when you want it to go so
sierra putting that out there it's going
to go viral people are going to talk
about it she's going to be relevant
because she hasn't released any music
she hasn't released anything relevant in
this do you know what that you know
genetic screams to me of it screams to
me of someone who
understood that they used to be sexy and
they used to have relevance and they
used to be in the public eye and now all
she's become is a wife
and she's now saying
[__] i'm just a wife
but now i can show you exactly what i
used to be it's like yo we're finished
with that what's wrong with being just a
wife nothing there's nothing wrong with
yeah i agree there's nothing i think
there's a different way sorry of showing
that like there's other ways of being
more than just a wife maybe it's not
just the beauty shaking but maybe she's
gone around it the wrong way i think
sometimes women just want to get their
femininity
back but this is the false femininity
that they're fed it's like you're
it's nice to look sexy it's nice to
shake your ass and whatever it is but
realistically it's because that's what
other people want to see you're right
maybe her husband doesn't want to see
that but he probably i doubt that he
will make a big issue out of it because
he's a simple soros that's why men don't
respect him because he's better oh
he's a simple soros like
we can we can see
yeah so pretty girls hit their wall
later do you guys know what the wall is
that's when you start
so so the wall are it's basically as
women our primary primary agency is our
sexuality and how good we look that's
why when you see women protest something
what do they do they take off their
clothes like every single time [__]
march
like it's because it's the best way to
get attention if a pretty girl says
something she gets 10 times the amount
of attention if an ugly girl says it's
not it's not fun it's just you know
reality
but basically
between the we live to be 90 and between
the ages of 18 and 28 that's when like
we're the most attractive that's when
we're at our peak
and
a lot of times what will happen is when
girls realize like their looks are going
they do things to get attention last
minute because it's like it's the end of
the party the lights are the lights are
going off and it's typically around 18
to 28 for like the average girl but if
you're
if you're this year it's like eight nine
or ten it's delayed a little bit for her
yeah
um and so this is her last hurrah yeah
so it's not an age but it's a mindset
it's a subconscious acknowledgement that
she cannot compete in the same way she
did when she was younger so it's not
necessarily always physical but mental
it's like when you hit 30
when you hit 30 50 of your options are
gone on dating apps
so question do you think this is the
same for obviously spoken about high
value men
but you think this is the same for
higher value women there's no such thing
as a high value i believe so no only
high value women can only men have to
pick a high value man has to pick a high
value woman
well then what is a high-value woman i
know someone who's a high-value woman
who i can't really say names
describe what makes her happy okay so
she's high value because she
as much as she's a mother she has
children
she has multiple businesses
she um is doing really really well in
her career men don't know is she married
she's not married but she's in a serious
relationship okay so she's in a
relationship she can't get a ring why if
she's a high value woman
what do you mean why can't she get
around she's on the way to get in the
ring so she's does she have a ring
engaged she's
not engaged but she's in a relationship
they're comfortable they're happy yeah
they've been together
yeah but that i can't say
yeah
yeah years months i think it's years
yes they should have been married
already if she's a high value woman if a
man has a high value woman he's not
taking years to cover wait you're saying
that there is not taking years
because when you guys spoke about high
value
your description was someone who earns
10k a month and they've been doing that
for a man for a man for a moment not for
a woman would you mind so a woman that
earns 10k no that's not high value so
it's not high value because men do not
because meant because men do not
care about a woman's finances as a
matter of fact
do you know you know the footballer
ronaldo
yeah his wife used to work at um
some shop some she was a reta she was
worked in retail yeah now she's his wife
this is what high value men do they look
for the characteristics of a quote
because people would have said she's a
retail woman no she was a high value
woman that's why i married her because
he saw the qualities and and the things
that he needed in her wife in her and he
said yep that one so a high value woman
isn't necessarily somebody who makes a
lot of money a high value woman is down
to the qualities as a woman okay so tell
me exactly what a high value woman is
so if i was if i was to ever describe
someone a woman that could
possibly be high value i'd say someone
that can organize my my life
someone that is submissive towards me
someone that is cooperative someone that
can be a good mother can be a good
mother under 150 um someone that stays
in shape
pounds i don't know what you guys have
here yeah
under maybe like in shape so under 150
pounds a certain way we don't have power
we don't do pounds over here
what's that in stone i don't know like
probably probably
like my point is all the things that
i've listed have nothing to do with what
you've just said okay so but like what
you're describing is what you would want
in a man yes so
so wait let me explain so all the
characteristics that you've listed
that woman has
it's what she wants in her ideal husband
a great career
money yeah
um money power respect money power
respect she's at a high status in her
career she's doing really well for
herself
men don't care about becoming
the husband yes she wants to have
correct okay so
and you see the children that she says
she's got is it for him and high value
the closest thing to high value women
they get swooped up immediately that's
what i'm saying they're they're gone
is because
so obviously like you guys described a
man as high value i heard 10k a month
and been doing it for x amount of years
right
so if a woman is also doing that for x
amount of years and is desired by men
then what does that make her because a
woman's money doesn't make her desirable
to men but it's not about her money
they're not desiring her because of our
money
all the other things that you describe
someone that can organize your life
someone that can be submissive that some
someone that can be caring all of that
be a great mother she's also that too
but just because she earns the money
makes her not high value no no it's
nothing so so okay a girl's money is
like a shoe collection
so if we meet a guy and we like him and
he has a shoe collection we're like oh
that's cool but we're not a trap we're
not like
oh damn that shoe collection like we
don't care and and so it's just there so
if she's fit feminine friendly and has
those qualities she probably would have
a ring so something's probably missing
do you think as well sometimes men try
to marry their mothers three hundred
percent
do you not feel weird about that
no because women tried to marry their
fathers essentially too yeah we don't
it's like
i think
i was like
sorry
the thing is a lot of time i don't think
it's conscious it's a subconscious thing
it's a freudian thing it's like traits
that your father wants yeah it's like
those traits that you think okay my dad
had these good traits my mom had these
good traits i want to kind of go for a
woman or a man who kind of has the same
thing i don't think it's like
i don't think it's i think it's normal
for people to do that if i'm talking
another thing as well i feel like with
certain relationships they fail because
they don't understand what marriage or
certain relationships are and how
they're supposed to work because like
you said you like a woman that's
submissive
but then
what would you do for her
to also
what that okay let's say this like
in the morning she makes you coffee
every morning she makes you coffee
before you go to work
now between the time you've gone to work
and come back what would you do for her
to encourage her to keep waking up in
the morning to want to do that for you
security
does it provide
understanding you can provide but after
a while should be like
i need yeah i don't know understanding
there's a lot of women yeah like we said
earlier on you're getting 20k a month
if a man's giving you 20k a month a lot
of you need to outline that early though
i think in any relationship you outline
early what your expectations are what
the goals of the relationship are
because if you're looking for different
things then there's no point you know i
mean if you so my example would be if i
want children and the man i'm with
doesn't want children why am i here yeah
if the man who i'm with wants to achieve
this thing say like a business or
something and i'm saying well i'm not
really about that and i'm not really
interested why am i here my job as a
woman is should it not my job but my
duty as a partner should be to support
my partner
and when he runs out of steam kind of
sorry
when i'm talking to them my voice annoys
me but
yeah well um so as i yeah but we can't
hear you yeah
so as a partner um
you know support that and kind of push
for what's good for him to reach those
goals because when a man feels respected
he'll give you love
oh sorry he'll give you love and women
want love but they don't give respect
am i not in it no you need to go close
like this can you not turn the oh this
but duty is actually the key factor of
certain not even certain just
the foundation of a like a relationship
yeah i feel like yeah i agree with you
yeah duty is part and parcel of a
relationship of course because with the
whole thing about 20 000 or whatever
okay
if i know we're a good team
and
if yeah if i know a good team will know
what each other's duties are then i can
come to terms with
you going to do
whatever because at the end of the day
you know i know that in the next 10
years
we're still going to be
rocking with each other so right
yeah
and i think that understanding that um
that a woman adds value to a man's life
if she supports his goals because if a
man doesn't have goals or purpose he
doesn't want to why is he there he's not
there's nothing driving him do you get
what i mean if you're if you're kind of
taken away from that as a woman
then you're counter-intuitive you're
you're counter-productive he can go
somewhere else and find a woman that's
willing to support
you know what he's trying to do where
he's trying to be
and it's effective
so that's what i think anyway so what
about um
hold on i wanna i wanna hear what you
two have to say after what she said is
that something that men look for as
someone to
support them 100
okay 100
because a lot of powerful men sorry i
was going to say a lot of powerful men
have a woman as a backbone
like hillary clinton like hillary
clinton for instance she
is a prime example because she was a
backbone for
her husband for a long time and then now
she tried to come to the forefront i
mean he was allowed to do monica
lewinsky and still be chill yeah
i mean maybe she had an agreement
but i'm saying that she supported him
see so he could he had the ability to do
that
to do that she said i'ma stick beside
him
that's my man
i know he's doing crazy [__] that's my
man okay so then
what about the women who are supportive
they're um
they are supportive they're supporting
the guy whatever it is and for some
reason he's still
acts a
he's still cheats no it's not just the
cheating it's the cheating so
there's no
like there's no respect in it
there's no um
there's no 20k
not even close to it we're just
understanding that he doesn't rate you
like that then yeah or she doesn't have
respect for herself or she doesn't know
how to pick men
like she should probably improve her
ability to pick
like ladies you don't need me to tell
you there are a lot of deadbeat guys out
there yeah that lady's entertained and a
good one
yeah but these are the same men that
will say oh i want a woman that's
supportive i want a woman that's this i
want a woman that's that and i feel like
really they're looking for women that
are mothers
just watch their actions like this
people that's why people can say all
we're talking right now right
but
really and truly if we live a real life
people can check and balance to see if
what we're saying here right now is in
real life
stop listen to what people say check
their actions and if their actions match
their words then you're good yeah but
most of the time people listen to what
people are saying while their actions
are saying something totally different
and then they get confused like yeah but
you said forget what they said what did
they do yeah but that's because we
romanticize what we want that person to
be so for example
i'm never gonna get this right so for
example
yeah okay so for example as a woman if
you like a man
regardless of what he's doing you like
him so not to say all women a lot of
women they romanticize
who he is and what he could potentially
be and that potential could be zero but
because you like him you're looking at
him with rose tinted glasses and you're
not looking at the facts so
that's why you see a lot of women they
will all go for the same man not because
he's actually doing anything and i'm
talking about the everyday man that you
see on the road that maybe isn't
financially viable he's not doing
anything but women either got money
muscles or frank frame or game
what's that well i don't i'm not a woman
don't go after a man with nothing he's
either got money muscles framework yeah
well it's usually a framework so what
they're getting they're getting they're
getting from this they're getting
finessed in this day and age framework
yeah it's framework anyone can flash um
and
i think and then when it starts to go
left they blame everybody by themselves
and it's like but you are you chose
you're looking at him you're seeing his
behavior and the way he speaks doesn't
match up with what he's
what he's saying so
what he's doing sorry so for me like my
dad always told me if a man wants to do
something he will do it if he tells you
he's gonna do it and he doesn't do it he
didn't want to do it in the first place
he's just trying to satisfy you so you
can not to be rude but be quiet stop
going on that just
be chill
and he didn't say exactly like that my
dad wouldn't speak like that but
if a man tells you he's gonna do
something and he doesn't do it he never
intended to do it in real terms and if
he does it and those ma actions match up
to what he's saying then you you need to
look at that and appreciate it for what
it is
you know so i think as women we over
romanticize people that talk to talk
some kind of talk they can show off a
little bling but we're not looking at
the facts the facts are this guy is not
viable
he he's desirable maybe image wise
but in real terms
it's not a lot it won't last
do you know a lot of this stuff what
you're saying comes from i'm thinking
about oh wait that's why i've seen this
in a disney movie
but um i think that's a big issue at the
moment where
our childhood is affecting a lot of our
behaviors as an adult because
we're not unlearning what we've seen
does that make sense no it's a
generation that's changing though it's
changing now because kids nowadays
everything's on demand so whatever they
want they're going to get it whereas for
us
we grew up with that whole
fairy tale fairy tale we're protected
we're not waiting for it yeah we're not
holding certain things at certain times
to stop us from doing things which is
and that's why when men say that now
we get backlash from women
because it's like we're breaking your
dreams that the dreams that you've been
sold for so long
right and that you've held on to yeah
like there's a lot of men just like
saying you know what ladies i know you
got sold that but this is what it's
really like no no you're misogynist just
like no
we're just telling you how it is do you
know what's crazy every time a man has a
standard women shame him for it
like if a guy says i don't i don't date
fat woman he's fat phobic if he says i
don't
date
um if i don't date fat woman he's fat
phobic if i don't date older women he's
ages
if i don't if i don't take if i don't
date singles single mothers misogynist
yeah it's like every time a man has a
standard he's shamed for it but women we
can say oh i want a guy that makes this
much money i want him a guy that's this
tall i want a guy that does this this
and this no one says anything but it's
like women as soon as a man has a
standard they automatically shame him
it's as if we're supposed to just
whatever women say we're just supposed
to go along with it i'm forced into like
yes
oh i like that too like we know what we
like and we don't like yeah yeah i like
that yeah
because i don't want to take the
backlash of being called fat phobic
whatever phobic misogynist and da da but
now what is happening is men are saying
you know what you don't care cool that's
what you want but we're going to say
i just would never shame a guy into like
because i feel like why would you want
to beg someone to like you like i've had
guys tell me like they're just not into
like ginger it's like tall like pale
like there's another thing they're into
like tanner darker girls yeah and i'm
like i'm not gonna be mad at you but
that's just a preference what's wrong
with having a preference yeah everything
that i listed is preference it's a
preference yeah and not everybody is for
everybody so for me i if a guy says oh i
don't like i don't know i don't like
girls that are over i don't know five
foot three then okay like that why would
i be offended by your height you're
hyphic no no because you know women say
they want a guy that's six foot or
they're above six foot and that's highly
um you know unrealistic
i said all the time like you're five
foot two you want a six foot five man
you know you're climbing a tree yeah
he's kissing you he's going we're not it
doesn't make sense so whenever like my
friends are like oh i can't date a guy
that's like my hat i'm like babes
imagine yeah
you're wearing your heels and you're
tired you have a pole you can just lean
on him like it's just i'm just yo i
never thought of that like it's it's
much more convenient than you think it
is you just have to
step outside but where does that i don't
have that problem as a six foot two male
1 where does that start
where does that standard come from
because it's like saying oh i want a guy
to be six foot or above like it's
unrealistic but where does that come
from it's because women have slept with
so many people nowadays that they get a
guy that's a certain height and
they'll sleep with guys that like so for
girls of five or six you can sleep with
a guy that's an eight nine or ten but
he's not sticking around
and so the guys that are six four six
five like they get their pick of the
litter why would they pick you but
that's the thing though how did two men
get idolized as you're the gold do
you're it's a biological thing yeah so
we're still rooted in biology so
um
we're biologically predispositioned to
like taller men because they could take
care of us
so if there's biological reasons we feel
the way we feel we can't just undo them
but the problem is is that women think
they deserve more than they are and i i
like i see girls all the time i'll see
them reject guys and i'm like honestly
he's better looking than you
mm-hmm
do you think that beauty standards are
biological
yes it's so it's facial symmetry so like
when i'm ranking people one to ten i use
kevin samuel's scale a lot and like
because i'll do it in videos i'll be
like okay that girl's with that or that
or that and it's based on your facial
symmetry so if you're an eight nine or
ten that means you can get a modeling
contract sevens but they don't give five
six is pretty cute
yeah but it's like when i say that it's
like i think different cultures have
different beauty standards yeah yeah i'm
saying so it's like
um if you were to go to south america
and go to a tribe in south america right
they've had their beauty standard within
their tribe for thousands of years so
their beauty centers are as what a woman
is beautiful isn't the same as the
western world no i think it's somewhat
stan like i think facial symmetry is
standard no matter what about body type
yeah body type um i i want to say it's
still the big hips is like for birthing
children big boobs is for for
for feeding children feeding
no there's some biological reason behind
a small waist and i can't remember what
it is there must be but there's
biological reasons behind a big ass
there is especially for black men
that's cultural
i've seen that we've seen that for
thousands of years you can hypnotize a
man just by having it like yeah what's
my facial symmetry like
off like just
what i would give you yes oh
can't make me do this no it's fine like
i i i'm expecting lower than
um i'd give you five six okay
that i i think i called that before can
i just ask what country you're from if
you don't mind me me zimbabwe i thought
so it was either south african or
zimbabwe
um
and i was asking that because you would
talk about beauty standards
and i think like you're saying it's
different everywhere so
and even in different african cultures
it's completely different you've got
like
some parts of africa they want slim
women maybe big hips maybe not it just
depends on maybe the tribe for example
and there's some places where they want
women with big hips they might just be
big and that's what they like so i think
that where we live in the western world
it's like i feel like we're being
conditioned to expecting that oh this
person should be like this or this
person should be like that but we're so
diverse now
that there are going to be people for
example in london that prefer this and
then there's going to be a different set
of people that prefer that and that is
because it's biologically within us so i
don't think it's like
i don't know that's why i find it
difficult
when
people
kind of shame other
women for whatever they have for example
you could be shamed for being skinny you
could be shamed for being fat you could
be shameful not having an ass you could
be shamed for
sorry do you notice the language you're
using
you're shamed but men
no one's going to say oh men are shamed
for being short men are shamed for being
i was i was getting there i was getting
there um i was going to say the short
men are suffering
they are suffering
and bald men
oh
i don't think it's shaming i just think
it's what is like i just think if you're
not realistic you're gonna be delusional
no it's shaming no i i don't think it's
shaming i think the dating market is
harsh what people want to date and you
should be selective in who you date and
there's no there's nowhere in the world
and if you can pull me an exact tribe
that is active in 2022 you could show me
and prove me wrong but that that wants
obese women
oh there are tribes where they feed
women milk to make them bigger
okay so
more here for example men feed women
so that
other men can't have them that's one
part i have actually i've heard that i
have heard that as a form of makeup
really really sad it's so sad whatever
relationship
but like in terms of like when you're
saying shaming
me sitting here today
three years ago i was a size six and i
was skinny as hell
i looked fine on the outside
so for whatever reason people still
tried to move to me but i'm just not i'm
not interested in men like that either
way
um
are you gay no i'm not gay i just
i am not gay um
i'm kidding but like i said i'm just not
ready like
yeah and i think because we'll talk
about dating online as well and i've
seen some
i've seen some things i'm just like yeah
no i'm okay i'm okay i'm actually happy
i've found the people though in africa
that feed people where um they're called
uh they're
islamic republic of mauritania west
african nation with the population more
than four million people a country that
is deeply
patriarchal in society in which women
and girls are taught that they are
inferior to men and must please men in
order to have a fulfilling life one
manifestation of this culture is the
standard of beauty for women which
emphasizes obesity as a sign of wealth
status and desirability
because back home if you've got a man
that is big
eating well yeah i would say oh sorry go
ahead no i was just going to say you're
eating well so that must show you have
some sort of money in some sort of
wealth yeah i would say in um
and i can't
completely speak but just from what i
see and what i hear um latin people
experience like their abuelos would be
like have you eaten here e-e-e-e and
they'll feed them because it's just part
of their culture to
have those hips for the kids and be
ready to
um
have kids and whatnot no that's so
interesting i've just never heard of it
yeah that's so interesting
but even in general like you see when
someone is really really slim
the minute they start to put on weight
people look at you like oh
you're looking good what's going on
but it's like
i'm still the same person hello i think
there's a
i think the culture changes because i
remember when i was younger yeah
light-skinned black guys were in style
those are desired black yeah right
that's what happened when i now it's
like the dark skinned black guy yeah and
i'm like i'm good do you know what i'm
saying but like like just
preferences change for that time i think
sometimes to go back to what the two
things you said one you said um when
someone um
is gaining weight you're like oh they're
eating good
i want to know
from everybody's like
perspective whenever you see
a celebrity when they start off they're
small and then once they get in the game
and whatnot they start gaining weight
what
do you guys say
it depends i feel like if you're a big
bigger person losing weight sometimes
it's scary
not like that if they're if they're
small because it's something that me and
my
we like we see and it's like funny
because you have said it when they're
small at first and then like when they
first start out whatever it is music or
acting or whatever it is like rihanna
how she went really slim and then they
came back to
no no so what i'm trying to get is that
um
it's a funny thing like when you see
somebody at first they're like oh
they're slim and then they go pools just
so that we um
i'm trying to think
there was
there was someone i saw when i went home
i cannot remember like actor but the
thing is when uh when like a famous
person is small and they get money
they're like oh they eating good because
they got money now they eating good they
so it was just that that i heard you
saying and that's something that you're
no longer struggling basically and you
got money now you can you can eat good
you can afford to eat good you know what
i see that in wrappers
i've seen rappers like you see they
start off they're not they're not
necessarily skinny skinny
but like
you just see this
on social media as well they'll be in
all these nice restaurants you'll be in
all these like different places and
you're like oh okay that's why you're
living the soft life that's a sign that
like someone has
money is
they eating good like you can't eat now
eat
and then another thing that you said
earlier you were talking about fairy
tales and how it has um
how it has like gave us this image of
relationships i think another thing that
has given us this image of relationship
is a popular story in the bible is ruth
and boaz i think that's one thing that
um
was taught from a young age wait for
your boaz wait for your boats wait for
your boats and they didn't tell us about
like
oh
ruth was actually working i didn't hear
about like the real story until i got
older like oh ruth wasn't just sitting
around waiting for her man to come sweep
off her feet like no she was like out in
the field working like being in places
where
her like man could uh could see her yeah
i could see her and it's like man
and it's like they
partially gave us a story to put in our
image you just have to wait and they
will come to you you don't have to be
anywhere don't put your self in no
position and everything will work out
and it's like man we were like given
a false image of what
what we need to do to be in a position
to get because you're even saying that
now like you see that even when people
are trying to date like oh
i'm i'm looking for a guy with money
i'm thinking where are you going to find
him he's not you have to be in that
environment he's not looking for you
he's not looking for you but you have to
be if you really want him you have to be
in that environment you have to either
be working where he's working or
in the social environments that they're
in to get that kind of person so so what
do you think when women are in that
environment what do you think the
competitive nature is with women like
that around those men
i feel like it is yeah i feel like you
can't i feel you can't give a [__]
you're gonna go into that
if you're looking for that man with six
figures seven figures
you cannot care because if you start
caring
and i think i was gonna say there's a
there's a thing that women in that
environment have that the average woman
does not and there's a level of
refinement like when they go out they
don't wear they don't go to certain
shops and buy certain clothes and have a
certain look they they kind of hold a
bit of modesty about them things for the
man to kind of find out whereas this
culture that we have in the general
mainstream is give everything up show
everything yeah and
um kind of be vulgar and be open about
certain things it's those things that
the man doesn't know he will pursue do
you get one because he doesn't know it
so he has to find out and in that kind
of environment from what i think i'm i'm
not in that environment but
there's a it's femininity that comes
into play so being a bit more reserved
um
talking and having certain types of
conversation so gossip is not
conversation that would be happening in
that environment swearing and being so
abrupt you know come you know what they
would call as traditional a traditional
woman i guess do you know what i mean
so yeah i don't know i i'm not there so
what can i say
sorry
away from the traditional woman for
whatever reason it doesn't like in the
sense of that's why you've got sierra
twerking yeah but she was probably my
plan is in that environment what um
what we're talk what we're talking about
so where the higher paid
desirable men are
those types of women are you know what
we would call traditional more reserved
and the people like sierra and cardi b
are in our arena and that it almost
makes it a pool
because the majority of people are
trying to appease that social norm of
sierra and cardi b so while all of us
are focusing on that the the the
minority that is in in our in our um
in our community are actually in that
arena with the high value men do you get
what i mean so if we were in a different
country and a different culture it would
be totally different certain countries
the way that we behave here is totally
unacceptable for a woman
yeah so
it's a big part is the development of
birth control in the 1960s that's why
you see women
acting the way they do today they don't
have a consequence anymore
because they used to have to get married
young otherwise they'd probably get
pregnant but now it's like there's
basically there's two types of men that
women go for there's the alphas and the
betas and birth control gives them the
option to hook up with the guy
um for the short term like fun guy
without any consequences and then marry
the long guy later after after they've
been ran through in their 20s
[Music]
i lost the last video and i said mary
and mary the the the beta later after
they've been ran through in their 20s
like sierra for as a perfect example she
spent her 20s with future early 20s
future other rappers she was dating
everybody now she just happens to find
god which is always between the ages of
like 27 to 30. right when they need a
husband
and so then all of a sudden they have a
new you know then they they find the
provider guy
marry him
and they settle down you know when guys
are like oh it's time for me to settle
down you can kind of see in their body
language and stuff you're like right
you're trying to turn old like what's
going on but it's similar what do you
mean because um
there aren't many men in the church
there aren't there aren't many men in
the church no i think it's like 70 women
yeah
because the men don't get behind this
they're like i came to church for a pure
wife why are these hoes in the church
yeah they're like oh okay
and then now they're gonna make me wait
when the last guy got it for the last 10
guys got it for free yeah men don't get
with this [__] i i think i think that is
such a
backwards strategy by women right which
is why there's so many like single women
in the church like it's it's just
strategy you're you're balling backwards
like really and truly are balling
backwards because it's like
if you think that going to church
is going to get you the man that you
want when the church is mostly women and
most of the men in church are already
taken we like
that's not the place you're better off
doing this you're better off going to
the club or i don't know to the bar or i
don't know to somewhere
to find men you don't go to church a lot
of women do that a lot of women do i
think they they start off going to
church thinking oh yeah i'm going to go
to church and maybe i might find a good
man but when you really actually delve
into the faith i'm not going to say
religion because it depends on what kind
of things they did find a good man but
yeah if you
yeah
i'm saying like
when you when a person goes to church
and they delve into the faith it becomes
it moves away from looking for a man
you're not you're no longer looking for
a man you're looking for your
relationship with god once you gain that
relationship with god for whatever you
don't get a man no no no you just
actually you do you do because you then
i feel like most of the things that you
speak about they are within women of
faith no
no i think this situation is savage
because i'm not going to lie it depends
on what type of church you go to
that's what i'm saying
at the moment no okay but
but
it literally depends on which ones you
go to because
some
um there are women that will go
to find their husband
and their husband might already be taken
so then it now becomes a family affair
inside the church and it is common in
certain
i can't necessarily say what type of
church is but there are a few that it
really is
savage the issue with churches is that
one it tells girls that you need to find
a guy that's an equally yoked as you yes
and there aren't
no i've been in a lot of different
churches they all say the same thing you
need to find a guy that's equally yolked
what happens there aren't enough guys in
the church there's one guy usually for
every three girls so so they're you
can't find the guy that's equally yolked
right on top of that they they also want
you to donate it's like that ties or
whatever 10 of your income now how what
now most women are on track to be
homeless when they're 65. they're one
cancer diagnosis away from being on the
streets because they don't have the 2.5
million to retire they need to retire
now i know here you guys have saved nhs
yeah yeah but at some point that stuff's
going to run out they can't do it
forever
well it's been going for a very long
time yeah
there's going to be there's going to be
problem they're predicting that in a lot
of major cities there's going to be a
lot of issues because like a lot of the
social safety nets that are
unsustainable even in england
which is true and but
we're used to it we're accustomed to it
we will find a way
they'll and then they won't figures away
with the government but going back to
what you said that's what women do they
always assume somebody else is going to
take care of their poor decisions but
going back to the church though pearl
right like i said my old anecdotal story
there yeah
yeah that whole equally old thing like
women when when it comes to 70 of the
church being female and
there are all the men in the basically
all the men in the church are taken the
women are going to have to go outside of
the church to find a man and then when
they find a man outside of the church
the pastor says oh he's not equally old
get rid of him so the church is
perpetually keeping women single it
depends on the church and this is my
point it's not going to church is not to
come and find a man going to church is
to strengthen your relationship with god
who is a man people yes he's a man he's
whatever you want you are going to find
amanda
you will find a man but my point is if
you go to church without the intentions
of i'm going here specifically to look
for a man
you will end up finding the correct man
if you strengthen your relationship with
god if you understand your faith more
you will end up going out and you will
meet a man he may not be equally yoked
at the time but you're like you know you
were saying about like a woman that's
supportive a woman that's encouraging
xyz if you're looking for a man of faith
you will find a man that may want that
faith and he will eventually become just
as faithful as you are church is not
foreign then why are there then why are
there so many single childless women in
the church right there there's there's
there's government to heal no but i'm
saying i'm saying i'm saying okay okay
but i'm saying that that you're the
results are not there if what you're
saying was true then there would be
results to show for it but there in
every church i go to even even in
england it is three women for every one
men there is a surplus of single
childless women
and so like what you're saying isn't
correct because if it was correct there
will be results to show it yeah i don't
know i go to a church and every
every month there's at least two people
being married
okay so how many are in the congregation
they're in the congregation what
percentage of women would you say is in
your church it's probably the same
percentage you're saying right
there like at that church some of them
some of them met at the church some of
them met outside the church and came to
the church some of them
yeah some of them met at the church or
some of them were introduced through the
church if that makes sense i'm saying
that's that's exception not the rule so
that that happens i'm starting to
realize yeah you've been on this podcast
i'm clearly um
no but it's not because you said even in
your church it's three women to every
one guys that means at least two are
single that means the majority of women
even in your church are single
yes but the point is the rate of
marriage
is quite high in the church people are
in serious relationships but that's not
that's not quite high if two out of the
three girls are singing i don't know the
the full percentage but what i see
is that when you're going to church at
some point all of those men are going to
be married yeah off and they're still
going to be 70 of women left in the
church
but my whole point is church is not to
go and look for man
so if you take that out of the equation
you may find the correct man i i
understand so if you take a church at
the equation you may find the correct
man no i'm saying if you take go into
church to look for a man out of the
equation you will find the correct man
church is about your faith sounds like
manifestation i i i understand i
understand what you're saying
that
you shouldn't go to church to um to look
for a man
but with with what pearl is saying there
comes a point
in women's life they realize
i
i need a certain type of man because i'm
going to get to a point where my
eggs ain't egging no more and i'm
getting old and i know that a good man
is in church so let me go
find god in a church and yes you
shouldn't i don't think you should do
that because it's like you're going
there with the wrong intentions but that
is the mindset of some women is that
they do go there to find somebody so
that they don't end up alone when you go
there as your
self who's now found god
what obligation does that man in church
who may be a quote-unquote good man have
towards you and your madness
like you're coming to him
with all of this baggage like oh i found
god now but really and truly you don't
understand how men think men aren't
thinking oh she's found god now men are
looking at your baggage saying
don't really want to get involved with
that like it doesn't matter church or
not it could be mosque i don't care
church mosque synagogue it doesn't
matter where you go
that's that's the i mean you know god
might heal but but the men don't forget
yeah and that's and that's the lie
that's the lie that that like oh my gosh
i have a whole bit on how church markets
being a hoe i swear to god i said that
yeah that's all right
because this is what they do they tell
girls you can do whatever in your 20s
you can get ran through and then all you
got to do is apologize mean it and then
there's a husband waiting for you at the
end
and then and then on top of that then
they give those girls a platform to go
talk to younger girls and say hey i was
so broken
i was so broken and then i and then i
found god later and now look at me and
i'm so happy i waited the second time
around and i got married so this is a
mating strategy that only benefits women
and doesn't benefit man because what
does the second guy get he gets a ran
through wife
who
maybe had one or two baby daddies that
now now he has to wait for like then
this is what happens is the church
leaves women single because they they
tell girls to do this
that's a terrible plan the church keeps
women perpetually single like i don't
think people understand like the church
is not a place for you to go and find a
man it will i said if it's not the
pastor keeping you single then it's the
actual actions of the people within the
church keeping you single because the
judgment that happens a lot of the time
in church when a woman gets with a guy
who's not in church right and they start
saying oh is he in the church no he's
not oh so he's he's of the world or he
hasn't or or you have to bring him to
the church yeah what the like and what
what leader guy that's a leader that is
alpha that has the traits of a leader is
going to want to follow his woman to
church especially with the way churches
are today because even these mating
strategies they only benefit
women and they see the church for the
women you're not going to church for
each other you're going to church for
god if you invite god into your
relationship it will help to heal your
relationship and that's what like this
whole thing of like forgetting about a
past year you cannot forget about the
past but it depends on your behavior
moving forward and if your behavior
let's exclude sierra because we're not
talking about sierra here but if you if
your behavior moving forward is of a
faith in god manner then god rules in
your relationship and you become
whole
do you know what that sounds like i want
to hear from you okay do you know what
it sounds like as a man yeah god rules
in whose relationship
it's my relationship then if you've got
that mindset
you'll have a problem in your
relationship no but that's but that's
the point you like women a lot of women
don't understand how men view god and
how women view god because the reason
why women gravitate towards god is
because he's a powerful man
whether it be conscious or subconscious
you put you gravitate towards god
because it's actually a powerful man and
women are attracted to powerful male
figures
a man is not sexually attracted to a
powerful male figure it's just not like
he doesn't see him like that
no but i'm right but what i'm trying to
say is the attraction for men for women
to be attracted to powerful men is
different than the attraction of a man
being attracted to a powerful man when
you are constantly
talking about
god
and your relationship with god have you
have you not heard women say i don't
need a man i've got jesus jesus is my
boyfriend jesus have you not heard women
say that
right you said right there you go
because women view god differently you
never heard a man say i don't need a
woman i've got jesus
and i want to hear from the guys if a
girl if a girl's been ran through
do you do you think if she finds scott
at a later date is she is she equally
valuable to you
no no yeah like you'll never find a guy
that's like
and i've talked to so many men on my
podcast about this they don't this is
why men leave the church they don't get
whip this [__] because it's taking all
the accountability off of women because
the choice because the truth is if you
make those decisions in your 20s you are
less valuable you are not as valuable as
you were before
two men two men that less men want to
date you like because the men decide and
they're the deciders in the sexual
marketplace they they're in charge of
marriage they're in charge of commitment
but isn't your twenty supposed to be
you're like
that's what you say
that's what they say
but
i wish i wouldn't have been told that
like yeah live it up in your 20s because
now that
i'm where i'm at now it's like what i
did in my 20 a man doesn't doesn't seem
deemed that as
valuable in his eyes so if i wanted to
go for a high value man a six figure man
and i told him like yeah
this is my body count he'd be like no
and i'm like wait i know i'm a good girl
i promise like he's still gonna be like
nah cause
they say that
every
one person that you have slept with is a
19 for a man so if you calculate that up
if you have hold on calculate what is a
19. yeah 19. so if you have bonding wise
um if you have five and you times that
by that's 95. wow to them
but but the but the church says oh you
can just like in no offense but like
heal this away and it's just it like you
have to understand how this sounds
demanded sounds like [__] it just
sounds like really sounds like this
sounds like i made poor decisions and
i'm trying to make it go away later no
no no no i feel i honestly feel like if
you had a man in this room that was a
good
man of god
and grew up in a christian household i
did he was here you did you're gone okay
cool
i just feel like it would be completely
different and at the end of the day i
feel like when you talk about healing
you have to experience it for yourself
to know that the healing exists until
you really go to church to seek god you
will not understand
i can talk i can talk on this because
i'm a young man that grew up in a
christian household and i would say i'm
a christian myself
i've seen
girls in the church that
we were friends i didn't know them
outside or nothing like that
in church
faithful woman of god preaching a word
speaking in tongues like
praying like big like
ex exemplary figures speak to them
outside
see them outside
different
yeah
you go you go you go to you go to uni
with them different you hear stories
about them differently you know it's
saturday night they were willing yeah
sunday morning they're presented
let me finish let me finish
years later
coming back
on a whole different tip
like oh
i'm not worthy did she find god she
found god
and got married and then and then you
see the friends
when on the days where they're that on
the days where they're getting ready for
the marriage thing
friends are crying
of joy
going
you did it
you did it we all watched we all watched
you demand them watched you and you
found a brother and you did it
and you so you so no one can tell me
what paul's saying right now ain't real
because i've watched it happen
unfortunately there are brothers out
there that don't know the game well and
and here's the thing like when when i
was talking about him so he married a
whole basically when i was talking about
man having standards like you shamed him
because you were saying that a good
christian man wouldn't think like this
but but in my in my experience the good
christian men they they do think like
this because why would they pick the
older girl with a high body count when
they could just go get the pretty virgin
22 year old they could but for whatever
reason that's why i'm saying when god is
within the relationship and he's able to
heal things
it makes him become possibly
understanding of the woman i'm not
saying this every man there are
anomalies as we've established
one thing i will try and leave you on
this for me
women
look at a man's future
which is exactly what you're saying
we're going to look and heal to the
future men are different men look at a
woman's past because your past is going
to embarrass me in some way shape or
form and i need to bet that
i need to ensure paternity biologically
so i'm looking at a woman's past to see
if she can be within my future whereas
you're looking at my future
to see if i'm the right man that can
guide you in the right place you need to
be i don't know i mean i'm also looking
into your into your future but also into
your past because say for example i
don't know say i've met a man who
he could i don't know you could have had
a kid somewhere i need to know that
that's not possible okay i need to give
a thumbs up if i've had a kid what
what as in like if you've had a kid
somewhere and you've abandoned the kid
i'm not gonna want to be with you all
right so what about if i tell you i've
had a kid if you've had a kid and you
take care of your kid and you do what
you've got to do
then cool
if you if you're if you're a man of god
you're faithful you're understanding you
provide you support you do what god has
called you to do
then what's wrong with that that's got
nothing to do with my past then
everything that after the the kid thing
is all about my future but your past as
well it plays into it all right my my
key issue i can ignore the past if you
have if you do the right things in the
future yeah about the past was based on
the fact that i hadn't i hadn't told you
something
but my my caveat is you may tell me
something and that is a deal breaker but
this is the thing everyone needs to lock
into everyone's past because
if you have a past that's wild and you
haven't tried to sweat out it's going to
creep up in the future so like you might
be
let's say
a predator
and you're like oh no i'm good i'm good
i'm good then you get with someone then
later on this person seen like yo why
are you always looking at this kid like
what's wrong with you okay all right
girls exactly no no no she like you know
i'm saying like she's right when you say
look into someone's past that's why you
shouldn't wife up a girl that's been ran
through like that's that's that's
exactly she she just explained it to a
tea that's why you don't do it
okay so but then if both girls have been
run through
then then there's nothing so does that
mean that the girls that have been run
through don't deserve happiness at some
point of their lives it's not about
desserts not deserving what did they
earn it's like what it's it's it's like
what what do the men want and are they
what the men want so your philosophy is
basically women can't change so because
they can't change
you can't turn her home to a housewife
meaning she's not going to change her
past so because she can't change her
past meaning she's never going to be
good in the future so basically just
left her there and that's it no i'm
telling you what men want and what men
say
i'm not i'm just telling you what it is
i'm telling you this is how men view it
and men don't want to wife up hoes
and so
and i'm you know there's things you can
do to increase your market value like
you you lose weight right you like
there's things you can do to like to up
your value to a guy
and it doesn't mean it's over for every
hoe but in general it's over for a lot
of them that's why you see 50 of women
over 30 being single and childless
and it's
it just proves like the whole statement
of this is a man's world so in reality
if we don't if we don't oblige to what
you ask or say well you better fall in
london
what the hell would they fall in line
like if you know it's a man's world
it works both ways like if i if i can't
provide for you if i'm not being the
strong man you need me to be you're not
going to select me as a mate
you're not going to give me access to
sex like this works both ways this isn't
a one-sided argument no no i'm just
saying like
there are conversations of if she's a
hoe then
like yeah if she if she's she there's
consequences to being a hoe yeah it's
not like she don't know that yeah i'm
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that if
women were told like hey this is how men
view it if you got
five to
i'll say 12 5 to 12
bodies at a certain age you are deemed
as less valuable i think less women
would be in that bracket
but we're told and especially in the
church they say you can just apologize
later and you'll still get the same
husband you would have got at 22. and
that's just not true i think that
they're misunderstood you have to work
for it it's not that you can just
like forget your parts
what what do they have to do they have
to go to bible study and get back
together it's
a lot of people a lot of people what are
they gonna do a lot of people think is
is just that oh i can just
pray it away
and i cannot
do the work that i need to do yeah
they're so this is something that i've
learned growing up they just said oh
pray pray pray pray pray and i don't
acknowledge what i need to do for myself
because the scripture says faith without
works is dead we have to do our part as
well to heal ourselves yes god will step
in where he needs to step in but if we
don't do our part we're going to be
broken and in the church there's going
to be a broken person and a broken
person coming together because they
think oh we're in the church we're fine
we're going to be able to live it up i
yes i have a past but i'm okay i'm in
the church now i can do it and they
never dealt with what was back there
that's going to always come so a whole
is always going to be a hoe even if they
are in the church no matter if they're
there faithfully every single sunday if
they do not deal with what they have
done in the past they're going to be a
hole when they marry the man they're
going to be a whole at the end of their
life this is the truth what i'm trying
to say about church sorry pal it's
literally like it's for yourself it's
not for the other person once you do the
work on yourself you obey the word of
god you listen to the word of god you
take it in you understand it
that's when you can heal and that's when
you will feel the true healing well and
i'm not talking about internal though
i'm not i'm saying but your result even
if you do the internal healing and
you're better the result is men don't
care in general the men the men that the
girls want the men with options they
they don't they don't care they just
want to grow without a past so why would
they deal with a girl that's gone
through all this work of healing and did
all this stuff when they could just pick
the pretty 22 year old who has it you're
healing for yourself you're not healing
for them
so if you're healing for yourself when
you get to that man whoever that man is
that man really and truly he doesn't
care about you he cares about what you
give him on face value right and so if
you're also talking about oh well i'm
healing and blah blah blah like pearl
just said he may be like that may be a
little bit too much work i'll just go
for the 23 year old who's like just cool
do you know what i mean it's like
the 23 year old could also be a hoe and
then no
she could be
she could be a a hoe but only have slept
with then that bracket before it gets to
the amount where it's deemed as forget
that
she could be a hoe and slept with more
people than you but she's younger
if she's got fertility and then she's
low value no no no but no because it's
because it's it's it's not just it's
fertility too
so so they'll take a younger girl with
more bodies but if she's if she's hot
and she she's 23 20 22. she can produce
i mean it's in the same hood that you
can't housewife i mean at 30 she yeah
the only wife on her once once once she
gets to 30 and she decides to do a
sierra and she's bored and she wants to
twerk and she wants to do this and then
all of a sudden oh she's now low value
how many
men especially let's say rich men you
see that in young girls actually wife
the younger girl like not a man in his
30s mid-30s going on 40 like probably
like okay they say mr is going down
how many of them do you see actually
look at jay-z and beyonce what's it
what's the age difference
right
that's generally
when
women are attracted to older men
this has always been like that
and men are attracted to younger women
i'm 25 i'd probably date someone up to
like 45. okay let's say that it's maybe
i have limitations maybe
i've
dated
okay let me give what's his name
leonardo dicaprio or something like that
yeah he loves to date younger girls but
he's never going to wife them
he wouldn't i'm not saying never but he
doesn't look like he's going to at this
point yeah he looks like he's having fun
yeah like he's just enjoying and these
girls are like 21 23
maybe i think the oldest i've ever heard
is 25.
stretching it but
but i get why you order young women to
keep yourself you know lively what does
that show you though
doesn't it show you that older men can
definitely bag younger women oh hundred
percent
but then older women can't generally bag
younger men
i feel like that's changing now no
that's just the cougar
yeah the cougars what's the thing is
there are younger men that
are attracted to older women because of
as a younger man i would have had sex
with an older woman yeah just to say i
had sex with an older girl you know she
was oh my god she was like 10 years old
because she probably knows a lot more so
it's blowing his mind he's not going
anywhere but she's not a relationship
it's not my wife it's not long term
those you're kind of paying him to be
there let's say yeah you're mothering
him you're mothering to be there like
you've got the money he ain't get he so
he's a sugar baby he's a baby and some
guys
and they'll stay they'll stay for a
sugar baby but they won't stay for
anything after that they'll be like oh
if a older woman was to a younger man
like oh
i want a relationship they're like
and she is an older woman feels younger
when she's touching the younger man
so it's better she's like oh my god it
makes me feel so young yeah that's what
they always say
speaking of this it reminds me of um
angela and what's her face nighty day
fiance
oh you're talking about the young boy
and she had oh no i was thinking about
another one
there's a there's a lady who has a
special nissan and she got she's like 48
and she got like the 25 to 23 yeah 25.
no i mean i'm just thinking of angela
and i don't even know his name i don't
know his name but i know his face very
round he's also bold sorry sorry um
the one the one where he said oh you got
a little big but i still love you that
one i don't even i don't know
but angela angela 90 day fiance she went
to do surgery all of that that one
she got with this guy
and they're together they've been
married all of that he don't even want
to leave his country for her
but he wants a kid but he wants a kid
mm-hmm
she's a doctor she can't give him she is
but it's so messed up i think you're
describing it i haven't seen it but what
you're describing is a desperate woman
because yeah yeah she is she's
describing the destruction the mere fact
you would be on 90 day fiance says a lot
yeah honestly you know what i mean
anyway i've said before marriage has
become a joke the fact that you can make
a tv show
called 90 day fiance out of marriage and
it's a tv show then you've got what is
it love at first sight
marriage shows yeah
people don't care about marriage
nowadays i feel like it's a game show
profitable thing to challenge love
to challenge someone's capability with
being with someone else
like
how can you so there's this one called
ultimatum you're with a partner yes and
now you have three weeks to live with
someone else and
decide if you want to get married to the
partner you came with first and that
alone i said this is a disaster i'm
sorry what so the creators of love blind
nicholas shea
nicholas shea and his wife they created
another show called the ultimatum so
these couples come in and whichever
person the man or the woman gives the
other person an ultimatum either you
marry me at the end of these three weeks
that you're with somebody else so they
are connected with another person for
three weeks after those three weeks you
can either choose to come on as a couple
yes they come on as a couple and then
the then you go and see someone else yes
there's someone else that you're
connected with you can either stay with
that person
after the experiment or you can leave
and go with the other person and get
married to that person yeah but so you
stay with your current partner or get
married to the new person no no you
marry your current partner after the
three weeks or you leave your current
partner no matter how long you've been
together five years four years and you
go with this new person that you've
known for three weeks so you willingly
go on the show to give your partner to
somebody else
get out get out of here you know what's
so funny about this
was um the only couple that was
genuinely gonna get married i think the
guy was like
in his early 30s and she was like you
know the white guy was from texas or
something okay yeah yeah yeah they
seemed more logical because she was sick
the woman she was like i don't want no
one here except from you so i don't know
what i'm doing here like she did
something
yeah exactly she did tell one guy she
was interested in him but she was like i
call [__] on you because you're just
a mess
but everyone else on the show was
literally
27 going down to 21. so i was thinking
your relationship is not going to last
anyway
and you can't get a grown person to be
on that show and think that's a smart
idea yeah but that it just shows the
mentality of the people it's social it's
like social conditioning
for younger people to think that's okay
that it's
feasible if you go on a show like that
you're basically setting yourself up for
failure do you get one there's one girl
on there
she's the one who gave the ultimatum to
her boyfriend is the the black girl yeah
with the tall light skin
him yeah
he was
he wasn't ready
she taught like not even that he wasn't
ready she's not ready technically but
she's the one that gave him the
ultimatum and in the end they broke up
and she ended up getting into a lesbian
relationship
[Music]
oh my god
if you look at that dynamic for you to
go on that show
your relationship is already failing
because you know you know why you're
going on the show you you're either
you're a woman trying to force a man
into marriage with you which is
something that's in the back of your
mind like why hasn't he married me and
really think about it and then and then
as a man you're putting him in an arena
potentially to be with somebody else so
you already know the answer if my woman
came to me says there's a show babe yeah
it's called this and this is i said tell
me what you want to tell me right now to
talk about a show what is it that you
want right now exactly you ain't got to
take me on no damned show to tell me
automate him exactly tell me now if not
then just shut up so you already know
the answer when you're going on the show
and it shows that your your relationship
is fragile and you're putting your
relationship under more pressure
to prove a point and that point might
lead to you losing your relationship
you're getting almost money yeah what do
they pay them yeah
yeah they make money afterwards do you
think
i'll just say the two ladies that we've
been talking about
if cardi b and sierra were just
regular everyday women like us do you
think that they would be married right
now no
no no definitely yes russell wilson
russell wilson wouldn't be in the same
arena
i know i'm not saying to the people that
they're married to i'm just saying in
general do you think they'd be maybe
sierra may be called
i feel like they could have been married
but they would be divorced
or it would be like really toxic not
toxic but like difficulties
on what she's showing us
probably but cardi
she's a loud personality so for someone
to be with her they've got to
they must be able to control that like
they have to have matching lifestyles
and as i said expectations and her
career was so occurring she was still a
stripper yeah
oh
oh that's a good one because cardi b
before she's in stuff
yeah she wasn't able if she would not
have gone on um
loving hip-hop
i don't think she would have been able
to
as quickly get all of the things that
she got done um yes
like if you you think cardi b would be
married yeah the way she looks i'll
explain explain like cardi b
if you just watched how she was
before she got all that done she was a
hustler her and her sister hennessy
hustlers they were always grinding to
get the money they did what they had to
do so do i think
like she probably wouldn't be as
successful probably not but at some
point she would have had enough money to
get things sorted it would have taken a
longer time but
those kind of traits
would have attracted some type of man he
may have not been an alpha man but it
might have been a better man okay
okay same way sierra
she would have just used the the church
tactic
i was going to ask that was my next
question do you think they would be with
the alpha man or a beta man you answered
it
yeah but twenties before well i got a
roller in about 15 minutes
no
don't do
[Music]
okay so
the world is like speaking to the mike
sorry thank you appreciate you sorry
sorry 90 for telpee the world is like
this now because women made it this way
yet at the end of the day men allowed it
if we stopped putting kitty on a
pedestal then woman would act right red
devil studio
if you read the book of ruth boaz
actually that's ruth he
gets intel first the part
is conveniently left out by most pastors
boaz would not have wifed up ruth i shed
just been if she'd just been hoeing it
up
um
nora church is great for rehabilitating
women for men that have fewer options
making opportunities for men and women
that would have been alone otherwise um
dragon stallion 101 quit blaming men
it's your decision so that makes you
unwifeable oh gosh ea um change my mind
if a couple shares the same values how
to raise family finances ethics morals
then the likelihood of them staying
together is higher
dragon stallion one zero zero one one
man baby mom one man baby mamas 33 kids
not a polygamous relationship but these
women um been being ran through by the
same guys
just human mormons have a divorce rate
of 18 percent the culture there is there
and people believe that marriage is
relatively stable um essence you see
shout out to you the producer repping
zim i'm guessing your name is also
is
nasu that is correct my guy
yes sir
cultures that prefer fat people usually
are poor the weight is a sign of wealth
i think both biology and socialism play
a part in attraction um up north society
just is looking hot
yo yo come on they are loving the hair
she is popular today
yeah no oh sorry i hadn't i'd meet your
max because there was a lot of noise
going on
you were oh thank you thank you thank
you
thank you you've been for almost 24
hours jesus
women who make a lot of money are more
likely to have independent boss babe
mentality which men abort combative
and caddy
dragon stallion 101 career money and
motherhood decreases her value to wife
up alan maxwell you're almost there 24
hours fai to ord could only stream part
of the flight keep on keeping on
smile teagan keys please stop the cap uk
sisters aren't twerking
out of some tribal tradition the
following
the following the us sisters tried to be
meg the stallion um
jcm6 i recently found this channel and i
love how it's helping the average man
and women but i must say the cheating
talks aren't please stop let's embrace
the role of average man and woman paul
koso men lies to protect
uh oh chris pearl is reverse scissoring
the girl in the couch we were sleeping
on the couch um sleeping we were
sleeping don't be nasty
this ain't only fans um i and max so
much of this channel is single people
talking about how to be in a long-term
relationship i think you need to at the
at the start at age status longest
relationship um mr t 1000 a woman that
can't love a man a woman that can't
listen can't love a man that can't
provide can't love mr t 100 1000 men
love different than women the only way a
man can love a woman is to protect and
provide the only way that women know how
to love is to be submissive to a man
then you feel love chris um bring back
the rude feminists and i will send you
one whole bitcoin tim north pearl you
have you ever heard of stephen crowder i
think yo wait hold a minute
feminist no he said bring back that rude
feminist and i will send one whole
bitcoin do you know how much of the
bitcoin is wait who's the rude feminist
though i think chess we can figure that
out that's not a problem how much is it
a big a bitcoins like put the name in
the chat the scriber who's the rude
feminist describe her what is it wait
it's a grand seven
seventy grand for one bitcoin seventeen
grand no seven zero wait how did the
question still go up that high but i
feel like
you're serious dm me on instagram
i would be a rude feminist
nah you know i'm not the rude feminist
he said get chester on
get me on and let's go at it
get your ass over here girl
yeah i should talk about that
they're still asking for you
i want you back sarah still wants to
like
verbally
[Music]
i've heard so many stories nice to meet
you oh you never met jessica did you no
wow
jessica's a good old chestnut
sarah's favorite person listen man
is she from england no she's american oh
man she's going back
no she's still here oh she's doing it
from my now we had some back and forth
man it was it was classy i saw he was
classic
yeah you had the one day i invited both
of you over here was so random that was
such a good yeah it was just us three
right that was good
i felt i was like oh my god i wasn't
expecting her to come at you as hard as
she did i was like huh
she was she was great she's she's good
tv yeah bring her back jessica we miss
you
and i think she i think she actually has
a disdain for me which actually helps
he's like
i think she really does not like me so
it actually helps like i mean she's
definitely she i can tell you she really
does not like she don't like me i know
like i know it like you know how girls
are with the guys they complain about oh
they really want to have sex with them
ain't gonna happen jessica move on girl
[Laughter]
you wouldn't
nah
hmm yeah i have questions
you know what it is
in my 20s or 30s maybe
but now
i'm just like i prefer people to
burn
i prefer you to want me and i just don't
care
i gotta have that i prefer to get like i
want that burning feeling in your chest
like [__]
i like i like that for some reason
no it's like i i want to know that you
want me but i'm not going to give you
any attention no no give me attention
please no it's like now i'm all right if
that works out if you don't give someone
attention they'll keep coming for you
yeah they'll keep coming for me
but i'm not going to give it to him but
anyway that's a whole different subject
it does burn you're like why are you now
sending name not even high just name
you're like
why is this calling my name do you feel
like guys like do you do you feel like
guys like the girls that like them
you think that's a true statement no
yeah
no no they don't know like you do
i would say they like to be violated
small small wait not
violated guys it's not like
let me explain i don't explain that
but is this like
if you show that you don't want them
like that
then they're going to keep persevering
to but that's not true what what do you
mean it depends if i wanted you in the
first place yeah but if i know you want
me okay but i'm like
that might be age specific i won't lie
because if a woman should if a woman's
showing me nothing i'm not going
anywhere that might be a beta man
mentality
it's a reason
[Music]
because the alpha alphabet i can't even
i ain't going to tell you i can't
believe i'm saying i know i hate it i
hate that term god i never thought about
it she is red
oh but the the alpha man
he
he knows what he wants so if you act
like you don't want him like okay bet
cool oh
i must say
he's an agent oh
if a girl if you like a girl and she
acts super interested is does that ever
turn you off no
okay yeah that's that's what i mean no
if you like a girl and she acts super
and she's she acts like she's interested
does it turn me off at all it's a level
of maturity yeah
i want i want i want to see you
like me
i want to see that as a man yeah i want
to know that you like me
if you're gonna run don't run i'm gone
like you're gonna be running by yourself
yeah but that's maturity like certain
guys they they have a bunch i'm gonna
chase you
i don't chase
i i chase in the beginning if i see
something i like i'll chase it if i see
that you don't want me to chase you i'll
be gone
i think that's what most people that oh
yeah i don't don't chase and be like
no
i just feel like once um once a girl has
been chased
and she actually starts to show the
interest
then he's like
i can move on to the next is there
anything to that sarah or did he catch
you and maybe he depends on what he
wanted if he wanted to just have sex
with you then yeah yeah he got what he
wanted yeah but it's not there's imagine
there's no sex he's like he's chasing
her he's trying to talk to her he's
doing whatever he gets her she starts
she finally starts to talk and then
kabum he's like maybe he wanted to show
himself that he could still chase that's
that he could still get girls it shows
that women just basically get used
i mean that's not usually yeah he didn't
get set he didn't have sex she's got
used to feed his ego i think yeah
then women do the same when they go on
dates with men that they absolutely know
they're not going to date again no i
wouldn't go on that i wouldn't want to
date but but girls do no girls go and
get three meals nowadays
that's a bit crazy it's not it's not an
anomaly it's like 56 of women when
surveyed admitted to it yeah i feel like
we have this whole i say like disposable
culture like literally you could just
toss anyone about like oh i'll talk to
you today tomorrow no
so i think that whole everything is in
demand plays into fact like you can go
in an app and get 10 girls today
and then i can download it out right now
and get vagina in half an hour
so that's the problem like back in the
days you actually have to
meet someone in an establishment or a
friend of a friend
mom dad someone someone's going to
introduce you to someone whereas now
yeah but what are you looking for that's
the real question
are you looking for a hook-up or are you
looking for a relationship are you
looking for marriage are you looking for
something serious do you get what i mean
so if you're in an arena with guys who
are looking for a hookup and you're
looking for marriage it's not going to
work is it and then if you're going for
girls who are looking for a hookup and
they're going to hit you up just to go
on a date to have a meal that's a bit
mad you can kind of tell when a woman
doesn't like you and she's just there
for the meal but then it's kind of like
a pat on your back um a lot of girls
know how to act on a date like
everything's cool you know what i'm
saying like
they can act like everything's cool when
they're nice and then
they won't see yeah tomorrow they want
if you won't even hear from them
but i think a lot of guys have that
understanding when they go out that
they're gonna blow so much cash on a
girl i don't know okay maybe type of
woman why that type of woman i might not
even know you in this this is what you
think is me right
i said you're talking to a man who was
in like a relationship for 10 years i am
very well versed in grand gestures i
know what a grand gesture is to my woman
i'll take you on a holiday i will
buy you things valentine's day birthday
i was very well versed in it i'm coming
from that and i'm coming into a
marketplace where women want grand
gestures and i've just met you are you
crazy my woman got grand gestures
i don't know you
let's go for a picnic in the park and
i'll have a talk with you do you know
what i mean i'll see you let's go for a
coffee and then and i'll see what's
going on don't ask me for grant don't
ask me to spend two three four hundred
pound in a restaurant at hackathon i
don't know you yeah but you see sorry to
her but like
i like the grand gestures however i
don't expect it from you if i say let's
go somewhere nice best believe i'm ready
to put in
let's go somewhere nice and enjoy the
food because i'm sorry like i don't want
to say i'm a bit boozy but i'm a bit
[__] bougie and i don't i don't like
i i can do picnic in the park
give me m s yes i'll do picnic in the
past in the park
i will provide the m s because that's
and she knows that's that's just what
i'm like i don't care like i don't i'm
not bothered about what you have what
you don't have like as long as
i'm happy and this is like then i'm cool
you need to be by yourself
piss off like you do you need to be by
yourself
that's what i'm saying but you need to
be by yourself like
you're you're acting like the man in
this no i'm not acting like the man i
don't think i'm acting like the man i
just
i'm not going to settle for
bs because someone doesn't want to give
it to me like give it to you what
obligations do they have to have you
don't have an obligation to give it to
me but if you want something from me
you're gonna have to show me
that
i'm i'm actually worth you even getting
that okay well what are you showing to
him what about yeah like what are you
what are you doing i'm chasing you down
what does he get i'm a very intelligent
woman i'm very caring i can be very
submissive it's just that you you can be
submissive that's a huge choice it's
it's a choice i can't every woman has a
it's not sweet
i'm not going to submit to every man
that i meet
no no no submission should be your
default setting your energy when it
comes to men yeah but you can you can't
because
all right if i said as a man i will
only be masculine for the right woman
you won't so you wouldn't get a woman
where will we work
right exactly but that's how it sounds
to men when you say i can be feminine or
i can't be submissive they're like oh i
don't want to deal with that headache
i'll just find a girl who who is
submissive
but like that sometimes just because if
i ask a guy to do something for me why
is it taking you 10 years right done
like today i've asked you the nicest way
possible cherry on top everything but
it's taking you 10 years now i have to
take it to my own initiative to do it on
my own yeah so when you keep doing that
when you have to keep doing certain
things by yourself you will have that
mindset of
i will choose to and i will choose when
to be submissive if but
like i don't know the guys that you're
around like i said i'm i'm a little bit
older i don't know but
like i said all i'm saying is
the expectation of a lot of
women
wanting certain things when i know as a
man what i can provide and what i have
provided in the past
i'm just like you're not you're not you
don't deserve that well and i'll give
you an example my dad's a one percent
guy so in top income earners he had one
percent he had 10 kids with my mom and
if my mom demanded these ex
so he's one percent earners like he
he's a multimedia yeah yeah he owns a
software company he's
a lot of like women
would have overlooked him because my a
lot of wealthy successful men aren't
trying to spend money like that my dad
is cheap yeah
he's not he's not going to spend a bunch
of money on a [__]
like i'm sorry he doesn't know you
and so and so then you're going to put
yourself as too high you're going to put
yourself like in okay like and same with
my brothers all every single person in
my family makes six figures that is
older than me so all of my brothers
they're engineers they're successful
they're tall they're good looking
they're there are a lot of things that
women want and if and i'm telling you if
they heard oh i need to take you on a
nice date or we'll split it we have to
go here because you're making it about
you and so they're going to overlook you
because they're like well that just
sounds like a headache yeah like i'm
going to take the nice like the nice
girl that wants to get coffee because
she wants to get to know me exactly
because the date is about a date right
in my principle it's about getting to
know one another we can get to know each
other we don't have to have a nice
restaurant to get to know each other i
want to get to know you want to get to
know me we can do that in a setting
that's nice it doesn't have to be
sparkly and with you know diamonds and
crystals and all that kind of stuff
i wasn't talking about the hackathons
though notice i said we can go to a
picnic in the park but i just like mns
that's just me personally as a person so
at the end of the day like this is fine
even down to like when i have been
online and i've seen these
weird men that want to be doing up oh
i'll take you to this place i'll take
you to that place i find it unattractive
i find it scary i feel like you're
trying to lure me into something that's
not real and then you know what's the
scary part i have met
and i'm sorry to make this personal
but i have met somebody
online thank god i didn't meet them in
person who ended up being an actual
convicted sexual offender thank god i
didn't fall for the glitz and the glam
that he was trying to
throw at me because imagine if i did
what would have happened then
it would have got scary
and also to another thing that i've
noticed
especially like
from
mid-20s
going to like yeah mid to late 20s it's
a lot of guys are becoming lazy
and the reason why i say that is because
i don't know if it's because you can get
access to so many women or
um just get access to anything
the
willing to push to like actually put
effort to meeting someone or like
actually come up with an idea
be proactive
it's because okay i'll tell you there's
two reasons one it's the 20 80 rule so
80 of women are
20 of men have access to 80 of women
because if you ask 80 of women what they
want in a man they list 20 of men
so we're all going after the same guys
so it's just supply and demand those
guys can get a lot of girls a lot of
proactive men are now disappearing too a
lot of white proactive
do you know i'm a pro i would call
myself a proactive man but i'm
when i'm proactive
that's just my default position
like some people's default position is
not proactiveness um do you know what i
mean like some people are
dtf
do you know what i mean like
just down
they're not trying to go on days you're
not trying to do all of that but that's
what i said earlier you know you have to
discern who what type of person are you
do you get what i mean you you're
looking at the man but you have to take
accountability for yourself first and
then put forward your best self i think
that's what's happening now like a lot
of people are getting confused
that's right and then with and also with
the men that you're attracting you have
you know if you're attracting the same
type of guy
in
the same type of guy in different bodies
what is it that you're putting forth
that's allowing these
those men to be in your space
um
and having high demands of men that
clearly can't perform to that level it's
like a losing battle do you get what i
mean so
it's good to have expectation obviously
you have standards but are your
standards realistic
do you get what i mean as as a woman i
know i can't go to a place where there's
millionaires and be like yeah i'm
demanding this in this knowing that i
personally i'm not up to par
you know so it's a counter can you can
you imagine
wanting princess behavior or or
demanding princess behavior and you're
not my princess
like
it doesn't make no sense like you're
asking men that you have no idea about
you don't know the i'm not saying you
ladies but i'm saying ladies and
gentlemen they're asking men to treat
them like a quote-unquote princess
you are not my princess
what obligation do i have to treat you
like my princess i'll treat you like an
individual and a person with respect but
you're not getting all the glitz and
glamour yet that's that that's earned
yeah but that's why you need to ask
sorry to cut you but that's why you need
to ask questions you need to be
inquisitive and understand the person's
core values do they align with your core
values what's the point of being treated
like a princess
if that's a temporary day out it's not
realistic do you get what i mean
if you're talking i'm gone
no problem
no but yeah it's true because there are
i think now there is this big
disillusion of
ah another thing
some women
if something happens to them once like a
guy buys her a bunch of flowers 80 flat
80 roses she automatically not all of
them but quite a few automatically
believe
everything
and i'm thinking
sometimes some and then when i do talk
to like younger guys i'm like be careful
what you do because if you do it once
best believe she's going to ask you to
do it again so if you're going to do her
nails for her once
she's going out
she's going to expect you to do it again
so
but the thing is i've done that in my
relationship my woman needs to know
i'm trying to say like men are they're
spoiling the market
there's so many men out here spoiling
the damn market and spoiling women in a
way which they get used to yeah and then
when the next guy comes along she's
already been spoiled by this next guy
and not because and that guy that
spoiled her didn't even want to be with
her essentially he was just doing it
to try and be nice but you guys do it
for women that deserve it
and so and that's what i've done in my
relationship yeah but that's what i'm
saying like outside of that a lot of
girls a lot of girls don't ask me for
nothing a lot of girls feel entitled to
that but if you're not getting it you
don't observe it how do you how do you
how do you come up with the entitlement
aspect
where does that come where does that
come from so for example so just to give
an example you're going out with a guy
on the first date this is your first
date so where does this inflated sense
of importance come from how can you put
that forth as your best foot do you get
what i mean it can't because once you
start dating that person it's just going
to get more and more and more and more
and then you're not going to be able to
keep up do you see what i'm saying so
it's unrealistic
and this is what when it goes back to
the fairy tale that's one
we're fed this fairy tale that you
should get x y and z you should be
treated like this and whatever it is
without it's like you're saying like we
need to talk to each other first you
need to talk
you can't just get up and say i'm going
on a date
without actually knowing the person
properly i think there's no point i mean
it depending on the type of date sorry
the title of day do not women do they
talk amongst other women and they say
you know what yeah you know when he
takes one a date he's got to do this and
he's got to do that and he's got to do
that and he's got to do this and he's
got to do that and then and then
men yeah that say hang on a minute no oh
if you're broke just say so yeah but
it's like yo
what i'm hearing here sorry but what i'm
hearing here is that like men are
allowed to have expectations of women
and women are not no your expectations
are too high you're asking for men don't
have high expectations
and men don't have high expectations i
don't want to hike i don't have it
because
when i have conversations with the
mandem
you just realize it's so simple and
straightforward you're like oh wow
cool
but that's something that we need to do
more of we need to actually have
conversations with each other because
as women you are surrounded within women
you are surrounded with
a circle that's just like you so if you
don't know
the opposite it's gonna be a problem and
that's what's happening now i've always
heard that it's like sex sandwiches and
silence that's that's exactly right yeah
that's the men
sorry i've got to roll out okay see you
see you sarah
sorry i was wondering who that was
listen ladies continue
peace out no i've heard that it's it's
sex sandwich is in silence and that's
that's what men want
sex
matches
silence was silence like they they want
us to shut the [__] up they don't like
talking i don't want to shut the [__] up
sorry
i know but then you make it about you no
it's not about me but why why should i
keep my mouth shut what if i've got like
goals in life what if i've got
listen i gotta leave you're making me
want to stay
i'm not shut up no no talk to your
girlfriends that's not don't worry i do
talk to my girlfriends but i still want
to talk to my mom that's that's like a
headache like like why is it a headache
talking to my mouth maybe your partner
shouldn't be a headache at all you can
but i'm telling you you should look at
this from the man's point of view men
don't use as many words as we do daily
so they want silence
women want to talk a lot so why don't we
just talk to each other and let the men
like silence the killer there because if
a woman stays silently and something is
brewing up inside of her best believe
she might catch you i'm not talking
about i'm not talking about passive
aggressiveness i'm talking about men
want
they do have peace
you have to work together you know you
know it's a bit messed up like it's like
for a lot of women it's very confusing
because they will be with one guy yeah
they will do all of this and the
relationship still won't go well they'll
be with another guy they'll do the exact
opposite of what you're saying it'll be
an issue some women can shut the [__] up
as
to the high heavens
and they will still sorry to make it so
extreme but they will still get bettered
it's like there's nothing sometimes i
feel like there's there's not enough
that you can do but you just keep
painting the women as the victim no it's
not about your victory
you just took the extreme they get
battered but they do that it's not the
majority of women the majority of the
majority so i'm saying like you're
saying oh what if we give men what they
want we might get battered like that
that's a fear
no no no no no no no you're saying
you're saying they do i'm saying that
there's situations where they can't but
okay but then it's still it always come
back to us like i just think we should
take accountability we either need to
learn to pick better or be better
partners pick better because sometimes
these are sorry but these are some of
them are high value men you think that
they're high value men you think that
they're good men they're going to treat
you well x y and z but then that means
that men are clearly not packaging
themselves how they say and how they
sometimes even how they act sometimes a
man can act however he behave you see in
the actions you think he's a good guy
and it turns out to be completely
different so it's very very confusing
for women of today i feel like it's like
you just don't know what you're going to
get well then then you should learn to
pick better but it's like something yeah
saying learn to pick better but
everyone's good at lying everyone's good
at deceiving everyone's good at
pretending to be something they're not
but also too we do not so are women no
but i'm not saying just yeah i'm saying
in both parties everyone can like
everyone can do whatever but the problem
is we don't have actual conversations to
decipher
what kind of person you're right
we've said this
multiple times in different ways it's
about core values if you are talking to
a man and your first questions aren't
about you know your core values why why
would this progress it's true you know
and i think
holding accountability for your part to
play in the suffering in a relationship
it takes two to tango as they say right
so
it's a contribution from both sides
nobody's perfect we understand that um
but at the same time you do not want to
take the victim position
because then that means that you're not
taking accountability for your part to
play in the problem
sometimes sorry quick thing when there
are situations where no one's taking
accountability that's why it's so
helpful to go for these like mediations
and counseling because someone on
outside can look into what you are blind
yeah but one but my point is if you
if you discern this early on you will
not have to go through all of that but
sometimes i feel people
choose that they can see something but i
choose to like turn a blind eye to it
before
for a period of time
because you know how like women i feel
like a lot of women see a man as
uh
not his purpose
potential potential yes you meet someone
to see the potential you don't meet
someone to be like oh
i see you you what am i going to like
say about you you're sorry
you're just discern what my point is is
when you have a conversation with this
potential
future you know your man you have to ask
questions that discern the information
you need to know if you don't know what
the man's goals are from early on why
are you here if you don't know if the
man wants a family why are you here
if you don't understand his family
dynamic why are you here do you get me
what what relationships
he already has established will show you
a lot about the type of man he is
and
um i just wanted to say and with that
information you can make a decision
that will be beneficial to both parties
well and you attract what you are
so if you keep attracting toxic people
something about is toxic like you're the
only common denominator in every single
situation you're in you can't run from
yourself
um
i'm sorry can i just
say you're saying that like you have to
discern by asking what are their goals
what their this what are their that
right
people's
decisions change
things influence them and change so you
might meet someone and they might say oh
i want children by this age
they get to let's just say they say they
want children by 30.
they get to 25 and they're like actually
i want to live my life a bit more no i
don't want children so you've been with
them for five years thinking like okay
we're gonna get to a stage where we're
gonna have kids we're gonna do this
we're gonna do that
and then it changes or it might be like
might be like business goals for example
and then you might be supporting them
you might be being submissive being
there for them and then that business
idea changes but then when you when say
for example i'm saying that but i feel
like the response is going to be then
you pick the wrong man and you should
have looked better but
you got told what you got told
so what i'd say to you then is i'd go
all right
after two years have i married you have
i put an engagement ring on you or have
i told you in five years time this is
where my business is going to be and
this is when i want to start looking at
possibly being serious with you but
that's what i'm saying those are the
things that you might ask and they might
answer correctly and you will believe it
yeah so if i've answered correctly right
let's just say for the two years
engagement i haven't done that but i'm
still talking about i'm i'm not in
financially secure
position i haven't done the two-year
thing
are you still sticking with me for the
five-year term so you're saying that
like i'm saying there was red flags
before
that you ignored because there was other
goals that you wanted to
i said i was going to reach
and i'm saying at that moment you've
made a choice to stick with me so all
the consequences that come from that
choice
are essentially your own fault
and it's it's the red flags that you've
ignored because you've seen the
potential or the things that i've said
i'm going to do but
prior to that there was probably on the
date i said oh yo we'll meet for eight
o'clock i've come at 10.
there was probably
the small white flags you might call
them but they were red flags from the
jump that
showed my character
and it's those things that you will
ignore because
you're seeing the potential
and also wanting to do it all over again
because that's another factor as well
speaking to them oh that's another
factor as well um having to do that all
over again imagine you're in a
three-year relationship
and then now you break up and whatnot
and you have to do that all over again
before you know it you reach 30 and then
you get and then you're valued well but
that's that's because women don't date
intentionally like a lot of times we
don't from our early 20s say i'm dating
for marriage if you're not dating for
marriage like be on with it be done we
don't do that and then later when we
waste a couple years and bring it up
down the road and he doesn't put a ring
on it then we waste half our twenties
and we're confused what else is is
really confusing
but i don't i don't think it's confusing
at all i think men generally are pretty
honest about what they want and if
they're not their actions show pretty
early what their intentions are i think
women we just get attached and we don't
listen
but would you not say
men
because you know how like the same men
are a bit more less mature than women at
a certain point so would you not say
that
from let's say
early
late teens to mid
20s they're just free balling it they're
going with whatever
the vibe is
we could choose an older guy okay an
older guy now for him he's got
he probably has things
set he's probably he has goals like he
knows like
i want this this and this and i can't
lie like that's very attractive because
it shows that like you're
straightforward like you're not playing
about you know what you want you're
gonna get what you want but it does it
doesn't necessarily mean you've got a
time frame you just know you want that
and some women have to understand
that when a mind is when a mind is set
it's set so you're either with it or
you're not basically well i mean let's
let's let me look right now so the
average age
of first marriage
uk let's see average age of first
marriage in the uk
um
is 31.
wow so i mean like you could look at 21
you could look at guys that are 31.
that's not that that's not a bad age gap
10 years that's that's perfect yeah i
like that age
what well i don't know about that age
group
i can't hear you i said
oh me and the smile hey can you hear
yourself yeah yeah yeah i can i think
you gotta you gotta push it yeah yeah i
can't hear myself
hold on i think the wire maybe is
stopping it from what i'm saying is five
to ten years age gap is all right
yeah that's i think that's i mean i
would do up to 20 to be honest
do you know what is a bit difficult now
is because of this whole modernization
and how women are changing because if a
girl is now in her 20s
[Music]
depending if if culture and religion
isn't a factor that's different but if
it's not
she just wants to
see everything be everywhere like have
fun live her life because that's what's
seen
on tv that's what's seen on social media
so it's like marriage is not a thing to
them at that time
or settling down at that time together i
mean because you do have these people
that are in relationships from 18
they're like i've been my man for like
three four years you're thinking how old
are you like oh yeah i'm only 22. you're
thinking about um
so when are you two gonna break up and
then make up again like when i say break
up when are you gonna separate from each
other
get to
see the world do whatever and then come
back again if that makes sense because
if relationships i feel like
long-term relationships have a gap
for a little bit if that makes sense
because of how much you change
so if you don't take a break
it's just going to be a continuous cycle
and then eventually just going to blow
up and be like like you want to break up
for a little bit and then get back
together you might separate
i don't think
that's really unhealthy
saying it like that sounds wild no no
there's no way you could say that it
wouldn't sound well and i'll explain to
you why
whoever initiates the breakup right
will have an idea that you're an
expendable asset
as in like i can break up with you
and then get back with you
with no repercussions because i can call
it a break
i went through this in my first
relationship where i had no clue what
was going on like
i took a break
yeah because
my partner felt like they needed that
and i said cool that's fine
and then i learned that at that moment
like you become an expendable asset
because that person can take a break or
break up with you and get back with you
whenever they want
yeah and then that's an emotional toll
for you
because they don't value it as an asset
they don't think they can lose you
it's only when you can say boom
we're done
we we we're not getting back together
and this is done like you can see it
like that or you can see it as like
you need to separate from one another to
have an understanding that yo this is
actually the person for me because you
might have a break for four years maybe
i mean because i do the reason why i say
that is because i do see relationships
where they were dating when they were
younger they've taken a break and
they've come back together again when
they're much older and much experienced
with life and everything okay so
that's very much a woman's point of view
because like basically you're saying to
a man
let me go get ran through
let me go rack up more let me go four
years you're gonna sleep with somebody
okay if you're having sex with him
you're gonna sleep with somebody so
you're saying let's take a break let me
go acquire more damage
let me go get more bodies and let me
come back to you later
and ask for a higher price which is a
ring no but you'll seen it from a man's
point of view you're seeing it from a
woman's point of view like ish am i
wrong
yeah
i'm not saying your point of view is
wrong i'm just saying this is your point
of view and i'm talking from a man's
point of view and so is paul
she's only telling you what men are
thinking
and essentially you as a woman
if you want to acquire a man you need to
understand what i'm thinking
maybe maybe it might not even be
important to you i don't know but like
like if you're looking to get a man then
as long you can make a decision and
that's up to you completely but at least
you have the knowledge to understand
okay this is what i feel
but this is what he thinks this is what
men think
so
so if if you've been with someone for a
while yep
and you can feel yourself like not
feeling attracted to them yeah but you
still love them
so you're going to carry on staying with
that person i mean
okay if you
because you're showing a man what is he
going to get as a wife
that's that's what you're you're
applying for so if i'm if i'm away if
i'm dating a man and i'm up i'm applying
wait wait so if i'm dating a man i'm
applying for the position of a wife
because i wouldn't spend my time or date
a guy that i i wouldn't marry just me
personally like why why are we wasting
my time so that's the position i'm
applying for so
i'm showing him that when times get
tough and i get bored i'm gonna leave
why would a man want a wife a girl that
when she's not
happy
she's just gonna leave when things get
tough because you're gonna live until
you're 90 there's going to be years
where you don't really like each other
and so this is men's problem with modern
women they're selfish because we put our
happiness above all else
but i'm asking in the sense of
if you are with someone and you can feel
it like okay as a man you're with a
woman for a long time but you can feel
yourself
detaching yourself from her but you
still love her yeah are you still gonna
stay yeah
okay
because at that moment i'd understand
that there's more to it than just my
feelings or at that current moment in
time because if you're telling me at
that moment i'm not feeling it cool what
happens in two months time no but you
can feel the relationship deterring like
you just
you can feel yourself you know i'm about
to do something unfaithful
oh yeah if i'm about to oh gosh like god
forbid but if i'm about to do something
unfaithful which
yeah i'd i'd i'd leave like i would
never want to do that to someone john i
mean
okay so yeah if i leave but here's as a
man of principle
if i leave i'm not coming back
because
my my mindset is
what
took it so far that i couldn't have
worked hard to make sure we didn't break
up what have you entered something
prematurely
wait uh all right if i
explain that how would i enter something
prematurely
you met a girl now yeah
and
maybe you're younger
okay maybe it's because you're younger
you're now dating her and whatnot what
not and you're like oh
i would have known within the first
i'd say 15 seconds whether
i want to take her seriously or i
did this is a casual thing
just just to let you know
like
that's whether i want to i i would then
find out through character that maybe
she's not a serious candidate or maybe
she is but within the first 15 seconds i
know
okay so there's no premature thing maybe
i amanda might be lying saying oh like
there is like i i couldn't tell i don't
know what it is they're lying they knew
exactly what it was from the jump they
know within 15 seconds the first
conversation whether they are feeling
you or whether this is a
yeah i'm just trying to smash and move
on so can i just
sure um i feel like from this
conversation and previous conversation
it feels like even paul said that we are
applying for role as a wife
even though there can be women of high
value
even they have to apply for the role so
everything revolves around the man
and
without the man
you can't do nothing because it's im
impossible to be independent
but um
it just feels like
if you're if you're a certain type of
way if you're modern whatever you want
to call it
then
you're not going to find a
i don't even want to say high value
because it's not necessarily just about
money because my def the definition of
high value that i've got is about money
but for me obviously the high value is
something completely different but then
you guys would say that's beta no
i would say
in general the guys that women are
attracted to
don't prefer modern women it's not to
say that they never date or marry them
but most men prefer traditional women
you're just you're saying that some
basically it won't really end well with
a modern woman no and look at we're all
most girls in the west are modern to
some extent
if i'm i'm 25 if i'm going up against
like a 22 year old girl from eastern
europe she's probably gonna win
but at least if we know the game you can
play it better
but
like like
like it's just western world we're just
we have too many options
like we have so many different options
you're you're right you have options at
this age and that's the important thing
that
feminism doesn't really
showcase to you like it doesn't showcase
to you the consequences of your actions
at this age at this age you have so many
options you're a pretty girl
yeah you're gonna have pick it a bunch
but you were you may not realize that
the pick of the bunch that you're
looking at
the guys at the higher end of that pick
that you have
just want to smash and dock they're not
looking for anything long term and you
might be excusing the guys that maybe
are on your level and you'll go
um i can get better than you because
you you're probably getting with guys
that are a lot better let me let me read
them
oh yes who do you guys remember the
thing they saw oh goodness i do want to
say something before you read that long
long list
email i don't know if you said this ish
but um something that i've learned from
just being around pearl
being on the podcast watching the videos
is because you were saying um what if
you feel like
um
you're not what if you're not feeling it
men
don't think feel they think logically
women are like oh i'm not feeling it
feel feel feel that's how women think so
when you were saying that i said uh
that's that's understanding because
that's how women think but men are
they're not thinking like oh i'm not
feeling it they're either going to
be with the girl or not that's just it's
like their brains are so simple
and we're living in such a pc world at
this moment in time that
let's say there's an action that i've
seen you do yeah
and i don't like it
i'm not gonna tell you i'm just gonna
move on quietly
or i'm just going to allow our whatever
we're doing to finish and then move on
because i understand that in the world
we live in today
me trying to tell you about yourself
will come across as ah i'm trying to
control you or i'm trying to
you know i mean i think it and it's it's
one of those things where
it's not so that i'm trying to control
you i'm just laying down stipulations to
say look this is what i would want
in my partner in order to have a
relationship if you don't want to do
that then call i understand you we can
go our separate ways no harm done
but
it's i feel like a lot of
no not a lot i feel like
the young a lot
yeah
being straightforward
is
rare
so then as paul said you shouldn't be
going for the younger lord go for the
older lot no but that's what i'm saying
like
some people may not feel comfortable
going for the old a lot yeah but that's
because that's the thing like girls want
everything
so it's like we want a guy that's driven
or successful we got a guy that's our
age we want a guy that's taller than us
we want to like we have all these things
we want and the thing is like you can't
have everything you have to think about
the trade-offs so if you want a guy
that's ready to get married quicker find
a guy that's older you'll have more of
your youth to leverage
guys
all right
okay no problem
appreciate your time
thank you for coming thank you for
coming
back
no seriously come on yes
just justin's doing but you know what i
will say before i leave i feel like
being here the other day and today i
think i said it before it is all a
learning lesson for me i take everything
with like
i don't see it as a
oh because i used to feel like stuff
like this is me being attacked and
whatnot but like no i honestly really
appreciate being able to come and
actually listen and understand because
it's
kind of answering some questions yeah
yeah get your gears turned answering the
crazy i don't know
but yeah no thank you yeah once you
unsee it you will never be able to once
you see it you will never be able to see
it
you can't
like i i used to like
hear this stuff and it doesn't sound
nice because you're like ah
it is yeah but it's just like at least
yeah but at least like when you know
okay like if i lose 20 pounds i gain a
point like [__] then i'm gonna work to
do that like it's like if you know the
game at least you can compete and like
some [__] you can undo sure but it's
like at least if you know the game you
can compete better and at least if
you're like if you listen to the guys
you can get the guy like then we can at
least go for the guys we want rather
than settle for the guys that come to us
yeah
like true yeah i don't even settle for
the guys that come to me anyway i don't
want to
i don't want to well you
yeah thank you for coming it woke me up
yes
oh my gosh
i've got a lot of energy right now i
don't know running on fumes come on come
on let's get it
okay we got seven hours long we got
seven hours left
stream thank you for being with us we
appreciate you thank you thank you thank
you we know how much
oh you guys have been with us the whole
time
what
she starts acting crazy okay she might
we'll see if she
in part two of the stream um
once again thank you please
don't forget to like comment
subscribe and see you in the comments
yeah like i'm gonna read some of the
super chats yeah that's that's big we
love that there's why is there a black
bar around this the camera you see that
on the live
no
you see this look at it
it's a black bar black bar black
is it around it yeah on the top it might
be in the stream lab setting
i'll have a look okay
um i'll read super chats well
yeah ellie's here
she's living her best life
um
okay so
red devil studio if you're struggling to
find the right man ask a father pastor
elder matchmaker who you can trust to
pick for you um i did actually my dad
said he was busy um
if i fail an exam multiple times i ask
for help be humble and ask for help
javier ramirez the woman with
unreasonable standards and the victim
mindset this insistent need to be to
discharge verbal diarrhea is
insufferable and needs to be solacism
try try being pleasant
randall man preach sarah it's hard
explaining how why men move the way we
do especially when women don't want to
hear it
control alt delete in my 20s
let's watch
my 20s i've had girls buy my cars take
me on vacations and bring home girls to
keep me around now i'm making more money
in my 30s and i pay it forward by for
by spoiling young women out of chad
guilt king darius part-time submission
is code for not submissive king darius
she's right that the church is super
simp factory passionate rebellion modern
women always argue against male nature
men like young slim women who don't have
a lot of body stop arguing with what men
want 90 for tope
the the
world is like this now because women
made it that way yet at the end of the
day men allowed it and we stopped
putting the kitty out okay that was i
did that one already
okay yeah thank you for the super super
chats i'm trying to get eight cameras up
in this [__] um ideally um
and it's like 15k which is crazy but i
think we can do it and get that bitcoin
oh yeah i really gotta get the bitcoin
oh um
afro
jill 88 listen to the guest
regarding ons the woman in the gray
shirt would be my last pick but in the
long run she would easily be my first
pick
to birth my child f looks at f age she
got it all figured out um
women in the gray one was that
uh maybe they thought her shirt was gray
the woman i don't know i'm gonna go get
something from the front before i forgot
so i think slayer was oh okay okay okay
all right no worries
okay oh yeah um yeah she was telling us
about that she said it'd be ready in an
hour i just completely forgot
it's been an hour it's been more than an
hour this is in the morning all right
y'all the real mvps were sticking around
uh it's right there
i need to um give them an overview but
it's been like working here best job
ever
overview of what it's been like working
here should i go first right there it's
right there on the countertop pearl on
the countertop
right there on the countertop
to your left to your left alright i
think i'll go first um
an overview what has been like working
here like it's been amazing to be honest
um
i started like five weeks ago
you in my shot the keys are in your room
yeah nice it's been it's been a pleasure
actually um i've had a lot of fun
um i've got to meet some amazing people
we've got to reconnect with a lot of
people too shout out to every guest
that's been on so far yeah shout out to
everyone that's been watching shout out
to the chat you lot have been so
supportive
um
obviously i'm usually behind the camera
so it's kind of nice to be
in front of the camera today
um
i've got to work with jess
jess super cool shout out to jess
um hell has been amazing um she's been
super supportive
uh
[Music]
like yeah and it's just been a really
plain sailing kind of movement
throughout the time i started i started
here when pearl was on 35k so that was
my first
yeah that was my first show i was here
when she was on 35k so to see the growth
within the past
five weeks which is insane
um
of her getting to 100k
has been wonderful um it's been a
pleasure i've seen her
literally grinding working hard
any type of advice that i had for her
she would put implement it straight away
um
especially with like the help of
all the super chats which
pearl and the team are literally so
thankful for
um
no but she's done an amazing job here um
there's always drinks on deck me
personally i don't drink but um it's
always a good vibe on set
um
but yeah just a pleasure to work here
what about you jess like
um it's just not nigerian you are
zimbabwean
people
yes
um but it's been fun it's been fun
working here like i was telling uh
pearl earlier i can't remember if we
were
on live or if we were just talking but i
was telling her that
i enjoyed doing like behind the scenes
stuff and where are we on live doing
what we're live now no no no when i said
this earlier no i don't think i was
there okay
um you probably were there just mentally
mentally i was god
it's been a long day
but i enjoy i enjoy doing behind the
scenes stuff like organizing stuff
making sure everything's set and ready
to go for like production so the
producer can do stuff and like pearl can
do her thing so she's not um worried
about just this minuscule stuff that she
doesn't need to worry about so
i've enjoyed it i haven't been here i
haven't been working here long but i've
been here since
the beginning with pearl um
i've been i was on the first um
initial show the yeah the first initial
show on the um for the pre-game and
um it's just been fun i remember when
she came and talked to me about it
and she was like oh do you want to be on
my pockets i was like yeah sure why not
like whenever you need me let me know i
live on campus and so it was just an
easy thing to come to and i'm always
down to help out people and pearls
looked out for me and just been able to
help me in
my youtube and everything so it's just
been it's just been a fun time to like
kick it with pearl kick with we laugh
and joke all the time like after
after uh streams that we'll do we'll sit
here for another like two three hours
just talking and laughing
and there's so much time
and then we'll just be like well sun's
coming up we'll see you see you tomorrow
same time
yeah no it's been a lot of fun yeah it's
just it's fun like why work
and not have fun like make sense five
six seven we still have seven hours so
yeah yeah we got seven hours pearl i was
talking to ish and i was like we're
really doing this for 24 hours he's like
yeah i was like i know i'm just
flabbergasted that we're really doing
this
um we have a person coming in like about
i would say 30 minutes let me be honest
i don't think i'll ever do this again
i'm like thinking about the roi on it
i'm like
yeah i'm glad i tested it i got to do
everything once yeah
it was it was an experience it was
outstanding it was an experience let me
know in the chat if you think we should
do this again i think this was a chat
loved it don't don't dance
i would think every 100k but like have
it like a party style yeah like every
100k he's celebrating yeah yeah
just but
it to where like hey at this time this
group is gonna come in and we'll either
sit down and talk or we'll sit down and
just have fun it'll be like a
celebration so i don't know if we'll
still have to be on brand with the
channel
but
yeah
no i mean we'll do it differently
and then uh i just think it i think it
could be a good like thing like well
people will be expecting it and they'll
be like oh man like did you see their
last 24 hour stream at 100k like yo
let's get her to 200k and let's see the
next 24 hour stream i think it would be
something that's yeah we could do that
we could do it every 100k no more than
that yeah yeah yeah what if we get 100k
in like a supermarket
[Music]
we're definitely on track to make 200
thousand
and then next month
if we're just going off one day's growth
yeah because we definitely got to four
four oh yeah we got 4k i wonder 4k in
one day that's what i'm saying
look four times 30 that's 120 yeah 200
000. he's here so i'm saying
we're on track on your track same time
next month
yeah you can't do 24 hours without
events i guess okay yeah guys i
understand that now
without what events and guests i'm like
oh yeah i did my best
we could get to a point where
we may be able to
have like a bigger venue and have like
more people like in front of the cameras
and like behind the camera so where it's
just like a big celebration and like the
more and more yeah
the more more
uh k's we get the more more people we
can
do and then once we get to a million we
we renting out a whole building
make sense everybody's celebrating but
it won't be a 24 hour i'm kidding i
always i have this idea i like i want to
when i get to 100 episodes i want to
throw a party i like told myself when i
got 200 episodes like that i was either
going to throw a party or i was going to
quit it because clearly it wasn't
working
like
no because like this is what like in the
beginning yeah i'm like if i make it to
100 episodes
and i'm not good at by that i think it's
a lot of episodes yeah
like i think because i think we're at
like 40 or 50. yeah i think we're done
yeah i think we're at 50 something yeah
yeah we got a check yeah um do you think
it's working
do i think the show's working yeah what
the [__] yeah okay because you were
saying if it wasn't working you were
going crap i was like dude i think it's
working i think it's working but i'm
saying this is when i it wasn't like
this is like before you guys were here
yeah okay when we just had the glass
table and everyone had to hold their mic
dang oh my god that was a horrible sight
hey you had to start somewhere yeah
and the big thing is you were consistent
yeah
that's a big thing there that's what i
told myself because i had the choice to
go on spring break and everyone asked me
to go and i was just like you know what
i'm gonna stick to this for three months
and i was like if it
well i had two goals three months and a
hundred episodes i guess three months
came first but i was like if three
months i have no indication that this is
going anywhere but it kept like growing
yeah and i just saw a market because i'm
like there's no
no women there's no women really doing
this not not group shows yeah so not at
all um even um
it was uh
troy and chalula is that okay
yeah
they were talking about it when they
were here and they were talking about in
the back and they were like is anybody
doing something like this and they were
like no not in the uk so you're
literally the only person and women
woman in the uk that's doing something
like that anyone i don't know any live
show i don't know i don't know any live
shows
i've seen some channels where they make
like they kind of have talks and [__]
but not not a live show yeah they're
probably the only person period doing
something like this yeah
trailblazer
well and
i mean i don't i mean there's guys that
do it so i'm not gonna say like but it's
just a different
well what guys have done well like fresh
and fit have their but it's like theirs
is such a different format different
format yeah and they're
they're paying for guests that are
very very beautiful
and well established like we're talking
to the average person
not even telling them what to do but
like explaining a different narrative
yeah and you're open opening their eyes
to something different literally
a whole new king richie's i guess does
live shows all the time have you heard
of them i don't know king richie
yeah i know king richard the third
searched them before
my history
what's good
oh is that talk no
are you just talking to me
oh my gosh what
he's blessing blessing is done talk back
blessing
you can press a button
and
i can talk to one person and one person
i'm like shut up
let's put your headphones on let's see
if can you talk to anyone else is it
just me
but it's also so cool to
him you know
yeah it's so cool to see
i can eat oh who are you talking to oh
he's talking to me on the headphones
wait can none of you hear that
oh i don't know
hold on
you can't hear me now oh i can hear him
i thought the bass there's a lot of
people now is that basement to be that
heavy that's crazy he just has he just
has a deep voice he said can you hear me
now
i don't know i am
good it's so cool to see how many girls
come on and they're like you know what i
don't like feminism you're right like
it's so it's so cool so true like that's
happened so many times and
that's like i don't know i've always
felt like i just could talk to women in
a way like men just can't very much say
the feminists are gonna come after pearl
they don't cancel pearl well and it's
nice because jess is here and she's a
little nicer than me
[Laughter]
so if they can't take it from me jess
will be like look
no no but there's time there's a point
where i feel like i use my hands a lot
so when my hands start moving i'm like
get it
if you don't hit it don't need to get it
i'll be trying to break it down in like
layman's terms and i'm like
this is
pearl been in it i'm gonna talk to you
from someone that was outside of it i'm
i'm walking i'm walking towards it i'm
getting closer towards it i kind of
realized that my approach is a little
bit more i don't want to say aggressive
but it's very more
stunned and straightforward to the point
like
it's not conducive to trying to get
someone to like change but
sometimes i feel like my point is
conducive once you guys have tried to
mm-hmm and then it's like a man's
explaining
oh
we
understand i was like we literally just
said what you said
um someone says don't do a 24-hour
stream do a two-hour stream and then
schedule an after party somewhere and
vlog and
the party's celebrating pearl's success
that's a good idea that probably would
have been a better idea look it
i'd be experimenting out here look i'm
just someone when i have an idea i got
to do it
but y'all enjoyed it y'all are enjoying
it
it's fun i'm just real tired oh yes all
right yo once again guys thank you guys
for being here we appreciate you yes
because we could be on this thing and
zero people
yeah yeah let me just be like i know
some of you've been here from some of
you've been here for a minute
we appreciate it again
if you were on this live sign up for
memberships there will be exclusive
merch for the people that were on this
live
and i can't disclose quite a few members
sign up today no we appreciate the ones
that have signed up yeah yeah we're
going out to dinner saturday and jess is
going to vlog it yes you can use my
vlogging camera that one right there
yeah yes
um
and only the members are going to see it
so yeah it's members only you can see
we're going to get dressed up we're
going to get dressed up guys yeah
if she's going to buy us dinner yes it's
just taking us out he's taking this out
to a five-star meal i need to come out
three dollar signs and more
steak daddy
[Music]
take that i'm gonna order an appetizer
i'm gonna order a main course
an aftermath i'm gonna order a four
course
they deserve it so
they're gonna be eating well they're
gonna be looking beautiful
um are we gonna get picked up
a little sofa no i'm kidding
come on
huh i was to say what what wait
chauffeur he's getting us he's getting
us he's getting us a limo
[Laughter]
joking
you
you you picking us up you picking us up
we'll see we'll see
well look we'll look at what congestion
says oh my new member yes
what else do they get from the from the
memberships jess
they will be getting um besides
exclusive merch and behind the scenes
content there's like some
um like avatars that will be created
that can be on there and it'll be
exclusive questions you can communicate
personally with pearl ask her personal
questions that you'll be able she'll be
able to
answer back to you and it's only
exclusively in the merch so it's kind of
like it's kind of like our own little
family um for memberships you get to
be more like personalized with pearl
with uh ish with myself just be able to
see more of how we put this show on and
how we get this thing running yeah
oh yeah sure
um
it says say goodbye to a few zeros in
your bank account
yeah honestly
honestly
these guys got the p's for it
blessing i'm so tired of ish not sharing
his hose with me it's so
tiring yo
does he have a hose blessing blessing do
i have hers does he have hoes at the
church
no no
absolutely not jesus jesus
maybe
[Music]
he said
maybe
these guys forgot to buy them dinner
um
what is the best way for ish
to
get more hoes
i don't need i i don't need that in my
life
man's found purpose
yeah what can it do
what can what can jess do to get married
yeah yeah let's help jess out help us
both out help us all out okay we all be
lonely
what i really want to know what the what
they'll say what can i do to get married
if i'd be like lower your standards
i don't i really don't have high
standards how much weight have i lost
i'm down like 20. i don't know about not
having high standards because the
biometric chart that we did this morning
oh told us it's different he told us you
have the highest standards here oh yeah
yeah
but then apparently me and ish basically
got the same standards we need to do
that again because i'm gonna because i
was like thinking about money and i was
like that's very high
and i'm like
i ain't even got that so i'm like it's
fine for you you're a girl so you don't
need to be
earning the same as the guy that you
wanted
i don't want to be alone and homeless
i'm kidding
i think i said that i can't lie to you i
don't think the chat will allow it to
happen that's okay we won't be homeless
we'll be live streaming our life sister
wives we'll we'll be sorry sister wives
that'd be a cool that we could all be
like a content house we could live
stream
hey sister wives huh i'm just team live
stream i'm like
why don't we just livestream to the
water back
yes make sense
i'm here for
that um
are they saying what i can do are they
giving me advice
did you learn to cook oh i already know
how to cook why'd you assume that i
didn't know how to cook
excuse me doesn't just still have a date
with ty
yo oh yeah this feels so long the chat
know about you
yo that means y'all we're here from the
jump that's crazy how does sentience
know i have a master's
i'm actually i'm really bad who
what else did they say um just just
import an ethiopian man
hey send me the link if just stops
speaking she'll go from a two to a nine
if you stop speaking you'll go from
the audacity
um cook jess
okay i already know how to cook i just
said that
um
just is gonna have to learn how to cook
nigerian food
okay i can i can do that i've had it a
lot okay so i know what what's the
rice dish
jolof okay
i've had pounded yam
and eggs
i've had like i think all the students i
just can't remember
what's the main one
you haven't mentioned
um begins with an f
and it's like thick porridge i actually
don't think i've had i've had like uh
efforty roll okay did i say that already
oh yeah you did you did uh oh it's uh is
it
begins with an f
that is correct but i wanted jess to
figure it out oh the the stew yeah
no i have not had fufu
is that no no i have a headphone oh is
he getting the phone
the phone door
no one can hear you
but i i
they're on the table
um i've had uh
is it eddie kanko oh yeah
i've
oh we should read crazy dms we've gotten
oh my phone's over yes um
what
hey blessing
blessing some of you guys aren't loyal
we talk me and just talk to each other
okay
we know we know if you dm both of us
can you toss me my phone please
it's the
purple one
yeah
your talkback is loud you can't turn
that down
oh thank you yeah that
yeah it's a little bit
most of my messages are pretty normal
actually i'm trying to see if i can find
a weird one
had a married guy hit on me
and he was like i'm married but
hey i had a guy i had a guy that was
like i think i'm going to shoot myself
no it's like a guy that was like
i'll go on a date with you and overlook
your red flags i'm like what the
[Music]
that's so disrespectful i know i was
like what's the audacity
yo do you okay do you want to go to like
now that's a question of do you wanna
wife me
because he definitely want to date you
you want to do a lot more as well
but does he want you long time
if he's overlooking red flags all right
let's look at these dms
it goes down in the dms
it goes down everywhere
ellie
what are you doing
is anyone else coming
dressed up
my friend jess from netball is coming oh
what time is she coming
uh she's on her way right now oh but one
more do i know her
uh i don't know i doubt it
actually i i never doubt it that's not
yeah
women don't like me because i'm autism
and adhd and depression i don't know i'm
a good guy but hypergamy
what what do i do
meat so blackpilled
um
i mean the only thing it's money muscles
game and frame that's i mean you
that's all you can do is
try the best you can at improving those
four things
whose
um
okay
we're reading our estranged dms oh yeah
so we're okay just you go first oh let
me let me find one please talk to my
wife
sir what do you want me to talk to your
wife about i'm i'm just confused
they really want us to do sister wives
um there's both
there's an amazon cape
thank you for the five dollar super chat
yes thank you
open it first before you tell me yeah
make daddy a sandwich
like
that oh someone really sent that to you
yeah because brother said i got it like
that
shout out to women
oh this was wine
oh no let me read you the reason why i
forgot about that one that's the best
one hold on
so
um
i can't answer that okay so
oh
yo
[Music]
oh no
it says
um this is from i'm not even going to
say his name because that's
a little man people look them up um it
says you'll probably never read this or
maybe you will hey baby girl i truly
feel and believe that god is telling me
you're my soul mate let's connect
i watch your youtube video on your
channel and i really feel like your
outlook on life and faith in god is
identical and mirrors my heart posture
and i would love to talk to you more
about deeper things and just more
and the icing on the cake is when i
found out you're originally from
michigan me too i'm from flint actually
don't think i'm weird i just feel a
spiritual
inclination that you are truly my soul
mate so serious i believe it's spiritual
discernment and clarity would love to
hear from you my name is
by the way bye talk to you ttyl
beautiful you will be my wife i confess
it in jesus name
see you dm'ing them back amen
you both
no
[Music]
it's a god-fearing man yes it is a
god-fearing man but it ain't my coffin
i don't know what you look like
i got that i called my brother i said yo
let me read you this
he said paragraphs
yo there is one person
go ahead what's up
huh
i want to tell this story tell it do it
oh my gosh
one of the callers earlier
speaking to my what sorry
god
no no i i should tell this off camera
never mind nevermind
was it beginning middle or end of the
stream of the first stream
it was oh god i don't even know it was a
long time ago now
i know so no it was a story of something
[Music]
um
i really want to know if the chat would
like asmr i know one person was like
two louder and slower
yeah guys what if just did an asmr
channel
you want me to do it for five minutes i
can do it for five minutes
just tell me what tell me what you want
me to say in the actually that's a
little dangerous
but
i'll read some comments
i just need to thumb up i just need a
thumbs up
in the chat if i should do it
if i should do asmr y'all did calls yes
we did kevin we did calls
a t-shirt with a mic stand that says
speak into the mic
yo i thought about getting a sign and
it's being able to push it if someone's
not speaking in the mic and it lights up
and he says speaking to the mic
kevin said nah
um if i could talk to jordan peterson on
a stream i'd be so freaking excited oh
my god i would die i'd be so excited
they've been here they've been on here
for 17 hours yes we have been
um
[Music]
oh yeah
are you sure dude
thumbs up
roar sports media okay
that's one thumbs up
you know what
um i was like thank you
i said
not naughty stuff
no i'm not saying that
well for boston for a certain number of
super chats yeah if you send it in the
super chat if it's the right price
warriors
so how many subs do we get from
yesterday we're almost at four
um so that's two thumbs up i said i
needed three
and i will i will whisper
at 4k subs
a day he said it's horrible
that's 24k subs in a week if we stayed
at 4k subs a day
oh my goodness
that's crazy
pearl's looking fine i do not look fine
right now i look horrible
then like the distressed look like i
look exhausted
how many guests spazzed
the biggest thing i've had i guess
threatened to sue me even though she
came on her own free will
what's mods
like the mod oh moderators nevermind
that's three thumbs up someone gave a
thumbs down but it don't matter oh yeah
guys can we get to a thousand likes
i mean i know i know there's only 300
people in here
but
y'all should like the video share it
blessing
are you red pill
yeah
yeah anisha
what uh
when did you marry your wife
when oh i thought you were married no
oh i totally said i'll laugh oh i
totally i totally thought last time you
said you had a wife no no
okay are you a girlfriend
you have kids yeah okay
yes
well yeah i said yeah no okay no he said
yeah
no kids
what's that
oh you don't have a girlfriend so
so you have a girlfriend where you're
like looking for your wife
so she's like a for now girlfriend
okay so it's like does she know that
does she know
have you talked to her
how long have you been together
i don't know
that's how old is she
how old are you
okay and it's been a year
yeah
so
does she think this is for the long term
i don't know
have you even talked about that in a
year that's a long time
what are her red flags like what's wrong
with her
okay she always like look ask her where
you're at looking through your phone
oh she thinks she's ugly
like confidence issues
well it's better than a girl that's
cocky right
i was like is it is it like that better
like the insecurity yeah
yeah okay
so if she fixed that would you marry her
they said tell him to get on the mic he
is on the mic can they not hear you
oh they can't hear you really
oh okay so what's what's what's wrong
with her like so other than that like if
she fixed that would you marry her
yeah yeah everything else is all right
it's just nice
okay so if she was more confident then
you would you'd put a ring on it
do you want to be married anytime soon
or is it kind of the wrong time
okay
so but you'd be open to it it sounds
like yeah
yeah
but it's like exhausting having to like
tell her she's pretty all the time
yeah no i've had that like that that was
a problem for me with my ex-boyfriend
so i understand like that's
yeah like you can see it yeah if they
don't believe it
okay
if you want a question answered
i see you answer asking the same
question
do you guys hear me know put it in the
super
okay perfect
yeah and i will answer it
i didn't i didn't realize you're only
26.
why did i look older yeah
i think he looks younger
i think the beard makes him look older
that's the point
he has like a he has a baby face i think
he likes not like a bad like teenager
but like like young like young early 20s
it works yeah
you got the bit it's a happy medium
damn dead they are going in in the
comments yeah
you say
they said if she wanted to fix it she
would
okay if she wanted to fix it she would
yeah okay um there's two super chat his
reluctance to marry is because he has to
buy bride price
no really actually
my girlfriend
is
from el salvador and they don't do that
what is i don't know what that means
she's from a different country in africa
you have to pay like
a bright price to the family
like you bring like money
or they charge you money isn't it
thousand what the stuff isn't the
bride's family has like a set amount and
if the man can't pay they move on to
like the next person that can pay the
amount yeah
it's more like a negotiation okay your
family comes in and her family comes in
and they negotiate ah like
what she's worth in there because
rv writer said y'all need some detroit
mail logic if you want to call in and
share the detroit mail logic go ahead
go ahead on instagram
i think i'm gonna do asmr for a little
bit i think you should do it
okay so
we're gonna read some
comments there was this one question
i cannot do a twirl i'm sorry
live in
white stem life and wisdom i cannot do a
twirl
that is very naughty
guys we're testing a call line
so if you guys want to call in
so is there a number they can call my
trying to do camera right now
i don't know if this is
nice for anybody
i literally i can't put my arcades don't
do a spinner do you guys have a version
no i actually brush my teeth so i don't
have morning breath thank you
do you guys have a version of like that
google one like like you have a like a
fake phone number thing here
you can create a whatsapp
with a fake number
and get a whatsapp number
oh yeah i mean how much is it
oh that's it
okay
is that
turn the volume up
they're requesting to turn the volume up
with that
i wish i had
i think i had one oh no there's a the
bomb thing is on that table i said stop
okay okay okay wait here's his i think
yours is on the
right counter
yeah
um
[Music]
oh wow thank you should i do an asmr
channel would y'all like
follow it if i was just on there just
just talking and answering questions
jess would you prefer back
back neck or neck massages just so i
have a point of reference for what i get
in the uk in three weeks
the new hair is i know but it's about to
switch up because i need to get my
birthday hair
oh no sorry just kidding it's gonna stay
like here variety
what it needs right right
back neck back or neck massage
i can't disclose that information online
lo siento
what's with the whispering it's called
asmr
there was someone on here that kept
asking me what's my type i can't
disclose that information on the web
i don't have a type i ain't got no type
bad [__] are the only thing that i
like
so i'm sorry they said you look like
jada pinkett oh no i look better
okay
she was pretty good looking back in the
day back in the day in the 90s yeah she
was
i'd love to call
in but got off work at 5 pm central
i mean
isn't it
5 p.m right now okay i'm done i'm done
with asmr
pookie hayes liked it though you said
stop but you wanna make that joke
how old is your mom
how old
if i'm my age that i said earlier and if
you didn't hear it
what age do you think i am how old do
you think my mother is
how old do you think i am turning i want
to hear what y'all which i'll say
i've done afro puffs before
oh my days y'all are wildin in the
comments
no i haven't known a lot about jess
she's usually pretty quiet on most shows
but you've seen a different side of her
on the live stream jess is funny you
guys don't you don't always see it on
the lives yeah but just just as like
these side commentaries i'm like what'd
she just say
yeah i usually on the light on like this
48 don't disrespect her like that i know
how dare you 62 yeah mama
uh
43 48 29 38 24 i'll take 24.
26 27 62
minimum 43.
yeah mama
um that's a good guess i have older
parents my mom is not 47.
oh you're talking oh they're saying how
old my mom is ah that's what the old num
the big numbers are for losing oh sorry
um
how old is my mom
she's not
no she's not 39.
um she's older
i'm not
in synchro backstreet boys zachary in
sync i actually have an in-sync shirt
that i should have wore today
my mom is around um
62 i think she's
who
is
my mom is
past the halfway mark
i don't know
um
i i don't
i don't because i know i know around
where she is i just don't know the
second number and i know the first
number but
i think i don't know
i'm not 26.
i know trust me
whatever y'all say in the chat i've
never taken offense to it i laugh at it
it's funny y'all are funny so we have
some sense of humor we can get rid of
yeah we don't we're not sensitive hoes
yeah some of these hoes they can't get
roasted ever yeah
you see them their eyes like get sad
when i talk about born again virgins i
was like guys the second to last one
pearl
can you talk a little softer
if i started i know
an asmr live
on my channel every friday night you
absolutely could do it every friday
night we're going live at nine o'clock
london time asmr for an hour straight
answering all your questions and giving
you my deepest darkest secrets
i wonder if she's nuts me no i just have
a sense of humor
is it because you're bad
yeah we are would you say we're old
school pearl
yeah
this 24 hours is insane
ah doug you're gonna you're gonna be
very upset with me doug
i haven't
i have not seen poetic justice and it's
like one of the movies that i do want to
see this summer
but
one thing that um
yeah i'm just wearing this shirt is one
of my movies that i want to see
um
like real real bad and i don't know why
i haven't watched it
but i did
go to
i'm like 6-2 if you count there i wish
um
there was something in
uh california there was a
a tupac exhibit oh my gosh amazing but
i'm not gonna say much check it out on
my channel it'll be posted
before i leave a holiday um about the
exhibit it was pretty pretty awesome
sarah went home
you guys are 25.
be a walk
i don't think 25 24 hours of walk in the
park for anybody
yeah who said that in the comments they
said you guys are 25 years old 24 hours
should be a walk in the park what the
who said that in the comments
no sebastian you cannot take away my car
that is one movie i have no i just got
off a flight from london last week yeah
she has not adapted
right was it last week or the week
before
it was last week
wow because last week was the first
or last week yeah next week what's the
first it goes slow when you're like
doing a lot of [__] like it feels like
forever ago
oh gosh that's my dog
but um
oh no ellie
torturing yourself to celebrate is odd
osmosis reacts we're not torturing
ourselves torture is something
crazy
jim carrey being the grinch now that's
torture if you've never heard that story
you should go look it up i feel like
okay i'm too invested like i've made it
too far yeah do you know what i mean
yeah like if we quit now i would be
upset if you were like you know we're
just gonna shut up i'd be like i know i
know because it's like you made it this
way yeah i wouldn't be like what was the
point of us staying up until 3 00 p.m
yeah it's like we made it
let's order some starbucks
yes
but to answer y'all's question i'm 27
and i'll be turning 28 on the 16th if
you follow me on instagram i will have
my snapchat
um
paypal we got another member
[Music]
member
j ocean 19. boop thank you
you just ate
me
you're australian no wait what do you
mean was the door person there
yeah when i went to go get the door
thing there was no one there i was like
what is going on because you're
australian i don't hate you because
you're australian i hate you because
your name is dubs
dubs
dude i'm sorry i'm just kidding
nah
my mom for like a half hour can you
entertain this chat
yeah yeah
yo
no
fandemonium vr
we are not hoes
if you're looking for hoes go find them
somewhere else i always think about it
like what's a hoe i'm like we're
probably all hoes by 1920s standard
they're all virgins
zachary moore how old are you
yes i brushed my teeth i know they said
stop whispering you have morning breath
like i brush my teeth
yes it is it's based in london
all right my friend jess is almost here
oh day
all right
it's about
so i'm i'm being serious would you guys
tune in if i did like an am asmr like
live stream
once a week
if you guys
oh if you guys like would do
i would probably do it because i've had
a lot of people tell me
um
like oh like you have such a great voice
you should do asmr i'm like personally
i hate it i'd probably do it without the
headphones
because
i don't know how people do it but if it
helps you sleep
helps you
with whatever do you like playing
anything other than basketball
um
you seem like you ran track i did i did
run track i
i did a lot of stuff in track i um
where's the search um one second
i think the only reason me and you can
make it through this is because we're
athletes yeah mental toughness yes and
the competitiveness to see it through
yes that is it
i'm sorry
thanks for convincing me to cancel the
show saturday that was a good call i i
appreciate you i appreciate you
i literally was like
ish
please don't do it justice asmr today
only fans tomorrow
okay
oh with the advice
but no like if i don't do it jess is it
oh that's what's good
it's in the bag
so you take out the um
the thing on the top on the other side
let's see what's trending in the
manosphere right now
the one on the top you have the pink
thing and it's in
is that the one up top the last light no
no no no no no
pull it out so i can see sorry
so
it's um
pull it out i said
can you hear me
i said pull it out so i can see
do you think good wives have an ability
to play in the background
good wives do they must they be in the
background of their husband
they play their role for whatever they
need to do
what do you think chess
do you think good wives have to play in
the background suck it on air mike isn't
it
um
do you say do i think good wives yeah
good wives
um
i think i won't say
have to be in the background but i would
say i think they need to know
that they're going to be in the
background more than
in the forefront
yeah that's what i think too
[Music]
ever read rational mind
perfect book for understanding human
nature it's purely based in research
manny fresh
thanks manny
just show feet
not the forefathers
yes
i played a basketball
i i never i never said it was like
creepy i said i just don't like the
sounds like i don't like the
food smacking sounds like this is
something that i can't take
and it's just like
gonna be
yeah i'm not even gonna do it that's why
i said i would have to do without the
headphones because
okay
yes
all right chat
not my mom calling me
my mama let's see if she wants to be on
the call i'll ask her some questions
hi mom
we're on the 24 hour live stream the
people can hear you say hi to the people
no you're not are you serious hello
no they can hear your people
everybody say hi to my mom they were
asking about you
because we're here just on live stream
right now
they were asking how old you were and
they were like you don't remember how
old your mom is i was like she's over
halfway
that's all i remember
november 23rd oh wow some of you all
were right 62.
good guess
yeah
me talking oh my god
hello to the people yes hello to the
people they say hi mom hey jess's mom on
the chat oh yo
okay so
yes
hey it was good
how are you
i
went out here to rob in the face not
like that it's all love
so appreciate it i appreciate you
for a brief intermission oh everybody
saying hi mama hi mom
gum asmr that's ish over there smacking
[Laughter]
um
okay mom um for for a brief no no no no
no for a brief intermission um we're
gonna talk a little bit about sports um
and then um we might ask some red pill
questions um
what
is your
now i want you to keep it 100 what is
your
thoughts on the finals right now
well
i have to well of course
i feel a little nervous because they won
that last game
so first thing popped in my mind is ish
over there when um
when he was saying like uh boston was
gonna i just thought that
i'm just kind of not nervous because i'm
like they're getting paid so it ain't
like a nervous like oh okay somebody
life or life or death that kind of
nervousness but
they getting paid and so but i'm like
you know what you're coming up against
and you're gonna have to man up and just
do what you know to do and these
commentators and reporters and stuff
what irritates me about them you know
you shouldn't ask me a question
what irritates me about them is because
they go oh the celtics are big and
uh they're athletic i'm like these guys
been
to
the finals how many times was it six in
the last eight seasons
and they um
it's not the first big team that they
came up against they played the lakers
it but i get what they're saying it's
like it's not a rest like you can play
the big dudes maybe uh twice out of the
year or whatever and there's
back-to-back games and stuff but they
prepared for this and like someone else
said it's not over the only thing that
scares me that they got that two up to
that one
and if they if the celtics and they're
on their floor and like everyone is
saying
the
boston celtics is vicious
they
one dude said even the even the kids be
vicious it's like everybody is vicious
and and if you're not mentally prepared
for it and that's with anything in life
if you're not prepared for it
and get your thoughts and get focused
the enemy is going to come in and get in
your thoughts and deter you from the job
at hand so
i'm hoping that they win tonight and if
they don't it's like hey overweight okay
yep if they don't win the night no they
don't
they're they're getting paid so
everybody's still good ain't nobody
losing no houses no children yeah
um no our moms don't know each other um
i just wanted to ask my mom that
question because she's a big basketball
fan and her an ish
you're going back and forth about who
gonna win
um i've got golden state winning
today's game
the warriors have played again uh
tougher teams than the celtics during i
am a celtics friend just saying warriors
got it oh
got it um
did steph get injured someone's asking
that he he got he did get injured but i
i don't think he was um that's severe to
where he can't play yeah okay but it was
a bit of an injury yes we'll find out i
guess
all right hey mom leave my belly
all right mom no i got a question for
you
i had a question special this morning no
i've called i've called everybody but
jordan i think jordan is the only one
that wouldn't want to be on is he at
work right now because i might call him
no no no no he's probably down there
he'll have to be at work until okay but
um
and you're in on your idea how many
how many bodies do you think would be
too many bodies for a woman to have
do you know what i mean by bodies
oh partners how many people shouldn't
slept with
oh i know what you meant okay cause you
was looking but i ain't stupid
um
hey
you know what
i know they
it's different for a woman but
it all depends because reason why i say
that is because
once you know christ you know where i'm
going yes it's like all of that
all of that is covered it is done with
none of the blood but now
if
she's not professing jesus christ and
she's just out there just
wilding out i'm like okay come on just
not because she compared it to how i do
do it because you know how that double
standard is
all the um
the men they like hey
and ain't nobody counting you know but
with her with the female it's just uh
you know because she's
i look at a woman mother mom
give the number jesus you gonna be here
all day talking around the bush give the
loan because you i can't give no number
it shouldn't be
oh god because it's different i can't
give no number because what would you if
what would you think whatever
what
ask that question again what would you
think is too much
too
much um
too much
okay you say 20. that's okay
that's just your number
anything is too much yeah
okay um i'm sorry no you know
i know i mean the people in the chat
are they can't hear me no they can hear
you i got you up to the mic they can
hear you there are you serious yeah they
saying oh we love jess's mom she's
awesome
so they like you
um
y'all she know nothing about no red pill
no blue pill no purple pill no green
pills you know nothing about none of
this
um what was my other question
no not birth control mother
y'all what's another red pill question
that i should ask my mom
um
i had one in my head i just forgot it
i'm not about to ask my mama that
question y'all what what what what what
she's safe so she ain't she got one man
and one man on it that's my daddy
yeah they're asking your body count
overall they're like
ass
ask your mom
her body count
if you say it they can hear you
i know
there's been some she's 62 y'all so it's
been some years
she's been suppressed them
well y'all listening see you when you
got kids and they listen they can throw
this junk back up in your face doesn't
matter
i'm trying to think
how is it disrespectful if she answers
it she answers it it's not disrespectful
first of all you don't know my mama and
my relationship so you can't say that
um
yeah
i don't know enough about red pill to
explain it to her
um
okay
um while you think of that
uh
oh goodness that's a good question fill
more pockets all right um
we got a super chat
just go ahead and introduce me to your
mom okay roar
sports media
sir
someone named roy says hello mother
hi
um
so
um mom
what
in a perfect world
what do
what do you think
that
so let me
in a perfect
world
what's your your ideal man for me in a
perfect world what's your ideal man for
me
that's easy
y'all this is hold on hold on this is
her
this is her ideal man for me it ain't my
deal man for me
because it's my mama okay go ahead
oh the perfect man for you oh that's
your your idea
i know i heard you for the fifth time my
idea okay you only gotta say it again
so
the uh
first of all i'll ask that one nobody it
just makes it
is it all right if i say about um
the nationality yeah that's fine it's
your idea so you can say
oh okay okay okay i don't want to be
offensive okay of course a black man
and um very athletic
and um
i'm outgoing love the travel
and oh out for lord jesus let me go back
to the first one not yet not yet uh
zachary love
love the lord love
let the lord love the lord yes with
wisdom with wisdom because these people
love the lord ain't got no wisdom with
it ain't got but so love the lord with
wisdom
and really actually be seriously
be a kind and gentle person where
they know how to
love
the love of jesus christ because
you can
love but not
that that love but love you and treat
you
so that when they look at you it's like
hey that's that's my girl that's my girl
i love her and just look at you
and have that
that hunger to be with you
and just just love you but athletic and
and want to treat you kind and gentle
and
and know how to handle their business at
all
know how to handle their business all
the way around so therefore he probably
would be
not
older but just
just a wise dude just a real wise dude
to love the lord and operate in
what's right with character and love
from jesus christ
is that it and font and fine
all right um if you guys were on if you
guys were on the chat earlier um we have
another super chat rpc p5v18 says i
think more and more women will get red
pill due to circumstances the more
uh the social order thinks ruins their
lives then they will start searching for
answers and real pull is just for them
um
okay i'll ask her if you guys were on
if y'all were on i'm not mixed y'all if
y'all thought i was i'm not mixed i'm
black i'm just like anyways um
if uh
this is my mama's requirements for me
okay she may have a long list i may just
have a little notepad a little sticky
note but earlier
in the wee hours of the morning uh
ish asked me about or somebody asked me
about doing the rock johnson mom what do
you
what are your thoughts about dwayne the
rock johnson
that's not fair
love him for so many reasons because
what i understand he's a good dude and
me
he and plus he has a bunch of girls he
knows how to treat his girls and
he's still
uh cool with his um
ex because they have a production
together and he has like i said he has
all girls and when he travels he travels
with his family
and wherever they go he loads them up
and everybody goes with him and
he's very dedicated to
his um and treating his uh family
and his mind and body right i just love
him all around and plus
he's been fine for the longest and
that's just in my eyes but
all around nice dude
all right awesome if you're just now
tuning in um right now pearl is
on a call
um
and she'll be back soon so that's why
we're not doing our normal red pill um
segments
um she'll be back soon that is why i
have my mom on the phone so this is just
like a little intermission so if you're
coming in and you like the other stuff
i'm sorry that we're not doing the
normal stuff but which camera am i
looking at blessing that one i'm looking
at the wrong one i'm looking corral side
up here
but if um
if you're just tuning in that's why
pearl isn't here it's just in here and
you're just you're just looking at me
look really hitting me
so um
mom what my mom is from she was born in
maryland
baltimore baltimore maryland
but like our roots are like from the
south so
we country a little bit um what is your
thoughts about feminism mom
um
i really i don't know i
maybe i
reason why i'm stuttering or pausing is
because maybe i don't have a clear
understanding
exactly what that means uh
so i'll explain it to you
um if someone can put in the chat the
actual definition
so i don't have to
i'm just going to assume
okay um
so can someone put in the chat
yes yes yes so the feminist movement
essentially um
the feminist movement is essentially
telling women
that um you can be independent you can
chase the bag you can
yeah
yep so
so since you okay got it do you think it
helps women or hurts women
you know what it all but it helps
because anytime you give a person a
freedom
it helps
it's just the individual their thoughts
and how they were raised what hinders
any operation
is people in their process and their
ways and stuff yes anytime you have
a freedom what is the knowledge is what
you do with your freedom
okay so typically fem
so typically feminism is
um
the feminist organization or the or
uh is
mainly to go against
men it's like you don't need a man you
don't need um thank you you don't need
um
like essentially you don't need a man to
do anything you can chase the bag be
independent and live out your life and
in the end
maybe wasn't using the right word but
yeah she can she don't have to
so you want so if i was
so essentially
what i've learned is that when women
um when women do this and they chase the
bag and they're independent
they end up
a lot of women end up being
i think it's i can't remember the number
it was like 40 and like
40 and childless and then um
essentially
the
trajectory of it is that women who are
uh
unmarried and childless
are in a higher percentile of being
homeless
because of
it's the stats don't look at me like
that's the stats and so essentially what
feminism is
because they don't have a man it's
because they don't have that second
stream of income to
live
in the society that we live in today if
mom if i wanted to live by myself
in california i would need to have two
to three jobs just to survive
now say if i got married and i had a man
and we had brought those incomes
together i wouldn't have to work two to
three jobs and so essentially feminism
is telling women that you don't need a
man you can do everything by yourself
and you'll be happy in the end when
statistics show that women who are older
and have no kids and aren't married
aren't
understand what you're saying i still
think it's just
i
and that's i get what you said i get it
i get it but i just feel like that
and that's your opinion
the
definition of that because i'm thinking
it's like the freedom of
of having this uh
being paid the same the freedom of being
um
doing whatever her choices and stuff
maybe i have a misunderstanding of what
the
what that means because
i'm like she just
is equal and being able to make what i
mean by the equalness is being able to
work and do things and brain is just as
well capable of thinking and doing
whatever a man can do you know
physically yes we are different you know
okay
mom the chat earlier i asked him what
what do i need to do to um to get
married
and they said cook can i cook
yes okay
thank you i told y'all i can cook
what did i what did i cook very healthy
cooker too say that one more time
a very healthy cooker exactly very
healthy
justin cook i can cook okay
so earlier today they're they're telling
me
ish they're telling me
oh we're good
oh hold on um so
let me
um
sounds like that whenever it zachary she
is
uh
okay um
whatchamacallit
uh ish they told me to ask her about my
friend
okay mom so
i called um i called ty
earlier
um
i obviously i will
i will
actually i have to get it from him again
but
um
what
jesus i'm scared to ask
give me your give me your honest
thoughts about tai
i really don't know much about it so
from from like uh just from what you
what you've seen not what you know about
just from what you've seen and like just
you've seen him a lot and you've been
around him a lot
and just he's a good good kid a nice guy
i call him a kid a nice young man a good
young man i truly don't can't because
i've only been around him like hey hey
how are you and
you know
like i've never been around him far as i
know of his pretty cool kid kid
young man i keep saying kid okay
young man i i really can't
say anything towards this character as
far as i know
can somebody explain to me what bass is
issue what is bass solid okay
character
that's what i've i've learned today
today
all right bye steven thanks for
okay do you guys want to know more
about um
my friend and what her thoughts are
about them
about my friend or y'all are you all
good
about it
because early
so earlier
okay say that again
i don't think you guys are
should be
partners at one time i thought so but
not anymore you know because no that's
not
that's that's not as they say that's not
your person i don't think that's what
god has for you
all right there you have it folks should
i call off the date should i
text him and be like you know what
i'ma call off the date
oh jesus
so
so earlier we had called him and uh
pearl was like pearl asked him if he's
asked me today he was like yeah i was
like i don't remember when and so he was
like oh if i can get out here in
december for your graduation uh
then we'll go on a date and he was like
where are we going and pearl was like
you can't ask her where um
where you want to go you have to plan it
and so he was like okay were you on a
date with me jessica he was like good
job girl
you just said that i don't think they
need to be together as
mean by partners that she called him oh
hold on say it again say it again yeah
she called him out that wasn't yeah she
did call him out
um
no they are
not because i don't think he's ready to
just
oh no don't say that chris
my mom's wife if you're just now if
you're just now tuning in um pearl is
has stepped out and it's ish and i right
here right now um
we're just taking a break from the
regularly scheduled program it's an
intermission
um and
and so we're just my mom's on the phone
if you're wondering who this other deep
voice lady is on the phone it is my
mother that is why i have the voice that
i have
um
and so
you're going to the movies
yeah who you going to movies with
don't say it like that
okay
um
you looking for a holy sanctified man
mom
you gotta be holy saying divide
sanctified and
you gotta have some money
and i'll send you to my mama
and if you live in if you live in uh
uh the uk dual citizenship
my mom's great but all right mom
thank you for allowing me to interview
you
what'd you say
what did you say baby i said thank you
for allowing me to interview you is
there anything you'd like to say to the
people before you leave
keep it short
jesus love you more always
stay encourage people
all right do you want to say bite it
all right she said i know your way bye
take care
all right everybody
they say bye mom
everybody's love you guys thank you
love you too everybody's gone bye
uh that's my mom y'all i hope y'all
enjoyed um
i hope y'all enjoyed that little
conversation
uh with my mom
um
jess mom it's a hot girl summer it's so
hot just mama's getting her city girl i
know she's not do not say that
no
my mom is not outside i promise you
nah she ain't looking for nobody she
like
done that
you gotta love the chat you know
i don't should i should i call it off
with ty should i just be like you know
what we just friends
hey do you know what sometimes the mom's
mom knows yeah
and that's crazy because like
i don't even know how much your mom
knows but like
yeah
yeah just hearing that from her it was
like oh
wow
how many times have they been um mr
nitro no she's not yeah
yeah he is kevin's
um
um but he's funny sebastian okay
sebastian
you are
wilding in the chat but it's funny
um
what questions do y'all have for uh ish
and i
oh zachary go ahead
call in um
get
see
thank you nobody he said get a free meal
just don't cancel period free travel he
said we're going to italy i'm going to
get flute out
that makes sense sorry i'm no i'm like
similar but the
all right let's try and test it oh we're
testing the call
how do we
okay um
i know it is all joke sebastian
don't cancel get a free meal
ah saucy buns
hey watch out your headphones um
um zachary it'll be
by um
um ig
if you want to call
um my personal on you can i don't know
oh that sounds super loud
i thought
i took the headphones why is it hold on
real quick ready
yeah we're testing some things real
quick sometimes that's the problem i
know he's sitting
here
like we can't hear you at all yeah no we
can't
um zachary if you want to call my
[Music]
what is it called
my instagram you can zachary
it's
it's dot yeah
girl underscore yes
and if i want to follow me hey thanks
for the the congrats um there was a
super chat super chat super chat where
did you go super chat super chat
i don't know
[Music]
i think i read oh no
um congratulations on the big
achievement do you think two will ever
end up
back oh do you think you two will ever
end up back stateside with your families
what is the thing you're most thankful
for learning on your redfield journey
um
i don't know if we'll end up stateside
anytime
anytime soon
um
we want to be able to
it's not clear anymore build a little
bit more
um and pearl has a lot of things that's
more of a question
i'm looking at that camera sorry that's
sorry
that's more of a question for pearl
um because she's the
leader of this show
but um
um
what else was i gonna ask in super chat
what is the thing you're most thankful
for it's
from learning from the red pill it's
literally everything because i just love
learning hello yeah that's perfect i
love just learning new things and this
is like crazy stuff that i wish i would
have learned when i was younger
um
but
yeah
um
there's nothing like specific i guess
for me
i'm always the one to
want to know and understand how
like a man views the world how a man
views woman or how a man like thinks
more and with this i've been able to
understand a little bit more and i'm
like it can't be that simple like it
can't
it can't be that simple for y'all brains
because women's brains are so complex
and sometimes i hate it because i'm like
just shut up
but
i think that's one thing that i've
enjoyed the most is just hearing from
men and learning from men just like
how they are and how they operate and
how some may do this somebody do that
and it's just it's just a different
world and it's just
cool so i'm very i'm very open-minded
and just
love to learn
um
oh have they
they must have did that right when i
left
oh the mic is ecstatic
sorry guys yo mike's like
sorry guys for testing things
oops i don't have any sisters
i have no sisters i just have bro bros
thank you for congratulating pearl honor
is the mic still static
because
i can hear ourselves normally you know
yeah i can hear myself yeah
um yeah so
jess is still stuck sorry
no it's not oh
sorry hey guys this is still static in
my ears it's not
but
yeah hey let me know if it's static
y'all
um i'm not too sure
it is
it's fine for yeah the statics come back
again
yep and now it's gone
and yeah no it's still here when i start
peeking if that makes sense
um
yeah we played we went to university
together yes let's do the best like
and we went and we played basketball
together that's how we know each other's
how we met
um
it's my red pill people oh yeah no
that's still
it's still blowing they said it's a
small echo but there's no static okay no
static small echo
okay
i'm kidding i'm kidding i know y'all
don't like that okay
all right i'll let jess kevin talking
okay
um
i have a
ish
i have a friend coming in her name's
jess
[__] like she's walking over to co-op
right now
she's a little short
colombian
oh my days
okay
is it still
basketball
so how popular is nfl again um
it's pretty popular honestly when i
first got out here was in the middle of
the um
nfl season and one sunday they have this
like one area where they show all the
games and people were wearing
bad nfl uniforms they had like the
dolphins the um almost said the bucks
that's basketball
the packers the cowboys
um who else that they had they had like
a whole bunch of people were just
walking i was like how they know about
it out here
but
basketball not basketball but
american football is
becoming popular out here maybe not in
the uk but
different teams
i have a friend that plays in germany
and then a friend that plays in austria
as well and they're on american football
team so it's pretty big out here and
it's like growing so they don't allow
very many
americans on the team because they
wanted to be the people from like over
here so they can grow it so yeah
i don't i don't know if i've had proper
british food the only british food i've
had is the breakfast as a proper english
breakfast
i've had it once and i've never had it
again
i
it threw me off because in the states we
have bush's baked beans and i don't know
if y'all know what bush's baked beans
are but they are delicious that's why i
saw beans i was like
excuse me i was like oh bet
i can eat bushes baked beans i love
beans
and i bit into it and i was like oh this
is not what i thought it was
and the bacon out here is different it's
a little bit on the salty side
um
but other than that take away the beans
and um
a little bit less salt on the bacon it's
cool i i mess with the tomato the eggs
the toast
um
i can't remember what else it is and the
tea i love tea so
it was cool but i don't know any other
um
oh new sub
r amir thank you so much
um
yes so
have i ever
no
yes
yes i have to answer your question
there's some there's some like uk slang
that
i pick up
jazz
yo
sit down sit down sit down
[Music]
all right put you guys don't put
yourself outside if you want to
yes justin d
these are my friends from uni my role
dogs they're gonna come in
i'm gonna have to buy a louder speaker
oh am i talking i'm sorry if i'm talking
really low i know i have a loud voice
sometimes and so i don't know how loud
it is on um
how long it how loud it is on the stream
so i talk quiet sometimes
uh should i call again or is this a bad
time um
no you can call zachary i'm sorry i
didn't have my um
i didn't have
my instagram open so give me a second
and i will open it
and i will call you and we will
there we go i got your utter message oh
you called twice sorry zachary okay
um
[Music]
here we go
and sit down come and sit down
so you can sit anywhere you can sit on
the couch on that side or you can sit
here
um it doesn't matter you can sit
anywhere
hey are you sitting there
it's just sitting there hello sir how
are you
good how are you i'm doing good how's
your day going
not bad how's yours you know been up for
almost 24 hours i think we're doing good
that's great yeah so do you have any
questions you would like to ask
actually yeah so because you've been on
live for so long have you all been up to
now here and there so what we did on the
first live because um
youtube only allows you to stream for 12
hours what we did in the first one was
we actually had a show
um the first like two three hours we did
a show um
with a group of people and then from
there it was as people like left it
started it was just me ash and pearl and
we were just talking about different
things um in the red pill um i don't say
universe because it's not like marvel
but in the red pill area
that's its own universe there's tons of
us yeah and the red pill universe and
also
um
just talked about um
just life thrilling just had a good time
and tried to stay awake and then on the
second stream we had
people come in and so it was
pearl
um
red pilling the women that had came in
and we had sarah come in and um ish was
sitting down with us as well
uh okay yeah i know that um youtube had
this 12 hour rule
i didn't know that either someone told
us and um
and
we were like oh well we got to end it in
a few minutes or like an hour until we
ended it and just restarted back up
yeah the longest one i've ever actually
been a part of where i actually called
in was um
actually one of pearls where it was like
five or six hours
that was months ago wow for a live
stream
yeah i don't think she meant for it to
go that long it's just the conversation
kept uh
just kept going on and on she's like wow
it's here this has time to go okay that
one gotcha gotcha gotcha
yeah what other questions you got for me
sir
well any plans to do like the the
pre-game again are y'all just going to
kind of sit there and wing it until
like for the next six hours
um no so i have my friends that came in
my friend jessica and
dee and i'm gonna try my best
to um
ask them some questions
about red pill and everything and i'm
gonna have ish help me out because i'm
i'm still a rookie and so um
yeah that's like the next plans and then
we're just gonna have people come in
um for the next
five hours
and just see how
it ends and then we'll wrap it up once 9
o'clock hits
so how far have you gotten in your red
pill journey like what do you know so
far
um i feel like i know nothing but i feel
like i know
quite a bit at the same
are you okay hold on real quick what'd
you say ish
i think he's got his phone on speaker
okay
okay hey are you able to take your phone
off speaker because it's interfering
with the mics that we have here in the
studio
sure also can you take it off video for
a moment yeah i'm not sure
how to
do that
um i don't i'm not sure
hold on
how do you take it off oh there we go i
pushed the wrong button sorry y'all
that's what i was supposed to hit
there we go
how does it know
is it better
better awesome
um
so i i've learned about
um i've learned about the alpha and the
beta men and then i've learned about um
the feminist group i've learned about um
oh my goodness
the peterson yes jordan peterson the
uh
wage the pay
uh the
the pay the pay wage gap however you say
it um
what else have i learned
um i'm trying to think
um
there's a lot i can never remember it
until like pearl starts saying it and
i'm like oh i remember that i remember
that i feel like we've talked about a
lot today and so i feel like i've
learned everything and like what a high
value man is and like
the it's like
fit
yep finances
and frame are those the four f's
that's only three oh sorry that is three
um what's the what's the fourth
look it's been almost 24 hours i can't
count um
it's all good i understand uh what's the
fourth one
is there four
oops
ish is there four
there's four sixes what's good
the the high value man
what how about
[Music]
and then that six figures six foot and
six inches what's the he said there's
four sixes
ah oh i haven't heard the six pack one
before oh yeah
oh wow most people only say three but
they do
interchangeably okay
so yeah those are the ones that i can
like spew off the top of my head that
i've learned so far
okay
yeah
so it's been it's been a journey
um i'm still on it still on the roller
coaster of the red pill i don't know
when i'm gonna get off don't know if i
will
get off because it's a scary roller
coaster
did you watch anyone else's red pill
content or did you just kind of help her
make hers so the funny thing about it
i've seen like the people that pearl
like mentions like i've i've watched the
roommates i've watched album preach i've
watched a fresher fit i've watched those
um
those like three not three guys but
those three channels
um before i even knew what red pill was
and i've seen like little like videos of
i've never watched like
long um like multiple videos but my
brother um
my brother introduced me to um
uh fresh and frit and album preach he
watches both of those but i had stumbled
on the roommates one day
when they had a video they had the a
video with these two guys that um talk
about how to dress like a high value man
and they were in suits and i was like
this is interesting
that's the interesting part of it it's
not just um
relationship stuff there's also how to
dress there's yeah how to conduct
yourself in daily life yeah
it's a lot but it's very interesting and
i am appreciative of it
it looks like it's changing but this
place wasn't the friendliest place for
um for women
that's what pearl told me that's what
pearl told me i was like oh goodness
they were like leave
i don't know if pearl knows about this
right now but there was a woman that was
around here before her really and
well now i mean there's several now but
this is like a year or two ago i only
know her by reputation but uh
she kind of infiltrated and everyone
liked her for a minute but then uh they
kind of slowly realized she was turning
everybody against each other and
it's like okay we gotta kick her out
she's gotta go oh wow
that would be a big part of why they're
so skeptical of y'all
gotcha
i know that for the longest time
that's crazy i didn't know that they
kicked people out of the red pill
my goodness
well i mean well
i don't know if they kick me out or not
i'm sure someone has but
i they kick women
i can understand it like if a woman's
coming into a man's domain trying to
turn everybody against each other it's
kind of like you're
trying to destroy the system from the
inside out and it's like nope you can
leave before
anything gets bad i can understand that
well for what i hear it did get bad but
then they all figured it out and made
her leave yeah
that's not gonna happen with pearl and i
we're not here to turn anybody against
each other we're here to educate
well she's
too nice
yeah
like i like i'll watch people get on a
tangent on her show and she'll just kind
of sit there quietly and let it happen
like
sometimes she'll check them she'll bet
she's better at that than me she'll be
like jess you need to check these people
i'm like
one day one day i'll get there
if you're not used to it it's kind of
weird just just cut somebody off that's
yeah
it's the it's the feminine instinct in
me
hey that's what they claim to like
around here yep yep yep
i guess that's a good thing
but all right zachary i'm going to
interview my
two friends that i have in the studio
right now thank you for
calling and i appreciate all you do in
the comments as well
all right good luck with the rest of the
show all right thank you
bye
hey chad can you let me know if the
audio is still
like moving funny
so i can try and fix it
i know you guys were letting me know
that it was
yeah there's something wrong with it
dude how does it sound in
your houses headphones just sounds good
in my headphones okay um which is good
turn me up in the headphones dj this
kitty
okay
i just need to find it let's find the
video first
she's um
brief intervention brief intermission
good audio all right wonderful thank you
chad appreciate that awesome okay um
just let's get into it yeah all right so
i have
my two wonderful friends with me today
um
if you guys want to introduce yourself
you guys can also also let us know your
age your status
and
how
your lot your longest long-term
relationship
and how old you are okay so
speaking today
i go by just d.d just d in the house
yeah
i am 22 years of age
yeah you can pull it closer to you okay
there you go so you don't have to sit up
yeah so i'm currently single 22 years of
age i had a longest relationship of
almost two years
which ended in a tragic state but
yeah
i'm here
breathing
all right
yourself me i'm jess
jessica
um jess um i'm 22
23 in a couple months yeah energy that's
right i'm single
um
what else a longest um relationship a
year a
year and
it was my fault i i left it it was
just not it i didn't feed it so i was
like
um and yeah
that's it
all right bye guys that are leaving the
chat we appreciate you guys for coming
and sticking on this along with us
all right so
um
have you guys heard
anything about red pill before
i don't know what that is if you can
like give me a brief rundown so i can't
come to an understanding have you heard
like red pill blue pill i've heard of it
i haven't
i'm someone who doesn't like pay
attention so okay now you're good um
could you give them uh like a definition
of what red pill is because this is
something that i've written um so
my understanding of red pill is that
you be
it's bringing awareness
to
things in society things that are
happening in and around you um it's the
idea of your eyes being opened to
what actually happens in society but on
this podcast we really speak about
um the dynamics between the male and
female relationship
um how
predominantly females sometimes don't
see the world and what's happening from
a male perspective
and we try to shed light on that and
just have a discussion on what
our differences are and also kind of try
to come to a consensus where
there's a better understanding
to to the females but from the males
so this is something that's been around
for a minute i don't know how long it is
but um
there's a lot of people that don't know
about it like if pearl wouldn't have
told me anything about it i wouldn't
have known what red pill was like i was
telling um the guy i was on the phone
with um zachary yes
that i've watched um i've been preach
freshman fit and the roommates are the
ones that i've watched and they're
usually in the it's called the manual
sphere
and so um
like i said it's really just
understanding
from my perspective as well as usually
just understanding
men how they operate how they think what
is a high volume in and then they'll use
terms like alpha and beta and all that
good stuff so my first question is
um
what
do you think
feminism
helps or
hurts women
maybe a bit both
okay how so
i don't know
i don't know i i just think
i kind of agree because
um it can go both ways as in europeana
basically
setting you up for
success um on the green side right now
setting up for success
as in
being protected being sure of yourself
and
not just let in
what a man does
become your moral values
and that can also set you up for failure
because you also need an insight from a
man's perspective
so
when i first like started this journey i
thought i'm like feminism is fine like
there's no problem in it
and i kind of had the same view as uh
you two did but learning about it um
feminism is in the grand like
overarching and correct me if i'm wrong
ish
is really
talking about
or going against the idea of
need a man like i don't need a man i can
do it all by myself i can chase the bag
i can be older not married no kids
and happy when
the statistics show that is it 40
uh
48 year old women or
is it
gone
is it 40 year old women or 40 of women
oh here comes pro
so
um pearl be able to help me uh this is d
pro and this is jess oh oh yeah
and this is jess
um
is it 40 year old woman or 40 of women
end up unhappy and alone
she knows the stats now
um yeah over um
like wait which which one so it's like
over 30 50 over 50 of women end up
single and childless there we go and
then um the least happy demographic is
women career women making between
50 and 100k per year that are single and
childless
and it's like you might when you google
it you might find like like this is what
they do because they want they want to
like promote that this makes you happy
and it's it's really sad because i don't
know why they tell girls this like
because
they'll they'll take a one-off study
that didn't really have a good sample
size and really didn't wasn't like no no
psychologist would deem it as credible
but there's like 10 different studies
that say the same thing
like women at the age of 45 that are
queer women single and childless aren't
happy because it makes sense like you
you're living we're going to live to be
90 probably also most of our lives we're
going to be like ugly and old
no no no i'm serious but like you want
to be ugly and old because like there's
a level of attention you get when you're
young right there's a level of like
like beauty youth there's like a level
of just you know
um
like
stuff that you just get and like social
groups and it kind of goes away when you
get older so if you don't build a family
what do you have yeah you might have
millions in your bank account but like
i've been in a room with like more
millionaires than most people in their
lifetime would like ever be in like
literally like if you go to private
banking event so many rich people but
they're all like 70 and i know all of
them would trade all their money for my
youth
yeah yeah so it's like and then like we
just tell girls
chase after a career that's going to
dump you when you get too old anyway
your job's not loyal to you yeah and you
need
it's 2.5 2.5 i knew it was two points
something you need 2.5 million dollars
to retire and
unless you are
up there making them p's you
need a second income to
account for that and
i can't remember the percentage but
women are the highest rate of women or
the highest rate um to become homeless
at the end because they don't have a
second growing highest growing yeah
men still take the cake okay because
like because society views men it's
expendable right who yeah who we don't
who who goes to war men or women
women
no man men expendable sex but like like
women are the highest growing homeless
population and the funny thing is you
know what they're doing in the major
cities in the us at least i don't know
what's going on here they're they're
they're legalizing prostitution why what
are the homeless women gonna do
wow how are they gonna make money so
you'll see it in like new york seattle
they're they're legalizing prostitution
that's crazy they got to do something
with these hoes
so another question for you too
um
do you think body count matters no
no no okay what is a high number for
body count
would you say
because i don't because i say that it
doesn't matter
no matter like
whatever number you have like it doesn't
matter okay 50
what do i have to do with that listen
pause sorry for a woman what do you
think a high body count is
i don't
oh i don't know i think everyone would
think like
10 would be a lot okay nowadays if some
guy met a girl now and be like oh what's
your body count
you know yeah turn hell is frozen over
yeah
that's a lot you've got opening your
legs a bit too much then but um i think
ten or fifteen around there okay that's
what you've seen all right
um well if it really doesn't matter to
you then why should you have
you know
a body count if it doesn't matter but if
in that case since i can answer this
question
for women
i guess
like 5 or 10 or 15 however much it takes
them to get satisfied
probably whatever number you say they'll
be like yeah that's last time see the
hard thing is they don't have good
numbers on like what the average body
count of the youth is today
because like the the way the average
body count they say for a girl is like
seven okay but
you
like based on like the people you know
i don't i don't know about you but like
that wouldn't be the average like what i
would guess because i know some girls
that are probably over like a stupid
high number right so you don't really
know how it's distributed and the other
issue is that
the um
how did i put it like they take that
number from women from like age 20 to
age 70 80 90. those girls were like
i don't want to say a different cloth
because they still have birth control
they're so wild and to some degree but
like i don't know i feel like every
generation just starts to wild the wild
and wild more
true so it's like it's kind of a
double-edged sword right
so
with that um
in the uh
zachary i said we're uphill universe and
zachary's like yeah it's a universe
in the red pill sphere um for a high
value man which is someone that is make
six figures is six foot has six inches
and then zachary said
has a six it's just to be a high value
man no then what is it am i saying it
wrong
you're saying it right you're you're
close
is it it's money frame i'm so proud
sorry it's money
frame
so so you got this 10k per month so it's
120 a year yeah
money frame game no no no that's not
high value
it's money money frame game that's
that's that's if a guy wants to be more
attractive to women that's money muscles
oh okay gotcha that's what a guy like
has to do if he wants to up his value
okay but but high values you need i i
have some of these in front of me yeah
this took me forever to memorize though
um 10k per month so 120 per year and
that's adjusted so if he's in like a big
city like la new york it needs to i
don't know exactly what it is but it
needs to be more right the other thing
is that other men must accept you as
high value so like if you're just kind
of a loaner and you got no network you
don't count i don't know why i can't
tell you they just they don't count you
um so you need a network of high value
men other men must accept you you need
to be linked in level visibility because
otherwise you're not a high value you're
a man of value like some guys get their
money they don't want to talk to anyone
they go on their piece of land they
don't do anything
but that's different than like the ceo
of mergers and acquisitions
right vps like that that's that sort of
level and they have to be useful to the
group and to others okay
so that's that's a high value management
okay that is a high volume man and then
when
when it comes to
body count
it's
23 years old or
that
which one which one for the body count
so a high volume man
looks at
actually i'll say this first so
when it comes to a body count
a high value man
looks at a body count and if it's if
it's on the lower side you're more
valuable as a woman because
every
one
man that you are with it is 19
uh women that a man is with essentially
that's how they calculate it yeah it's
like your ability to bond like enough a
dude
you're a guy right so you talk to them
and i talk to women more i you know
balance probabilities like you ever have
a guy that's slept with like six figure
girls and like he just can't really like
pair like that like he can't really bond
with women girls anymore that happens to
men too but like women it's just like
quicker because over history like what
do we have to do we need the highest
value guy in order to produce the best
offspring
where men they they were trying to
they're trying to [__] these hoes you
know i mean like they're trying to
spread that they were trying to genghis
khan what was he doing
he was wilding in these streets
and so if you go throughout your 20s um
and you have over there's a lot of
people that said no more than 10 i think
12 was the most that i heard throughout
the day
your friend said 50. 15. nobody said 50.
who said 50. your friend said 50. it was
one it was someone you were on the phone
with said no no
my mom said 50. 50 what 50 uh
bodies i thought just said 50. i did she
said 50. did you say 15 15 15 15.
yeah
and so the more throughout your 20s the
more bodies you have the less valuable
you are as a woman to a high volume man
so you could have so the more you have
less the less you are because um
there's this thing called the wall and
you're 22 right yes so you're good
um okay i don't i don't know much about
the wall i just know i'm approaching it
and i'm like how do i knock it down and
not see it anymore so the wall is
essentially your
uh
what is it called something something
pink i can't remember yeah so it's
basically like as women we're gonna live
to be 90 right and i think you know as a
young woman you just get more attention
from men right like like they tend to be
more attracted to you the younger you
are i mean i'm not talking about like
teenagers but like you're 22 you're
going to get more attention than a 42
year old
in general
jello is what
yeah yeah exception though right like
but the average 42 year old mom if the
guys had to pick they're picking you
well yeah
um fertility because they surveyed men
between the ages of 20 and 70 and they
rate 22 23 and 24 year olds as the most
attractive across the board from met
like ages of 20 to 70.
because they're attracted to fertility
right that's what they want so
um
but basically like when you hit the wall
it's a subconscious acknowledgement as a
woman that you can't compete the way you
did so when and this is it's sometimes
later for some people like jlo it hit
her later right obviously you know this
girl is fine forever but but it's
basically around the age of 30 girls
realize okay i got a couple more
wrinkles in my face like i'm a little
heavier than i was 10 years ago i don't
i don't look as good as i did and so
they realize mentally that they can't
compete with themselves from 10 years
ago so the guys that they're she was
pulling at 20 like she can't pull them
at 30 anymore and she's thinking you
know what i should probably find a guy
to settle down with
because otherwise like i'm not going to
get a guy i want right so it's like like
girls just feel oh shoot girls just feel
the clock like ticking faster basically
is like what the wall is
um okay but what about the women that
are in their 30s and 40s that decides
that they would rather go for younger
men
oh that's a mating strategy for sure
because because young men like that
that's that's a very common and you're
going to see that more and more and more
because young men have less options like
because a lot of men said they didn't
realize how many [__] they were going
to get when they got into their 30s
because they're like life gets so much
better because as a girl we we wake up
at 16 and boom we get all this attention
right i mean some girls more some girls
less but even an average looking girl
gets more attention than like most guys
yeah so when a guy hits 35 and he he's
gone to the gym for 10 years now he's
got muscles now he's learned to talk to
women a little better he's got game he's
learned you know he's dated a couple
girls so he knows how to like hold you
know you know how these hoes be like
like that we'd be tripping for no reason
but like like as a guy like at first
when you're younger you might like give
in and start like arguing with them but
like
holding your frame as a man is like
important for attraction and then money
right so you do all four of those things
by the time you're 35 you have your pick
of like 10 years or less
and like
um
so a mating strategy women will do is if
they're in their 30s and they're like oh
[__]
my values gone down what's the way i can
get around this
i'm going to go for the young guys the
same way like young guys go for the
older women it's like
and but then i've ever heard from young
guys and they're like yeah if i sleep
with an older woman she's planning on
our wedding basically in a week
because because like that's like because
she's got that clock ticking because
after 35 it's geriatric pregnancy so
what like you can't
like i mean
soon if you if you hit 35 like life
makes choices for you
and some people are lucky like my family
like my mom had kids into her 40s but
that's the exception it's not the norm
and the other
so
it's one thing to say i don't want kids
when you're young it's another thing to
like have that choice taken away and
your only option is ivf but what is ivf
it's 25k a year
and it might work it might not even work
so can the average person afford that
and so it's like feminism is pushing a
luxury lifestyle on average people the
kardashians can do that
[__] five beautiful kids and she hired
someone else to care like they can do
that but that's not for the average
person like you and me like
are you done
so it's like
yeah and that's so that's like what
like the wall is basically like the the
party's over for women it's they're
realizing like like that they're you
they're
they're their beauty is going where men
men have that too it's just a little bit
later because women are we're still
attracted to you guys for money and
we're attracted to you guys for
power we're static like there's other
things that like we're attracted to that
men aren't aren't necessarily yeah yeah
but
i'm looking at the chat
um
the
kind of though oh and the other thing is
girls think that like men care about
their career too because like you always
i know you're guys
[Music]
but like a career woman they're like oh
i have
all this money right and so they're
thinking like the same way we're
attracted to a man with money they'll
think they'll be attractive to men with
money then like they hit 30
35 whatever it is and they're like i
have all this money where's my husband
and they're like nah we just wanted a
girl that wasn't ran through and maybe
it was a bit younger
and like hot
and she's like what
um so what about the men who actually
makes money
they more look at
women who aren't making money to match
their
level of you know
what the [__] is it so so they don't
care like men it's like
if if a guy has a shoe collection i
don't care like that's cool you know i'm
sure you might look cool in your jordans
but like i'm not like oh i want to bang
that right but like girls want to bang
the president they want to bang the ceo
they like they're attracted to power and
maybe like maybe it's a rap or maybe
it's like whatever whatever their their
thing is right so
met like women it's more like women
don't want to date a guy that makes less
than them
because when women get promoted they're
they're like three times more likely to
get divorced
if they out earn their husbands yeah
yeah because like historically we had to
have a guy that we looked up to so
it's not fun like i don't think that's
like a fun
reality but if you look at the data like
you can't deny it's there so i think men
don't necessarily like need a girl that
makes less than them it's the girls that
make the same don't usually want them
and they kind of look at them as like
below because i've had guys calling the
show and they say i wouldn't have a
problem with a girl that makes more than
me but it's like
she feels like she's better than me and
that's why i can't date her because she
acts like she's above me
just
wait no good go ahead do you think
honestly want different things you still
want the hot guy but you your brand
prioritizes long-term security a bit
more as you get closer to your fertility
window closing
yeah yeah so like if a girl is 30 she's
like oh [__] where's the most like i
don't even care if he's hot
i'll take the ugly guy with the money
please
okay so jess i got a question for you um
say you're with a high value man and
it's all the things that pro just listed
and he's
giving you
um
20k a month
but he's allowed to
essentially
cheat or have an escort would you stay
with him
why am i even thinking about that i
can't lie
no i
i think no i couldn't do that
i just know why not what like would i
have kids with him like yeah you can so
you're you're so like you're the main
one he loves you unconditionally
everything and you're you're his main
one and he gives you you have kids the
whole nine but he has the ability to
be able to
essentially cheat and have an escort
would you stay and he's giving you 20k a
month let's hop into 30. 30k a month 30k
a month you don't have to work
um
you just get to chill at home
and you you work the rest of your life
those are your options no i just
couldn't do it no why i just
i don't know
um like
you're either mine you're not that's it
like i get it i feel like jealousy i
think cause i'm very killer i'd kill her
sorry literally i think because i'm like
like i look at my parents and like
i would want to be together nothing like
interrupting yeah you're helping you're
giving me money and all of that
but
i i don't yeah no you can't have like
someone on the side and i don't know i
just i think i look at my parents quite
a lot and i don't see my like
dad do that so it's like a bit mad and i
yeah so um of course everyone's
different so yeah in that case
because i don't think it's considered
cheating if you come to an agreement
that he's gonna pay you 30 000 a month
and sleep with other people wouldn't you
rather use that money and build a
foundation for yourself
because he's doing what he wants but he
just wants you there
no he still loves you
he's still like i don't like guys can
cheat and still love you
i'd rather they didn't yeah
but you know but you're good
what it's like no this is it's it okay
in a girl's head this is inconceivable
okay this is like how about how dare you
yeah this is yeah the audacity
i am in but i've talked to guys okay
and they tell me they're like look at it
she was just there
like it was just better than my hand for
the night it was it's like a handshake
to them sometimes
sex
and as a girl we're like
what like i could never do that but like
to guys it's just
it's literally easy like i've been in
that situation
um
it wasn't great i eventually i stopped i
was like i can't do it because i thought
about myself i wouldn't
want to be like if i was that girl i
wouldn't be in that situation i wouldn't
be like cheated on um
but yeah they take
if they have that opportunity they will
take it no hesitation whatsoever no
matter the age bear in mind this guy was
he was way older than me he was i think
and now i'm way older
yeah would you
would
you do everything that i just mentioned
and he doesn't cheat would you would you
essentially stay with him but he's not
he doesn't have no escorts no nothing
yeah
okay so now
thinking now no but maybe of course
no no i'm talking not not not the guy
that you're talking about no no no no
the situation i explained the high
volume in yeah so you wouldn't you
wouldn't stay with them even if you had
kids maybe now i'll say no now because
i'm like i'm still not at that stage yet
okay
i think as you grow as pearl said
your like mentality changes and then
you're just they're like
no
it's time to have like a family you know
if you're ugly or not like i'll i'll
take the help yeah if that was in the
future if i got that that and i would
literally build a foundation for myself
and then scroll for that like
as long as i'm fine in the future then
like
do whatever yeah so you think that would
be you losing say you're staying with
him while he's having fun with other
people
it's almost to me looking like you're
really there and the only thing he's
given you
that he's been giving those girls that
he haven't is money
and that he loves you
because he's given them sex and
enjoyment and all these stuff he's given
you the same thing
so do you think that's a bit of
self-respect
partially like i i personally like i i
couldn't sign up for that right yeah but
the point is there's a group of people
that do and the reason why is because
they get the legacy they get their name
on the deed they get the life insurance
they get the last name they get the kids
they get they get him at home they get
and to them if they're like you know if
i get to live this lifestyle if i get
the man of my dreams if he has every
single thing i want
i'll just put up with it i don't like it
but
if there's no stds no one ever finds out
there's no outside babies he's not in
love with her who cares
that's that's just the mentality i i
personally i think maybe we grew up kind
of similar like my parents were together
they didn't they didn't do that stuff
yeah yeah but
but it's just interesting because it's
just a lifestyle for a certain group
yeah yeah and it's not and it's not
really cheating because
he lets them know yeah it's exploring
their options because one thing i've
learned and it still blows my mind today
a high volume man has
umpteen options yeah and so if you're
his main he still
has those he still has the ability to go
out and cheat why not let you know up
front hey this is what i'm gonna do
because it's in my nature to want to do
this but you're
you're my number one you're my main i
love you i don't love these girls
because men can have sex and not be
attached to
uh women at all so they just like pearls
say they see it as a handshake so
wouldn't you rather have him
tell you straight up what's gonna happen
instead of he's going to cheat
regardless because
or explore his options regardless
because he is of high value and he has
the means to be able to do that
but when you want to be told up front
that is happening and be able to sit
back chill i'll get 30k a month my man
still come home to me
i'll take it no i i really won't but
well i think
because of how society has you know been
advanced how it has just grown i think
now most women would
go through with it because
almost like money is literally
everything at this point so they would
take that money and invest in that money
and have him there like it's literally
their sugar daddy yeah well he can do
what he wants as long as they're getting
money and they're enjoying their life
but the question of the hour is
because you can love this guy and come
to an agreement how would you feel if he
actually ended up having kids with other
women while he's with you yeah i mean
that's usually the
the line right that's why a lot of these
guys use escorts because
these girls are literally like paid to
be clean and not get pregnant like that
like they're paid thousands like
hundreds of thousands of like this is
their job right
um but no i think most girls like
that that's the line
that's over the
that's outside of the agreement and it's
interesting because as much as i want to
say like
like i mean so these guys have like
tiger woods
he remember his cheating scandal way
back when yeah and everyone was judging
him and for good reason he had a lot of
hoes oh my god i heard there was like
facebook groups with all of them
yeah yeah wow
yeah oh my gosh reckless and um but
oh someone said you don't know what it's
like to get to like
to get off like the the what do they
call it the field the green the green
to a boss full of 18
uh was it like 18 something woman yeah
like eight like brazilian models yeah
all dying to sleep with you with no
strengths attached yo that's like that's
hard for any guy yeah
i don't care who you are you could be
the
guy that has the most self-control is
still going to be hard for you throwing
themselves yeah at you like please like
that's
fighting over who gets to like be with
him that night
and it's a super this is it most guys
will never experience oh yeah
just like most girls won't ever
experience having high value men fight
over them yeah
this is the live this is the one maybe
one day pearl if we keep in this in this
fear maybe one day bro we're past wall
i'm not past the wall yet i'm not
passing yeah like are we peaked at like
22 apparently 20 30. no first i
personally and people may say
they will arrest you yeah but i
i think that now
i
i think i look better now than when i
did in high school okay
i
rarely look the same but i think that
just
how i
kind of like how i carry myself because
i was very like we talked i was very
tomboy in high school so it was just
like a i looked like a dude or a lesbian
and a lot of people thought i was a
lesbian you're a lesbian yeah i would i
would play that you were that far in the
time
look i just was like very very tomboy
and i would play that joke on people
like yeah i'm a lesbian people would
believe it because i was a tomboy i've
gotten that one
yeah and so i think
now i think i look better now than in
high school i know people i'm like
that's cat but if you saw me in high
school
you'd probably agree
oh they said 24 was a woman's peak hey
they said i look 24 so
i'm right there so
the cool section's funny i i gotta love
them
reverse ageism that's what i'm doing
benjamin button up in here
um
but yeah i don't know it's a very small
percentage of society that does this but
it's interesting because it kind of
shows people's true natures like
what happens when a guy gets all the
money and power in the world and what
what happens when a girl gets all the
beauty in the world and the youth who
who do they pick each other
mm-hmm
but then you also see hollywood where
they also have terrible relationships
like and that's kind of a combination of
the most beautiful women in the
maybe not i wouldn't say most powerful
men but like at least they have status
and stuff yeah yeah i would say their
status is higher than most because there
are a lot of
excuse me there's a lot of powerful men
that nobody knows about there's so many
like i would say undercover like
billionaires that nobody knows about
because they're just
they just they're in the top one percent
right and they just go to work go home
and they just chill with their family
yeah
and nobody knows about them because
they're not in like mainstream what have
you guys talked about so far what red
pill um
i asked him about feminism but we didn't
dive deep into it okay
um
so
did you guys know the pay gap isn't real
the the pay gap i didn't mention what
that is
the difference between like
uh women's wages and men wages how they
say women get paid less than men oh that
pay again yeah they get all cap though
yeah you think it's all cap you think
it's really it's true okay women get
paid less than men yes
it depends what you do of course
yeah so it's interesting i used to
actually think that too
but it's interesting because if you take
into account
the jobs that women work
so women tend to pick careers that make
less money and they tend to work less
hours
so if me and you we're gonna work a job
and i worked eight hours for a year and
he works 10 hours for a year he's going
to beat me by the end of the year
and it's interesting because
let me find this
um
men are more
i want to say 17 times more likely to
die in the workplace
so it's like oh they're picking the like
you get paid more if you might die
oh
no i'm serious who wants to do like yeah
women don't want to take that risk i'm
not like if you if you made okay if you
made six figures you had to work an oil
rig would you do it
um
sorry i'm not speaking english
no you would not they know you don't
speak english
she's playing she does
oh i do
she just didn't want to answer it i
thought you were american
no she's not she's a colombian oh oh
well i'm venezuelan sorry i always get i
don't know why i get that
venezuelan sorry lo siento they're right
next to each other no venezuelan she's
from america oh 23. men are 23 more
times more likely to die in the
workplace than women oh
yeah that's mad
yeah go ahead you know when it comes to
the wages and stuff and the difference
people only say that now
that the men get paid more than women i
mean again history has changed and
they're mostly sticking to what's been
you know it's been that way in the past
where
women have to get paid less or women are
not supposed to work and the men are
supposed to so i guess that's just
driving straight through
till today for men to be working as hard
as they are and i mean men love money as
well as they love women so they rather
work to get money and
women come on money get women yep there
you go they're like they're running
you know it's okay so why are women
looked at as oppressed throughout
history when men were the ones that had
to go to war and women were protected
and got to stay home
that she just
trust me she does it all the time
but we look at women and did you know
that women when they asked for the what
the majority of women didn't want the
right to vote
because that meant you had to get
drafted
and let me tell you in 2022 if i had to
pick if i had to give up my right to
vote and my other option was drafted
i would give it up
i'm not trying are you trying to fight
an award no i'm going to put anything i
know i don't know if i can say that on
youtube
i'm a scaredy cat by oh my god though
yeah no i'm i'm not no i'm like get back
to the i'll be in the kitchen yep i as
crazy as it sounds i would be like i'll
stay at home i'll cook and clean wash
everything
i'll do whatever you want just don't
send me to war yep exactly but um also
when you look at it with the war and
everything you know
i'm not going to go into specific data i
can't remember but i do remember that
once there was men that went to war
and
the women were the one who actually got
the community and the environment back
together which made women
more powerful than a man
yeah i'm sure there's some societies
that's happened in
yeah because even when you look at it
now
some men look at women as oh you can't
do this job because it's just for men oh
i do
you do yeah i think that
yeah a lot of people just look at it as
what is she doing here like if a woman
decides to go work at the old rig or do
construction or just do manly stuff
they're just
not looked at as the same anymore oh i
just i don't think women are capable of
doing a lot of hard jobs
like and i i the the reason i think this
is because i have numbers to back it up
like the those industries are 99.5
male
and i don't i don't think it's because
women want to do them i think it's
because they're like dear god please no
an oil rig
anyone else oh my gosh it's the worst
place to work for me yeah
i don't even think most men want to do
those jobs no not at all but i mean most
men would just go after the most money
yeah even if it's worth risking their
lives yeah
but i think that's that's that's just
something innate in men because you guys
always had to provide for us yeah no
matter what just like women always had
to nurture the children
and so it's interesting because if you
look at countries where um
where they they listed countries from
the most free to the least free when it
comes to women it's pretty easy to do
that because you take like places like
the middle east um i know saudi arabia a
couple years ago like women couldn't
drive and you take the most egalitarian
countries in the world like norway um i
think was one of them but you know what
i'm saying like the most where they've
taken the most measures for women to be
free and it's interesting because the
pay gap it increases in the free
countries and decreases in the least
free countries because when women are
given the option to choose they pick
jobs that have to do with people and
those don't tend to pay as much
it's true yeah that's very true yeah
like who t and it's funny because we'll
march the streets because women don't
they
they're not in the one percent right but
what about only fans why aren't we
marching the streets for equality
strippers models
kendall jenner makes too much money yes
hey pay the men the same
crickets right
but it's interesting because it's like
it seems like sometimes we only march
the streets when it doesn't benefit us
but we never advocate for men
i agree 100
do you think that there should be a um
[Music]
uh a men's support group
cool i feel like it shouldn't
you feel like they shouldn't they should
women support group and also with that
being said is that the right word
i think you mean men's shelters are you
in the menstrual support group
no so
okay yeah
i was just making sure i was right i
don't want to be out here walking yeah
you're fine
okay go ahead
yeah just as um
with the kendall jenner the male models
and the female models i feel like
everyone should be paid
for the hard work that they put in not
because you're more beautiful
more gorgeous and you work the runway
men do it too men look good men look
gorgeous as well
i feel like everyone should be paid
equally just for the work you put in to
the job when it comes to that kind of
thing
you know i feel like it's pretty unfair
on their behalf because
it's more look that like
i've done so much work so much more than
what this person have put into yet
they're still getting paid like what is
difference so i i i do my channel right
so the
and let's say i had merch and i wanted
to pay you both to model for me for
march
if when she wears my shirt my
sweatshirts i sell
50 and when you wear my sweatshirts i
sell 10. should i still pay you the same
i mean
like the work because
looking at it is like
it depends on how you sell the product
so
if she looks good in your product it's
more likely to sell than a mandate yeah
that doesn't yeah so i guess it's the
same for the modeling situation because
women tend to sell a product more
well i just like it's funny because when
you start like hiring people you kind of
understand like the employer's point of
view and so if if you're not making me
money then i like why would i pay you
more you know what i mean like like if
the girl's pay making me money of course
i'm gonna pay her more and that's a
group
so
that's like why you see um and like the
one percent too
because more men are willing to work 80
hours a week for like 40 years not me
couldn't be me no yeah most men aren't
going to do it either but like of course
they're going to pay the men more
because more men are going to do it and
yeah they're more men are going to be
good at it because most girls want
like it's a long time most girls are
like you know i'm going to start a
family i'm good yeah
now you were saying about modeling there
are areas where men
don't
get paid um the same as women but you
don't hear
men saying
oh we want equal rights we we don't want
to pay gap in these areas in these areas
they just they don't say nothing so why
do you think women
put substitute infinite emphasis on
things like that when it really
there really isn't one there's just
things that are
innate in
um
females and innate and men that make men
more viable to have those
top earners and like ceo positions so
why do you think women um
go so hard for a pay gap because they
probably feel like they're more
deserving
than a man
getting
you know more money how so if
say say we get um
how can i best explain this
say
you're you're a ceo and i'm a
i don't know what's a step down from a
ceo we have the same degrees and
everything i actually know let's say
we have the same degree same um
application everything
um but you get paid more and i get paid
less
there is what i was talking about
there's things that are innate and men
and innate in women you're going to get
paid more because
of just
they want somebody that can negotiate
that's not going to be
more
um agreeable with somebody that's going
to get the job done and that's just
something that's biological in men and
when i heard that the first time i was
like
well
why can't
women
learn how to do that
but that would be
considered
turning into a man because i asked pearl
that i was like well why can't women
learn how to be more masculine to get
these positions
but it would be
more
when they act more masculine
that's
less valuable to a man in a sense so you
would get it because you have traits
that
are viable to the company and it's
success
and i wouldn't get that does that make
sense so it's not
oh i'm not getting as much money because
i'm a woman
it's that i don't have the qualities to
get this job done and that's just
something that's innate in me
yeah i agree definitely about getting
the job done
more than just like i need to get more
money yeah
is that right pearl
yeah okay she is red pill no
i'm scared don't say that no oh my gosh
i like she it's funny because she didn't
know any of this stuff like
i don't know two three months ago but
now it's like she could recite it it's
so funny to oh goodness to see the
evolution
you know it's interesting we're talking
about body count earlier
if you're a virgin what's your chance of
a happy marriage as a girl
i don't know
i mean
i'm not so i don't know i don't know 80
guess what it is after five partners
i was able to say ten but no
it's higher than ten oh oh oh wow
thirty percent oh was it twenty-five
i thought it was twenty-five i said that
earlier it's actually thirty that is mad
see
i'll be back there
be careful
all right
you know
and so
with that little snippet of information
would you
um
do you think you would have
done things differently
to
be able to be in that on that pathway
essentially i don't think so no you
would have i i would just
yeah i wouldn't have changed anything
okay
interesting
oh yeah
no i won't change anything you wouldn't
no no would you oh my god yeah yeah i
would you would yeah
i wanted to wait till i was married same
if i could if i could go back and change
it i would i would still be a virgin to
this day yeah me too
i don't know
she's like [__] too fun
you can't give that up she said i want
to ride i want to run i mean i would i
would have waited but i think
i think i just
it was the moment
at that moment i was like you know what
i'm gonna eventually do it anyway so it
was like so i don't think i would have
like
waited i mean i've waited a lot i didn't
lose it like
what is the average age that someone
would lose it i'm guessing like 16. okay
i lost it when i was what 20 okay same
so i
i was gonna it was gonna eventually
happen yeah
when am i
like when am i gonna get married like
what when i'm 80
yeah
like yes no you're not
you have 10 more years to live
that's all just
another thing with people not waiting is
only because
they don't know when it is going to
happen
people are more impatient these days to
be waiting for
someone to come along instead of just
going to explore your options some women
just like men explore the options to
know what and what they don't like in
women
or just to just have fun some women
rather do go and explore their options
but not as much as a man would in order
for them to say okay i would rather
settle down with this man and make
things right
but
who knows you know
well yeah i do think it's a lot because
i do remember being 20 and being like
when am i going to meet my husband
are you sure at 20 or like 8 years old
you have a dream of just getting married
and just having like 20.
about what seven i was like yeah but i i
don't know 18 i'm moving out 20 i'm
gonna be married 25 i'm gonna have kids
none of this
i said that at 25 i was going to have
kids have five years with just me and my
husband actually i think i said
i said like 20
no i said five years with me and my
husband and then 30 i would have kids
well
here i am sliding door dm's right please
lads
i want to be in slip and slide i want to
be an auntie yes
another another red pill truth women
initiate divorce seventy to eighty
percent of the time uh and if you're
college educated ninety percent so if we
get divorced there's only a ten percent
chance that he did it
men ain't leaving it's the women
because we're incentivized to do so they
don't get what they want no because
because women can leave and take half
his money and put them on child support
for 18 years
did you know in certain states in the u
in the u this is in the u.s but
if
a man
let's say me and you are dating okay
and we have a kid and your name's on the
birth certificates chillin year three
you find out that kid's not yours you're
like oh my god he's white
i didn't even notice and
i just thought he was light
anyways
so so
you're still on the hook for child
support in certain states
oh yeah i think i know about that for
sure yeah
because your name
is stamped already you already stamped
your name so now
i gotta deal with all of that which is
crazy because the woman had the bad
behavior she trapped the dude which is
yeah
so then in that case
can she
still file for child support for the
one who's actually the father and
receive
basically double that would be funny not
funny that's horrible but like that
would be like that would be crazy if she
could do that yeah because then you're
receiving money from the man who isn't
the child's father and the man who is
i think you probably can you know
i think you know that coming in that
situation
probably can
who knows yeah the
wow that's mad yeah yeah
women
i can't believe that
i thought it would be the man
no no and that's the thing like women
always talk about how a man's gonna
leave you high and dry like he'll trade
you in for a younger model but it's just
not the reality
men really don't leave
women are leaving
and and it's crazy too because women
really shouldn't be leaving because we
own two-thirds of consumer debt
so
yeah
women
women spend a ton of money on stupid
[__] all the time that's true yeah and
yeah
and since we need 2.5 million to retire
like a lot of women are on track to
being homeless
oh yeah if they don't get married and so
they leave
although they might get a good chunk of
change because they took half i don't
know so some girls it works out for but
it's not it's not like right you know
yeah but then
just like you said they spend money on
stupid [__] so that money
that they may win from a divorce you
know
they're gonna spend it on stupid [__]
yeah and then they're still on track to
being homeless because they don't know
how to control their spending yes
correct you're right yeah you know like
the investing part of it is so
you know so amazing that if you got that
money you could literally take it and
put it into something and put it in a
way that you would receive
back so i put my money that i won into a
business where i can get the money back
do something that can save you from
becoming homeless in a couple years or a
couple months or next week you never
know what's gonna happen so investing is
so important
when you've got that money there
like come on go and buy a hotel i would
take that money back hotel because i
know i would get a lot of money back
you know
yeah
um
when
have you guys heard of the term
hypergamy
big big bud you know you can refresh me
that one
so hypergamy
is the action of marrying or forming a
sexual relationship with a person of
superior sociological or educational
background
women date across and up hierarchies hmm
so
a woman if she's a five she needs to
date a six or a seven
like women date uh where men date down
mostly when it comes to status and money
women
that is true you know
yeah
they need that support they need that
money
they need
stability
from a man
at this point instead of
not getting it
is it stability though
they just don't want to spend their own
money
partially
i mean some guys say women marry the
lifestyle not the man
that is true very true yeah
and if the lifestyle goes away so does
she
yeah
that's a very
good way to put it
wow
damn my brain
they say that women can't love in the
same way men love
because men will love you just for being
you and men
sort of love each girl they've been with
because they they um
release a hormone that makes them
territorial
that women don't release
um
and
but if a girl marries a guy and tomorrow
he starts doing nothing and becomes a
bum she doesn't love him anymore
but
a man
with a girl she could be a bum he
doesn't care
so like we don't love the same
that's so crazy like women are sex
objects
um men are success objects
she literally just
put everything in one like
yeah
it's very true when you
think about it you know
i mean women go after success but
men are their success
don't you think
maybe i don't know
it's true i do agree that men and women
love differently
but um
i don't know maybe
i think the way i am i don't know
like if you're a bomb like i
like to me
like the amount of money and stuff that
really doesn't like
bother me
like i would prefer
to like
not work together but if we're on the
same like level
to like
have each other's backs like and then
grow
together
this is me no i understand i would
prefer a guy my age where we can like
build something together
but i i still would prefer a man that's
smarter than me
and that i can try like i i really feel
better as a woman if he's making more of
the decisions and leading and i can
trust him to do that yeah
yeah
like it's because when we're pregnant
we're so we're vulnerable for nine
months
like we're crazy we're insane
and now i'm serious i want this
you know how you feel right before you
get your period and you're like i'm so
mad at the stupidest thing oh yeah yeah
like nine months
and so we need the guy to be like
logical and lead and then on top of that
like we want him to be able to provide
while we raise the kid for the first
couple years most women you definitely
need that support level in a man
like what's the point of it if it's not
you know
um a question is
why do you think that some women go
after
men who struggles to make money
there's four things women look for it's
money muscles game frame
so it's just probably a guy who looks
good and is a smooth talker
like the guys you can
the guys that you can think of that did
that
are are they hot are they pretty
attractive yeah there it is
so like there's mating strategies that
women go through so she might take a guy
that has the jeans that she wants so
that's like the looks the jeans and
maybe the status
and he might not have the beta like
provider provisioning
but she thinks maybe she can build him
up
that is true yeah but if he if he's a
bum too long she'll leave
she won't it might take a couple years
but she when it gets time to like i
gotta bet on a guy to have kids with
like if nothing changes
yeah like she's got she's not gonna
for for the majority they're not gonna
trust him with like to be the father of
her kids
yeah it's too fat
i see that yeah
because the closer and closer we get to
35 it's
like it just becomes more like crunch
time like you gotta pick
you know it's like like that sounds so
bad it's like horses you gotta make a
bet
it is true it was scabby i know
i know 22. oh my god i wasn't 35 and
then you just said like no i need
someone now like
you got i'd hope you could find someone
in 13 years
well that's a long time
yeah
i think
this generation is just
completely different
so different
and it's like
i don't know i i just see them very
different of course
our parents times
was
yeah but i feel like it was definitely
better back then because now it's
so much harder to actually find someone
that you would consider you mean there's
hot people out there there's people
that's making money that you would
literally be like oh i will date
her for sure
but then
the way things are going now
people lose
sight of the date and
or they lose the definition of what
dayton actually is
and take it more of
is just
sex
which
come on i know everyone would enjoy sex
but people really just don't do that
anymore
they just are so this society is so off
track
that
people would rather date someone who was
born
before this gen z
crap that's been happening
because it's more likely to be set up
for success
and support
so you don't know why that is so
basically in the 1960s when they
developed birth control that changed the
world forever
there's no going back so women have two
mating strategies
alpha fox beta bugs which is the the
jeans the provider makes sense when a
girl's on birth control she gets to
fulfill both mating strategies so when
she's young she gets to screw the guys
that are the alpha [__] and when she
turns 30 and she's like oh [__] i need a
guy she'll find the beta provider
maybe cheat with the alpha guys
it's not fun it's not fun not like but
it's just it's true that's that's the
that's the
you know i was telling you the kid that
got trapped like that's that's the
strategy like women are getting the beta
pro provisioning providing from the one
guy get the genes from the other guy
and so
a lot of times what you're going to see
is if you ask 80 of women what they want
in a man they list 20 of men sometimes
less some studies say 5 some studies say
10 some studies say 15 but i do 20 on
the high end so the reason women say
things like men are trash and are the
problems is because we're all screwing
with the same ones like for example how
tall are you
six four so you're probably in the top
like one two percent of height
because i know it's ten percent um are
six foot and taller so i feel like
that's six foot and taller it's ten
percent
indeed
no but you see what i'm saying so
so you find that the girls
are more promiscuous and they're
sleeping around more because they have
birth control so they're not afraid of
getting pregnant as much
but then
you see one in three men under 30 are
either haven't had sex in the past year
or a virgins
yeah and so it's like
yeah and so you see more and more men
not having sex with anybody and then you
see
um
more and more women sleeping with a
smaller and smaller percentage of guys
and it's partially because of social
media because
a girl that's an aide
has access to those guys yeah
so she can
yeah she can
like drake can fly her out
coat like
oh no he died sorry
i don't know an nba player right yeah
and she she then is gonna think she's
just like hot enough to attain those
guys she's like oh i slept with him so
i'm on his level
no
he's just no you were just better than
his hand
no no i'm serious a lot of them yeah
literally i mean he looked good but he
like he's never gonna wife you
yeah and so girls will like confuse the
two so it'll be like you'll see
girls that are fours fives and sixes
or you know
you could do two threes and four but
like you'll see them sleeping with this
sevens eight and nines but those guys
would never be seen with them in public
and so they'll think they're on that
level instead of getting a guy in their
own level
i definitely agree they definitely
rather
be seen in public with a man who looks
successful
and who is successful who has that money
to take them out on beautiful dates and
stuff because of public figure i'm
talking about the girls yeah the girls
i'm talking about no but i'm saying like
the guys won't be seen with them yeah
they wouldn't want they wouldn't want to
take a guy out who's not no they don't
the guys don't want to take the girls
out oh the guys don't want to take the
girls a very small percentage so like
the the 20 or less right the guys that
are screwing everybody
they the girls they are sleeping with
they like they're sleeping with 80
percent of women
so a lot of them think they're as hot as
those guys and that they're on that
level but they're not
oh yeah
definitely you know you won't see them
out in public yeah what do you think is
gonna happen when a man who's sleeping
with 80 percent of women go out in
public and a few of them are out there
he's being caught in public with one of
them
no i mean i think he just has them all
with side chicks
i mean i like what it would have men
like drake do they just say oh [__] i
can have ig models every weekend why
would i tristan thompson yeah like
they just i mean some of them end up
getting married but i think for their
20s they're like this is amazing
different women every weekend i guess
they call this the hoenn stage of your
20s yeah that guy's grown
why are you doing that
because you can
but what do you think about people who
haven't gone through that stage
in their 20s and decides to go through
it in their 30s instead men men do that
more because that they get the ability
to have that stage in their 30s
where women we get that ability in our
20s so a woman has a whole face it's
usually in her 20s men more so in their
30s that's why you see men have like
mid-life crisis
because they're like oh my god i have
access to women now
because essentially
oh women don't need finances to go
through a whole phase
no they just got to be there yeah
gotta have access to something else
essentially hot available and willing
yep that's it
it's that simple like
they don't even have to really be that
attractive yet yeah i've heard guys oh
my gosh the things i've heard them say
is like
yeah like i was embarrassed in the
morning oh my god i can't believe i did
that like yo embarrassed in the morning
yeah that's crazy like post not clarity
have you had any of those moments where
you're like dang i'm embarrassed
no not really no i think there are some
people who actually are embarrassed
after oh yeah right after they're
finished having sex they're like what
the [__] did i just do
you shouldn't have you're a body wasted
have you ever had a wasted body pearl
have i ever had a wasted body
i mean my last boyfriend it didn't work
out so i feel like everyone i'd rather
be a virgin
yeah so every single one is a wasted
body pretty much i mean yeah i wish i
was a virgin
i can see that so
do you think women are a lot happier
when they're a virgin yeah according to
the data yeah yeah you you don't go
for me personally
the mental turmoil i've been through
since i started
engaging in sexual activity
is
i'm a virgin guys
is um
i told them that um
i literally there is so much that i
would not have gone through if i would
not have
been
doing any of that
like a lot
and i don't know
if it was helpful or more helpful or
more hurtful
i think in some ways it
opened my eyes to a lot of things that i
was naive to
and just
didn't want to see but like
it was right there in front of my face
and then it
yeah just things and just didn't want to
go through things and i went through
them so i think it's definitely a 50 50
between that because it's always a
lesson learned
but then some people are traumatized
or just go through many other things
that are going to be a negative impact
on their lives yeah because of that it's
not even that i'm traumatized it's just
like
i'd rat like if it was up to me i'd be a
virgin again so
like if i could undo it i would yep
so like i would look at everyone where's
your button pearl push it oh born again
yes
born again virgins
um
so and it's kind of and then there's the
mating strategies in the church where
women will ask the next guy to wait and
pay full price even though she gave it
to the last guy for free mm-hmm
so
these guys are what
i
imagine
no
my first time the guy waited ages
believe it or not
why
i don't know i really don't know
did you give another guy like no i
wasn't talking i was a lot happier
that's why i asked that question would
you be a little happier but then i i was
like i actually was like i wasn't i
didn't care about guys back then but um
that guy waited
i think i met him in 2018
and i ended up doing it 20 20.
you're lying i'm serious
two years
yeah literally were you guys friends or
dating we
my guy had a whole girlfriend
oh
a whole girlfriend we're talking to mike
he had a whole girlfriend
so why'd you sleep with him
did you not know i did but i i did my
own research basically she said you
wouldn't take a cheater but you got
cheated on for free
well not not me
sort of you're like but besides
i know i know and i d like i noticed
that after because i i really noticed
that you just said because i really
liked him like i
liked him a lot i i get it but i'm just
like so you you would be there you you
would take the 30k cap
yeah you're gonna take the 30k i'm
finding this i'm finding this out put
the caps in the chat that guy if i that
guy did like now you did it for free
you did it for free
yeah it was really sad after i was just
like what the [__] just like
no you can't you okay yeah but did you
get this guy
not tell you he had a girlfriend no he
didn't tell her no she just said she do
i did my own research i found out oh you
found out he didn't say it from his
mouth
um
before actually before but i was before
we did it before it happened i even
thought i was like should i and then i
was like i'm gonna do it eventually like
i might as well do it with someone i
like
but i could have
someone waited
i mean he couldn't be having sex with
other girls for all i know
mm-hmm but what and
his
according to her
um i saw it his girlfriend is hot
i would rather take his girlfriend from
him she's gorgeous and treat her like a
queen
than him cheating on i think i told you
this story jess i think so um
is it
what
i know you're younger but what why
like what
what attracted you to like do that even
though you had a girlfriend um
i think the way he was
i i liked his personality okay
um like we had a good vibe
like it was never boring
um
like we could literally just chill
and just randomly look at each other and
we'll just burst out laughing it was
that kind of like
friendship would you say i don't i don't
know mm-hmm
and then um
i i knew him for a long time so i
he knew me inside out not inside out but
he knew he was like no yeah
he knew you inside
but um
i knew him quite well so
yeah i just don't know why i think i
just i created a story in my head and
then i was like just do it um but his
girlfriend's pretty and then eventually
i was like listen
i don't want to talk like i just
i think it's better you just go your way
because i wouldn't like it um if it
happened to me
still dating
i don't know because i think the last
time i spoke to him was this year
and um
he oh yeah he ran
i think last year um he randomly called
me
after like a whole year of not talking
he randomly called me
and then i was like who's this
and then from then on we
we just got this contact back um and
then this year again i was like listen i
can't lie
like are you still with your girl um and
he was like yeah and i was like okay
cool like
this is fine
but he would he messaged me in february
and was like
he was trying to meet up at night and i
was like that's a bit dodgy
and
i said no guys i said no good
good job because i was in bed and i was
tired
and i was like i can't do this anymore
like i can't and then
eventually i got really tired i was like
if you're still with her i don't think
we should be like in contact anymore
like mm-hmm and then we just
ways
um
yeah
yeah he doesn't he doesn't um he doesn't
come
he didn't go uni
he got a full-time job as a
[Music]
i'm not sure but yeah what is that what
is it alpha widow oh yeah alford wow
look at me knowing terms
um have you
can you
is it is just for yeah because it's a
widow anyways um
so
is there one person that
you
can think of that was just
oh the sex was like astronomical best
you've ever had
um um
not the best but
like the best i've enjoyed like out of
all that you have done it's like top
recently but um
let's leave it there
would you
how do you how do you do like
define it would they go back to them or
would they yeah do you
okay if you had all your exes in a room
who would you run to
none of them oh no you gotta pick like
you have to pick one
like everyone you've had sex with which
one would you run to
like who is who do you think about the
most
no no one no
maybe she's not i don't know she's um
probably
i think the first one yeah yeah yeah so
it's basically like alpha widow is
when a girl sleeps with a guy and she
sees him as the best he could he can do
have you ever seen a girl that gets
cheated on a million times and you're
like why does she go back
and with her like you're like why on
earth would you be willingly a side
chick well it's because they see that
guy as the best they can do like whether
it's connection whether it's hi whatever
it's whatever they're looking for that
guy has the most qualities of a guy that
they want
so
when she sleeps with guys in the future
this is the problem when you sleep with
more people um the other guys can't
compare
so you might see the next guy but you're
thinking of the last one
um
he wasn't the best evil but
i'll pick the first i'll pick the first
one
i mean you're young so i don't know
maybe it hasn't like not ever got my
whole life ahead of me no i'm saying not
everybody
you said you lost you're 22 you lost
your virginity at 20 that's two years so
i don't
like it's not that much time so maybe
maybe you're not alpha widowed but it's
really common like i'm sure you've seen
a girl that's dating the next guy but
she her heart's still with the last guy
alfa widow mad
no i feel smart now that i know what
that means
so
so imagine okay we're on the savannah
okay
and
that
you two were dating actually you're both
dating you're like the ruffle and we're
dating sister wives okay so you guys you
guys fight
okay
and
he he wins so he kills you
he is gonna take
the wives with you
and that's like why alpha widow like is
a thing because before the the best guy
that we could do
like
the the loser would be dead
so we would spend the rest of our life
with the best guy that's why there's
like so many wives and one man
isn't that the same for men though
because men go through all these women
but there's always this one girl
that he would go back for for sure uh
well men love differently they can feel
that about multiple women
but yeah no i mean it's it's a little
different because like men from what i
understand can love more than one girl
at a time
where women it's it's one
it's just who has her
mentally anyway
i agree
but yeah i've always heard like there's
a group of guys that are like obsessed
with their high school girlfriends
like it's like a it's like a thing like
he's still
she was perfect i was young i don't know
it's like you graduate from high school
and you haven't seen each other in years
and when you see them again you could be
in a relationship with someone else but
be like oh i just fell in love again
yeah that's true um
okay let's see so super chats pearl what
do i think about the black pill oh you
don't know what black pill is do you
wait there's more pills
no black pill isn't it's not as complex
red pill is like the biggest one black
pill is everything starts with looks
basically
so like like red pill is money status
game frame basically black pills looks
like 90 percent of the dating market
looks butchered
um i can understand that i think if you
want genuine desire from a girl
everything starts with looks but the
dating market isn't necessarily like
that because a girl will date a guy for
long-term security like that's why you
saw those models with hugh hefner
but i think black pill i i do think in
terms of like genuine desire
which is basically like when you're a
girl's first choice
um and she she's like very very
attracted to you i think that that's
pretty much black pill
but you can do things to increase it
like
you know what percent of guys are jacked
so if you want to
increase your smv like that's something
you can do so a lot of the black pillars
are like doomers they're like i was born
a sub five my life is over but they're
not jacked i'm like why don't you try
getting jacked first see how that goes
yeah
it takes a while though apparently i
wouldn't anyways um
hanger
bbc does a pay audit finds that women
are paid more guys
given raises too much feminists go
hysterical and re-victim dragon stallion
1001 massachusetts asked women if they
wanted to vote in 1895 and only four
percent said yes 96 percent didn't want
the right to vote
wow
because we hey can i call around one to
cst sebastian asked her mom was the in
the day was six foot tall
minimum height a thing oh that was when
my mom was on the phone oh i heard you
talking to her yeah did you tell her i
missed her
no i didn't i'll tell you next time i'm
sorry
we are on the back end pearl home
stretch yourself you guys got this
we can just end it now
i'm kidding
what was that
she was like oh what we've come this far
for what
i would
like pearl if you got anything in your
head and you're like yeah we're just
going to end it now i'd be pissed
and i'm like
i'd be pissing i didn't even stay up all
night
i mean i said
11 p.m
no no like um
whatever that 11th hour is
it's past the little hour
isn't it isn't it 5
19 p.m yeah 17 19. but like it's isn't
it
oh shoot i'm thinking 24 i'm thinking i
can't do math i don't know this is 24
it's 17 19. so what when's the last
hour it's 9 30 right yes 9 30. so the 20
so 20 minutes 6 30 7 30 so four hours
left yeah
2100 hours i feel like i'm in a prison
[Music]
i don't know i think someone had to
sleep on the sofa
what did you say oh is it just yeah it
was us too they said we were reverse
spooning
sickos i'm kidding
imagine i would sleep
how's ish doing
he's good really
he's right there he doesn't seem good
ish yeah he's out what's up just let him
let him do you need a massage
i like went to the bathroom and he was
like asleep in the air
he's like yes i'm okay just need some
sleep
that's so
hard but all right i haven't slept in
like seven days
this guy
you haven't slept in guys thank you so
much for the super chats we are trying
to get 15k
i know that's a huge number right you're
like why on god's green earth would you
need fifteen thousand dollars right
cameras and lights yeah so no i ordered
or the lights all right with the lights
it's just cameras yeah it's here so what
i want to get is i want to get eight
camera angles so when i have a full
house we can put camera here put camera
there put camera there
and i want to get um
yeah so basically it's like two thousand
dollars a camera
and we already have two and we want to
get eight total so
roughly 15k anyways i know it's a huge
goal but ways that you can support are
super chats
and memberships yeah they they help
support the channel and allow us to
upgrade the equipment
um i appreciate i know you guys um
i i know you guys
helped us with the sound board and all
this other stuff so we appreciate you
yeah but yeah our goal is fifteen
thousand dollars in the next like month
or so in super chats anyways guys
um
you guys have put in a lot of work and
no one would be grumpy if you need to
sleep no we don't need this never never
no sleep dude
make sure we're hydrating nine o'clock
like what that why are they why are they
hating on us i know people are coming in
the chat they're like they're still like
this 24 hour stream what do you expect
24 hours i'm gonna i'm gonna make a
smoothie lowkey okay
i applaud you guys oh thank you thank
you for making it this far because a lot
of people couldn't pull it off ah guys
are awesome
no
all right
do you have any other red pill questions
for them pearl
i don't know
[Music]
oh ask
when was the first time that you
realized these
um
pearl said when was
when did you realize that these hoes be
lying
jess you can answer that too oh yeah
ever since i met them
i don't know ever since i've been
cheated on the first time really
yeah how old were you
17.
oh wow wait how do you know 22. okay
wow
yeah
yep
wow i was like
women ain't [__]
dang i hate women and i just wanna date
myself at this point for now
until i grow older and i'm ready to
start dating again
okay jess
um
i don't know
hear me
i said
since the first time i've met and then i
just
i don't know i really the first time it
was the first time
that guy
because
i don't know
you're pretty young
yeah you're young yeah
see in
the
in the manosphere if a woman were to say
oh i'm just gonna focus on me and not
not date for a long time
she would essentially be putting herself
on the chopping block to get like
knocked off and no man would want her
because
essentially men
see
when a woman says oh i'm focused on me i
need to heal blah blah blah they see it
as like that's a lot of
that's a lot of work i can't do it so
[Music]
that was it was a blender i thought it
was a bit more
yes so
women basically put this up on the
chopping block yeah they decide to take
you know a step
away from dayton
focus on their selves and essentially
that is the image that
i would
that's an image that feminism portrays
like oh focus on yourself like you don't
need a man and then they do all this
focusing on themselves for so long and
oh my gosh and then
they say oh i'm ready and once they're
ready it's like the men that that they
could have had and you know we'd be fine
found because they're like that's gonna
that's that's long that's too much work
we don't want to have to do that because
from what i've learned from just being
here and hearing men
men essentially want the woman to be
their peace and if they have to
do all this work and wait for them and
all this stuff it's just like i don't
want to do all that i don't i want what
i want and if you can't provide that i'm
going to
move on to the next one yeah basically
to look as
is as
your time is not my time
so if you cannot be in the same time and
as me
i rather move on
and let you do your stuff yeah
i'm not gonna wait on you to finish
discovering yourself
because i have a wide variety of women
out there that i can go to yeah
well that's funny because we're never
taught as girls like where to find the
men we want and how to get them
and to prioritize that young
i feel like the women who do believe in
the other ones who
are the ones who are going to be less
successful in a relationship who won't
find her one oh why
because
why that is the question
why well because i would think if you go
after what you want you want you're more
likely to get it
like i think that men are the prize i
don't think women are the prize
because again it's like supply and
demand how many pretty girls are there
how many guys are there that are at a
certain caliber
so i feel like every girl should feel
like the guy she's with the surprise
but then it has the men who actually
treat women as the price
see as society
we kind of
and i think men have this natural
empathy towards women right
but
honestly in society i think that men are
kind of treated like [__]
and women or i think women treat men
like [__]
a lot and i see this because women will
say things like men are trash what are
the problems
but they take no accountability like you
picked the cheater
like
but like if like you're not you're not
sitting on here hating men but i have
girls that come on here
super man-hating but it's like because
of choices they made
and i just i don't really see men come
in with that same energy
yeah
like like and then if like a girl gets
cheated like i've been cheated on and
like honestly it's my own goddamn fault
i picked him
so i either gotta learn to pick better
right or i need to
or i need to figure out like what is it
what is it about me that's attracting
cheaters
yeah it could definitely be do you doing
something wrong yeah
instead of just looking at
the men's fault why not just take a step
back and look to see what you did wrong
yeah and like did i do something that
drove him to do that
and that's like
but like when i talk like this
it's almost like that that's absurd
when i talk to you like you're very
rational and reasonable but like a lot
of girls that i bring on they're like
like they're first whatever has happened
to them in life it's always the men's
fault
and
and i don't i really don't
agree with women looking at men all the
time as it's your fault
you're the one to blame
a lot of women make so much bad
decisions and are so stuck up in their
ass
that
they're blinded by the fact that it's
them who's pushing the men away yeah
instead
the man rather
some men won't leave you but they will
cheat on you find satisfaction somewhere
else then stay
with you the whole time yeah
and just being either treating like [__]
or not getting the satisfaction that
they need
so question how
explain this contradiction women always
make i wish men would just leave us
alone not approaching them in public
like at a bar or an event to start a
conversation and men going their own way
is misogynistic
but aren't they the same one that
actually want the men to come up to them
yeah so only if they're attractive like
what's the point
your own man
looking scruffy you know
you know hey if you want men to leave
you mentally alone then stop looking for
them
facts
facts they look for the men they want
the men to be attracted to them they
want to dress up all beautiful and
everything and not expect men to be like
oh she's hot i would want her i would
want to date her i want to take her out
stop looking for men and then men would
leave you alone yeah
so question so if a woman has an
unplanned pregnancy
she gets to have an abortion right if
she doesn't want it like a woman has a
right to choose
should men be able to have a financial
abortion
because the woman if a woman wants to
kill the kill the child or feed like
whatever you call it but like the baby
right and the man says no i want to keep
the baby he doesn't have a choice he has
zero say in that
but if the woman end of heat but he says
get an abortion and she says no i want
to keep it he has no say so should he be
able to do a financial abortion
i think it will definitely be unfair on
the woman's behalf i mean you put that
sperm up in her
you know
it's her body if she's not but i mean if
he's going to support her financially
then
okay but it's still her choice if she
wants to get rid of the child she should
be able no so i'm saying like yeah
that's fine but i'm saying so because
she can get rid of the child should he
be able to have a financial abortion
should he pay yeah so so if a man if he
gets a girl pregnant
it takes two to tango right they both
picked each other and let's say it's an
unplanned pregnancy
um and it was iris we can agree it's
irresponsible equally on both of their
parts when it comes to
like getting pregnant i mean i would put
a little more on the woman because she
could be on birth control and stuff
where the man doesn't have that option
but like
for the sake of the argument that's
equally irresponsible
and the woman gets the right to choose
it's her body so she gets to have an
abortion
but if the man doesn't want to be a
father can he have a financial abortion
i mean
why would he pay for it
well child support
you know um
if he doesn't want it and he wants to
pay for
the abortion go ahead sorry i think you
misunderstand why so a financial
abortion means
he's not on the hook for child support
before the patient comes before the baby
comes he says you know what i don't want
to be a father just like she can say i
don't want to be a mother and so can he
say like sign away his rights and sign
something that says he will never be on
the hook for child support
and he has a right to oh yeah you know
he i don't think they don't right now
i'm saying do you think he should yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah you guys are based
you know what that means yeah yeah
yeah i feel like you definitely should
just like women have an option men
should as well
yeah
um
imagine
do you feel like men and women can
really be friends
i swear on my days you brought out
that's mad because a couple days ago i
was watching i don't know if you know
ksi
he spoke about this
on the video i don't know if you watched
it no i haven't seen it but he was
basically
saying like
he's sick
like i'll
i'll probably send it to you but he was
basically like
no
because a guy's
um like
a guy
like is attracted to a female and if
he's friends with a female
eventually
say if she stays over or whatever
eventually something might happen
like
and get like freaky whatever
um so he was basically saying like no
um
you just have to watch the video because
he explains it
is mad but i can't agree
that they shouldn't be friends and i
can't agree that they'd
know
men and women can be cordial and not be
friends
and the reason behind behind that is
because men and
i have a girl as a friend
she can be there as an option where i
choose to
be sexually involved with her
if i don't have anyone else there
you know
it could be a high chance say she has a
boyfriend
and we're friends with each other
i feel like that they're the percentage
of her cheating with me
it's very high
you know things can lead to one another
feelings can be developed and they're
hiding it from each other we can go for
a drink one night and then boom
they cheated yeah so you think that they
can't be friends on some level i feel
like cordial
acquainted
but not like a good friend no
you always know that those guy and girl
where it's like clear one is like
in love with the other yeah yeah it's
all we i'm not gonna lie it always
happens for some reason it always
happens the two friends turn out to be
romantically in love with each other
yeah
oh gosh is this one makes
if a man has friends doesn't want any
kids
gets a maid and can buy a prostitute
what do women have to offer
their body that's it
he gets a prostitute so that's not my
he has a prostitute what else can a
woman offer what else can she the same
thing that the prostitute is given yeah
that's what i'm saying the prostitute is
basically there for sex
no he said so if he has friends he
doesn't want any kids he gets a maid and
can buy a prostitute what does he need a
woman for
he doesn't need a woman at that point
he doesn't you got a maid
that cleans and you have a prostitute
for sex
i'd say like they can't make a home
though
only a wife makes a home yeah i
definitely agree yeah if they wanted a
home obviously they would need a wife
but if it's just like
you just want someone to cook and clean
and
us essentially
pleasure you sexually
you just gotta get absolutely you just
gotta get the people that can do that
and then you'll be gucci
would you would you guys sign a prenup
maybe
just in case because things can happen
yeah i would yeah things [__] happens
these days like
like you fell in love with someone you
get married and then all of a sudden
that love's gone or someone cheats or
something happens you need that backup
so you won't be left broke
oh yeah oh yeah you ready because i just
know how biased the laws are against men
so i could understand like a guy wanting
to sign one
um have you ever had a girl pay for you
on the first date
no
never
yeah
i'm pretty karen in that case so
before he even decides to
before you even decide to make a move i
would have done made the move
i don't wait i just do it have you ever
had a girl ask you out
or like the first move yeah
yeah
um
i mean i i wouldn't want a girl to x me
out but if she wants to then
why not go ahead
do it i don't i don't mind
i think it's
for some reason pretty hot
i took a girl a girl to come and ask me
out so
she's like she's like she's really into
you yeah like people that are i do well
damn
definitely not
what do you think if it's hot if your
girlfriend proposed to you
oh good question
good
um i wouldn't think that it would be hot
but i think it would
be putting me on the spot
definitely just like now you're putting
me on a spot
yeah i think it would be
something else
that's all i can say about that because
that means that she's ready to get
married but
i rather i do it so i can take the
embarrassment instead of
her because if i am not ready for the
relationship or the
the load of marriage and i decide to say
no especially in a public place
that can shred her to pieces and i don't
ever want to do that
so do you think
a man knows when he wants to
marry somebody
i mean
i don't know
i mean in my case i think i would take
the risk
you know if i am in love with
someone to the point where i feel like i
can spend the rest of my life with them
and i'm receiving that same love back
and i'm sure of this person
hell yeah
i would definitely get married
definitely take the risk of you know
proposing but if they're not ready for
it then
there's still an option in the future to
get married
um
how are religious people viewed in
today's culture
[__] up
okay
why
because um they
i
consider myself a believer in god
but going to church and being
bashed in the head with the bible
oh yeah i thought you're gonna say
something
like they didn't hit it like actually no
no no no no no i mean i've been up the
door
like a baseball bat
what are you doing at your church but
they basically just
put in so much
effort into making me a believer of god
and
you know telling me to right from wrong
what to do with a relationship to not
and what to not do but they're doing the
complete opposite i feel like that is
definitely [__] up
that's so unfair
and
you cannot call a person a sinner for
having sex before marriage when you're
doing the same exact thing
you know it makes them kind of a
hypocrite well it's um
we call it the old order versus the new
order way of thinking so the old order
was before the birth control pill was
invented
and back then it made sense to get
married young
and be with one partner
because there were consequences if you
didn't you'd probably be at a shotgun
wedding
but on the other hand after birth
controls developed the world changed the
people you see are married to like
18 to 21 now it's 27 like 28 29.
true yeah
you have changed but i've still
the old order is still there as much as
society's change is still there and i
believe in getting married young
no i want to live my life out with the
person and grow old when i say old i
don't mean starting from 40 years old i
mean starting from
27 or 28 years old or even younger like
if i meet someone now that i definitely
think we can get married and we do
oh yeah
no i i agree with you i think it's
better that way but what i mean is that
the the the church is teaching old order
which is waiting until you're married in
a post
birth control society uh the jesus never
talked about birth control
yeah that's why i feel like instead of
teaching the old order you should you
can have the old order but still make
sure to have what's
now for now
being teached to people so people can
have a better understanding to not make
you look like a hypocrite like a literal
hypocrite
you know for just teaching things of the
past because
we're so advanced now
do you think that
horoscopes
is going to be a religion here soon
no
why not i don't i i don't think so
i mean people are starting to put i
don't think so do you
that like a proper religion no
but that will be more like
what's the definition of a proper
religion um so like christianity you
know islam like they're actually like
there's people that are like believers
from years
years ago
but i think the definition of a
um
proper religion is just really believing
in a higher power
horoscopes i just believe in the
universe true
i think
i think it could possibly
be one do i want to be one no
do you guys i think it can it's not it
won't be anything with religion i think
it can be compared
but not be a relationship no part of a
relation it did it won't make any sense
yeah
i don't know where do i go but
i think people are trying to make it one
because i swear there's like new um
zodiac signs or whatever
now that they've they've even like
changed the name and stuff oh i don't
even remember the name but yeah they're
heard yeah yeah i think even with that
now
as much as i can consider myself as a
scorpio
i think it's kind of stupid although
you may read into whatever this is and
it may match certain things it may make
sense to you i still feel like you
should not
try to compare yourself to that because
you are who you are
and
you basically just putting yourself
on this [__]
it's just making you basic like anyone
else
when we're all unique in our own base
why
compare yourself to a horoscope or you
know the zodiac stuff when you should
compare yourself to yourself make
yourself different that's the point of
today what makes you different
you know not what makes zodiac make you
different
it you know
yeah
um
for
would you rather wait for marriage slash
be celibate or
be in the hook-up culture
be in the hook knows
just actually for the streets she's like
she's like this fucking's too fun
i don't know
a bit of both
gotta choose one
i would say the celibate and marriage
stuff because i know i can be celibate i
have been earlier this year at least for
a couple
weeks and stuff i have been only because
it's a way for me to
know exactly what i want and develop
myself even more than i was because now
i'm just going through a stage where i
just want to be better than who i am now
i'm always trying to better myself of
course
but with being celibate to relationship
stuff um it's gonna be hard as oh yeah
because you've lost your virginity which
means you've opened up yourself to this
world of having sex now and satisfying
your needs if you were a virgin i don't
feel like those needs would be that high
oh no not at all so now because we've
already we're not a virgin of course i
think it's going to be more difficult
to wait until marriage and just be
celibate because those urges are gonna
come
but it's up to you
to actually fight off the urges or
just look into something else that can
satisfy your needs like hobbies
something you love to just take your
mind off of it but it's going to be hard
work just like how you got to work hard
for other things yeah exactly
how about you yes
what to be said of it all
someone super chatted this does no
always mean no
that's true there's no oh wait does no
house mean no yeah
i mean if i say no to someone or a girl
says no to me and she means no then you
gotta accept it no i know but does it
ever does she ever change her mind
i mean she can okay
i say
but you just gotta make sure that she's
sure yeah yeah i say from personal
experience at first i'll be like no i'm
okay
and then
there's a switch that flips and i'm like
no but in the back of my head i'm like
please
you think that's confusing for money yes
i do think it's confusing for men it's
confusing for me in this culture we're
like
yeah i don't think so i think
it's it's the way you say it though
you'll be like no
and then i'll be like you know
you want to but you say no yeah i feel
like some women would actually say no to
a man only because
lord i forgot what was this thing
it's okay we all had that moment
um i think
i think essentially
men
men are gonna no matter what when i have
sex yeah and so
if we
if we're saying like no no but we're
still
moving and grooving towards that
towards that area it's like
they know that we don't mean
no we just don't want to sound like a
hoe and be like yeah
come and get it like you're gonna say no
but your body language says yes yes
it's like your your words and your
actions have to match for it to be like
think no
or some women just want to play not play
hard to get yeah
i want these there's a microphone we got
mr fisher's back keep up the good job
ladies simply amazing mr fisher
hello mr fisher
hello mr fisher how are you
the blue one that winks for pearl from
from pearl to you
in many cases the difference between
sexual harassment and not as the female
friends is if the female finds that
person attractive would you say that's
true could you repeat that again in many
cases the difference between sexual
harassment and not is if the female
finds that person attractive would you
say that's true
kind of yeah because if they don't find
you attractive
and you're literally
in that case then you don't find them
attractive or even if you find them
attractive but you don't want to
have sex or anything with them and
they're pushing for it then yeah
okay
what about you
me
do you think the difference between
sexual harassment and not sexual
harassment is the woman finding the man
attractive
is that to me yes yes
can you repeat that again is the
difference between sexual harassment and
not
if the woman finds the man attractive
they say we look high
we're just tired yo
okay we're at six
hours
how many hours three almost every three
and a half [__] through forty
three hours and ten minutes we are not
high we're just like we started at 9 30
didn't we
don't say that
we didn't start at nine
huh
39 30 jesus that's just hoping for okay
so question do you find the facts that i
told you at all today misogynistic
no okay
i get that i hate women a lot i was just
wondering if i came off as woman hating
i don't think so at all
i don't think so i just feel like you
want
things to be equalized
i just want honesty
that's that's what i like i just don't i
don't like i i'm all about women doing
what they want to do i think if you want
to go be a host start your only fans
queer if you want if you want to go
beside chick no offense
you said it
um like go go do that right like i'm
like dude like live as you want to like
i'm all for women picking what they want
to pick what i don't like is the media
lies to us
and they try to convince us that a
career will make us happier than a
family and that's just something i can't
get behind because at 65 you will be
quite lonely if you don't have a man
sitting next to you or a wife it goes
both ways but men can better deal with
being alone than women can because
historically they had to
and i i just don't i can't get behind
yeah i just can't get behind
the the lying
is mad i don't know how they can do it
they're lying
and being delusional
and the other the other staff that's
have you ever heard the one in five
women are graped on college campuses
great oh we can't say that have you
heard of i have heard of a lot of
stories actually
because now
people can say is one in five but it
might be five and five
no i'm saying that's not true that's
stat
you sure because now there's more
stories coming out about people
being raped and i'm wondering if it's
great if it's great okay just you know
yeah
are they lying or are they just looking
for attention that's the i mean amber
heard johnny depp mm-hmm
sorry we can't we can't believe stories
we have to believe evidence yes
which was a very delusional
but that study do you know what they
included they included if a girl was
drunk
what yeah and even if the guy was drunk
too so question if i get super drunk and
i rob you
i'm still going to jail right
i mean you're under influence of alcohol
okay fine if i if i get super drunk and
i murder someone
i'm going to jail right
i'm pretty sure they would yeah
so why is it not a choice when i get
super drunk and have sex
i feel like it should be the same as
well though yeah like like something
huge if you're enthusiastically saying
yeah strong it's one thing if you're
like
drunk and saying no when they take
advantage like that that's a whole
nother thing that actually is assault
but like
if you're just super drunk and you have
sex like
that
we're not why would we include that yeah
like so why are we teaching women that
were victims and i just don't like
the victim mentality i see and you i
would like to say i'm not talking about
you you really i have not seen this
mentality at all with you
but i i see it this victim mentality
even the girl we had earlier today
like it's just this victim mentality
nothing's my fault and i just can't i
hate that it just because i just think
your lot in life is your own fault like
come on i think responsibility is so
important
it's so important like why can't you
take responsibility you're not always a
victim and when you even look at women
murdering men
and then all of a sudden it's looked at
it was just self-defense
and they walk free is horrible
and the crazy thing is i've heard
stories of where
i've heard there's been cases where i
was like
they're not stories cases
where the the man calls the police and
they arrest the man
like what what kind of [__] is that
he's asking for help
i hate that now there is that now that
to this day
men are looked at
they looked like people who can't be a
victim
when they are majority of the times they
are victimized
and is just overlooked by the law men
are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime than women but we're the
ones who quote-unquote are afraid to
walk alone at light but men aren't
they they just got to deal with it and
do it
and then the second thing is that men so
in most domestic abuse relationships
they're both abusing each other
so it's not just one side like maybe
he's he's hitting her but she's you know
hitting him in the head like
with the chair or something right
and and so in the cases where it's one
person hitting the other and it's not
retaliated
70 of the time it's a woman
so women in one-sided domestic abuse the
majority of it is women
i agree
and yet somehow women are always painted
as like they're being abused by men they
should be afraid of men i'm like what
the
heck
are you actually more afraid of a woman
because of how much power
women have been given
red pill yeah
yeah don't trust these hoes
and it's not it's not that i think women
are innately like worse than men because
i think they're shitty men and they're
shitty women i think there's men that
would absolutely lie about women if but
they don't have the power to do so
and so when you give
a population the power to do the wrong
thing more
like of course they're going to do it
like what on earth
if you hand someone a gun what do you
think they're going to do with it yeah
if you make murder not illegal more
people murder oh
there you go so if you if you let if you
don't punish women for domestic abuse
more of them are going to do it
it's like so
it's so cut and dry
if you let allow women to ruin men's
reputation based on a story and no
evidence more more crazy [__] are
going to do it
you see angela angelina jolie brad pitts
coming for her
really why yeah he said same thing
character assassination wow
that's crazy
oh my god okay it's 58.
are you guys about to head out yeah
thank you so much for coming thank you
for coming we appreciate you guys
guys yeah that's an accomplishment on my
first date do this yes we will make it
you guys should come back on like for
sure
i'll hit you all up i'm in charge of
recruiting salachano oh anytime
you guys will make it i know you can i
know you're tired but you're on the home
stretch
just keep talking just keep you know
yeah going ahead
i know yo like i'm like jess is so red
like
she's so red pill after this
conversation
after 24 hours of redfield i think i got
nothing else to teach you i know guys
let me know in the chat is there
anything i still need to teach jess yeah
cause i literally can't think of
anything just gonna be able to read it
she's starting
she's starting to recite
yeah
oh i'll let y'all out
yes um oh i'll wait till you come back
you can open the door is it that way
this is like straight down the hallway
[Music]
we need public areas coitus boosts with
cameras and consent forms upon entry is
what it says what does that mean i read
that
like basically
basically like a machine that
records both of them consenting to sex
oh okay okay
the lifespan average male life span is
76.3 years average female 81.4
why do women not approach men we're
afraid of rejection
[Music]
would you jess would you marry an
average man
wolf pack that sounds interesting dm me
on instagram
maybe i would not propose to a man oh no
no no women i think women who propose to
men are desperate
yeah and like rushing into it because if
it like
i never thought that is this was true
and people like say if a man wants to he
will but i've learned it as i've gotten
older if a man wants to he will
because a man will know
and if he doesn't do it then there's
something wrong with you ma'am
get it together
um
so once they want to call in and talk
about female narcissists
y'all can call in and i can call in in
30 minutes we're taking a nap bye
i'm kidding
yo
should wake up
oh my gosh
have you gotten into work blessing
what's wrong the phone have you gotten
it to work
i don't have an instagram account yeah
that's the only way you could call us
wolf
yeah wolf of wall street
i think she's a good dog
what's the biggest difference between
the uk and the u.s for you
for me let me answer that okay
healthcare healthcare so you got to
teach me how to use it i still don't i
can't figure it out i think the biggest
difference is that the uk is actually a
scam
and the us isn't why is the uk scam
because although there are scamming
people in the us of course the uk is the
biggest of them all um and i can say the
biggest scammer is the queen
why you say why because she sits in her
chair
all high and mighty and just
you know take all the taxes all the
funds everything from us people what
we're working so hard for
and she isn't doing nothing but just
sitting down
and being old and with her in a way and
dying
you know
it's a big scam like delivering wages a
big scam the food is a scam everything
is a scam transportation is a scam and
every time something else comes out new
they up the prices on every single thing
so
because they've lost so much money
especially during covid yeah
you've realized that a lot of things
have just went up drastically high
where do you think it's coming from this
is why especially in london is so hard
to live and people rather live outside
of london and treat london as
you know like a weekend getaway just to
come and party and not live at all
after being here for at least you know
for a while i've realized that
immediately that london ain't [__] the
uk ain't
and although
london has a support it still takes the
money away from you
than the states does
it takes more money
oh yeah no that absolutely does
it absolutely does
see i can't attest to that well let me
just think about how it's
okay um i put this oh this is red pill
thing i can teach you sort of this is
more conservative
okay if you have
if i'm gonna sell you if i'm gonna start
a business okay and i'm gonna start and
uh
i let's say a healthcare business
my job is to get the best quality people
for the lowest cost
and take a big chunk of that change and
make a [__] ton of money
okay
that's what you do when you start a
business
now imagine actually let's do it with
this let's put like this business right
that's my my goal here same thing
if the government took this bear took
this business and said we're gonna give
this away for free this studio away for
free what would happen
like if everyone all of a sudden gets
free studio time
um
i don't know
well the quality is going to go down
because why on earth would i keep up the
quality if i'm not getting paid because
they're giving it away for free
and what else is going to happen is if
the availability is going to go down
because everyone's signed up to use it
so i'm not going to pretend i'm not an
expert on the british healthcare but
that's like typically the more free [__]
you have
that like it's it's not good because
it's not actually free and where does it
where how do people pay for it it comes
from your taxes yeah
that's that's something that i did hear
that like they do take a lot take out a
lot of taxes at the end personally
i would say like take it out i know it's
a lot but like take out the taxes i
i
like the free health care i think
everybody should have
access to the bare minimum
um
excuse me for healthcare
because
there's
a situation where just people can't
afford and it's just like how can
how can they go to the doctor and get
checkups so they can't afford it but i
think the reason they can't afford it is
because the government hiked up the
price so much
because it's the same thing with college
when you gave it to everyone what do
they do oh [__] the government yeah well
so if it was private it wouldn't be this
expensive yeah and you can see this
because you can look at like
um
i want to say
opt optometry like eye doctors like none
of them are stupid expensive
um
i think i think they use the example of
eye doctors is like outside of the
government okay
because whenever you add like the
government into anything it just
i'm not against like a baseline like
free program you know but
i don't know our healthcare system
doesn't make a lot of sense
bye guys
healthcare hair is free but it's not
free yeah it's not actually free you pay
for another way for medication yeah less
is like from the surgery
yeah yeah
nice to meet you nice to meet you so
much thank you so much for coming
okay guys i'm so tired this is the worst
idea i've ever had in my life
also subscribe to the channel if i could
get to 105k if i got 5k from this live
stream i don't think i'd hate myself
for having this idea
um
hide your feet okay i'm too tired to
care
[Music]
people won't learn until the system
laser eye surgery that's what it is
i love except i
if i don't know stat you guys always
come through
i'm gonna
read um
about a nine iron rules of tomasi when
jess gets back
um update
ish is dead
like passed out basically
um
oh
help me
oh my god
hello
jess
jess i'm gonna read you the nine iron
rules of tomasi
so this is advice for men
essentially
so iron rule of tomasi number one
frame
is everything
always be aware of the subconscious
balance of whose frame you in which you
are operating always control the frame
but resist giving the impression that
you are
you know what frame is
that body type
no it's like bringing her into your
world oh okay basically i think tell me
if i butchered that in the comments so
let me know
um
so
two never under the pain of death
honestly
or honestly or dishonestly reveal the
number of women you've slept with or
explain any detail of your sexual
experiences with them to a current lover
lover
okay
because i guess she'll like use it
against you later or it won't be high
enough for her yeah
iron rule of tomosi number three any
woman who makes you wait for sex or by
her actions implies she's making you
wait for sex the sex is never worth the
wait
oh
interesting because okay think of the
most attracted
you were to a guy
did you make him wait
no yeah
um okay iron rule of tomosi number four
never under any circumstance live with a
woman you aren't married to and are not
planning to marry in the next six months
say that one more time never under any
circumstance live with a woman you
aren't married to or are not planning to
marry within six months um
i like that one never allow oh this is
for men by the way so yeah never allow a
woman to be in control of birth
wrap it i think vasectomies yeah
um
six women are utterly incapable of
loving a man in the way that a man
expects to be loved in its simplicity
this speaks volumes about the condition
of men it accurately expresses a person
uh per
pervasive nihilism that men
must either confront and accept or be
driven insane and denial and denial the
rest of their lives when they fail to
come to terms with their disillusionment
women are incapable of loving men in a
way that a man ideals is possible in a
way that she
that he thinks she should be capable of
men and women can't love the same
basically
like like women
fall in love with the women
wait at the finish lines and [__] the
winners
dang yeah so it's like men are success
objects women are sex objects
um iron rule of tomosi number seven it
is always better as but it is always
time and effort better spell spent
developing new perspective women
than it ever is in attempting to
reconstruct a failed relationship never
root through the trash once the garbage
has been dragged to the curb
you get messy your neighbors see you do
it and what you thought was worth david
digging for is never as valuable as you
thought it was
i like that a always let a woman figure
out why she won't [__] you never do it
for her an integral part of maintaining
the feminine imperative as a societal
imperative involves keeping women
as the primary sexual selectors as i've
detailed in many prior comments and
posts this means that a woman's sexual
strategy necessities that she be
at in as optimized a condition as her
full capacity
attractiveness allows for her to choose
from the best males available to satisfy
that strategy
okay
nine never self deprecate under any
circumstance that is the kiss of of so
true that is the kiss of death that you
self-initiate and is the anthesis of the
prize mentality once you've accepted
yourself and presented as a complete
douche there's no going back to
confidence with a woman never appeal to
a woman's sympathies her sympathies are
given
by her own violation never when they are
begged for women despise the obligation
of sympathy never kill arousal like
nothing kills arousal like pity even if
you don't seriously consider yourself
pathetic it never serves your best
interest to paint yourself as pathetic
self-deprecation is a misguided tool for
the afc and not something that would
even occur occur to an alpha
wow
would you think those
for the most
i'm like why can't i hear myself for the
most part
um
[Music]
all those are true
yeah i would say like they're
self-explanatory and i'm like yo i like
those
i don't know about the
about the baby one
that one i was like being controlled
birth yeah i was like hmm
yeah i think it's just not like
don't get trapped
okay okay okay
that makes sense i can't i don't believe
her she's on birth control
yeah
how's everybody doing
yo
and she's back from the dead
somehow some way he has a red eye
i'm over here
bobblehead
so you want to do this next week
i'm not here next week
absolutely not
yeah we really i feel like this was not
worth it for anybody involved no i like
i i think everyone agrees this is a
terrible idea but we've made it this far
oh sorry yeah i feel like we've all
agreed this was a terrible idea like a
horrible idea 100 yeah but we made it
this like it sounded good on paper
did you know the worst thing yeah
i definitely was up
all of yesterday same
and then came here at nine
and then stayed up
like you didn't sleep the night before
either like i slept then i woke up in
the day like like it was a normal day
yeah me too and then like
i
had done my day
got ready came here
horrible so then like i'd been up for
more than
24 hours 24 hours yeah i just i just
feel like i've made it this far i gotta
do it 100
but this is a horrible like
i don't think anyone involved like feels
like this is worth the time
no i definitely was like i i think the
chat
pushed us through in so many ways thanks
jeff i felt like
what it was a hundred k and we did
something for it yeah uh
we will never forget this
i tell you that for sure um we did get i
think we're going to get 5k subs from it
crazy shout out to everyone that's been
here with us
anyone that's joined in
through the journey um we want to thank
you like honestly yes
i appreciate that man appreciate that
thanks blessing
everyone okay let's go around everyone
say your worst red flag
about ourselves yeah bad breath
about yourself oh about me oh my my i
was like
no there's a like
that i would avoid uh my oh
yo they said marcy wouldn't approve this
bad breath
um
my worst red flag no i don't know like
oh
you can't leave anything wrong with you
nothing
that's a red flag
that you can't think of anything wrong
with you
no no
you ladies haven't said anything
yeah thank you
trying to make me look like um i didn't
say nothing
paul what's your worst flag
[Music]
oh my god i never i have a youtube
channel
that talks about relationships like if
that's not a red flag like i literally
don't know what is
that shouldn't count because then i'll
say i'm a producer of a youtube channel
no because you don't put your whole life
on the internet
like
hey
[Music]
brother found food i respect it
um
i don't know if it's a red flag
but
i would say
i detach easily
i don't know if that's a red flag
so if you're like done you're done
mm-hmm
yeah
isn't that within female nature
is it
yeah not me
i'd love that
there was i think it's like when
back in the day when uh
the winners used to win
within the wars
they would take the females and all the
spoils
so the females
had to detach
from the men that lost
to the winners and that was how wars
were won and that was what was
part of nature so
being able to detach from as a female
once
the purpose is done
with the man that she's with is
should
come innately essentially
but hey someone says red
hair equals red flag yeah i like that um
yeah now communication skills probably i
can get very busy with the things i'm
doing
and communication i don't really keep my
phone with me like i don't even know
where my phone is right now um yeah with
you out this in your pocket
yeah probably him
but yeah
no i did not choke out the dog i just
grabbed the dog by the collar and walked
it out i'm not abusive y'all you guys
can put questions in the chat
we can put questions any questions no
i'm talking to fans i mean selectively
answer
but
okay i took off my jeans because it was
hot in here this room gets so hot
they're like it's prone naked
[Music]
interesting um oh my red hair is a red
flag
you
[Music]
sexual bucket list married sex
yes yes
respect married sex
sex all day with one person the man i
marry
i just want to say
that's my husband
that's my bull
one day hopefully fingers crossed
we'd be lonely out here bro
yo
oh do you think women should delete
their instagram if they're in a
relationship
no
it all depends on like what
what type of instagram they have well i
think she should be willing to give her
passcodes up yeah if she has nothing to
hide yeah
um
yeah pass codes possibly um
i think it also depends on where
the man's kind of stays if he's able to
kind of
you know how they say um
women cheat men exercise options
men can only exercise options on the
basis that they have the ability to
so
i don't think all men
have the ability to say yo give me your
insta because they haven't
acquired enough kind of
as such
in order to
make that something a woman would do in
order to
be with that man
so um
yeah i think it's dependent on
um status as such
what was the question
would you
give your par would you oh take off your
install
no
i'd give him the passcode i'm like here
have it like
but you wouldn't get rid of it
no because the way mine is set up is
just like
it's not
bold or anything so it's not
yes
what other questions y'all got um talk
to us and at each other we're trying to
stay awake
are you guys pro-life for pro-choice
pro-life yeah pro-life
what about you blessing
yeah okay come on get in on the combo
we're tired
you're another one that's not exhausted
i'm alive
so
yeah worst question
pro-life or pro-choice
pro-life there we go
what so i don't even know you're coming
today blessing when did this happen
i had safety plans
in case i i've sleep dead in there in
case you died yeah oh okay and this was
my safety safety plan
and it came in effect
i was like he figured out the phone line
oh we couldn't do it in life we tried
okay
and then everyone was telling us the
audios messing up we were like yeah
let's not try it now
i think i would go on there for an
episode yeah yeah i think i'd do it oh
the sorry the question was um at yes
since pro will never return to fn lf and
f
will you i think i would go on a show
yeah i wouldn't
like people have asked me this like if
i'd go back and like
like i wouldn't i don't care if other
people do
um
that's just that sounds too controlling
what's everyone's personal experience
with firearms
oh i i hate i hate it do you think they
should be legal
definitely
wait hold on a minute what was the
question firearms should guns be legal
nope
yo
i forgot what the audience is saying but
no
i don't think they should be i think you
think so they should yeah
why i don't
okay where did did you where'd you grow
up
a group here okay
were you like safe typically where you
grew up
not particularly not did you ever get
like mugged or anything yeah yeah yeah
like to me it's just i feel like if
you're in a bad neighborhood you should
be able to carry a gun
so if you if something happens
i i don't really need one but to me
that's kind of like for me like a
privileged point of view because
i grew up in a safe what like white
picket defense neighborhood so who am i
to say to people that grew up in bad
neighborhoods they can't arm and protect
themselves
i think it all it takes is one wrong
decision
from someone that was ill-informed or
didn't have the experience necessary to
make the right decision
you could buy them illegally and take
someone's life
yeah so then like the only way you have
a law is it so people that break the law
get it and then the law-abiding citizens
who want to protect themselves can't
and someone said i wish i could have a
gun here honestly because i hear like
all this equipment
i live alone like i'd just rather have
one
personally i i don't like them i've shot
i've shot a lot of i've shot a gun
before
um and i just didn't
i don't know what it was about it i just
didn't
like it someone said like they support
like gun laws but they think it could be
regulated but i agree with the um the
regulation i think it could be
regulated so much better because
watching this show
and this one boy who was of age went
into
a gun shop and he bought a gun for
someone that wasn't of age and it was
just simple as that gave it to him and
he walked
walked and i was like here here you go
and it's just like it's just too
easy access for anybody to get a gun
i think i like the fact that in the uk
most people
um aren't able to get a gun
easily
and that kind of deters most people from
carrying a gun and the consequence of
carrying a gun in the uk they could get
me a gun here i'm sure you could find
someone yeah like someone like
i'm just saying like
i don't i'm not even from here
and i had someone offer to get me a gun
on like from the show yeah so like it
doesn't seem like it's that hard if me
american who knows no one yeah i'm not
saying like if i wanted to figured it
out in six months yeah like i i'm sure
right now if i asked a friend of a
friend they would they could get me a
gun yeah i'm just saying
it's
most people for the common person it's
not needed yeah in the uk and
what tends to happen is people that are
trying to mug you especially like
i was mugged at a young age like
secondary school
um
it was
more so
threats with
weapons
and then they they move on
as long as you kind of like understand
where you stand look is my life worth
my phone
probably not like hand it over keep it
moving
well
then why don't they just bear knives
like
still carried
and then but the the reason that um
the guns we we believe in the first
amendment but it's not because of
it's not for like guns it's because um
government overreach
so if a government ever becomes
tyrannical the people should be able to
protect themselves
and before hitler um that was like one
of the things he did before he
it wasn't like nazi germany happened was
he got rid of the guns he banned him
wow yeah so it's like it's like if the
government comes knocking on your door
how do you protect yourself
that's what it's for
that's i like that but i just think like
if i was a girl if we get graped like
what like if i live alone like why can't
i have a gun to protect myself
i don't think a knife will do it
true
but i mean
you know what's funny though actually
the reason i wanted is the equipment
i'm not really that worried about that
but
you know some people again because i
feel like i'm in a privileged point of
view but like there are people that live
in like seriously dangerous parts
why do you believe in guns
it's the government
it's the government thing yeah the
government you're coming from zimbabwe
where the government is a bit mad
um that's that's how i came to that that
decision
he is all right but
other countries people definitely need
to have guns
so
next question chap
do you want to see a dance
party you want to hear us sing again
we are
if you
we are dead
there's 400 people watching us be dead
we appreciate y'all for real
no we're not talking about guns now
we're done pearl a man was detained for
having a potato peeler when they started
banning knives
wow that's crazy
24 hour live stream was a great idea it
sure was i shout to you visions
okay
this is it
yeah that's all members is we get
another one we got a member nah he just
one of the members posted something
where did he post oh he said twerking i
got you drop a beat
go ahead twirl
go ahead pearl jimmy
shoot me
what else
we did it give us something else
we need a list of something
yeah
jess can you freestyle no i cannot no
no no i got scarred in elementary school
really they were like my teacher was
like who came we're doing like a vocab
or something or like how to write poems
they were like who can freestyle i'm the
only one that can't wait you can
freestyle yes all right
[Music]
hey what's up just take a vacation hey
what's up
alienation take me on vacation i'm here
sitting in my studio i got three
new hoes
you look at me this is where i go
i can do it
i get nervous
give her credit give her credit we we
liked that we liked it the floor was
cold i never said great but i could kind
of do it no i give y'all give credit
where credit's due if the modern woman
typically ranks themselves 11 out of 10
why do they need makeup and face filters
because they're lying to themselves
lying
because they live in a false reality
delusion
dropping bars that she is
look
i'm just shocked i i just figured
someone pre-game got bomb oh my gosh we
got a new member
a new member yay
thank you thank you thank you
let's go
how many kids do i want i want like five
i thought
i don't know i change it
she just wants kids like video people
who like the video like it up like it up
like it up where we at on the likes talk
to me
we are at two i'm kidding we are at oh
my gosh 909.
we almost
that's why i was like the podcast
doesn't sleep i notice it's a 24-hour
live stream shout outs to y'all fam from
los angeles from l.a
what's up active la appreciate you
that sounds familiar what's up
wow from l.a
los angeles
out here breaking racial stereotypes
that's what i was saying i was like no
one period
she got black on the inside that's not
true i'm the whitest girl on earth
i mean my videos used to be
sorry pearl but you're high on sleep
deprivation but
we're not reading that despite being
meal okay questions question three
necesitamos preguntas
do you speak spanish see
i don't know if you all understand
understood that i said we need
questions
to be fair i also treat the whales as a
joke
favorite equality we're not answering
that look questions we can answer on
live
don't you what'd they say all right
favorite
westside till i die period
i can't do it this hand cannot yet we
saw you
no i'm not six foot i wish
i'm not
he said we are all black on the inside
it's dark in there shall we
oh gracias actively
yes you speak spanish definitely went up
i went up another point because i speak
spanish well there's hope for me yet
yes doug you are correct why do girls
get butt implants
because they're flat as a board
i asked a lot of guys they said they'd
rather take a flat butt that didn't
that wasn't fake
good thing mom root
yes women can be red pill i am a woman
and i've been red pilled
hi my name is jessica and i've been red
pill
hi jessica i give you a funny tech talk
i'd be like hi i'm jessica and i've been
red pill
life at life after the red pill is
terrible i realize i'm about to hit my
wall i realize i'm going to be old and
homeless
it's great no i'm kidding
um
why are women so emotional oh it's how
we were made how did jess and pearl feel
about being replaced by transgender men
what the [__] what where's that question
at who's they're doing they they can't
replace us
y'all see us look at us
do you want
um
what you're gonna call it up here
they're talking about in sport
um well we don't i'm not for that okay
still they can't replace us who would
you rather see them on the court or us
huh answer that thank you appreciate it
i don't think you want to hear the
answers to that
then they're questionable
[Music]
they can't hit you bro okay so then
you're wrong energy
speaking spanish
in my ear
what's it called
asmr asmr asmr
you can speak spanish
with the asmr
should a biological woman who
transitioned to a male register for the
draft
no everyone should just stay in their
biological categories
like these people are weird what is a
woman
watch what is it
biological males because they are
actually biologically a male
that's on netflix right jd
i think sarah told me about that
what do you think
rp men saying a guy will cheat
give an opportunity says about their
willingness to take accountability it
comes off like they're
flaming dna for their personal decisions
oh i agree actually
like okay if a dude wants to do that
and he and he that's what he can swing
it
cool like
i mean [__] if you you got an
arrangement or whatever but
these guys act like
cheating's okay
not even okay like they can't not do it
i'm just like
like i don't know people i'm so tired i
wish i could articulate this better but
like people have
choices
in life
and you can either and you can make
choices to not do things like i'm
hypergamous i mean just if i'm married
does that mean i should leave him the
second i meet a better guy
and like
when tallulah was on here she was like
you're not even looking for better guys
i'm like okay
drake walks into the room or whoever
your celebrity there's always a better
guy thanks always there's always going
to be someone so
we make choices just like you guys
there's always going to be another [__]
somebody's going to be someone easy
someone said we can't go back to the
states they are blessed to have our
mindset seep through the fabric of this
society
thank you been watching since hour one i
was 40 minutes late and i haven't slept
yet shout out to the caffeine
that's one of the members as well yes
you're a real one been here since hour
one wow appreciate you
are women with breast augmentations
bbl's lip fillers lipo just lying to
their future me and passing on bad dna
to high value man's
jenny
i don't know what that means when they
talk about cheating it's that the men
can yes i know
um act of la i'm i'm from l.a i just was
out there
so and i know i need to
when i'm out there i need to speak as
much as spanish that i can
because
i live in a town
with
a lot of spanish because
um
why don't women get get out into the
draft equality right hmm weird would you
want women
leading you into battle would you want
it flipped where you had men being able
to opt out of the draft and women
leading into battle huh
then who's gonna who's gonna produce the
babies huh
if we're all dead
think about it
pat peeves guys
pear peas
fetishes and i'm kidding
is she sleeping no she's not sleeping
it's pearly alive
yo they thought we were high
no i i i mean but we've been on stream
the whole time or
kind of
oh i mean
little do you know
i don't hate olay but
it's a love-hate relationship
hey not me
i'm good
okay you had like a hour nap oh sorry i
thought we were talking about being high
oh yeah yeah
i'm kidding is there somewhere you guys
have always wanted to live
spain
greece i was going to say greece but i
always wanted to visit it that's like my
dream destination for my honeymoon
might just be going with myself
she said
bucket list
marry myself just the point is you're
supposed to like
like you know
settle
but
i'm not getting the point
unless someone hear me out hear me out
go after the guys you want that's what
they encourage women to do in the red
pill all right
or find the guys you want and go after
them
never heard of a 24 hour live stream
well i'm glad you're joining sir don't
get used to it yeah
next one next k we'll be doing it um
really that's dover part of la we got
something dope just gonna go with her
friend
oh yo you weren't in here when i asked
my mom
um
i'm not
la it's on the outskirts it's
um
[Music]
but i love oh literally i love the food
in l.a it's the best ever someone asked
about english food not a fan
on to the next question
i got 5 on it
so can you hear me pearl
while i'm talking yeah
so i called my mom and we were talking
they were like ask her about her friend
like what she thinks and so um
and so i asked her she was i asked her
like what she thought about him and she
was like oh he's a nice kid everyone's
like yep she called him a kid that says
it all
and then she was like ask for you two to
be together no i don't think so she was
like i thought so at first but
nah that's not the person god has for
you i was like okay cool and then i said
should i cancel the day she said
you have a date and she got all excited
i said mom i thought you just said we
weren't supposed to be together but
she's like you have a date i was like
okay
huh
yeah shout out to the 626 period
what'd you say
i
i will be surprised if he actually came
out here for my graduation
best city to live in the u.s san antonio
texas austin texas washington dc orlando
florida
phoenix arizona anyone else have any
suggestions
much respect for 24 hour last year
thanks
i just spent three hours
staples there's no such thing as staple
center anymore it's a cryptocurrency
center
what video games could you guys play for
24 hours
um
i could play sims probably for 24 hours
or
there's this old school basketball game
um
street hoops i think it's called
i could play that
or crash bandicoot
or the old school pac-man on the
gamecube
gta
if i was good at driving games i would
play gta
i think you should date sarah in the
chat someone said that no
why they said that him and uh
uh a chess club should smash
they were like him and chess could just
need to smash oh yeah i get so many
comments on the sexual tension like i've
gotten me
[Music]
how do you pronounce that break it down
for me kevin that's your new spanish
asmr channel name
what does that mean
another thing i'm cheating do you think
all men think about cheating or they all
think about having sex i feel like the
two are different constantly thinking
about cheating or your partner is a
little
psychotic to me i think they all think
about having sex i don't know about
cheating
but sex for sure
nba jam yes nba jam
i see jess future
i see jess's future and sorrow's bald
head i'm
done you lots of crazy
street hoops yes street hoops
with the um
with the like the
bump
slim i think his name is do y'all think
a woman wearing makeup or filters is the
same as a guy wearing
a
a wood sock
or renting a lambo
what
what is that what is that
a wiener sock what's a wiener sock i
think you look bigger
that's a thing
yeah it's the same
because first of
all you ain't got nothing down there
and
second of all
that ain't your car
so you ain't got no money and you ain't
got no
hot dog without the bun
so
i think it's the same
metal gear i could play that game for 24
hours the old one on playstation
i could play that for 24
hours i love that one oh metal gear
solid this would be a big
um
video game
i used to be a big gamer but then would
you write sorry out of 10
sorrow out of 10.
i've rated him on my show before what
did you rate him
yeah i would rate that
seven or eight
have you ever lived with a guy
no i have not
no
i'm not i really don't want to live with
someone until i'm married yeah i would
live with them
like after we got engaged if there was
like a pros like the process of like up
until the marriage
i would do that
pronounce
oh
yes i'm gonna go up there and screenshot
that thanks kevin
i like that
jess why do you think you're based
i don't i don't i don't i don't know
do you think your parents are based
someone said my mom was
i still don't know what that means i'm
so i'm so lost what did your mom think
of the red pill stuff i didn't hear it
um
she
she thinks that
she thought that feminism
was
like
good like the freedom side but she said
it all came down to
the choices that that person made and
how they went about using said freedom
um the body count she said
she was like 20 i think 20 is okay
and then um
uh
thanks kevin um okay for a girl
should women's nba have tighter uniforms
no because they wouldn't be able to move
around
for keeping that lady in blue in check
huh
thank you
thank you for the super chat we
appreciate it should we get like a
should we make a super chat jingle
super chat
super chat thank you
is down there across josh i try to be
i try to be
they said 20 jesus i know
my mom she said it doesn't matter
20 is fine i said mom vessel i've done
so much damage to my diet today yeah
same
like i i just can't even care right now
i'm so tired yeah many women really do
live different realities
yes as being a gamer red flag for women
sort of
um
i mean
yeah that's all you do all day
like i'm just not attracted to that i
feel like
like i have stuff going on i don't
really watch a lot of tv like i'm yeah
driven guys
for me i wouldn't say it's a red flag
unless it's like all you do like
you come home and you're just gaming
gaming gaming gaming gaming
no but if it's like every so often
i don't mind because i'm i'm gonna be
like hey i'm gonna play with you pearl
you have to live with someone before you
marry them you don't know them until you
get bad until you wear them okay the
data doesn't support you doug it doesn't
girls in their mid-20s that get married
and haven't lived with a guy it has
better outcomes than girls that didn't
so you can do it all you want i will be
doing that what do you mean might be
difficult thinking of topics for our
next live like the show
we're not doing this again yay we got
how dare you ask that question ramon
funk if you were on the live you would
know
you would know the answer to that
question green flags in relationships
green flags
tall dark and handsome boo
that is that is a very much a green flag
green flag
no um
nigerian
[Music]
someone that knows how to handle money
well
they're kids though usually like the
first generations
um can you change a diaper yes
it's not that hard
another green flag um
he says he's like looking for something
more long term
yeah
and he takes initiative
what's the damn most dangerous area
you've been to in london probably where
we live
you would think this is dangerous
there's a body found under that bridge
um
i don't know i would say this pearl you
haven't thought about this you want to
marry someone and then find out that
they leave their dirty underwear in the
kitchen sink i mean i think we could
figure out a way to work it out
like either maybe he pays more the rent
and i clean more like i think we could
i think we can figure it out doug i
don't know
oh okay i think you would kind of know
just by being around the person enough i
got you but the next live isn't going to
be
me it's going to be people that's never
been um
red pilled so
even though she's covered a lot in this
one there trust me there's still people
that don't know don't know nada i got
you i got you
okay we're gonna do a reaction video
this week we do
when
you leave the 14th right
we should do it you mean next week right
i leave next tuesday
i'm so excited
if y'all want to see
my stomach what happens on
my holiday follow me on instagram
and dm me close friends i'm gonna make a
close friends thingy
only fans
i'm kidding
sorry
i'm not a hoe
i'm the wife you can't have
period
uh
nope that's not y'all are some gangsters
because i would have been zombie by now
little do you know we up in here michael
jackson
i would have gone a lot further in
basketball if i could dunk oh yeah if
you and her live together why even mary
i don't know that's just i feel like my
husband
like that's the one thing i haven't done
with any other guy is to live with him
we're in the hospital
we sure thought
i'm not in a child that's all i have
left
um
the lead attorney
the worst child support case
like the video yes you tell them doug
like this video
like the video
i'm gonna doug's right man we're in the
home stretch we are in the home stretch
your parents
are you gonna ask your girl's parents
for permission
yeah
okay
with respect
if you could be married would you be
married
yeah yeah
i think i've understood that
there's a lot of
pros
so
can i cook nigerian food i am trainable
look at it
if she has the right teacher yeah i'll
i'll learn baby
y'all put some words in the chat and
test me on my spanish i need to i need
to brush up on it
jordan peterson said he didn't sleep for
29 to 25 days why not continue and break
his record
what it what happened
am i gonna make my husband sign a prenup
hell yeah
um if you get rich
are you gonna make your husband sign a
prenup
yeah
do i follow ben shapiro
probably
charla's not
married um
my insta is it's
girl underscore jess
they said i want to be a girl's friends
come on now it's exclusive stuff gonna
be popping up in there
no
i'm talking about uh close friends on
instagram did pro just throw out
a personal ad
i don't know
[Music]
i don't know jessica and pearl
what you shut down your instagram for a
man
serious about you we answered that kevin
i wouldn't shut it down but i'd give him
i gave him my password someone said
it's not about
like you being on there but it's about
like posting pictures for attention
what if i don't do that
but if i just like posting pictures
just post pictures
now if i am i'd be like yeah here you go
if i got to that point i'm in san diego
come through
you gonna fly me out we're gonna fly us
out
huh
if any men want to fly us out just don't
wear a package deal yes and we'd like
our own room
yes
thank you we won't say we won't be
sharing yeah
we're expensive right-ish
[__] yes
i'm about to find out tomorrow yes sir
jbp
claimed
do i believe that stay-at-home wives
should be able to ask their partners for
a salary
no
should you just you should just have one
bank account
yeah we're i'm gonna collab with melanie
king at some point
no i would never propose to a dude
i've been trying to put together a way
to introduce red people and pill people
in a way that they could swallow is this
something y'all could think of
women
it's just you have to do a video i'll
make a playlist for you guys of how to
red pill someone
you gotta start with peterson
ever heard of it
it's 24-hour livestream has taught me
never to get married manny fresh what
does that mean
tell you where my dad works
what do i think of this we can't go to
dubai we can't make a little coin i
think of i think of the term emotional
labor
as for women that are emotionally weak
yeah
what do you mean you know we have to
sleep with him right if we get food out
no we can get food out and not sleep
with nobody look at we're trying to use
you see us we can just be arm candy this
is we're just up front about the using
root for your resources now yeah
up front and you can take it or leave it
if you want to leave it
oh no he said this 24 hour live stream
time she tried to red pill brittany lee
i would love to i don't think she'd have
me i'm in a couple videos like
criticizing her
so
what do you think of the term emotional
labor
if you don't share you are not a pet you
aren't a package deal what do you mean
sure
um no it's not snowing it's like they
want us to be sister wives
we'll be such good sister wives honestly
we get along
we respect each other's time with the
man like honestly i get tired i'm busy
anyway so i just feel like you could
like
carry the team you know what i mean red
pilling someone sounds illegal you would
think
carried the two guys
i don't know
y'all tell us would someone really fly
a girl and her friend out just to hang
out
no
um women don't seem to be worth it even
the good ones better to just flog the
dolphin and hire maids for chores
i mean you can do that if you want don't
don't let me stop you how do you get
married without getting the state
involved
pearl how do you get married without
getting the state oh you just do like a
ceremony but there's no legal
[__] to like back it up basically uh
[Music]
couldn't be
given away
yo
these people on here zooming in on your
feet and screenshotting it
no
they said we gonna sell that online you
said we got feet piggy yummy yummy with
coco not as far as i know i invited her
on my show
i don't know
[Music]
i put together a future
the strip joint
you know i've always wanted to be a
stripper
jasmine was kinda just when i was
younger when i was younger just to get
through college when i was struggling
with money that's right
i said a little something
for some change spare change spare
change
spread change over here
too many of your previous interviews you
had to cuddle your friends feelings
nft feet lol
why aren't y'all saying nothing about my
feet
kidding this is getting weird anyways
[Music]
they don't like what info vader
let me show my shin
empty do women know what the code of
shivery really was
no explain
you
know big feet big shoes period
i don't have big feet my feet are
actually small for my height
besides you
yeah like six
maybe seven seven yeah like six seven i
almost said eight but that's in america
i'm not for the streets mentality
chill out it was my shin y'all act like
i pulled y'all like i went back there
and changed into some booty shorts and
was like hey guys yo this has to wake
people up from the chat
like wake up pearl i know
pro quit bruh
it's a drawing pearl's face
this is how we do it
it's friday night and i feel all right
the party's here on the west side so i
reach for my party
um i honestly think it's just social
media that pushed it
honestly that's why
and
we talked about this earlier
they scream
black love black love but
they don't really believe in it
we ran out of ice to do another ice
bucket challenge yeah sorry
y'all not about to finesse me
raymond
funk
funkadelics anybody know what the
funkadelics are
anybody
24 hours good luck 12 hours should
have
nobody knows what the funkadelics are
if you
had to build a guy
where would he be where would he be
located
would you want to stay here or go back
to the us no espana or somewhere i don't
know actually i don't know where he
would be
but
thinking back
i was stupid enough to tell my gf now
wife
she should think about stripping same
frame dress
that's confirmation from the lord above
i'm gonna become a stripper
he said he was stupid enough to do it
i was stupid enough to tell my uh
my gf now wife she should think about
stripping the same frame jess
i'm telling you
jessica what do you think of blm what
goes further back than that
what do you think of beyonce
[Music]
yeah
i
i don't know i don't like it
it was a
it was
shown as something that was
going to help
the community but then in the end it
wasn't
anything to help the community
whatsoever
if anything it just made the community
look
i did like the fact that it brought
people together
but apart from that
its purpose was never fulfilled in what
i thought it was going to be
but it did bring people together
black lives matter
hmm talking about black lives matter
yeah
in london in london like there was a
hawaii people like came together like it
was a solidarity which was
there was one monument that did get
ripped apart
but that was from uh
yeah it was yeah fair enough
build a guy sounds like a great biz
no cause it'll
discontinue all men in the world if a
woman could build the perfect guy oh
they wouldn't need functions
i like that money fresh i'll see you
many fresh is funny it actually started
from genocide you learned that yeah
don't don't screenshot my feet
okay don't do it
yeah they're like we selling them you
just put a negative out into the youtube
community yeah that's exactly what
they're gonna do no i said don't do it
why is spain why is spain not to think
about elephants
you're not going to think about
elephants
you teach me something put it
good out you
blm buy large mansions
i support that
no you don't because that's what they
did with the money oh
i get the joke
yeah
yeah and and like
it's crazy and candace owens literally
debunk has a video where she's debunked
the whole thing really it's crazy like
nobody nobody has been in a upper or
that she took all the money that they
raised from blm to buy a mansion when
it's supposed to go to multiple mansions
because they have different like
wow i think each
oh no got their own mention
correct me if i'm wrong and nobody's
going crazy over that nah
people were kind of outraged
but then it's like what can you do no
when people are outraged on
instagram you'll see it everywhere but
then what can you do like literally they
didn't extort the money
they made a page
they called it back like that black
lives matter they probably licensed the
name boom they've taken the money
and they've used it for what they
were going to use it for
they literally if i correct me if i'm
wrong i don't think they've broken any
laws
which is sad because
ethically what they've done is
completely wrong
why wasn't there a white lives matter or
a yellow lives matter who's yellow
great word hoodwink
um
we've talked about that
who said sd sucks i love sd
it's so nice down there what's sd san
diego
san diego
if a woman would build a guy
then she'd never get
a finished product
no lie was towed
mr fisher
you still shooting you still in the gym
shooting shots stay strong my future
love he said stay strong my future love
pearl you are almost there darlene
you got this paul
stick with it
my future love relate
[Music]
this is how we
this is how we do it
this is how we do it it's friday night
[Music]
this is how we do it
this is how we do it this is how we
doing our hands are in the air
and
since i was a lowercase g but now i'm a
big t the girl see i got the money
hundred dollar bills y'all if you were
from where i'm from then you would know
that i gotta get mine in a big black
truck you could get yours in the sixth
wall
whatever it is the ponies underwent so
tip up the cup and throw your hands up
and let me hear the party say
i'm kind of buzzing it's all because
this is hell he is in my way
like nobody does this is how we do it
this is how we do it jump down
[Music]
this is how we do it check it out once
upon a time in 94 mine tell me no money
and life so what's so and all they said
was 6a he stood the people the people
that the music that he made was good the
liturgy day and paul was his name he
came up to money that's what he said you
and ogi we're gonna make some cash tell
you a million records and we're making a
dash
this is how we do it
this is how we do it straight up coming
from the west side this is how we do it
oh geez got the flavor yes see how we do
it and money doesn't like
[Music]
this is how we do it
yeah
do you guys like that song
i appreciate just guys round of applause
shout out
ones in the chat if you enjoyed that
yeah
we don't want to see no tease
only one only once once one's
awake pearl up as well
should appreciate that
all right what's the next song guys give
us a song
that's my jam by the way
a song i appreciate you people yeah we
appreciate you yeah
you know what it is what do you think 30
minutes
go ahead pearl you can go in your room
do your thing paul yeah we'll wake you
up for the last hour
is are we approaching the last hour no
i'm sorry i just got so excited and i
was like oh my gosh
all right when the last two hours yes
ice bucket challenge for pearl right now
pearl works hard so we're going to give
her clap clap clap clap i think you
think you think he wins
my yummy
miami
what's your opinion i don't i don't know
the constant bill from spain i don't
know that
i don't know the week oh what
talk to me weak my swb
i don't know what it is that you've done
to me
but it caused me to act in such a crazy
way
all right i'm gonna move over there
[Music]
yeah yeah it's
this song is high for me
i get so weak in the knees i can hardly
speak i lose all control when something
takes on me
and i think it's all
amazing it's not a face i want you to
speak with me by my side i swallow my
pride your love is so sweet it knocks me
right off of my feet
in a minute i will do in a minute we'll
do some calls
um make sense
i'm relaxed right now i'm with it can't
explain why you love it makes me weak
yeah you know the password
i can't be saying
that's crazy
i was kidding raymond i don't want you
to fly us out
she says that until you put the tickets
put your money where your mouth is my
brother
on the wall i would say that's the
hardest fact
um for me to learn is the wall
and when you hit 30
50 of your eggs are gone i'm like oh
gotta get cracking honestly if anybody
wants babies out there
please draw a mustache on pearl and put
a finger in it no you guys are cruel but
sure what herself
yeah we don't want that for this
gangster rap
um
you guys know if i
how does that i can't play it um
it's snoop dogg
um
welcome back to the jack off hour this
is ej easy does anybody know that one
but
[Music]
when i met you last night baby you know
i want to ish no before you opened up
your game
i can't sing it all i had a respect for
your lady
is that considered gangster rap but now
i take it all back
um
next time you gave me on say
and you're leaving
just leave your number on the cabinet
and i promise baby i'll give you a call
next time you're feeling kind of okay
which camera are you talking to come on
over and i'll pick you on
shout out to each other appreciate you
that day baby
singing just lay back and
cause i
have never
met a girl
now
i love
in the whole wide world
i don't that wasn't gangsta rap
what's gangsta rap i don't know i don't
i don't listen to rap so
um
what's a popular uk artist i do not know
oh one yeah i got a one
tupac um
even though dukebox my twin i don't know
a lot of tupac music
um
i should
what's the name of that song i just did
i want to see if people know it
she said just the song because
anti-feminist cool
they said we like that over here
us
is that what you meant
sometimes
that is not i cannot speak on that for f
and f that is not my
information to tell so
chewbacca is the goat
uh darn demarco
um
hail mary
yes hi sasha
yes i'm on jukebox sasha give me a song
to sing
sasha
what do you do baby what do you do baby
you need to put jess on some uk hip hop
please do that's true i like the drill
dude
oh okay what time is it right now it is
7 20. okay so at
eight we'll do
a call [__] manny fresh
at eight we're gonna do some um
some calls we're just going to chill
right now i know y'all maybe want to
call in but y'all got to wait till 8 our
time so it's just the 40 minutes yeah
just 40 minutes 40 minutes
shout out to everyone that's been on the
stream with us
from whenever you came on even if you've
been known from the start even if you've
been up for an hour thank you for coming
yes we appreciate it yes appreciate you
big time we appreciate you we love you a
long time love you long time honestly
energy
like comment subscribe remember to do
all of that good stuff um sign up for
memberships energy
if you
have you become a member you get
exclusive merch i know y'all probably
heard me say this a million times but i
promise you you'll get exclusive merch
for being on this live if you are a
member
and people who ain't a member don't be
upset when it's all sold out in you like
i want that exclusive 100k merch i don't
i can't tell you what it's going to look
like but it's going to be exclusive it's
going to be a select few once it's gone
it's gone it's never coming back because
we're never gonna hit 100k again gonna
be up and up and up
um
and i swear you know i swear go on by
the moon and the stars in the sky
i'll be there
and i swear
by the shadow that's by your side
i'll be there
i love you with every bit of my heart
and i
swear
that's all i really know off the top of
my head from that one thing
oh eric about you
lady
you gonna hurt me
actually i know what to do
ordinary people
[Music]
you got
hurt my phone doesn't die
[Music]
oh
any does anybody know who anita baker is
yeah okay
i don't know her musical
[Music]
and well no i'm talking about my
earphone oh damn i think it might be
dead
oh damn
i'm gonna close in a minute
can't look at your number baby
i guess nobody ever told you
you must hold on to
is you
and you
one day
[Music]
[__]
a blessing are there headphones over
there
like white ones are beats
are there beats over there beats power
the power threes
or just no no no just regular just
regular headphones
i can plug into my phone
um that will be in the okay i got
something in my backpack
brief intermission i'll be right back
brief intermission give him a song from
uk
um
have you seen the state of her body
johnny adiola want to roll with the keys
on you see me on the livestream
sweetheart actually i don't give it
[Music]
i'm not playing
um
trying to think of a song
tell us about zimbabwe hey
zimza it's a beautiful place
i know i know you've heard a lot of
stories
but
yeah it's actually you go if you ever go
there you go to the right places
it's uh
it's a it's a
it's a free land
that that's not like i say whenever you
go out there you feel free
and i i can't describe that feeling
like the sun is beating it's good
sandy shores
i say shores there's no water
it's sandy though it's very sandy
everywhere you go but you know zim is a
it's a beautiful landman
scenery-wise gorgeous
can you uh
set up that set up would you
the computer so i can see this oh yeah
all right
dizzy die
i'm shaking oh i've had so much energy
drinks today that i'm
i tried to i tried to stay away from
that as much as possible
yeah yo
someone said cece what do you mean by
cece like cece winan like gospel
don't tell me to sing gospel i'll shut
it down
look at oh that [__] i should know
something about that
okay hold on we're gonna sing some anita
yeah honestly you know anna's been here
for time
he was like we shared the same name i
said yes we do my brother
oh i'm out of breath i don't know i
don't know whether this is my gym
where'd it go
you play through the headphones so you
can hear the song and you can sing along
i respect it
[Music]
this is literally my favorite song
i want you in my life
[Music]
i was just singing a heart
shout out to jess
i got your dad
nothing else
[Music]
i don't have cc whining vocals cc wine
and vocals at all who does
first of all
um
but
give me a song by cece
i love me somebody
you know cece no it's a gospel singer oh
okay
person you know cece
[Music]
i love you here by me
baby
you will let my love flow freely
i want you
in
[Music]
you know the craziest thing i think
about the stream right and i'm like
am i going to regret not speaking about
topics that i would have loved to have
spoken on
and if there is any topics have i missed
anything
is there anything i really feel
passionate about
[Music]
no uh
produce uh took a nap she's taking a nap
she'll be back she'll be back
as i speak on them now speaking of them
now yes
all right so here's one thing
i
don't believe in cheating no matter
how
high of a status of a man you become and
the reason why is because i don't think
it's conducive for a long-term
relationship that
you if i intend to have kids with my my
partner
um
i think
women have one
major
power and that's the ability to have
my children
and essentially i look at that and i
think that well that's my legacy and do
i want to jeopardize my legacy
over
over like
cheating if that makes sense like am i
is there a possibility where i could
jeopardize that um
someone said what if your wife stops
putting out
oh okay so if my wife stops putting out
yeah lord knows um
there's a discussion that needs to be
had
and
oh no that moment you kind of look at
that you go yeah we need therapy
because
the one
key function
that i need from my woman really
is that and if she stops putting out
then
we have a big big problem um
[Music]
obviously
last worst case scenario is yeah we i we
just like
i don't even want to say break up that's
mad in it
but i'd hate to like go outside the
relationship because for that reason
yeah um but no i totally understand that
the wife putting out being a massive
issue but yeah therapy would be my first
option but you gotta remember guys like
i
i mean i'm young so like i i don't even
know the game like that you know what
i'm saying um these are just my thoughts
and my beliefs and what i would do
men have to control their desire but
women have don't have to
oh
men of the control that is true
that is true
think about it seriously okay um
speak to me
um y'all
i i'm not taking any offense if you say
i'm a trash singer replace her
i already know i someone said replace
her yeah i already know i oh replace
like yeah they talk about me i was like
dang no
i was like all right you know i'm
attracting cause you just
there are people i think they're asking
how old are you how old am i i'm 26.
[Music]
it kind of puts things into perspective
um
you look at
the state of relationships nowadays and
like
when women start holding out and like
withholding things within the
relationship that are essentially
i wanna i would like to say like that's
their duty
like
it's my duty to provide and protect
um
but then her duty is to
help me you know what i'm saying and the
way to help me is to give me what i need
the good stuff
um
but yeah i
that's a tough one
because there's no right answer
and like the right answer for me yeah
definitely leave but like
is it okay to leave a marriage
like
i didn't even see that lf three rd
i was just overarching saying it
don't get me wrong if if i had to set
boundaries and parameters
to say look this is what i expect this
is what i want and as long as i'm
holding withholding like my end of the
bargain
i will leave
if necessary
definitely i i would leave if necessary
because i i'd say
yeah look this is what as a man i put
this in place if you're not willing to
cooperate or
coincide with what we've kind of agreed
from the jump then cool
i'm more than happy to walk
no sorry i wasn't doing asmr i was
singing the belair song prince of bel
air um
song just whispering i guess you can say
over there tomorrow
um
i'm doing good yes we're still on we're
on till 9 9 30.
when do we stop ish
that's true
oh yeah guys we stopping at nine and
yeah we stopping at nine we're stopping
at nine
if anybody wants to give me another song
i'll do some more karaoke
we was we was streaming at nine but it
wasn't live at nine i'm telling you that
now
guys we've been live since night
if anybody wants to give me another song
there was a song that somebody said
i love old school music
let's see
someone said 10 hours huh
chill out man
[Laughter]
the real ones know
do you think that you
oh hold up some other
ones
[Music]
and bring her over i'm finding a woman
in the uk yeah um
zim yeah i got a lot of love for my
country back then but defoe finding a
woman in uk um
i just
i've seen a lot in the uk i've seen how
women move
i understand
female nature a lot better
um
thankfully i lived with
in my first year of uni i lived through
some guys that
knew knew the game and they taught me a
lot i saw a lot so
i i saw things before i was even
got into the game
but yeah
zim
how to explain it
oh
did you better the devil you know than
the one you don't
they said um singing the fresh prince uh
theme song with the tupac shirt on
ironic
yo
where are these
oh no
membership yes thank you
thank you thank you
remember
what's your name
simply too awesome shout out to you
thank you for the membership thanks for
the membership we appreciate you
all appreciate you
knows
honestly i'll play la boiler
that's not i'm i don't mind marrying a
zim girl from the uk i'm just
not
fussed about going back to find one
but i'm not trying to pay bright price
i'm trying to pay that man it's all good
ish is she gonna be white or black hey
we'll see when it comes you know i don't
discriminate um i love women um we love
our woman here i love women
what's your favorite flirting move he
black hey yo
he this is what you do you walk up to a
girl in a club you go it's loud in there
so you got to get real close to here and
you go hey love mama
oh john oh i'm doing good thanks for
asking tell us
what's the drink of choice
that's sweet
i like a little long island
do you like it white liquor
or no yeah
or black no no brown
no brown no
brown is dangerous
i don't i don't drink honey
i used to
but henny i used it and
is
yes like please we're trying to get to a
towel we're
far away
um
you guys are giving me these songs hey i
hope i answered your question i don't i
don't know i don't i don't know
i don't know the lyrics too i may know
but i don't know lyrics too but someone
did ask me my favorite decade of music
i'm old school like
i'll say like wait a minute that's the
line
with the lights wait hold up
awesome
i hate to walk by just kidding
now she is out of it what languages i
was speaking spanish i didn't speak any
other language
have you been there then yes i have been
here the entire time
sweet thing
oh manny i don't know how i would phrase
that but okay i cannot so funny thing
about freestyle for me i'm scarred from
elementary school
my teacher we were doing like vocab
and
she was like okay we're gonna say it
like this we're gonna say like that she
said who can rap
my dumb self being the only black kid in
the class i was like oh me me me and i
started doing a beat on the table and i
was like i actually cannot rap i can't
freestyle and i said to somebody else
and i never tried it again
see
you remind me of a girl that i
want you i see your face whenever i
i look at you and i believe all of the
things she put
me through
this is why i just can't get i know
it's okay to simp for you online
i mean if you want to establish
[Music]
oh
all right
i like motown i love motown
i will turn on temptations earthworm and
fire old school
michael jackson anita baker i know
they're not all motown but i just love
old school music mm-hmm
that's my favorite era
i respect
ari
you were supposed to tell us
detroit slang you sent us a super chat
earlier
and you're supposed to call in
not doing calls right now at 8 o'clock
we're doing calls you're supposed to
call in and tell us about some detroit
slang
about the detroit slang
i'm from michigan by i may not know no
detroit
teach us teach us how the gentlemen talk
down there
um
mike jones
best rap album of all time still i rise
tupac and the outlaws
okay
hand the mic to the dog y'all want to
hear some asmr from pearl look no
i don't cut the stream and post it
for the next 12 months yes we are
oh don't jd jd jd you
that was me
ellie
she'd be saying things yeah
man i'm gonna pray for that dog
it was me hitting this okay jd you said
my favorite
favorite earth wren and fire song they i
love that song
i love that song when it comes on my
heart jumps david ruffin is the original
anti-feminist
ain't nobody coming to see you otis
they're coming to see me
that's one of my favorite movies
do you remember
the 21st night of september
[Music]
let me get to it
because that's my
jam
i'm gonna blast it in my ear
oh my gosh we have another another
membership y'all are awesome
michael smith jr thank you michael smith
jr
if you know it sing along
do you remember
the 21st nine
[Music]
away
for like behind the scenes content would
you guys like to do like a karaoke day
where i just come on and just sing songs
just like hey i know you guys have a
long week we're gonna do
karaoke i'll do it
i suck at singing but i'll do it i love
me some karaoke
[Music]
so like an hour and 20 minutes that's
when it ends
[Music]
and it's simba
we love you jess but no please okay
i get it
yeah today
as a famous spanish philosopher
all right manny
yo yo espanol
so
i need to search that
you want to say
i should have never spoke spanish to you
lots
because you over here fluent i am not
all right
bueno
[Music]
okay if you go i'm sorry i'm so sorry
that i'm singing on the mic so if y'all
want me to stop if it's really like real
real
annoying just let me know and i will
stop
this is just like a little um
intermission for us
i've watched
this was an hour long
this is all the best clips from the
house
yeah i know
it was
i know it was
it's crazy
you didn't hear this from me
but some little birdie sorry we'll get
back
no more
um
doug sir
sir you are requesting all the right
songs i wish i could come and talk to
y'all jody doug i'm gonna need you to
chill out bruh chill out chill
yo i love it
you're all the right songs dad
okay singing is fine okay i just
i know i
i do have my own channel if you guys
want to follow me on my own channel it's
um it's it's just it's your girl jess
with i think like seven s's no it's not
sorry that's my tick tock it's just it's
your girl jess on the it's you just add
an apostrophe and you'll see my face
there'll be more videos coming up
literally in the next few days um
i'm posting a lot before i go on holiday
so yeah oh we have another um membership
ish
of north society thank you
thank you for becoming a membership
ally's here
[Music]
what's up
what's that gear
okay uh we're gonna do i
i can't do kevin campbell i love that
song i'll sing that song in the shower
but not on live um
we'll do pretty brown eyes
so that is my channel if you guys wanna
go follow it
[Music]
yes like up the video oh we got to 1k
likes
we are finishing at nine at nine o'clock
nine o'clock sharp so if you don't get
here before nine you're gonna miss it
you're gonna miss it
you're gonna have to go back and watch
12 hours of two videos
if you want to this is good good content
i really do think it's good content
um
okay i will
give me one second y'all i will
get it and plug it in the chat get my
home
[Music]
breaking my heart
interactions
[Music]
so i just put in the chat that should
take you to it
me
no
uh
my channel yeah it should take you right
to the um
my channel if you want to subscribe to
it i respect it yes
you can't describe
[Music]
you guys like i don't let y'all know
y'all getting a rare version of me that
a lot of people don't see
so so special because i'm only like this
in my room and amongst my family
anything for content within reason
you said just just as she treating you
like family oh yes come and talk to me
if you've never listened to the
beginning that's what he does
let me know if that link worked oh thank
you of north society i appreciate it
trying to get my nerve done
be so strong
i really want to meet you
but i'm kind of yeah we all see the
partner
yes you would be sleep deprived too if
you stay there for 24 hours
5 hours 24 hours
next day
but when i see you
[Music]
or 60
60 frames it might be one kid that was
eight come on
come and talk to me
uh okay okay all right i'll get that
my birthday's next week on thursday june
16th if you guys want to send me money
my cash app actually i'll drop that in i
mean if y'all want to
y'all can i'm gonna drop it in the
comment my cash app and my venmo if you
are from the states and then i'll drop
my
paypal if you're from the uk
i don't know if i
that's
logical but
if you want to bless your girl
bring ellie back ellie's here
ellie's right there eddie's here if you
want to bless your girl with a little
birthday cash
the first one's my cash app
i know in the uk they don't have these
apps
they do
really yup cash out i've got cash up
really yeah
i didn't know that someone told me i
don't know i don't think venmo works but
i've got cash up
um
if you
just serious q what's your goal
um
the goal of my channel i like vlogging
so um
that's mainly what i'll be doing on my
channel is vlogging and traveling i have
a lot of vlogs that i need to post um
for me being out here for me being back
home
and so um
before i leave for my vacation or
holiday
i'm on to i don't have only fans
i'm um
i'm gonna post all my vlogs from back
home
um for my trip and then it will be the
ones from
my my holiday for my birthday and then
um
and then
yeah it'll just be vlogs and then i
might
i'm thinking about doing some reaction
videos
so um i've gotten a lot of videos sent
to me like hey check this out hey check
this out i'm like i'm a college student
i haven't had time to check them out so
i think i might um
might do that so
yeah i
it's just
me
a little reality tv show
makes sense yeah is your girl jess
it's your girl
is your girl yes
so yeah um
basketball starting back up again
there's basketball stuff this summer so
you'll see a little bit of that just
bear with me
i'm a one woman show
um so if it takes a little bit longer to
um
post
look at that my mommy show but yeah
if y'all want to bless me on my birthday
just private vlogs
or backstage stuff oh no it won't be
private vlogs
or backstage stuff like that's for
here like if we if we like go out
celebrate we like go out as a team or
something um to do whatever and just
like behind the scenes here that'll be
posted on memberships for here but on my
channel it'll just be you'll just see
you'll just see more of mwah
that's awe you get a lot of traction
from appearing on here and offering
backs yeah that's what that's the goal
with memberships so if you're not signed
up for memberships you won't see any
backstage stuff because her like main
content will be the pre-game and then
other stuff that she posts
um but
oh we won't forget to wake up pearl
thank you
um we appreciate it yeah that
that will be on here like backstage and
private vlogs will be here on
memberships but as for me just regular
regular vlogs
um we are we are we're gonna wake up uh
pearly yeah ish do you remember that
song panna
by techno
p-a-n-a by t-e-k-n-o let me have a look
because i'm interested
oh
he said thoughtbots be gone
[Music]
allegra um
nah dog i don't even know the song
no what does that smell
well
ellie over here just probably fun
passing gas
um
canary islands
i'm telling you which one
i'm gonna check it out let's pop it out
yeah i'm gonna check it out belly
between you two on the couch and wake up
pearl we have a whole hour
we'll put we'll put her there dt dt
listen to it it's amazing
okay
um
we think so she probably did
the smell
the smells boyfriend material
oh wow that's a good one it's like
what's that smell boyfriend material
biggest compliments or biggest
accomplishment so
far
um in my life moving out to london
i would say that's my biggest
accomplishment so far in life
mine's getting pulled to 100k
ah
i like that
um do you think a 15 year old boy is too
young to watch fresh and fit
yes okay yeah yes your question yes i
have cousins that are around about that
age watching fresh and i saw
i saw that the
[Music]
they were hating women before they they
could really understand why fresh and
fit got to that point yeah and don't get
me wrong i think freshman fits content
is really good like their
self-improvement stuff is amazing i just
think
for
young men it's not great to start there
because
it gives us the wrong impression as to
what fresh and fit are really trying to
portray
um
[Music]
but
i i appreciate
what i've done for
the community as a whole and you gotta
kind of respect it
they said ellie's ruining the ozo lane
on her own yo
eddie you hear that chat coming for you
they getting you
um
there are some rock um
music that and like metal music that i
know
um
where i grew up i had a
i was around a variety of people so my
music knowledge is very very very broad
i mean i know a lot in certain areas i
know may know more in some areas
but um
i know a lot of different genres
it's questionable if a 15 year old can
understand the context of the message
and the lesson that fnf is giving yeah
jess what are your ambitions as a
writer
what do you mean as a writer
what does that mean
yeah just what's your ambition as a
writer was a what's a writer a writer
yeah
i'm a straight rider you don't want to
win me
is it that yeah
that could be china portraying the
sexual way but a diet
is that is that what that means
what's the context it just says just
what's your ambitions as a writer all
right er
and living color you can do what you
wanna
personalities i don't think so i think
in living color and let me color was
snl before snl was snl
and living color if it wasn't for living
color and the wayne's family a lot of
people you see the day poppin would not
be poppin
i'm just gonna say that
oh it's a tupac reference i'm that one
right over my head
[Music]
they said you were wrong about fnf
or doug did or he didn't say you were
wrong about f and f
you were wrong about it says if you got
it wrong women are
indoctrinated to hate men long before 15
look at the media
oh ride or die okay from
gotta
what's your ambitions as a writer right
adoption i'm a rattata i'm kidding i'm
sorry
i'm sleep deprived
yeah
bruh
poison that's when i started
i
did i thought and living color started
before
snl
that's my knowledge but maybe i'm wrong
i am a youngin
90s blackrock
a metal band
oh
i'm sorry
rongo
i thought yeah
guys paul just needs a minute like i'm
sure yeah she's she's
yeah we're gonna get her before the live
ends trust me we're not going to end the
live without
the creator
um
she just need little rest that's all
she's been working yeah
24 hour livestream yeah we did it we
come to the end you know do you know
about this we we
did it
we did it
yeah okay
since y'all talking about snl and eddie
murphy has anybody watched
the snl eddie murphy skits when he's uh
when he's james brown
um
stevie wonder
what else when he's um the green dude
that whole like tape has anybody seen
that
because that's one of my favorite
oh i'm sorry it is 806. sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry we are calling in we
are calling in
um if you want to call in
you can call in on
my
you they said max power said um you said
we were calling in at eight i'm sorry lo
siento
um
what did
i just love i love the support everybody
i love the support
um give me a second
i know i'm i'm playing with you max
power i appreciate it
i appreciate it
um pearl is everybody pearl is still
taking a nap we're gonna wake her up
before the live is live stream is over
we promise we promise we promise because
this is not our channel
facts
cheetah balls
we gotta wake her up and this
we would be savages if we were like hey
guys bye and pro was not here
um
so
is there any way
that i can get
can you hear me the
the iphone charger over here my friend
jojo
um pearl unplugged it it's down at the
bottom
it should be on the ground or on the
table
because my phone's all about that eye
yes
is it not over there
where did she put it
no i just need i just need a cord to
connect
is her other phone over there
or no
i just need a cord
okay i just need a course actually
um do you know the code of that
oh bad all right y'all can call um
because pearl's phone has more juice
than mine so call pearls um
carl pearl's ig
if you want to um
if you want to call in and talk we'll do
like
two three minutes of person if there's
more people that want to call so go to
pearl's id just pearly things
um if you want to call in
justice hello thank you
oh i'm sorry
y'all there's things that go over my
head
and
i don't know and so i say like
i just say
things
and then people explain to me i'm like
i'm not smart
yes it's a beautiful day in the
neighborhood a beautiful day for a
neighbor would you be mine
could you be mine
oh
i missed that one i wish i like had it
on tape
buckwheat
oh buckwheat uh
um
what's the what's that what's the song
that he did is buckwheat
um
m
oh we're not getting pizza today we
already got pizza
earlier today
um
i'm mr
oh
mr um
um ride or die girls are needle in a
haystack
um
mr max power
are you are you going to call just
pearly things ig
just pearly things ig
and if your ig if your ig name is
something different put in the chat so i
know that it's you
um
yeah how much time is left how much time
is left let's ask siri
how many minutes
till
nine o'clock
it's 49 minutes until then
siri didn't say anything
[Music]
oh
okay i guess
max power
hey ari if you're still in the chat
if you get a break you can call in
if you would like to
um at just pearly things if anybody
wants to ask us questions
um you guys can call in
i don't know if i answered when's my
birthday june 16th next thursday
um
but yeah y'all can call in
at just pearly things ig
unknown
i mean there's there's a line but if
this if this line ain't lining you can
call in yes it's on the ig so
oh
this is oh this isn't
hello
hold on
um mr doug we cannot hear you
uh oh
one second
babies come
remember and then um
there's um
uh uh
everybody move your body
yes of course
[Music]
[Applause]
if you know the dance
and then um
what about um
you ever gotta be by desiree
listen uh
listen that's your day unfold oh yes
i used to hear that song on pbs kids all
the time
[Music]
oh yeah pbs kids i know that one
that's my desiree desiree had that
kissing you song off the romeo
and juliet sanjay you remember that um
no i don't think so
oh yeah um what's my i put come and talk
to me
do you have a round and round by tevin
campbell
and we go round and round and round no i
don't know why
still isn't found it was his very first
single look up round and round you
you'll see like a 12 year old
ted campbell yeah
doug
yeah sorry i was talking to the chat
the
new jack swing era marriage implies real
love oh
of course
and then um i said come and talk to me
by jodi c
pretty brown eyes
um
uh
yeah i know all these i i love it y'all
doug can sing duncan sang it he got a
nice little voice
the chat is hyping you up doug
no i sing in my room i never sing in
front of people so literally when i said
this is a rare occasion y'all are
getting i said only for content
anything for content within reason i put
it
i put it in the chat multiple times
the 90s were the most
romantic men oh yeah all the women like
35 to like 50 curb curbed all those
dudes and now they're like oh what
happened to all the romantic men
the 90s were the most simplest men that
ever existed at least at least in black
america and now that time is gone yeah
sorry
like the 90s ever again yeah sarah came
in and he was listening to boyce demand
he said yo i was in the boys man and
then boys were simps because he was
talking about end of the road how he was
like yeah i know you cheated on me but i
still love you i want you to come back
with me and i was like you don't say
that and i listened to it i said wow he
does but think about this
we had the r b
then we had oracle trying to get laura
for eight years we had roger trying to
get the uh the twins on sister sister
in our media dude yeah even freaking
the last uh season of freshman
when he was with lisa and he was sipping
all over lisa yeah
i do remember that
once you
do you have any instances where you've
been red killed and it's hard for you to
look back on certain people like me ever
since uh i've been read to them i can't
watch the color purple anymore oh but
you can't watch
that episode of the fresh prince of bel
air
where his dad comes back and he's like
why don't you want me man i can't even
watch that episode oh that's a tough one
that's a tough one
think about this
uh
dark-skinned aunt viv is impossible
how so
when they when they replaced dark skin
on thin with light skin on bib i was so
glad because uncle phil's a million
dollar lawyer and he has to deal with
that
oh no
um or um or that episode uh
will's mom on that show
uh
vibe
is impossible wow she is impossible
look every single episode she's in she
just has his attitude it's like what man
would deal with that
you know what i'm saying yeah most men
we don't leave the children
i mean i don't have any kids but
we leave the baby's mother because she's
impossible and will's mom on that show
was freaking impossible what guy could
deal with that man that's
that's deep
you're going deep doug
but even stuff right now
think about the marvel's the cinematic
universe
said the best every other superhero
character's woman got in line with him
except black panther
and t'challa
uh
lupito youngest character he's a king of
wakanda and he's begging his woman to
stay with him at the end of the movie
yeah
come on dude and you know
just real quick i'll say one last thing
talking about um
how 15 year olds
shouldn't watch freshman fit i would
argue
i put it in the chat women are
indoctrinated with misandry long before
they're 15 years old especially with
most with most of the teachers being
with them
yeah so true
you have cases where where
women teachers are putting boys boys uh
in dresses
keeping legos and stuff away from them
so women can be quarter
so because they want women to be exposed
to things all this just
dangerous stuff in school like
public school in the united states is
straight up i say maybe 70
of the sandwich nowadays
yeah and so i think that a kid
especially with a male's guidance
should watch profession
i can't say yes or no to that because i
haven't watched enough fresher foot to
be able to chime in on that
yeah yeah i mean
they just
there's some clown stuff but they're
messy they have a good message but they
do some clown stuff sometimes
ask pearl about her you know about
pearl's uh
experience a bit right yeah yeah there's
some people that asked me about i was
like can't talk about that y'all gotta
ask pearl yeah
yeah
let her tell it yeah yeah yeah
they do some clown stuff
unfortunately but you know they have
decent message this kind to figure out
their approach anyway unless you go
keep listening to all the old school
stuff okay i will
thank you for the best
yes uh decade of music all right i'm out
all right thanks doug
hi bye
um someone said something i'm not saying
i'm not saying boys to men is bad boys
and men is great i still listen boys to
men it's just the words of the song like
you don't
know the words of the song to you like
actually listen to the words of the song
like there's um too close
like step back and dance and kind of
close i feel a little coming through on
you like if you really think about that
song he was probably like
12 13 years old talking about that
so
it's like when you get older you're like
what's coming what
what
i was going to ask you all something but
i don't know
okay y'all can call in now uh 90ft uh
i don't you guys can call in um thanks
max power i appreciate it
um
y'all i don't know nothing about no
fresh and fit so y'all gotta talk to
doug about that
whatever you say it is what he said
um
f
retopi
for toby fertopie
um y'all call um pearls just stop pearly
things
so
fry toe
fried to pie oh okay
fried two pie ninety five two five
ninety-five
okay whenever y'all call in
um
and then
jay carr
you can call in after
90 frag dubai
uh
i was like what happy
uh you can call in once um
after they call in
no uh ish went somewhere
he will be right back what's my
ethnicity um i'm from america so all i
know is i'm black
unfortunately i don't know um
i don't know my
roots or heritage i gotta
do a test for that one
um
unfortunately but
hey
it's cool um
it's almost 8 30. i feel like it's about
to be like new year's or something
30 more minutes till new year's
um
van lee
i asked people this when they asked me
my ethnicity if you looked at me what
would you say like what would you like
think i was
like what ethnicity because i'm always
curious to see what people say because
i've gotten a lot of different things
i'm like i'm everything i'm kidding
yeah
stephen i'm telling you it was but when
we were younger
[Music]
it's like and girl i know you felt it
and
[Music]
i tried but i
i slept for 10 minutes i took a power
nap
um
thank you
i'm sorry i did that right in the mic
um
west african easy really interesting
i've never gotten that
that's the that's the goal is to get my
test back and be like this is what i use
um
i like me and i cannot lie you other
brothers can't deny when a girl walks in
with anybody wasting around thinking
your face you get sprung up
i'm hooking i can't stop there oh baby i
want to get with you and take your
picture
okay
chinese really
scottish nigerian ethiopian
mix but like mix with what
mix mix with what
um
[Music]
i i cannot i cannot kill a spider i had
a big one in my room when i first moved
out here
and i
could not kill it it was so big i was
ready to pack a moving back to the
states
yes y'all can call in we have almost 30
more minutes left it's just pearly
things her ig
call in it's not like a proper call-in
but on her ig you guys can call in and
ask it's just me right now ask me any
questions um
uh
ask me
tell me something funny make me laugh i
don't know sing me a song
whatever it is ask me a question about
being red pilled
and whatnot i'm just trying to keep the
the stream going before um
it's over
um
oh goodness
hi shaw marie b
hi hi hi hi
uh
the hardest class i took in college
it would have to be anatomy and
physiology that would be the hardest
class that i took in college and it
wasn't here it was back in
[Music]
california
the subject i'm studying or like just a
subject
do people know me like know me know me
on here i don't know
hi
what's up y'all it's me jess
literally
if i didn't take that 10 minute power
now it's not sleeping it's a nap
and i really wasn't like asleep asleep
my eyes were resting so
if i didn't take that 10 minute
power nap
i wouldn't be sitting right here with
all this energy for you lots at the end
of the live
so be grateful
yes
chilly freeman we are still going salute
to you
we are still going we gotta go all the
way to the end
somebody get these bots out of here
uh
what is that cap verdian what's cap
verdian
what's cap verde and blessing
huh
cap verdian
is it
okay i don't i don't know
okay
yeah i've watched so many dna tests
y'all
and so i'm like trying to study
which one
it's an island okay thank you
i was trying to study like which one to
take and whatnot
should use this degrees be done
oh wait yes i think useless degrees to
be done away with
yes
um are y'all not calling
i got pearl's instagram open call it
please
pearl asleep
she took a nap she took a nap but she's
getting up trust me we're not gonna end
alive without her
we're not gonna end
clarkson you're the only one being
negative sir clark's set
the only one being negative i'm waiting
for people to call in if you wanted to
be popping sir call in thank you
all right job enough with this spider
stuff
it's not okay
y'all are funny it's still beer in the
room i'm not 12.
um call call calls
90 fried to buy
for to buy i was waiting for you to call
sir or ma'am or person
when am i gonna get
hitched if i knew that if i knew the
answer to that question i'd be able to
tell you but i don't even know myself
i'm not ticklish at all
and i promise you that i got tickle so
much
when i was younger that i
would hold in like i'm being dead
serious i would like hold in when people
would take me i would like tense up so i
wouldn't get tickled and then
it like slowly slowly started to go away
yes i am single
yes she'll be she'll be back soon to
finish up the stream i promise you i'm
single
um try to call him but it wouldn't join
okay what is it what is your ig fred
9042pi is oh i don't know who don is
okay
hello
hi justin how are you
i'm doing good i'm showing that's good
quick question yes
what is your hardest real red pill
thought to swallow like out of
everything red pill what is the hardest
thing you swallowed it took like it took
you a long time to digest it
um
the hardest thing um for
like that i've learned throughout red
for the fall is
um the
the wall
and the um
[Music]
and the
the fact that like once you turn 30 like
90 of your not 90 goodness jesus 50
of a woman's eggs is like
they just disintegrate and it's just a
harsh reality and i'm like man and then
the uh
the body count fact as well i was like
wow that's interesting so yeah
those would be
um
the two that i or the three that were
like hard to um grasp because it's like
a harsh reality for me because
i'm i am on the latter end of
i am on the latter end of everything
hope isn't giving up don't give up
you're just only twenty-eight
he'll be right back yeah i'm um i know
it's just like whoa how much time um
27 minutes
no for the end
yeah
that was pearl y'all she's up
so yeah
so yeah that i would say that would be
the the hardest one to swallow
yeah interesting but like
the whole part about the whole biology
thing in 30 i don't understand why it's
not more
educated in the school systems whether
it be college or just high school in
biology
yeah i i don't know i wish this was
something that was taught in school
um definitely would have
moved probably a little different um
throughout my 20s
but you know
i may not be here right now talking to
you if i would have moved a little
different throughout my twenties
sex would be probably married and happy
who knows
are married and unhappy who knows i'm
go to the kidding the pessimistic view
no no no i'm playing i probably if i
would if i would have known that in high
school i probably would be married right
now with kids
but
i'm happy with my life
i would say the red pill community has
like opened my eyes a whole lot
i'm i've never been
labeled as a sim so to speak
like it i had a lot of mentality so
there's a lot of stuff i thought about
a lot of stuff that i thought about like
listening in to the with pearl and many
other um
many other content creators like
freshman fit i'm jordan peterson that
pretty much opened my eyes and like gave
me a whole new perspective on life
because
i'm only 25
so it's like it's a whole it's pretty
much the best thing that i've actually
seen in my entire life and it can help
me gear me
forward because of like i have my own
business i have my own stuff but there's
a whole lot of stuff that i also need to
create to make me a better person
for long-term relationships yeah i can
understand that
it's a it's a lot that goes on to get
ready for a relationship
a lot of people don't realize that
yeah definitely but anyways
thanks for
allowing me to call in of course of
course thank you for calling
you're welcome all right have a great
night
alright bye
all right
let's see
i don't i don't have i don't have spam
y'all i know how to work
what you're gonna call it
but
okay
i'm happy
i'm yes i would
i'm happy right now with my life yes i
want a family yes i want a husband yes i
want kids hey pearl's bad guys
but doesn't mean i'm not happy where i'm
at now like i still want that
um
let's see 90.
nope
your ig put your id in the chat guys if
um you're trying to call
uh jess what do you think of women that
intentionally become single mothers i
think they are
not smart
to say
the nice thing i think they're not smart
that purposely becomes single mothers
like
why
it's it
it's weird and it's just like a victim
i would say it's a victim mindset so
people like oh wow
you're so strong you're a single mother
and they don't know that they purposely
put themselves in that position to be a
single mother it's like
why would anyone choose to be a single
mother
nobody wants to call me
i know
um
uh favorite thing about being
black
it's like
my favorite thing about being black and
my
least favorite thing about being black
they're the same thing as the people i
love the people and i can't stand the
people at the same time it's like
we are our own in my in my opinion we
are our own worst enemy from
what i see in the states i can't speak
about everywhere else
but we are our own worst enemy will
support us all day but we'll be the
first group to tear
each other down in my opinion from what
i see some people may not agree with me
and that's okay
but of the culture and everything
we're almost there pearl
i'm so tired
when did ish leave
he didn't leave he's coming back he i
think he went to his car or something oh
okay yeah he'll be back
if nobody wants to call in you i mean
it's not a number
it's ig
just dot pearly things is literally her
youtube channel name
just a period after just
or you guys can send me
your
oh new member yay
welcome is it do say
please do say please
yes
um
the number of callers coming through are
oh
do they really they said girls get paid
to sleep on twitch
oh
they don't have it out here we tried to
get a google phone number but they don't
have it
thank you max power i appreciate
your help
because
i don't think i don't think people are
are hearing me
put your instagram names in the chat
and
and i will
call you
if you put your instagram name in the
chat if you want to call in since the
calling is not working
if your
calling isn't working
then
i know 20 minutes guys
what animal were you in your previous
life
what animal was in my previous life
hmm
maybe a bird i've always i always say i
want to be a bird but i always say i
want to be a dog
like a golden retriever
or a german shepherd
or a husky i don't know maybe i had
multiple past lives
so
uk we're in the uk
we're in the uk
do they have a blog talk radio i don't
know
i don't know
i'm going to sleep for a week after this
i'm gonna be sleeping on the beach
what if i don't want to be an animal in
my next life
your hair is not that's popular what'd
you say your hair hair is so popular on
the line thanks
oh you did ask me that doug um
it's been like this
since
without any like
texturizers in it um since 2000
2019 i just do twist so the hair that if
y'all saw me
in any of the other shows
the hair that i had i had in
i did myself so
um yeah
this is
so i guess nobody wants to send in there
ig's
sounds good
i'm not an olympian i wish i was
olympian
um
no y'all y'all are crazy you said 48
hour at 2k
livestream
no
never
oh my god i'm never doing this again it
was fun yeah funny
but no never again no it was fun
been ahead
stream and slept for most of it
her following exploded by just sleeping
well that's lame i'm kidding what
uh they said this one
girl um
is it po
tastic yeah potastic panda had a 24 hour
stream and slept for most of it uh her
following exploded just by sleeping
it's like 15 more minutes
15 more and a half hours at 9 30. mr
fisher thank you for the super chat by
the way i was last caller on ig don is
my middle name
am i trippin oh was it really
was it you are you sure no i'm not sure
i just swore it was 9 30 that we started
um
no you could be tripping though i don't
think so
okay it said it was it said it was nine
i believe you i'll tell you
congratulations on making it this far
thank you
i feel like i was afraid too this is the
last man standing she stayed up the
longest
god make me buzz i could fly far far
away i feel i feel uh
the bird two by two hours after bird
how about that mongoose
it's not gonna tune this and hey all of
us
my dad texted me he said are you still
streaming
and i go yes
30 minutes left you are crazy i thought
you would have been close now i have
proof
i know dad
okay fried to pie
we are 100 subs away from 105. are you
serious what in the world
hey hey
oh that's why
uh
right to pi i need you to
accept it
so you can call
you can go
there we go
hello
hello how are you
i am amazing
we're doing good hanging in there almost
at the finish line
i can see that yeah
uh you guys are doing very amazing work
by the way oh thank you it's all pearl
pearl's the leader and we just follow
him behind him are you carried this i
i would not have made it
oh there's an old stain in the church
that uh when the arms move the fingers
move too so you're together we all part
of the body don't get me shouting up in
here
all right do you have any questions or
anything you'd like to serve
uh a whole lot really um
uh it's just hard to get it on a couple
words yeah because i know you guys are
tired and everything but
um i think the big this disconnect
between men and women is that
men understand the game and like
like no one had to teach me that someone
could kick my butt i just knew that
growing up that
you know as you guys said that
guys we understand
um intense conversations because we know
at the end of the day someone might get
in their feelings and want to be
physical so you know
but girls
um and no thought of not you know that's
it's not your fault or anything like
that but
y'all you guys aren't in charge of
physicality so
um it's easier for you all to use words
and emotions and whatever else y'all
have up your sleeves to
make a point or whatever right so
i think
like i mean i'm i'm the one who's
mentioning patrice o'neil a lot because
he wasn't
like he i'm not gonna lie to you
um
so this is a little weird but basically
what red killed me was the 2016 election
because i didn't like i didn't like
trump but then when i found out that the
media was lying to me about him because
i did my own research
it opened my eyes up to
a lot of other things because growing up
in church i thought if i was a nice guy
i would you know
eventually some girl would find me
attractive and blah blah blah but
and i'm not gonna lie i did go through a
phase where i like i hated women but
that's just because i was stupid and
ignorant what helped me out a lot was
that if i want a good woman i have to be
a good man myself and
you know
because if i wanted an athletic wife and
i'm not athletic i'm just going to drag
her down to my level and that's not fair
so if i want someone to be smart and
mature and all that then i had to you
know do that in my life
and
i think that's just the disconnect
between men and women and like you guys
could be spitting all these facts to
these girls
but because of one
moment in their life all their emotions
are tied to that one moment and they
just can't let it go because yep
and i'm not trying to be sexist right
but like
facts
yeah if they're wrong about one thing
then they start questioning themselves
about everything else and you know
i mean most people can't handle that
right but
i mean i don't know if you guys looked
at most single mom cases but
statistically their kids are worse off
with their moms getting abused
by the by the boyfriend or by someone
else in the family
but you know we don't want to admit that
because then it shows society was wrong
about everything so but who suffers at
the end of the day man
you know
yeah
yep yeah so true
but like i said before um and like i
mean it's lost on the sea of comments
right but
um as much as men
as much as men complain about the state
of dating and all that it's really our
own fault because if we stop putting um
you know quote unquote the kitty on the
pedestal
then women wouldn't be acting like this
because yeah women like any girl behind
the mcdonald's counter can get can get
invited to a party a celebrity's party
just because she has the package
but
if we if like if all men in the world
decided no dig or uh you know whatever
no no sausage for a month
you would see all these ladies change
yeah
but
i mean there's i mean it's
it's a lie it's a lot it's a lot it's a
lot yeah but i mean it all streams from
like one thing because we're a gaming
nation now and as sad as that is
when you play a video game if you're
playing a bigger character you go with
the bigger weapons
and i think a lot of people are
forgetting that in life that
if you're
you can only get what's within your
level
and as much as you want to cry and wine
and like you know because we like most
guys we yeah we want a hot girl but if
we're not up to their level then what
are we doing we can't bring them back to
you know to our hometown we gotta we
gotta be elevated ourselves yep but i'm
just really excited to be talking to
y'all
i'm sorry about like
no you're good you're good i'm glad
you're able to call in
you love me too but really really really
really i can't stress this enough if
y'all
listen to patrice o'neill elephant in
the room it explains a lot okay and if
you listen to his episodes because this
he passed away in like 2015 i want to
say
but in 2005 through 2010 he was on a
radio show and he would give a lot of
relationship advice and almost
everything you guys are talking about
right now he was talking about it back
in the day because that's when feminism
was first getting it's it's uh
it's uh
it's energy
and you know he talks about like he
predicted will smith oh wow the way he
is and i'm not saying that he you know
said smith was going to do something
yeah yeah predicting he was predicting
the state of man okay gotcha yeah
well i'm going to let somebody else in
before we run out of time i know for
sure for sure thank you for calling and
sharing with us i appreciate it
well thank y'all y'all keep doing the
work i don't care what anyone says y'all
are doing the lord's work
yay all right awesome thank you have a
great day
bye
all right um next one next one next one
oh we're calling quick we're calling
quick oh my god okay a c c
e n
guys get us to 105 before the stream
ends
okay we're going to
you gotta
josue
josue i need you to answer quick sir
i need you to answer quick way
this is gone no
blessings did ish leave
okay
josue you're the next one you better
answer sir
if you don't answer you don't get
another chance i promise
i promise you
kitten's about to take your car hostway
uh oh i was way about to get left
oh swell sway
um my
[Applause]
ah oh josue hello you answered
yay
yeah hi looks like looks like you're in
a bit of a delay i'm sorry if uh if i
seem delayed no you're good um you got
about a minute or two to say what you
want to say because we got another
calling that i want to call in
so what would you like to ask us
that's what i get for uh being the last
one i guess calling the last minute i
guess i only get i only get so much time
right nah you're good it's just people
couldn't call in and time's running out
and we tired so
i feel that i feel that welcome by the
way shout out to you guys for uh doing
this for 24 hours i was i was in
i was chewing then a few times here and
there because uh
i work and stuff and when i get a break
from work i uh
see if you got to feel tuned in so uh
good job great job thank you thank you
guys pearl
yeah thank you you're the greatest man
it's an honor privilege to talk to you
talk to you ladies beautiful ladies uh
up there up in london up in london town
and that
yeah yeah well i i just
have a quick question yeah
so
um have you ladies ever shoot your shot
at a guy recently and if you all have
let's let's hear a story we we we guys
want to uh want to know
uh if you ladies are shooting your shots
out there at us
no i have not shot my shot at anybody
i probably probably have
um
you probably have pearl okay yeah
oh actually yeah i've i've i've i mean i
don't know if this counts you can't like
sliding into a guy's dms does that count
oh yeah that that's for me that
definitely counts yeah yeah
there's not that many women
even that oh no i mean it's like
like what's the worst that can happen he
doesn't respond to you like i don't know
to me that's right that's like low risk
clever war like
like it's like easy yeah i just feel as
though if um
if i slide into someone's dms
um then if i don't hear from you within
like a week or so then
it is what it is at that point
yeah yeah
yeah i haven't i haven't slept in
nobody's dms haven't approached nobody
i
i get nervous i get a little anxiety so
i don't do it and i just
i just sit back and relax
well that well that's funny you say that
jess because um some of us some of us
guys uh we're the same we feel the same
way we were very reluctant to sliding in
vm's or very reluctant too cold approach
because
we just don't know where your head is at
because y'all y'all's heads could be in
so many different places
what's the worst that can happen
why don't you do with that we get we get
labeled we call names we get like oh why
why you want to talk to me for
you know go talk to somebody else we get
that we get that vibe sometimes i don't
know especially like women over here in
the states yeah oh yeah yeah
are you from the states by the way yeah
we both are pearl is from chinatown i'm
from cali
nice nice okay
yeah
but yeah like i just i just feel as
though um
that's why
i guess you know talking about dating
that's that's why dating is you know
the way it is because you know we're too
we're too afraid to
not only be rejected but um
we're also afraid to like let people
know like exactly how they feel and see
where we can go with it
yeah no i i can understand that
yeah
i mean are there any prospects that you
might want to slide in the dms
that's for us to know and for you lots
to find out possibly
[Laughter]
but all right
all right josue we got one more caller
that wants to get in here thank you so
much for calling in and being on the
live with us we appreciate
you yes and thank you jess for
pronouncing my name correctly the first
time shout out to you yeah
of course yes you have seen you have
seen that name before awesome i
appreciate it of course have a great
night thanks for calling
yes pearl thank you thank you for this
uh thank you please you're welcome bye
all right last one miss kittens or mr
kittens i don't know kittens we just go
not assume
um how me and pearl met i've said this
earlier but
um
uh we met
playing her name in basketball yeah she
remember my name in basketball we met um
playing basketball at uel
and she's horrible with names but she
remembered mine
um
um is it how much of a compliment that
is for me
is it kittens
i don't know i think it's
oh gosh i don't know
um kittens kittens are
are cute
okay
um kittens are cute if um
if you
i don't know which one you are because
there's a lot
there's a lot of you so i don't know if
it's one three two one
one two three
i don't know if you could mister kit
actually i have a rejection story this
month oh oh my god i can't tell the next
i'm too tired
next time we're live
it is my mama oh they said he said it is
mama
i mean it's
sexy mama bear
um
it's not a raptor we say it's a wrap
hold on
um kittens kittens kittens kittens are
cute i don't i don't
do
no we're not having a slumber party
you're nasty lots
um kittens are cute i don't
i don't know
um
what your um
oh that i'd
i spelt it wrong that's why
y
u t
e
um
i still
still
said kgd
it's not popping up
oh oh okay okay okay i saw you get me
i'm gonna call you in a second girl give
me
actually i didn't see you kimmy i i
don't see you and ig i'm sorry girl
i can't call you
next time yeah um so i don't know where
um
where
ish is
he's gotta be asleep in the car yeah um
we
yeah we met
playing basketball
um for uel
um good let's see ish
how would you convince a friend to quit
only fans guys people are gonna do what
you get you're gonna do you're gonna
waste a lot of time yeah money and
effort trying to convince people to do
what they're like they're gonna do yeah
that's the type of person they are
they're gonna do it so i just find new
friends
yeah
you can't convince nobody to do
what they already made up in their mind
to do
um
thank you to everybody who was on the
chat we're ending in a second once we
find out where
um ish
are went literally we're done we're
blessing do you know where it is
well it'll cut the stream off if you do
it for more than 12 hours oh yeah that
is started but i think we gotta end it
somewhat yeah
okay
all right everybody that is a wrap we
don't know where ish is and we are sad
that he is not on here with us but we
appreciate
all y'all for
um
sticking it out with us and b
yes we made it a whole 24
hours don't you ever expect my
goodness that is good
yes if you say this again probably like
no shut up no don't but this is crazy
wow thank you all for um coming
like comment
subscribe i mean you guys been blowing
it up subscribe
um
if you want to follow my channel it's
it's your girl jess and it says aposhvs
and you'll be able to see me i'll pop up
i know some people are asking about it i
appreciate all y'all so
much sticking it out with us people who
are here for the first one and the
second chat and then chiming in salute
to you all for this marathon stream
thank you
thank you so much it was an idea a crazy
one and
we did it
all the red bull in the world was drank
today and everything don't ever do this
again
same time tomorrow get out of here doug
chill out bro chill out bruh chill out
duck popping we popping champagne like
we want a championship game yes a
membership
the surviving the swavy
ninja
y'all before y'all leave if y'all wanna
no subscribe not if y'all wanna
subscribe to the memberships y'all get
exclusive merch back uh
behind the scenes almost at backstage
behind the scenes exclusive footage from
just
the the back end you get to talk to
myself ish and pearl
um personally whatever questions y'all
have for us you never know you may want
to go into production on the back end of
marketing and back end of just how does
it look to get a show set up you may
want to be a youtube content creator one
day you'll be able to do that in the
membership so sign up it's only five
dollars it's only five dollars
it's not it's not that much five dollars
you spend five dollars on cheeseburger
that you don't need anyways
thank you all so much for being in here
we are tired we're gonna go we're gonna
sleep until tomorrow um if you're a
member you're gonna see our exclusive
behind-the-scene vlog to
morrow and pictures so we thank you all
so much
for um
being on this with us
uh blessings do you know how to end the
live perfect so
huh
okay
thank you guys get some rest bye